OKAY WELL WELCOME BACK.
OUR ATTEMPTS TODAY WAS TO START
DIRECTLY AT ONE PM SO THAT WE
CAN MAXIMIZE THE AMOUNT OF TIME
THAT THE PUBLIC HAD TO
PARTICIPATE AND SO WITH THAT I
WILL NOT REPEAT TO MANY OF MY
COMMENTS BUT I DO WANT TO THANK
MANY OF THE PEOPLE WHO DO MAKE
TODAY POSSIBLE IF IT WERE NOT
FOR THE SPEAKER STAFF FOR
ASSEMBLY RULES FOR OUR ASSEMBLY
SERGEANTS OR OR LEGISLATIVE
DATA CENTER. WITHOUT THEIR HARD
WORK IN BOTH PROCURING AND
CONFIGURING THIS TECHNOLOGY OUR
PROCESSES FOR THIS HEARING
MIGHT NOT EVEN BE POSSIBLE. SO
I WOULD LIKE TO NOW PLEASE READ
SOME OF THE DIRECTIONS THAT WE
HAVE. FOR THE PUBLIC WHO IS IN
THE ROOM AND SINCE WE HAVE NONE
AT THE MOMENT. I WILL MOVE ON
FOR THE PANELISTS. ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS ARE APPEARING
REMOTELY TODAY FROM A WITNESS
VIDEO ROOM OR OTHER REMOTE
LOCATION. WITH OUR STAFF
ASSISTING SO THAT THE PANEL CAN
CONVERSE WITH THE MEMBERS HERE
IN THE ROOM. SHOULD WE
EXPERIENCE ANY TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES WE ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE BE PATIENT WITH US. FOR
OUR- PUBLIC COMMENT THOSE OF
YOU WHO ARE REMOTE WE WILL BE
USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE FOR THE PUBLIC COMMENT
PORTION OF TODAY'S AGENDA. THIS
PHONE NUMBER WAS MADE AVAILABLE
WHEN THE AGENDA WAS POSTED ON
OUR WEBSITE LAST FRIDAY AND
SHOULD ALSO APPEAR ON THE LIVE
STREAM SCREEN DURING PUBLIC
COMMENTS. THOSE WATCHING THIS
HEARING REMOTELY SHOULD KNOW
THAT THE LIVE STREAM HAS A
SLIGHT DELAY AND THAT THE
ACTUAL EVENTS GOING ON IN THIS
ROOM. BUT ARE DELAYED BY ABOUT
TWENTY SECONDS. IF YOU ARE
CALLING AN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE INCLUDING YOUR
LIVE STREAM BROADCAST TO HELP
TO REDUCE SOUND DISRUPTION. YOU
CAN ALSO CALL THE COMMITTEE AT.
916-319-2090 NINE IF YOU ARE
HAVING PROBLEMS AND COMMITTEE
STAFF WILL BE THERE TO TRY TO
HELP. WE WILL BEGIN PUBLIC
COMMENT AFTER ALL MEMBERS HAVE
CONCLUDED THEIR QUESTIONS FOR
THE PANEL. I ALSO WANT TO NOTE
THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN
FEEDBACK THROUGH THE SUB ONE
EMAIL ACCOUNT. AND THAT
ADDRESSES BUDGET SUB ONE AT ASM
DOT CA DOT GOV. NOW I WOULD
LIKE TO ASK OUR COMMITTEE
CONSULTANTS TO PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ARAMBULA HERE FRAZIER.
MATT THIS YEAR PATTERSON. RAMOS
RUBIO HERE WOULD. ONE THANK YOU
I HAVE A FEW BRIEF OPENING
REMARKS AS WE BEGIN THIS
HEARING. LAST THURSDAY MAY
FOURTEENTH WE RECEIVED THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION THIS
MAY REVISION IS UNLIKE ANY
OTHER CALIFORNIA HAS EVER
EXPERIENCED IN MODERN TIMES. IT
WILL LEAD TO A BUDGET THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE WILL ADOPT ON OR
BEFORE JUNE FIFTEENTH THAT NOT
ONLY COPES WITH THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS BUT ALSO RESPONSE
TO AN ABRUPT ECONOMIC RECESSION
INFLICTED BY THE COVERT
NINETEEN CRISIS. THERE ARE MANY
CHANGES AND PROPOSALS IN THE
MAY REVISION ACROSS HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES. THE PURPOSE OF
TODAY'S SUB ONE HEARING IS TO
PROVIDE THE VENUE FOR THE
INDISPENSABLE ROLE OF LISTENING
TO WHAT THE PEOPLE IN OUR GREAT
STATE THINK ABOUT WHAT HAS BEEN
PROPOSED. OUR GOAL IS TO HEAR
YOUR VALUABLE FEEDBACK AND
ADVICE ON WHAT COURSE THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
SHOULD ULTIMATELY TAKE TOWARDS
A BUDGET AGREEMENT. WE WANT TO
LISTEN TO AND TO ABSORB WHAT
THE COMMUNITY SAYS IN REACTION
TO THE PROPOSALS AND TO TAKE
THEM SERIOUSLY. FOR THESE ARE
WEIGHTY AND HEARTFELT
CONSIDERTIONS AS WE CRAFT. A
PATH FORWARD FOR OUR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUSINESS AND BUDGET
PLAN. WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO
OPEN IT UP TO THE OTHER MEMBERS
TO SEE IF THEY HAVE ANY OPENING
COMMENTS. ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MATHIS. THANK YOU MISTER. THANK
DESERVED. DIRE TIMES AND AS WE
LOOK AT PROPOSED BUDGET CUTS- I
HOPE THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
IS- UNDERSTANDING THAT SOME OF
OUR HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
DEPARTMENTS OF ALREADY BEEN
CUT. FROM THE- A OWN NINE.
RECESSION AND WE NEED TO LOOK
AT WAYS TO KEEP- FAMILY SOUL Q.
ARE DISABLED COMMUNITIES HOLE.
AND BE ABLE TO FIGURE OUT WAYS-
THAT WILL BILLS TO HELP
EVERYBODY AND EVERYBODY IN
CALIFORNIA ENSURE NOBODY FALLS
THROUGH THE CRACKS- YET AGAIN
DURING ANOTHER RECESSION. THANK
YOU MEMBERS. NOW WE WILL MOVE
INTO OUR PANEL I'M GOING TO ASK
FOR ALL THREE OF OUR PANELISTS
TO SPEAK SEQUENTIAL AND WE WILL
HOLD OFF WITH ANY QUESTIONS
UNTIL ALL THREE. PANELISTS ARE
COMPLETE. THEN I WILL ASK IF
THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS FOR
EACH OF THE PANELISTS SO THAT
THE MEMBERS. MAY ASK OUR
QUESTIONS FIRST OF THE LA JOH
THEN OF THE ADMINISTRATION AND
THEN OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THERE ARE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF STATE OFFICIALS WHO
ARE AVAILABLE WITHIN THE
WITNESS VIDEO ROOM. TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS SO PLEASE BE PATIENT
AS THE ADMINISTRATION
REPRESENTATIVES HELP US TO
RESPOND TO THESE QUESTIONS.
WITH THAT I WANT TO INVITE OUR
FIRST SPEAKER GINA BALLOTS
DEPUTY LEADER OF ANALYZE. THE
ALEJO TO PLEASE BEGIN WITH AN
OVERVIEW OF THE HUMAN SERVICES
PROPOSALS IN THE MAY REVISION.
MISSPELL IS JOINING US REMOTELY
VIA THE VIDEO CONFERENCE AND
THE LA- HAS PROVIDED A HANDOUT
WHICH IS PSTED TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEES WEBSITE. WHICH
MISS BELLOW WILL BE REFERENCING
AS WE GO THROUGH THIS
PRESENTATION. THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US MISS BELLA AND
PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR JENNY
BELLOW AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE HERE TODAY TO
PROVIDE YOU WITH A HIGH LEVEL
OVERVIEW OF THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL FOR THE
MAJOR. HUMAN SERVICES AB
PROGRAMS AND DEPARTMENTS FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET YEAR. AS YOU HAVE NOTED
I WILL BE SPEAKING FROM A
HANDOUT TODAY THAT IS POSTED TO
OUR WEBSITE AND TO THE ASSEMBLY
IS WEBSITE. OUR OFFICE IS STILL
IN THE EARLY STAGES OF
UNDERSTANDING THE PROPOSALS
THAT ARE CONTAINED IN THE MAYOR
VISION. AND OVER THE NEXT
COMING DAYS AND WEEKS WE WILL
BE PROVIDING YOU WITH
ADDITIONAL ANALYSIS AND THOUGHT
HE TAKE AWAYS AND QUESTIONS
THAT WE HAVE. TO ASSIST YOU- IN
IN YOUR BUDGET DECISIONS COMING
FORWARD. PAGE ONE OF THE HAND
OUT. AS YOU'VE ALREADY NOTED
THERE THE BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT
YOU RECEIVED LAST WEEK IT'S
VERY DIFFERENT FROM THE ONE
THAT YOU RECEIVED IN JANUARY.
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
THAT IS BROUGHT ON BY THE
CORONA VIRUS PANDEMIC HAS
RESULTED IN SIGNIFICANT
ECONOMIC CONSEQUENCES FOR THE
STATE AND RESULTED IN NEGATIVE
CONDITIONS FOR THE BUDGET. SO
THE TABLE ON PAGE ONE REALLY
LAYS OUT THE EVOLUTION OF THE
BUDGET AD HOW IT'S CHANGED
SINCE YOU LAST SIDE IN JANUARY.
WE THOUGHT THIS IMPORTANT AND
IN AT AN IMPORTANT DISPLAY IS
TO HELP YOU TO UNDERSTAND WHERE
THE DIFFERENT PIECES ARE MOVING.
SO IF YOU LOOK AT THE TABLE
THERE'S A LOT OF NUMBERS HERE
SO I'LL WALK YOU THROUGH SOME
OF THE KEY TAKE AWAYS. IF YOU
LOOK AT THE- THREE COLUMNS THE
FIRST THREE COLUMNS. THIS IS
REALLY SHOWING YOU. A PICTURE
OF THE CURRENT YEAR TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY. AND IT'S
SHOWING YOU WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION THOUGHT THE
MAJOR HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
PROGRAMS WHAT COST. AT THE TIME
OF THE JANUARY BUDGET. AND
COMPARING IT TO MAY. AND
SHOWING YOU THE DIFFERENCE. I
THINK THE TAKE AWAY HERE IS
THAT WITH THE EXCEPTION OF THE
CHANGE IN THE CAL WORKS
PROGRAM. THE CHANGES HERE ARE
RELATIVELY MODEST THEY REALLY
ENCOMPASS CHANGES IN CASE
LOADING COST. ALSO THERE WERE
SIGNIFICANT EFFORTS UNDERTAKEN
BY THAT HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY. AND THE MONTH
OF MARCH AND APRIL. TO PROVIDE
RELIEF. TO COUNTIES AND TWO
RECIPIENTS OF PROGRAMS AS THEY
DEALT. WITH THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISES. THE OTHER THING THAT'S
REFLECTED IN THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY NUMBERS. ARE
THE FACT THAT THE STATE HAS
SECURED ENHANCED FEDERAL
FUNDING THROUGH THAT FEDERAL
MEDICAID ASSISTANCE PERCENTAGE
OR MAP INCREASE OF SIX PERCENT.
AND THAT HAVE THE EFFECT OF
OFFSETTING STATE GENERAL COSTS
FOR CERTAIN PROGRAMS. BUT AGAIN
THE REAL STORY HERE IS THAT THE
CHANGES IN NINETEEN TWENTY A
RELATIVELY MODEST WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF CAL WORKS. AND
THAT IS REALLY DRIVEN BY AN
INCREASEIN THE CASE LOAD WHICH
WILL DISCUSS LATER. MOVING OVER
TO THE TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
COMPARISON AGAIN THIS IS
SHOWING YOU. WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION ESTIMATED THE
PROGRAMS TO COST IN TWENTY
EIGHT IN JANUARY AND COMPARING
THAT TO MAY. AND HERE IS WHERE
YOU EE SOME REAL VARIANCE AND
SAM. IS A MARKED DIFFERENCES
AND CHANGES AND THIS IS
BECAUSE- IT IS A FULL YEAR OF
CASELOAD IMPACTS. THAT ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH A CORONA VIRUS.
SO AGAIN MAJOR INCREASES AND
PROGRAMS LIKE HOW IT WORKS ARE
ESTIMATED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. ADDITIONALLY IT
SHOWING A FULL YEAR OF FEDERAL
FUNDING RELIEF. I'M THAT
OFFSETS GENERAL FUND COSTS. AND
THEN FINALLY IT'S IT REFLECTS
THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION
PROPOSALS WHICH HAVE. VARIOUS
REDUCTIONS ACROSS THE DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS WHICH WE WILL AGAIN
DISCUSS LATER. THE FINAL COLUMN
REALLY SHOWS THE YEAR OVER
DIFFERENCES BASED ON OUR BEST
ESTIMATES AND AGAIN. THE MAJOR
CHANGES THAT WHICH WE WILL
DISCUSS. TURNING TO THE NEXT
PAGE OF THE HANDOUT WE WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT IT'S IMPORTANT
TO LOOK AT NOT JUST THE GENERAL
FUND CHANGES TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
THE PROGRAMS BUT TO LOOK AT
TOTAL COSTS. THAT'S ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT FOR THE WHOLE WORKS
PROGRAM ALTHOUGH THE GENERAL
FUND COSTA SHOWING A VERY
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN THE
YEAR OVER BASIS- OF OVER TWO
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT
PERCENT. THE WHEN YOU LOOK AT
TOTAL FUNDS THE INCREASE IS
STILL VERY SIGNIFICANT AN
UNPRECEDENTED BUT IT'S CLOSER
TO FIFTY FIVE PERCENT. AND THIS
IS REALLY DRIVEN BY AN
ESTIMATED INCREASE IN THE
HOWARD CASE LOAD ON A YEAR OVER
BASIS A SEVENTY FIVE POINT 6%
ANOTHER PROGRAM WHERE IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
ALL FUNDS NOT JUST THE GENERAL
FUND IS AN IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES PROGRAM. FOR THAT
PROGRAM YOU WILL HAVE NOTICED
ON THE PRIOR PAGE THAT. THE
GENERAL FUND WAS EXPECTED TO
DECREASE. IN A YEAR OVER BASIS.
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT TOTAL
FUNDS. IT'S ACTUALLY EXPECTED
TO INCREASE BY OVER 8% AND
AGAIN THIS IS THE EFFECT OF THE
FEDERAL ASSISTANCE RELATED TO
THE AFTERMATH WHICH WE USED TO
OFFSET THE GENERAL FUND COST OF
THE PROGRAM. SHE TURNING NOW TO
THE NEXT PAGE OF THE HANDOUT WE
FIRST WHEN WE FIRST RECEIVED
THE MAYOR VISION WE THOUGHT IT
IMPORTANT TO LOOK BACK AT THE
JANUARY PROPOSAL AS YOU'LL
RECALL IN JANUARY THE BUDGET
PICTURE WAS VERY DIFFERENT SO
THE ADMINISTRATION HAD SEVERAL
MAJOR AUGMENTATION PROPOSALS
BEFORE YOU AND WE REALLY WANTED
TO GO BACK AND LOOK AT THE
TREATMENT OF THOSE IN THE NAY
REVISION. GENERALLY THE
TREATMENT FALLS INTO THREE
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES SOME OF
THE PROPOSALS IN FACT MANY OF
THEM HAVE BEEN WITHDRAWN SOME
OF THOSE AUGMENTATION PROPOSALS
SOME OF THEM HAVE BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY MODIFIED FOR
EXAMPLE- IN JANUARY THE
GOVERNOR WAS PROPOSING TO
CREATE A NEW DEPARTMENT OF
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION AT
THE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY. AND NOW THAT PROPOSAL
IS TO MOVED CHILD CARE PROGRAMS
INTO THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES AS PART OF THE VISION
SO SIGNIFICANT MODIFICATION TO
THAT PROPOSAL THERE ARE A FEW
JANUARY PROPOSALS THAT ROUTINE
AND WE ARE CONTINUING TO DO A
COMPLETE INVENTORY OF THOSE
THAT YOU HAVE BEST INFORMATION
YOU GO FORWARD AND JUST. THANK
YOU. PAGE OF THE HANDOUT.
YOU'LL SEE THE I'M OF MAJOR
PROPOSALS THE MAJOR MAYOR
BUDGET REDUCTION PROPOSALS PUT
FORWARD BY THE ADMIN. I THINK
ONE BIG TAKEAWAY HERE IS TAT
AT UNLIKEOTHER AREAS OF THE
BUDGET THE ADMINISTRATION TOOK
A MORE TARGETED APPROACH AND
HUMAN SERVICES- SOLUTIONS IT
WAS NOT SORT OF BLANKET OVERALL
PERCENTAGE DECREASE AS BUT MORE
US SPECIFIC SPECIFIC ADD
DECREASES FOR A SPECIFIC
PROGRAM. ANOTHER IMPORTANT NOTE
HERE IS THAT THERE ARE REALLY
TWO TYPES OF REDUCTIONS IN
FRONT OF YOU. THERE ARE THE
ONES THAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PUTTING FORWARD AS PART OF
THEIR BASELINE BUDGET PROPOSAL
THAT THEY WILL DO YOU NO MATTER
WHAT. AND THEN THERE ARE A
CATEGORY OF REDUCTION OF THEIR
WE ARE REFERRING TO AS TRIGGER
REDUCTIONS AND THESE ARE
REDUCTIONS THAT ONLY GO INTO
PLACE IF FEDERAL FUNDING OF
FOURTEEN BILLION IS NOT. IS NOT
SECURED BY THE STATE. SOLVE ALL
WALK THROUGH THESE LESS AT A
HIGH LEVEL AND THE FIRST ONE IS
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING. THE
PROPOSAL IS TO ELIMINATE THE
MULTI PURPOSE SENIOR SERVICES
PROGRAM. THIS IS A PROGRAM FOR
LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
QUALIFY FOR SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY AND IT PROVIDES CASE
MANAGEMENT SERVICES TO THEM IN
THEIR HOME. THE NEXT PROPOSAL
IS TO REDUCE THE SENIOR
SERVICES NUTRITION AS THE
SENIOR NUTRITION PROGRAM AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING. AND THIS
IS THE PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES
HOME DELIVERED MEALS AND
CONGREGATE MEALS TO SENIORS.
THERE'S A PROPOSAL TO REDUCE
AGING AND DISABILITY RESOURCE
CENTER FUNDING BY THREE MILLION
THESE ARE YOUR NORWALK WRONG
DOOR SPOTS FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
SEEKING INFORMATION ON LONG
TERM CARE. THERE'S THAT REQUEST
THERE'S A PROPOSAL TO REDUCE
THE LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
PROGRAM BY TWO MILLION. MOVING
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF CHILD
SUPPORT SERVICES AS PART OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S JANUARY
PROPOSAL THERE WAS ACTUALLY A
PROPOSAL TO INCREASE FUNDING
FOR LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT
AGENCIES. I ABOUT EIGHTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS AT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS WITHDRAWN
THAT PROPOSAL AND ALSO PROPOSE
TO FURTHER REDUCE THE CHILD
SUPPORT AGENCIES BUDGET TO THE
TO AT TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN BUDGET LEVELS. FOR
SAVINGS OF TIRTY EIGHT POINT
ONE MILLION. MOVING TO THE IN
HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
PROGRAM THERE IS A PROPOSAL TO
REDUCE IN HOME SUPPORTED
SERVICE HOURS BY SEVEN PERCENT.
THIS WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS
FIRST DONE IN THE GREAT
RECESSION AND THAT WOULD IS
ESTIMATED TO RESULT IN AN
AVERAGE HOUR REDUCTION OF
AROUND EIGHT HOURS PER MONTH.
THERE'S ALSO PROPOSAL TO HOLD
HSS COUNTY ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS
TO THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
LEVELS. AT THE NEXT PROPOSAL IS
IT'S- TO ALIGN I JUST AS
RESIDUAL PROGRAM WITH MEDI CAL
AND WHAT THAT MEANS IS
CURRENTLY WIN AND I JUST LAST
RECIPIENT- LOSES ELIGIBILITY
FOR MEDI CAL THEY GO INTO STATE
ONLY I JUST ASK PROGRAM. THIS
PROPOSAL WED. ALLOW AND
ENCOURAGE AND PROVIDE FOR THAT%
PERSON I THEY'RE NOT TO FALL
OFF OF THE MEDICAL PROGRAM
THERE BY SECURING THE FEDERAL
FUNDING OR IF THEY DO IN
FACILITATING THEIR RETURNS THE
MEDIC HEALTH PROGRAM. THE NEXT
PROPOSAL IS TO CONTRACT OUT FOR
AGES THAT'S PAYROLL
FUNCTIONALITY THAT IS NOW DONE
AT THE COUNTY LEVEL FOR A
SAVINGS OF NINE POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS. MOVING INTO SS
I SS PETE. THERE IS A PROPOSAL
TO OFFSET THE S. S. P. PORTION
THE STATE'S PORTION OF THE
GRANT BY THE AMOUNT THAT THE SS
I PORTION WAS SCHEDULED TO
INCREASE YOU WILL RECALL THAT
IN JANUARY- THE SS I PORTION OF
THE FEDERAL PORTION OF THE SS I
SS P. GRANT. IS EXPECTED TO
INCREASE- DUE TO A FEDERAL
COLAC BUT THIS WOULD DO IS IT
WOULD ALLOW THE STATE TO. HOLD
DOWN THE STATE'S PORTION OF THE
GRANTS BY DOWN TO THE FEDERALLY
ALLOWABLE MINIMUM. AS A SIZE IS
P. RECIPIENTS WOULD RECEIVE AN
INCREASE IN THEIR TOTAL GRANT
IN THE BUDGET YEAR BUT IT WOULD
BE SMALLER- SIGNIFICANTLY
SMALLER THAN WHAT IT WAS
PROJECTED TO BE IN JANUARY.
MOVING INTO THE CAL WORKS
PROGRAM AS WE HAVE DISCUSSED
THE CAL WORKS PROGRAM IS
EXPECTED TO GROW AT.
UNPRECEDENTED LEVELS BY THE
ESTIMATES OF THE
ADMINISTRATION. WITH THAT COMES
UP COST INCREASES IN THE
EMPLOYER ASSOCIATE IT
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES AND CHILD
CARE. THE BUSH ADMINISTRATION
HAS MADE A DECISION TO THAT THE
NEW INDIVIDUALS COMING INTO CAL
WORKS AS A RESULT OF LOSING
EMPLOYMENT- DURING THE CODE
NINETEEN CRISIS ARE THOSE THAT
HAVE RECENTLY BEEN WORKING AND
THEIR THEIR NEEDS FOR
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES AND CHILD
CARE MAYBE LESS. AND AS A
RESULT THEY HAVEN'T BUDGETED
LAST COST PER CASE. AND THAT
RESULT IN SAVINGS OF SIX
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE MILLION
IN THE BUDGET YEAR. THERE'S
ALSO A PROPOSAL TO SUSPEND THE
CAL WORKS EXPANDED SUBSIDIZED
EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM THIS IS A
PROGRAM THAT FIRST CAME ABOUT
DURING THE GREAT RECESSION. IS
A PROGRAM THAT LINKS HOW WORKS
RECIPIENTS WITH EMPLOYERS AND
SUBSIDIZES THEIR EMPLOYMENT.
THIS IS AN ESTIMATED TO SAVE A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR MILLION
IN THE BUDGET YEAR. THE NEXT
PROPOSAL IS TO REDUCE THE HOME
VISITING PROGRAM AND CAL WORKS
BY THIRTY MILLION. AND TO
SUSPEND THE CAL WORKS
ACCOUNTABILITY AND REVIEW
PROGRAM I TWENTY ONE MILLION.
TURNING TO THE NEXT PAGE WE GET
INTO CHILD WELFARE SERVICES.
AND I WILL JUST NOTES THERE WE
GOT CLARIFICATION TODAY FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION THAT TWO OF
THE ITEMS THAT ARE NOT MARKED
AS TRIGGER REDUCTIONS ON OUR-
HAND OUT ACTUALLY ARE SO I WILL
NOTE THOSE AS WE GO THROUGH. SO
THE FIRST PROPOSAL IS TO REDUCE
RATES FOR SHORT TERM
RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC
PROGRAMS OR S. T. R. T. PIECE
AS WE KNOW THEM BY FIVE
PERCENT. AND THEN TO ALSO
SUSPEND THE ROLLOUT OF THE
LEVEL OF CARE RATE SYSTEM. UP
FOR FOSTER YOUTH THIS IS THE
LEVEL OF CARE RATE SYSTEM IS.
HAS NOT BEEN IMPLEMENTED ACROSS
THE BOARD YET IT HAS BEEN
IMPLEMENTED FOR FOSTER FAMILY
AGENCIES. THIS WOULD POSTPONE
ANY FURTHER IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE LEVEL OF CARE RATE TOOL.
AND WHAT BUT IT WOULD NOT
DECREASE RATES FOR ANY CURRENT
FOSTER YOUTH THIS IS ESTIMATED
TO SAVE TWENTY EIGHT MILLION IN
THE BUDGET YEAR. THE NEXT
PROPOSAL IS TO ELIMINATE THE
FOSTER FAMILY. ONLY AGENCIES
SOCIAL WORKER RATE FOR SAVINGS
OF FOUR POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS AND THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE TRIGGER REDUCTIONS THAT
IS NOT MARKED ON OUR HANDS OUT
THE NEXT IS TO ELIMINATE THE
FAMILY URGENT RESPONSE SYSTEM
WHICH WAS. A NEW PROPOSED A NEW
PROGRAM- PROVIDED FOR A LAST
YEAR. AND THIS IS A THIS IS A
PROGRAM THAT ALLOWS FOR A
TWENTY FOUR HOUR HOTLINE AND
EMERGENCY RESPONSE FOR FOSTER.
FAMILIES AND YOUTH THAT ARE
EXPERIENCING TRAUMA. THE NEXT
PROPOSAL IS TO ELIMINATE A
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE EARLY
INTERVENTION PILOT PROGRAM IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY. THAT WAS
ALSO PART OF LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
FOR EIGHT POINT FIVE MILLION
GENERAL FUND. MOVING OUT INTO
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES THERE'S A BIT OF A
DIFFERENT APPROACH HERE THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION TOOK. THEY
ARE ASSUMING SAVINGS ARE AS
THEY ARE PROPOSING SAVINGS OF
THREE HUNDRED MILLION IN THE
BUDGET YEAR. AND THEY'RE DOING
THIS OR- OF EFFORTS- FIRST IS
THROUGH SOME SOME TYPE OF RATE
REDUCTION WHICH THEY INTEND TO
SEEK INPUT FROM. STAKEHOLDERS
IN ORDER TO DETERMINE EXACTLY
WHAT THAT WOULD BE. AND THEN
SEVENTY MILLION OF IT WOULD BE
FROM EFFICIENCIES. THEY'RE ALSO
PROPOSING TO ENFORCE A UNIFORM
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT HAS BEEN IN
STATUTE FOR SEVERAL YEARS BUT
HAS NOT BEEN ENFORCED AND WOULD
REQUIRE. ESSENTIALLY FOURTEEN
DAYS A YEAR WERE PROVIDERS ARE
UNABLE TO BILL. THERE IS ALSO A
PROPOSAL TO REDUCE REGIONAL
CENTER OPERATIONS BY THIRTY
MILLION. AND IT TO INCREASE
ENROLLMENT IN MEDICAID WAIVER
PROGRAM SO THIS WOULD IDENTIFY
INDIVIDUALS WHO MIGHT BE
ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICAID WAIVER
RATHER THAN A STATE ONLY
PROGRAMS AND MOVE THEM INTO THE
MEDICAID PROGRAM TO. SECURE
FEDERAL PARTIAL FEDERAL FUNDING.
IS A VERY HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW
OF THE MAJOR REDUCTION
PROPOSALS INCLUDED IN THE
BUDGET WE WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT
THE MAI REVISION ALSO INCLUDE
SOME NEW PROPOSED
AUGMENTATIONS. BUT OUR INITIAL
ASSESSMENT OF THESE INDICATE
THAT THEY ARE PRIMARILY AIMED
TO RESPOND TO THE CODE BUT
NINETEEN CRISIS. TURNING TO THE
NEXT PAGE OF THE HANDOUT. AS I
HAD MENTIONED WE'RE STILL IN
THE VERY EARLY STAGES OF
REVIEWING AND UNDERSTANDING THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL. AND
WE REALLY WOULD NOT HEAR THAT
CASELOAD AND GETTING TO THE
BOTTOM OF HIS LEAD ESTIMATES IS
OF KEY IMPORTANCE- THERE IS AN
UNPRECEDENTED IN ESTIMATED
INCREASE IN IN THE CALYX
PROGRAM IS IMPORTANT FOR US TO
UNDERSTAND AND TO REALLY- GET
TO THE BOTTOM OF THE
METHODOLOGY. BECAUSE IT'S
DEPEND ON THE SIZE OF THAT
INCREASE THAT THAT DETERMINES
THE SIZE OF THE BUDGET PROBLEM
YOU'RE TRYING TO SOLVE FOR AND
WHAT YOU NEED TO SOLVE FOR IT
SO THAT IS OF KEY IMPORTANCE TO
US AND WE ACTUALLY HAD MEETINGS
OF THE ADMINISTRATION EVEN
TODAY ON THAT SO THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT. WE ENCOURAGE
YOU ALSO TO ASK QUESTIONS ABOUT.
YOU KNOW THESE ARE THESE ARE
VERY DIFFICULT DECISIONS AND
NOT ONES THAT YOU THOUGHT YOU
WOULD BE MAKING AT THE TIME OF
THE JANUARY BUDGET- SO WE
THOUGHT WE WOULD TALK ABOUT
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS. WE AS AN
OFFICE ARE ASKING OURSELVES AS
WERE DIGESTING- THESE
PROPOSALS. THE FIRST IS. DOES
THE PROPOSAL WHAT IMPACT AS A
PROPOSAL HAVE ON THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS. AREN'T AREN'T
INDIVIDUALS PERSONAL ECONOMIC
STATUS. AND WHEN POSSIBLE YOU'D
WANT TO LIMIT THE PROPOSALS
THAT WOULD WORK AT CROSS
PURPOSES- WITH ANY OF THE
PANDEMIC RESPONSE EFFORTS THAT
ARE IN PLACE. AND IS THAT IT
THE ADMINISTRATION AND NOT
REDUCING POWER GRANTS THAT
THAT'S THAT'S THE TYPE OF-
PROPOSAL WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
AND WHAT IS THE IMPACT ON
PROGRAM RECIPIENTS SO RATHER
THAN ELIMINATING A PROGRAM IS
THERE A WAY THAT YOU COULD HAVE
A MORE TARGETED REDUCTION. TO
THE PROGRAM AND MAINTAIN ITS
CORE. OF WHAT IS THE LIKELIHOOD
OF ACHIEVING THE SAVINGS AT IS
THERE IS THERE ARE- LIKELIHOOD
OF LITIGATION IS IT POSSIBLE TO
ACHIEVE THE SAVINGS ARE THE
FEDERAL IS THE FEDERAL FUNDING
BEING MAXIMIZES THE KEY
QUESTION ARE WE THINKING ALL
THE FEDERAL FUNDS OUT THERE-
ARE THE REDUCTIONS THAT WE
HAVE. PUT FORWARD- FORFEITING A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF FEDERAL
FUNDING. ANOTHER ANOTHER KEY
QUESTION WE'RE AKING IS
WHETHER OR NOT THAT THERE ARE
ADMINISTRATIVE CHANGES-
EFFICIENCIES THAT COULD BE PUT
FORWARD THAT WAS IT WOULD
RESULT IN AND SAVINGS AS WELL.
I IN THE IN THE MONTHS AND
WEEKS DIRECTLY AFTER THAT IN
MARCH AND APRIL AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY WAS VERY.
PROACTIVE AND PROVIDING
DIFFERENT GUIDANCE AND
DIFFERENT RULES TO ALLOW SOME
FLEXIBILITY AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
AND FOR RECIPIENTS. IS THERE
ANYTHING THAT WE LEARN FROM
THAT THAT COULD HELP STREAMLINE
AND LEVY IT COST PRESSURES AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL. I'M NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE WE'RE
INTERESTED IN EXPLORING- WITH
THAT THAT INCLUDES THAT
CONCLUDES MY- OPENING COMMENTS
AND I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU MISSPELLED
ON NOW I'D LIKE A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION MARCO MEECH.
DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR THE-
PROGRAMIN FISCAL AFFAIRS
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY. TO PLEASE
PROVIDE- THE GOVERNOR'S FRAMING
AND PERSPECTIVE. MR MEECH IS
JOINING US FROM THE WITNESS
VIDEO AROUND. MISTER MEECH
PLEASE BEGAN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
GREAT CAN YOU HEAR ME MISTER
CHAIRMAN YES SIR. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE HI MY NAME IS MARK
I'M EACH AND I AM THE DEPUTY
SECRETARY FOR PROGRAMMING
FISCAL AFFAIRS AT THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE
BEFORE YOU TODAY. I ALSO DO
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT
INTERVIEWS YOU TO THE
COLLEAGUES THAT ARE WITH ME
TODAY I'M JOINED BY KEN JOHNSON
WHO IS THE DIRECTOR OF OUR
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
GEN TRY OF WHO IS THE CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF OUR
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
NANCY BARGE MAN WHO IS THE
DIRECTOR OF OUR DEPARTMENT
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. KARL
ACOSTA YADA WHO'S THE CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL START THE
SERVICES MARK BACK LEAVE WHO IS
THE CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING AS WELL
AS DAVID KILGOUR WHO IS THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES.
ADDITIONALLY ON BEHALF OF THE
ADMINISTRATION I'M JOINED BY
ADAM DORSEY WHO IS REPRESENTING
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I'LL
START BY GIVING YOU A HIGH
LEVEL OVERVIEW AND THEN WE'LL
TURN IT OVER TO ADAM ADD TO
DELVE INTO THE FOR- FOR CASTING
THE FISCAL FORECASTING AND THE
NUANCES. BEHIND THEM A REVISION.
I'LL START BY SAYING FIVE. AGO
WE DELIVER TO YOU ABOUT YOUR
PROPOSAL CLUB LOOK DRASTICALLY
DIFFERENT FROM WHAT WE
PRESENTED TO YOU TODAY. IN
JANUARY ARE BUDGET PROPOSED A
RADICAL SHIFT IN THE STATE'S
INVOLVEMENT TO HOUSE THE MANY
AND SHELTERS PERSONS LIVING. IN
CALIFORNIA BY LAUNCHING THE
CALIFORNIA ACCESS TO HOUSING
AND SERVICES FUND. IN JANUARY
ARE BUDGET PROPOSED TO BUILD ON
MAJOR INVESTMENTS MADE IN THE
LAST FEW YEARS TEXT. TO EXPAND
THE I. T. SEE AN INCREASE CAL
WORKS GRANT BY INCREASING THE
AMOUNT OF CHILD SUPPORT
PAYMENTS RETAIN BY FAMILIES ON
CAL WORKS. IN JANUARY ARE
BUDGET MADE ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS TO CONTINUE THE
MOMENTUM ON AFFORDABILITY AND
COVERAGE ON THAT CALIFORNIA'S
HEALTH CARE DELIVERY SYSTEM.
SPECIFICALLY WE PROPOSED A BOLD
PLANS TO ADDRESS HEALTH CARE
COST TRENDS STRENGTHENED
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC OPTION
LOWER PRESCRIPTION DRUG PRICES
AND CONTINUE PROGRESS TOWARD
UNIVERSAL HEALTH CARE. IN
JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSED THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF A PERFORMANCE
INCENTIVE PROGRAM FOR
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. AND
MINISTER TO REGIONAL CENTERS TO
INCREASE BOTH THE QUALITY OF
SERVICES AND ALSO ADDRESS THE
DISPARITIES AND SERVICES.
HOWEVER TODAY WE FACE A
RADICALLY DIFFERENT REALITY THE
EFFECTS OF THE NOVEL
CORONAVIRUS OR WHAT WE REFER TO
COVER NINETEEN. ARE
UNPRECEDENTED IN MODERN TIMES.
IT'S CALLED ENORMOUS HARDSHIPS
FOR FAMILIES BUSINESSES
GOVERNMENTS AROUND THE WORLD
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES
AND ESPECIALLY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AS A REMINDER
EIGHTY THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
AND THIRTY CALIFORNIANS HAVE
BEEN INFECTED BY THIS VIRUS AND
THREE THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
AND TWO NEIGHBORS OF OURS HAVE
PASSED AWAY FROM THIS VIRUS.
SIMPLY PUT OUR LIFE HAVE
CHANGED AS WE KNOW ROOM. FOR
THE STATE COOPER NINETEEN HAS
SWIFTLY BROUGHT ON AN ECONOMIC
RECESSION AND GROWING DECLINING
TAX REVENUE RAPIDLY RISING
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
CASELOAD AND BILLIONS AN
ADDITIONAL COST TO COMPACT THE
SPREAD OF THIS VIRUS. AS A
RESULT THIS IS A VERY DIFFICULT
MAY REVISION AND SO DIFFERENT
FROM WHERE WE WERE IN JANUARY
AND TO THE ITEMS THAT I ALLUDED
TO IN JUST A MOMENT AGO. IN
TOTALITY THE ADMINISTRATION
APPROACH THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
MAY REVISION BY FIRST
PROTECTING PUBLIC HEALTH.
PUBLIC SAFETY AND PUBLIC
EDUCATION. BY PROVIDING
ASSISTANCE TO SMALL BUSINESSES
AND CALIFORNIA'S MOST HURT BY
THE PANDEMIC AND BY INVESTING
IN SAFE AND- INVESTING IN A
SAFE AND QUICK ECONOMIC
RECOVERING. WHEN WE LOOKED AT
THE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
PROGRAMS AND DEPARTMENTS ARE
APPROACH TO DEVELOPING THEM A
REVISION TO ADDRESS THE UDGET
SHORTFALL WAS GUIDED BY THE
FOLLOWING PRINCIPLES. FIRST WE
WANTED TO PROTECT THE LIABILITY
FOR PROGRAMS SECOND WE LOOK TO
CANCEL OR DEFERRED NEW
INITIATIVES THAT WERE PROPOSED
AS PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET IN JANUARY. AND THE
THIRD WE LOOK TO CANCEL OR DID
REDUCE SPENDING THAT WAS ADDED
TO THE TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET
ACT. IN SHORT AND TO BOTTOM
LINE WE WERE TRYING TO SERVE
MORE PEOPLE WITH LESS SERVICES
JUST TO GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE IN
MEDICAL PROGRAM ALONE. WE'RE
PROJECTING FOURTEEN FOUR POINT
FIVE MILLION BENEFICIARIES
THAT'S UP TO MILLION THAT'S
WHAT WE HAD IN JANUARY. IN OUR
CAL WORKS PROGRAM OUR AVERAGE
MONTHLY CASE MOD IS GROWING BY
ONE HUNDRED AND TWO PERCENT. TO
ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR
THOUSAND CLIENTS. TOGETHER WE
DID FLATTEN THE COVER NINETEEN
CURVE AND SAVE LIVES NOW WE ARE
CONFRONTED WITH THIS THE STEEP
AN UNPRECEDENTED ECONOMICS
CRISIS. WE KNOW THAT BEHIND
EVERY BUDGET CUTS IS A PERSON
OR A FAMILY BEING IMPACTED. AS
THE GOVERNOR HAS NOTED BEFORE
WE HAVE THE TALENT THE DRIVE
THE DIVERSITY AND THE WORK
ETHIC. NOT ONLY TO PRESERVE
BEER BUT TO OVERCOME THESE
UNPRECEDENTED TIMES. WE ARE
STRONG OF WELL AND GENEROUS OF
SPIRIT WE FACED AND FACE DOWN
ON ANTICIPATED DIVERSITY AND
EVERYTIME EMERGE STRONGER THAN
EVER. IT TRULY IS CALIFORNIA
STORY AND IT THIS IS THE BILL
THE LATEST CHAPTER IN THAT
STORY. SO I THANK YOU FOR
GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
PURE BEFORE YOU YOU AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO ANSWERING ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE TO.
THANK YOU MISTER MEET THANK YOU
MISTER BEACH AND NOW I'D LIKE
TO ASK FOR THE REPRESENTATIVE
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ADAM DORSEY WHO IS JOINING US
FROM THE WITNESS VIDEO ROOM TO
PLEASE PROVIDE US WITH ANY
ADDITIONAL FRAMING AND
PERSPECTIVE THAT YOU CAN
REGARDING THE MAY REVISION.
MISTER DORSEY IS THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AS PROGRAM BUDGET
MANAGER FOR THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES MISTER DORSEY
PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THE GROUP ID NINETEEN PANDEMIC
IS CAUSED ENORMOUS HARDSHIP FOR
FAMILIES BUSINESSES AND
GOVERNMENTS ACROSS THE WORLD.
IT IS IN DANGER HELP STRESS THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM AND CAUSED
DEVASTATING LOSSES IN FAMILY
AND BUSINESS AND GO.
CALIFORNIA'S PRUDENT FISCAL
MANAGEMENT INCLUDING IT
STRUCTURALLY BALLOTS BUDGET AND
RECORD RESERVES PUTS IT IN A
MUCH BETTER POSITION THAN OTHER
GOVERNMENTS TO CONTEND WITH
THESE CHALLENGES. HOWEVER THE
EFFECT OF THE KOBE RECESSION ON
THE STATE BUDGET ARE MASSIVE.
SUBSTANTIAL FEDERAL ASSISTANCE
IS ESSENTIAL TO SAFEGUARD CORE
GOVERNMENT FUNCTIONS AS WELL AS
TO SUPPORT A SAFE AND QUICK
ECONOMIC RECOVERY. THE DOUBLE
THE REVISION REALLY ATTEMPTS TO
ADDRESS THESE BUDGET SHORTFALLS.
BUT MAINTAIN A WOULD YOU
BILLION FOR CORE SERVICES. AND
THERE ARE DIFFICULT DECISIONS
WOULD NEED TO BE MADE- BUT THAT
IS THE WAY THAT THIS BUDGET HAS
BEEN STRUCTURED TRY TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUES I. PLAN TO GO INTO
MORE DETAIL ABOUT SOME OF THE
INDIVIDUAL- ITEMS IN THE BUDGET
BUT THIS BILL THAT THE ONLY DID
SUCH A GOOD JOB GOING THROUGH-
A LOT OF THOSE ISSUES THAT- I
THINK I'LL JUST AND MY COMMENTS
THERE AND- HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU MISTER
DORSEY. NOW I WOULD LIKE TO
OPEN IT UP FOR- MEMBERS TO ASK
QUESTIONS OF THIS PANEL BEFORE
WE MOVE ON AND WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN WITH- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO WHO HAS A QUESTION FOR
THE LA L. IF WE CAN GET THIS
BALLOT BACK PLEASE. WHEN YOU'RE
READY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WITH IF
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- I HAVE
A QUESTION REGARDING THE-
FOSTER YOUTH. OR THE CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES I UNDERSTAND
FROM LAST WEEK'S INFORMATION
REGARDING THE BUDGET THAT WE
WERE- RELEASING OR GETTING RID
OF THE JUVENILE HALL- SYSTEM
NOW A LOT OF THESE KIDS ARE
WOULD. PROBABLY AND I DON'T
HAVE THE NUMBER WOULD PROBABLY
BE GO INTO THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM AND ARE GOING TO BE IN A
LOT- AN S. T. R. T. PEAS IN
ORDER TO PROVIDE SERVICES FOR
THEM HOW ARE WE GOING TO ENSURE
THAT FINDING IS- I GUESS
SWITCHED FROM THE JUVENILE
SYSTEM INTO THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM SO THAT THE- IF THEY
HAVE A BIGGER CASELOAD BECAUSE
OF THE JUVENILE SYSTEM BEING.
DISMANTLED THAT THESE KIDS ARE
GETTING THE PROPER- SERVICES I
INSTEAD OF JUST CUTTING THE
BUDGET- WHERE ARE THOSE KIDS
GOING TO GOAL AND HOWEVER ARE
RETAIN IT ARE WE GOING TO
INCREASE THE BUDGET FOR THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM. THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION. I THINK IT'S
A YOU'VE HAD ON ONE OF THE
OTHER CRITERIA THAT WE ARE
THINKING ABOUT WITH EACH OF
THESE PROPOSALS. IS ONE ABOUT
COST SHIFTING AND MAKING SURE
THAT WHEN THERE ARE REDUCTIONS
THAT WE ALSO THINK ABOUT. WHERE
THE SHIFT MAY BE AND WHETHER
THAT'S TO OTHER STATE
DEPARTMENT OR OTHER LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT. SHOULD BE SOMETHING
THAT IS ON OUR MINDS- YOUR
SPECIFIC QUESTION IS NOT ONE
THAT I HAVE AN ANSWER TO YOU
ABOUT AB FROM ON THAT FROM THE
JUVENILE HALL SYSTEM IS
SOMETHING THAT I WILL TAKE BACK
TO MY COLLEAGUES. AND WE WILL
HAVE A DISCUSSION AND I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONBUT
MORE BROADLY. THIS ISSUE OF
COST SHIFTS IS SOMETHING THAT
THAT WE SHOULD ALL BE MINDFUL
OF. THANK YOU I. CAN YOU
PLEASE- PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION AS SOON AS YOU HAVE
IT SO THAT WE CAN HAVE A
FURTHER DISCUSSION ON HOW WE'RE
GOING TO SUPPORT THE FOSTER USE
SYSTEM. NOW THAT- THE JUVENILE
SYSTEM IS GOING TO BE
DISMANTLED. SURE WE WILL GET
BACK TO YOU ON ANY ANY
INFORMATION I CAN I CAN FIND ON
THAT THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AND- FOR THE OTHER MMBERS IN
THE ROOM I DO WAT TO REMIND
YOU THAT IN ADDITION TO THE
THREE. PANELISTS WE HAD PRESENT
MISS BELLA MISTER ME EACH AND
MISTER DORSEY. THERE ALSO ARE
AVAILABLE FOR. US TO ASK
QUESTIONS KIM JOHNSON CHEN
TORIA- DIRECTOR BARGE MEN AS
WELL AS- REPRESENTATIVES FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING AND
DEPARTMENT OF CHILD. SUPPORT
SERVICES. WITH THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO NOW- HANDED OVER TO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER. LEAVE
HAS A QUESTION FOR THE DIRECTOR
OF- DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. LOOKING AT THE NUMBERS
THAT HAVE BEEN SHARED WITH US
IN THE MAY REVISE ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES. WE LOOK AT. IN THE
YEARS PAST ALL OF THE UNFUNDED
PROCESSES THAT WERE THAT WERE
IN PLACE AND THEN THIS LAST
YEAR THE RATE STUDY WAS
PROVIDED. THE SHOW A TWO POINT
TWO BILLION DOLLAR UNDER
FUNDING. OF SERVICES TO THE
POPULATION OR DEFERRED SERVICES
FUNDING. SO HERE WE GO MOVING
FORWARD. LOOKING AT THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS WORTH
OF CUTS. WHAT THE CENSUS
CONTINUES TO GROW BY 2225% OVER
TEN YEARS. OF THE POPULATION.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE ATTRITION
RATE OF MARRIAGE BETWEEN
HUSBAND AND WIFE DUE TO THE- OF
STRAIN. OF UP ADDITIONAL OF
CARE NEEDED FOR THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT HAVE ADD OR SPECIAL NEEDS
WHEN DO WE WHEN WE ASSUME. THAT
TO THE LANHAM ACT THAT THE
STANDARD OF CARE THE SUPPORT
THAT IS DESERVED. OF THE
POPULATION WHOSE YOU KNOW
DEPENDING ON US ONLY US. TO
PROVIDING QUALITY OF LIFE
SUSTAINABILITY AND HOPE FOR ALL
OF THE THINGS THAT WE HOLD DEAR.
AND BUT EVERY TIME THAT WE COME
TO SOME KIND OF SITUATION LIKE
THIS. WE CUT THEM. AND THERE.
THIS JUST SEEMS LIKE WE THAT'S
OUR GO TO. AND I'M LOOKING FOR
ANSWERS. NUMBER ONE. WHERE DO
THE HEALTH PLANS COME IN. WHEN
YOU LOOK AT OUR EIGHT POINT
SOMETHING BILLION DOLLARS THAT
WE FUND TO THE REGIONAL CENTERS.
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THE
OBLIGATION OF HELPING ISN'T IN
THESE INDIVIDUALS. IS HOW MUCH
TO THE HEALTH PLANS HELP US IN
THIS IN THIS POPULATION. AND
SHOULD THEY HAVE TO STEP UP.
BECAUSE IT IS A DUALLY
DIAGNOSED DISABILITY. AND OTHER
FACETS OF HEALTH CARE IT'S FUND.
FULLY BUT YET WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THIS POPULATION WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT WHO HAVE. EXTRAORDINARY
NEEDS OR MEDICALLY FRAGILE. AND
LOOK AT. SOCIETY AS A WHOLE
WHEN WE LOOK AT THEM AND WE
WANT TO CRACK CREATE INCLUSIVE.
TOGETHERNESS WITH THIS
POPULATION NO WE HAVE
UNEMPLOYMENT WHICH IS 83% THE
SPECIALIST POPULATION WHERE DO
WE WHERE DO WE GO I MEAN WHEN
DO WE STOP TECHNOLOGY I MEAN WE
DID IT WITH PROP NINETY EIGHT
WITH EDUCATION WE GAVE A
STANDARD OF FUNDING THAT WAS.
EXPECTED BY THE LEGISLATURE.
AND BY THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
TO FULLY FUND TO PROP NINETY
EIGHT STANDARDS FOR EDUCATION.
WHAT DO WE NEED TO DO. TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS NEED DOES
NOT GO AWAY BUT YEAH IT GROWS.
OVER A PERIOD OF TIME. AND I'M
JUST LOOKING FOR SOME SOLUTIONS
WITH. MY COLLEAGUES HERE ON
THIS COMMITTEE- BECAUSE BECOMES
FRUSTRATING AT A POINT WHERE AS-
WE MAKE SOME GAMES WE DID SOME
SIGNIFICANT GAINS WITH MR TING
LASHER OF FOUR HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
AND THEN WE TAKE TWO STEPS
FORWARD. AND THREE BACK. AND
YOU KNOW I'M SEEING THE THREE
TO FIVE YEAR OLDS ARE NOT
PICKED UP AGAIN. THIS IS THE
MOST INFLUENTIAL. TIME OF THESE
PEOPLE THESE THESE LITTLE GUYS
LIVES THE WHERE THEY CAN BE THE
MOST PRODUCTIVE IN IN THEIR
GAMES. AND I NEED TO KNOW. I
MEAN WHEN YOU LOOK AT ALL THE
THINGS. BROUGHT UP HERE HOW CAN
WE. MAKE A COMMITMENT TO THIS
POPULATION. AND WALK AWAY HERE
FROM THIS. PROCESS KNOWING WE
DID OUR BEST WE DID OUR BEST
FOR THIS POPULATION BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE ANYBODY BUT US.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRAZIER I BELIEVE- AND KNOW
THAT YOU'VE BEEN A LONG TERM
CHAMPION FOR THIS GROUP. AND
WANT YOUR QUESTION TO BE
DIRECTED AT DIRECTOR BARGE MEN
IF SHE'S AVAILABLE. HI. HI THIS
IS NANCY PARCHMENT. PERFECT I.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER FOR
THAT THAT- QUESTION AND THE
CONCERNED FOR OUR POPULATION- I
I'D LIKE TO JUST TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT SOME OF THE
STRATEGIES AND CERTAINLY
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE CHALLENGE
THAT YOU KNOW OUR FAMILIES HAVE
FACED OVER A NUMBER OF YEARS
AND CERTAINLY DURING THE TIME
IN WHICH WE HAD REDUCTIONS IN
PRIOR YEARS AND THE FORTITUDE
OF OUR OUR COMMUNITY REALLY
PULLED TOGETHER BACK IN EIGHT
OH NINE TAKING A LOOK AT HOW WE
CAN REALLY TAKE- THE STRONG
STRATEGY IS RECOGNIZING THE
IMPACT TO OUR COMMUNITY IS ONE
THAT WE DON'T TAKE LIGHTLY- I A
COUPLE OF THINGS THAT I WANT TO
JUST SHARE WITH YOU WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE- THE APPROACH
TO. IDENTIFYING THE COST SAVING
MEASURES THERE'S A NUMBER OF
THINGS THAT WE WANTED TO PUT AS
A PRIORITY AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE WERE VERY SENSITIVE TO AND
MAKING SME OF THE VERY
DIFFICULT DECISIONS- IN LOOKING
AT THE WORK WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE WERE VERY
SENSITIVE TO THE UNDERSERVED
POPULATION AND SO WITH EACH OF
THE STRATEGIES THAT WE ARE
LOOKING AT WE WANTED TO BE
MINDFUL OF THE LOWER. INCOME
FAMILIES THAT MAY BE RECEIVING
IMPACTS FROM AND NEVER NUMBER
OF THE STRATEGIES THAT ARE
HAVING TO BE ADDRESSED IN BEING
RESPONSIVE TO THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS AND THE AFFECTING
RECESSION AND ECONOMIC IMPACT
YOU KNOW IN THAT AREA AND SO
WHAT WHEN WE'RE TAKING A LOOK
AT THE PROPOSALS THAT WE PUT
FORWARD YOU KNOW IN A COST
SHARING WERE IDENTIFYING THE
COST SHARING AND REDUCING THE
IMPACT TO THE LOWER INCOME
FAMILY WELL TAKING A LOOK AT
THAT THE STRATEGIES INTO A KIND
OF THOUGHT. OF IT TAYLOR UP YOU
KNOW YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER
TALKED ABOUT WITH OUR SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND REALLY DATA OVER
THE YEARS ROCKY THE ON. THE
RATE REDUCTION. LOOKING OUT OF.
THAT IS MORE ABOUT- IDENTIFYING
SOMETHING THAT'S NOT ACROSS THE
BOARD BUT USING THAT RATE STUDY
TO HELP INFORM US FOR A PAYMENT
REDUCTION. CERTAINLY WE
RECOGNIZE THAT HAVING TO WORK
WITH OUR STAKEHOLDERS ON
STRATEGIES WHEN WE TAKE A LOOK
AT- THE PAYMENTS. FROM
REDUCTION AT TWO OUT YEARS WHAT
IS THE WORK THAT WE NEED TO DO
TO MAKE SURE THAT WERE WERE
WORKING WITH OUR STAKEHOLDERS
TO IDENTIFY. THOSE STRATEGIES
AS WE DID IN EIGHT OR NINE SO
WHILE CURRENT YEAR WE DO. NEED
TO MAKE A VERY STRONG PROPOSAL
TO MEETING- THE IMMEDIATE NEED.
IN THE ARE BUDGET YOU'RE IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUT REALLY
WANT TO HAVE A FULLY ENGAGE
CONVERSATION WITH OUR COMMUNITY
AS TO WHAT OF THOSE. THOSE
THINGS THAT WE REALLY NEED TO
THINK ABOUT FOR A FUTURE. AS TO
HOW TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT YOU'RE
BRINGING UP- ONE OF THE AREAS
THAT- ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER
THAT YOU HAD TALKED ABOUT WE'VE
HEARD FROM MARK- I NEVER
STAKEHOLDERS TO IS HOW DO WE-
LOOK AT OTHER RESOURCES SO NOT
ONLY AND MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
MAXIMIZING THE FEDERAL.
PARTICIPATION BUT LOOKING AT
THAT GENERIC RESOURCES THAT MAY
BE AVAILABLE IN THIS SERVICE
COORDINATION AND THE- SYSTEM
CORD NATION IF YOU WILL.
BETWEEN OUR OTHER SYSTEMS TO
SUPPORT OUR FAMILIES. I'LL GIVE
YOU A COUPLE OF EXAMPLES SO
WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
FEDERAL FUNDING. YEAH THERE ARE
A NUMBER OF THINGS WE'VE
IDENTIFIED WAYS THAT WE CAN
ENHANCE OUR ADMINISTRATIVE
FEDERAL FUNDING WE'VE
IDENTIFIED WAYS THAT WE WOULD
BE ABLE TO MAXIMIZE. THE
PARTICIPANTS ON ON MEDI CAL
THROUGH INSTITUTIONAL DENEEN
YOU KNOW BUT ALSO TAKING A LOOK
AT HOW DO WE ACCESS TO GENERIC
RESOURCES THROUGH HEALTH PLANS.
LIKELY DURING TRAINING WITH THE
SERVICE COORDINATORS AT THE
REGIONAL CENTER TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY ARE- EQUIPPED WITH
THE TOOLS TO SUPPORT A FAMILY
MEMBER. IN ACCESSING THOSE
RESOURCES BUT ALL THE WHILE
PROVIDING A LEVEL OF A SAFETY
NET- TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE ARE RECEIVING THE
SERVICES THAT THEY NEED. TO
HAVE INSURANCE OF SUPPORTS IN
ADDRESSING- THE NEEDS OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WORDS AS WELL AS
THE EMERGENT NEEDS- RELATED TO
HEALTH AND SAFETY. WE HAVE NOT
ELIMINATED OUR STATUTE THAT
ALLOWS US TO- PROVIDE SOME
HEALTH AND SAFETY- AS FAR AS
ALL OF OUR HEALTH AND SAFETY
WAIVERS THESE ARE THINGS THAT
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE REMAIN AS
A SAFETY NET TO OUR FAMILIES.
YOU KNOW WELL WE DO HAVE SOME
SAID STRATEGIES THAT ARE PUT
FORWARD THAT ARE- CERTAINLY
SENSITIVE- WE DO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WERE ABLE TO BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT THE- INDIVIDUALS
THAT WE SERVE IN THE BEST WAY
THAT WE CANNOT. WITH THOSE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO US- WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
OUR STAKEHOLDER COMMUNITY ARE
SELF ADVOCATES THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS THE OTHER AT OTHER OUT
BECAUSE THAT THAT ARE
PASSIONATELY ADVOCATING FOR
POPULATION AND IDENTIFYING.
WHAT ARE THE THINGS THAT WE MAY
BE ABLE TO DO THAT IS CREATIVE
IN APPROACHING SERVICES. I'M
LEARNED A LOT THROUGH. HOPE
NINETEEN AND ARE SO. TO BE ****
AND INNOVATIVE AND THOSE ARE
THE THINGS THAT WE WANT TO
EXPLORE AND SEE ARE THERE SOME
LONGER TERM STRATEGIES THAT
WILL BE. A BENEFIT TO OUR
SYSTEM- AND CERTAINLY TELE
SERVICE OTHER OPPORTUNITIES AND
THOSE ARE ALL THE THINGS THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE EXPLORED IN THE
COMING WEEKS IN THE COMING
MONTHS- AND LOOK FORWARD TO.
ENGAGE IN CONVERSATIONS WITH
THIS COMMITTEE AS WELL. HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS. ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRAZIER THANK YOU DIRECTOR
MARGIN SO ESSENTIALLY BASED ON
THE OTHER LINE THAT YOU'VE
PROVIDED WHAT DIRECT SERVICES
WILL BE. REMOVED OR NOT
PROVIDED TO THE ID POPULATION
AT THIS POINT THAT THEY WERE
ONCE GETTING. SO THINKING OF
THE AGAIN NANCY PARCHMENT
DIRECTOR DDS- THE SERVICES THAT
THEY WOULD NOT BE RECEIVING
WE'VE NOT ELIMINATED I'M TRYING
TO THINK BACK AND I'LL HAVE TO
CORRECTIVE IF I AM INCORRECT
BUT WE'RE NOT ELIMINATING THE
SERVICE SO WHEN WE TAKE A LOOK
AT HOW WE'RE GOING TO BE-
MOVING FORWARD WITH THE PAYMENT
REDUCTIONS FOR SERVICES IT'S
NOT ELIMINATION OF THE SERVICE-
BUT IT IS A PAYMENT REDUCTION
TO THE SERVICE PROVIDERS
PROVIDING THE SERVICES- WHEN
WE'RE LOOKING AT. REDUCING THE
REGIONAL CENTER OPERATIONS- WE
ARE ADDING IN THE END SOME
FLEXIBILITY FOR THEM IN
MANAGING THEIR CASELOAD AS IT'S
BEEN NOTED THAT WE HAD A GROWTH
IN OUR OUR CASELOAD EACH YEAR-
PRIOR YEAR IT'S BEEN BETWEEN
FIFTEEN TO EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS EACH YEAR- WE DO
HAVE INCLUDED IN. THE I MAY
REVISE THE FUNDING TO GO FOR
THOSE CASELOAD- SUPPORTS AND SO
THE SERVICE COORDINATOR
CASELOAD WOULD STILL BE
SUPPORTED THROUGH THAT WHILE
THEY DO HAVE A- THIRTY MILLION
DOLLAR PROJECTED GENERAL FUND
DECREASE- WE HAVE AS I
INDICATED AND INCLUDED SOME
ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY IS FOR
THEM TO BE ABLE TO PRIORITIZE
AS YOU HAD MENTIONED. THE EARLY
INTERVENTION SIDE OF THE
CHILDREN WHO ARE MOVING FROM
EARLY START INTO SCHOOL AGE SO
THE REGIONAL CENTERS EED TO DO
SOME- MANAGEMENT TO CASELOAD
WAITING SO INCREASING- THE-
SERVICE COORDINATOR TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEIR SERVICE
COORDINATOR RATIOS ARE
RESPONSIVE TO THE YOUNGER KIDS.
REGIONAL CENTERS WOULD HAVE THE
ABILITY TO MATCH THAT AND THEN
IDENTIFY THOSE AREAS IN WHICH
AB ALTERNATIVE APPROACHES TO
SERVICE COORDINATION- MAY BE
APPROPRIATE TO STOP ME. ONE
EXAMPLE THAT IS THAT REGIONAL
CENTERS KANSEN TO DEPARTMENT
AND ALTERNATE CASELOAD RATIO OR
SERVICE COORDINATION. SO IF
THEY SEE THAT THEY HAVE A-
PARTICULAR POPULATION THAT THEY
CAN MAKE PHONE CALLS OR DO
REMOTE SERVICES OVER- A COUPLE
TIMES A YEAR. AND THAT WOULD
MEET THEIR NEEDS THAT WOULD
MEAN THAT A SERVICE COORDINATOR
COULD HAVE A HIGHER CASELOAD
RATIO AS COMPARED TO MAYBE.
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO NEED A
MORE INTENSIVE SUPPORT. SO
THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT- AS FAR AS NOT BEING
ABLE TO GET SERVICES WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
IDENTIFY. YOU KNOW WHAT ARE
GOING TO BE THE GAPS- BY- THE
STRATEGIES THAT WE'RE PUTTING
FORWARD IN PROPOSALS WERE
PUTTING FORWARD- BUT AT THIS
TIME WE'RE NOT IDENTIFIED
ANYTHING THAT IS A SERVICE
THAT'S BEING ELIMINATED. AND
JUST ONE MORE QUESTION. SO WE.
UP TO THIS POINT BEFORE THIS
PANDEMIC WE DID HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH ATTAINING- THROUGH THE
PROVIDERS ENOUGH MANPOWER TO
SERVICE THE POPULATION AND IF
WE DID WAS A HUGE TURN OVER
THERE WAS A CONTEST YOU KNOW WE
HAD- EQUITY PROBLEMS THAT WE
YOU KNOW WE DIDN'T PAY WELL IN
THIS IN THIS YOU KNOW MINIMUM
WAGE WHEN WE HAVE. OF SUCH OF
THE QUALITY OF CARE THAT'S
NEEDED- ALMOST LIKE A- KIND OF
A NURSING ASSISTANT KIND OF
ROLE WITH MEDICALLY FRAGILE AND
ALL OF THE THINGS WE'VE
DISCUSSED- GOING FORWARD. WE
STILL HAVE THAT NECESSITY FOR
WHEN YOU HAVE THE PURCHASE OF
SERVICES THROUGH THE PROVIDER
OF EITHER THE RESPITE
INDIVIDUAL OR OR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH BEHAVIORAL YOU KNOW
HEALTH AND YEAH. HE A NECESSITY
FOR ANYTHING THAT THAT THE
INDIVIDUAL NEEDS TO SUCH A WIDE
VARIETY OF NEEDS. AND YOU KNOW
GOING FORWARD IN TRYING TO GET
A POPULATION OF WORK FOR HER
WALK WORK FORCE THAT CAN
ACTUALLY BE EFFECTIVE. AND NOT
HAVE A TRANSITION- OR TURN OVER
HAS BEEN A PROBLEM GOING FOR
NOW NO WITH THIS. DO YOU
FORESEE. IT BEING PROBLEMATIC
GOING FORWARD ARE WE STEPPING
BACK IN OUR ABILITY TO BE ABLE
TO ATTAIN THIS WORKFORCE OR DO
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO AFFORD
PLANNED TO BE ABLE TO. MAKE
THAT INVESTMENT GOING FORWARD
IN SOME FORM OR FASHION TO BE
ABLE TO ADVANCE THE CARE. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER THAT
WE ARE AND I'M PRESIDENT OF
TIME. SO TO SAY WHAT WE CAN FOR
SEE- I WILL TELL YOU THAT IT IS
GOING TO BE A CHALLENGE TO KNOW
WHAT IT IS THAT. IS GOING TO
CAN BE OUR NEW NORMAL AND I SAY
THAT ONLY BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST
WITH THE- COALBED PUBLIC HEALTH
RECESSION BUT IT ALSO HAS TO DO
WITH HOW ARE WE GOING TO BE
DELIVERING SERVICES SO WE HAVE
TO HAVE A COLLABORATIVE
DISCUSSION AND SAY. YOU KNOW
WHAT IS THIS LOOK LIKE SO EVEN
TRYING TO OPEN UP SERVICES-
POST YOU KNOW THIS THE NEXT FEW%
MONTHS AND THE NEXT. YOU KNOW
ME EVEN WITHIN THE NEXT YEAR SO
IN IN ACCESSING CONGREGATE
SETTING IS GOING TO HAVE TO BE
DONE WITH A LOT OF CARE WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO BE SMART ABOUT
IT AND MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT
PUTTING PEOPLE AT RISK. AND ARE
YOU I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
THINK ABOUT HOW WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO HAVE A CONVERSATION WE
STARTED THIS ALREADY WITH OUR
SERVICE PROVIDERS AND WITH SOME
OF THE REGIONAL CENTERS AND WE
NEED TO DO THIS AS WELL WITH
OUR SELF ADVOCATES. AS WE'RE
LOOKING AT A RESIDENTIAL
SERVICES AND ACCESS SEEN DAY
SERVICES IT'S LIKE YOU KNOW
WHAT ARE THE STEPS IN THE
INDICATORS YOU KNOW SIMILAR TO
YOU KNOW CERTAINLY THOSE THAT
THE SMART WORK IS BEING DONE
FOR THE STATE YOU KNOW HOW TO
WE ALSO BE SENSITIVE TO THOSE
HIGH RISK NEEDS IF YOU WERE
JUST INDICATING. INDIVIDUALS OF
COMPLEX MEDICAL NEEDS AS AN
EXAMPLE YOU KNOW WILL WIN IS
THAT DAY THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
ABLE TO SAY SOMEBODY WHO HAS.
CONGER GET DAY SETTING IT MAY
BE AWHILE SO HOW DO WE CAN TO
REALLY DEFINE THAT SERVICE FOR
THAT INDIVIDUAL AND WE NEED TO
DEAL DEBT THAT ALONG WITH.
CHANGING HOW WE MOVE FORWARD
AND ALSO A ECONOMIC RECESSION
SO. I WISH I HAD IT A REALLY
CLEAR ANSWER THAT'S GOING TO BE
ABLE TO SAY THIS IS EXACTLY HOW
WE'RE GOING TO DO IT THIS IS
WHERE OUR GAPS ARE GOING TO BE
AND THIS IS HOW WE'RE GOING TO
MITIGATE THOSE REST. BUT WE
NEED TO HAVE BEEN ENGAGE
CONVERSATION WITH OUR COMMUNITY
WE NEED TO IDENTIFY THOSE
VALUES AND PRINCIPLES THAT ARE
THE PRIORITY FOR DELIVERING
SERVICES START IDENTIFYING HOW
WE CAN KEEP PEOPLE SAFE AND
THEN START USING YOU KNOW OUR
OUR WORK TOGETHER AS A
COMMUNITY. AND TO WHAT OTHER
STEPS AND THEN WHAT IT DOES THE
ACTIONS THAT WE NEED TO TAKE TO
MAKE SURE WE CAN A PROVIDE
SERVICES AND BE MINIMIZED THE
REST- SO WE HAVE TO WORK
TOGETHER ON THIS I MEAN THERE'S
NO DOUBT IN MY MIND THAT YOU
KNOW WE HAVE THE COMMUNITY
THAT'S GOING TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
THIS HAPPEN- IT'S NOT GOING TO
B DONE WITHOUT. SOME
CHALLENGES OBVIOUSLY AND- WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO HAVE FREQUENT
CONVERSATIONS AND- IMPLEMENT
SOME IMMEDIATE STRATEGIES TO BE
RESPONSIVE TO THE ECONOMIC
RECESSION- BUT AT THE SAME TIME
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
COLLABORATE TO IDENTIFY HOW DO
WE HAVE THAT SAFETY NET. AND
THEN WHAT IS OUR LONGER TERM
STRATEGY. THANK YOU DIRECTOR
BIRDMAN- WE ARE GOING TO NOW
MOVE ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATHIS FOLLOWED BY CHAIR TING.
DIRECTOR BARGE MEN- MY QUESTION
IS IN RELATION WITH THE RATIO
SEVERAL OF OUR OUR PROGRAMS AS
YOU MENTIONED AND AS MR FRAZIER
DIMENSION. IS THERE GOING TO BE
FLEXIBILITY TO MOVE SOME OF
THESE RATIOS SAY FROM A OF. ONE
THREE TO LIKE A ONE FOUR- SO WE
CAN HAVE THE PROVIDERS CAN HAVE
THE ABILITY TO CUT AND SAVE ON
THE BUDGETS BUT YET KEEP
SERVICES AND PROGRAMS RUNNING
IS THAT BEING LOOKED AT AND IS
OUR PROBABILITY OF THAT
HAPPENING. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MATHIS WIT. THE
DIFFERENT STRATEGIES TO HELP
PROVIDE SOME FLEXIBILITY IS
FOR- SERVICE PROVIDERS IN THE
DELIVERY OF THEIR SERVICE IS
DEFINITELY A STRATEGY THAT WE
HAD DISCUSSIONS FOR AND PRIOR
RECESSIONS- AND I THINK THAT IS
CERTAINLY GOING TO BE PART OF
OUR ACTIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
OUR PROVIDERS- WE WILL BE
MEETING WITH OUR DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES TASK FORCE THIS WEEK
TUESDAY IT TO HAVE THE INITIAL
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT DIFFERENT
STRATEGIES. AND I WOULD WELCOME
IDEAS SUCH AS THAT AND OTHERS
TO BE ABLE TO PRIORITIZE TO
HELP THE PROVIDERS BE ABLE TO
NAVIGATE WITH THE CHANGES THAT
ARE COMING FORWARD WITH-
PAYMENT REDUCTION IF ADOPTED
AND IS THAT SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO LOOK AT
AS FAR AS PUTTING THOSE
ADMINISTRATIVE CHANGE LEE WAYS
AND- BUDGET TRAILER BILL OR IS
THAT SOMETHING YOU'RE ABLE TO
HANDLE FROM THE DEPARTMENT
DIRECTLY. YEAH WE WOULD BE MORE
THAN HAPPY THOSE ARE THE
CONVERSATIONS WERE GOING TO
HAVE AND TALKING THROUGH. HOW
WE WILL BE ABLE TO TAKE STEPS
YOU KNOW TO LOOK AT THE SERVICE
DELIVERY WITH THAT WOULD BE
ASSOCIATED SAY WITH THE PAYMENT
pGENERAL. ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
THAT WOULD BE AND HOW USING
TELE SERVICE SO WE'RE GONNA BE
SUBMITTING A I REQUEST AN
APPLICATION- TO OUR WAVERED
AMENDMENT TO OUR- FEDERAL
WAIVER. TO BE ABLE TO EXPAND
TELE SERVICE AND DIFFERENT
STUDY. SO WE'RE GOING TO WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WERE HAVING
THAT CONVERSATION IT WOULD NOT
NECESSARILY HAVE TO BE AN
TRAILER BILL SPECIFICALLY WHILE
THE WEEK THIS PARTICULAR ONE WE
DO HAVE INCLUDED- BUT I AM- AS
WE ALWAYS HAVE BEEN VERY OPEN
TO WORKING WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS AND- IDENTIFYING
THOSE STRATEGIES TO BE ABLE TO-
IMPLEMENTS. POLICY IN THE LAST
UNSAFE SAFEST WAY. YOU. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
WAS OPEN TO ASK LA- A QUESTION
ABOUT THE ON SPREAD SHEET THE
PAGE ONE OF THEIR ANALYSIS. IF
YOU CAN. THE PARTICULAR SHE CAN
WALK THROUGH THE CAL WORKS LINE
ITEM. THIS IS A QUESTION THIS
IS A QUESTION FOR AWHILE.
CERTAINLY CERTAINLY SO WHAT
YOU'RE SEEING HERE IS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ESTIMATE OF
THE CHARACTER GENERAL FUND
PRESSURE. THAT IT WILL
EXPERIENCE IT'S PRIMARILY THE
RESULT OF A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASES IN ESTIMATED CASELOAD
BOTH IN THE CURRENT YEAR IN THE
BUDGET YEAR SO THE CURRENT YEAR
THEY'RE ESTIMATING ABOVE
JANUARY A 10% INCREASE IN THEIR
CASE LOAD. BUT IN IN FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR THEY'RE ESTIMATING
AND OVER A 100% INCREASE
COMPARED TO MAN THE CASELOAD
THAT'S REALLY WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING THE OTHER THING IS THAT
WE ALL HAVE TO KEEP IN MIND
WITH HOW WORKS IS THAT. IT'S
FUNDED BY A COMBINATION OF
FUNDS SO. THE FUNDING YOU SEE
HERE THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PROPOSING TO SPEND. GENERAL
FUND ON IT BUT ALSO ASK THE
MONEY FROM THE- FROM THERE
HUMAN SERVICES RESERVE TO COVER
AT FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION AND ALSO FROM THE CAR
CORONA ROBOT THAT CORRECT CRF
CURRENT NO RELIEF FIND TO FIND
TO COVER THOSE COSTS IN A
CAREER IN THE BUDGET YEAR. BUT
AGAIN IT'S PRIMARILY THE RESULT
OF INCREASED CASELOAD WHICH
THENHAS INCREASES IN
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES AND OTHER-
SERVICES IN THE CALYX PROGRAM.
IN AND JUST TO CLARIFY THAT THE
MONTHLY EXPENDITURE SO FOR MANY
OF. ON NOT FOR. RIGHT OTHER
OTHER AT THEIR ANNUAL ANNUAL
COSTS. ANNUAL OKAY SO THE
SEARCH SO THE Q. MILLIONS YEAH
IT'S ACUMEN OF NUMBER SO MAY IS
A ONE BILLION DOLLARS
CUMULATIVE. THAT'S ALL THAT
THAT'S SHOWING ACTUALLY IS IT'S
SHOWING YOU UP IN TOTAL WHAT IS
THE ADMINISTRATION ESTIMATE
WOULD BE THAT THE GENERAL FUND
COST OF CAL WORKS IN JANUARY
WHICH IS FIVE HUNDRED AND
SIXTEEN MILLION FOR THE WHOLE
YEAR. AND THEN NOW WHAT IS OUR
UPDATED ESTIMATE ANTHONY
REVISION YEAH I SEE OKAY. THANK
YOU FOR THE JANUARY THE MAY
ARMORED ARE REFERENCING THE
REVISIONS IN THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL OKAY. SO THEY'RE NOT
GOING SO HOME THEY'RE PROPOSING
A ALMOST QUADRUPLING OF. CAL
WORKS SO ONE FROM ONE BILLION
TO ALMOST FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
ON THAT OBVIOUSLY PUT
SIGNIFICANT COST PRESSURE ON
EVERYTHING ELSE IN THE HUMAN
SERVICES BUDGET. ON DO YOU DO
YOU FEEL THAT THAT IS FAIRLY
ACCURATE OR THAT TO ME THAT
SEEMS FAIRLY HIGH ESPECIALLY
GIVEN THAT CAL WORKS NOT EVEN
THE EASIEST PROGRAM IN THE
WORLD TO GET ON TO. IT DID
STAND OUT TO US THAT AS A
REMARKABLE INCREASE AGAIN WE'RE
IN THE VERY EARLY STAGES OF
LOOKING AT IT WE HAVE. HAD
DISCUSSIONS WITH WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AND WE ARE LEARNING
MORE- BUT WE DEFINITELY HAVE
MORE QUESTIONS- ESPECIALLY- OR
ONE OF OUR KEY QUESTIONS IS HOW
IT INTERACTS WITH THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE PROGRAM.
AND HOW IF INDIVIDUALS HAVE
RECENTLY LOST EMPLOYMENT WITH
THEY ENTER- THE UNEMPLOYMENT
SYSTEM AT THE SAME TIME AS CAL
WORKS AND IF SO. WITH THAT HOW
WOULD THAT AFFECT THEIR AVERAGE
GRANT SO EVEN IF THEY ARE AND
BOTH PROGRAMS WITH WITH THEIR
COFFEE LAST SO WE HAVE A- YEAH
BUT A NUMBER OF QUESTIONS
RELATED TO THAT ALONG THE SAME
LINES THAT YOU'RE ASKING. SINCE
SOME OF THOSE WE DON'T HAVE
CLARITY WHETHER OR NOT. PEOPLE
WHO ARE UNEMPLOYED BUT GO ON
UNEMPLOYMENT FIRST AND THEN ON
CAL WORKS. AT SOMETHING WE'RE
TRYING TO LOOK INTO AS WELL-
ESTIMATE ASSUMES THAT IT WOULD
BE CONCURRENT ARE NOT. AND A
LACK OF THIRTY IS MORE RELATED
TO JUST NOT HAVING ENOUGH TIME
SINCE THAT THE MAYOR VISION TO
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF IT WITH
THEM BUT WE ARE WORKING WITH
THEM AND THEY- THEY MET WITH US
JUST AS RECENTLY AS TODAY AS
WELL. GREAT SO IF I IF I COULD
SPEAK TO EITHER FINANCE OR-
WHICH OF REPRESENTED FROM THE
MINISTRATION ON THE CAL WORKS
NUMBER. I'M SURE WERE MISTER
DORSEY. WE'LL IS. I'M SORRY SO
SORRY I GUESS THE QUESTION IF
YOU COULD YOU WALK US THROUGH
THE METHODOLOGY ON THE
QUADRUPLE THE IN ALMOST 40%
INCREASE FROM ON THIS FISCAL
YEAR TO NEXT FISCAL YEAR HOW
YOU. ARRIVED AT IT. YEAH ALL
START AND THEN I CAN- HANDED
OFF THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES THAT THIS IS ADAM
DORSEY FINANCE. SO YEAH I MEAN.
WE TRIED TO DO IS TAKE A LOOK
AT HISTORICAL IMPACT OF
UNEMPLOYMENT ON ON CASE LOAD
AND- TRIED AS BEST WE CAN TO
TRY TO APPLY THAT TO TODAY'S
SITUATION- A KNOWLEDGE THAT YOU
KNOW EVERY ESTIMATE IS NOT
GOING TO BE SPOT ON- BUT THIS
IS A VERY VERY DIFFICULT
ENVIRONMENT TO. JUST SORT OF
MAKE THESE PROJECTIONS AND-
THIS IS KIND OF WHERE WE THINK
IT'S GOING TO IT'S GOING TO BE
OVER THE COURSE OF THAT TWENTY
TWENTY ONE FISCAL YEAR. PRETTY
THAT CAN YOU GIVE US. A LITTLE
MORE DETAIL. WHAT WAS WHAT WAS
THE METHODOLOGY YOU WENT TO
REACH THIS BECAUSE- BECAUSE
YOU'RE BASICALLY ASKING US TO
CUT THREE ALMOST THREE BILLION
DOLLARS OUT OF THE- REST THE
BUDGET BECAUSE OF YOUR ESTIMATE.
I THINK THAT'S ONE WAY OF
LOOKING AT IT THE OTHER WAY OF
LOOKING AT IT IS THAT WE'RE
ASKING TO PROVIDE SERVICES TO
THE PEOPLE THAT WE THINK ARE
GONNA COME INTO THE COLLEGE
PROGRAM OVER THE NEXT YEAR
RIGHT. AT WHAT IF I DON'T I'M
NOT MISTER DORSEY. WELL NOW
WOULD BE. AND WE LOCAL THESE
CUTS AND- ALL WE HAVE IS MONEY
IN THE BANK FOR SERVICES WHEN.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE SO MANY
SENIORS WITH MANY FAMILIES NOT
GETTING SERVICES. AND THEN THE
STATE'S GOT MONEY IN THE BANK
WHICH I REALLY DIDN'T. THE
NEEDS OF THEIR NEEDS NEEDED THE
MONEY TO BE HELPING THESE
FAMILIES AND- THESE INDIVIDUALS.
SURE YEAH I TOTALLY UNDERSTAND
THAT CONCERN- WE SHARE IT- AND-
CERTAINLY WILL BE DOING OUR
BEST TO UPDATE THESE
PROJECTIONS AS YOU KNOW AS- YOU
CAN BE FOUND COULD YOU WALK ME
THROUGH HOW YOU GOT TO THE FOR
BILLING. I'M ALL HANDED OVER TO
SOCIAL SERVICES SEE IF THEY'VE
GOTTEN MORE DETAIL. THERE'S A
LOT OF DETAIL. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR TING MRS CHEN TRYING. TO
DECEIVE HI NICE TO SEE YOU AS
WELL- THAT THEY INCREASE THAT
YOU'RE SEEING IS THE RESULT OF
AN INCREASE IN THE CASE CLOSELY
AT FIVE. AND MORE SPECIFICALLY
THE NUMBER OF FAMILIES WHO WE
EXPECT TO BE ACCESSING THE CAL
WORKS PROGRAM. IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE JUMPED FROM TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY PROJECTION OF FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND SLIGHTLY OVER
TWO SEVEN HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND FAMILIES- AND
THAT'S WHAT'S DRIVING THE COST
INCREASE IN THE PROGRAM. WE'RE
LOOKING FOR AN APPLICATION
TRENDS AND ECONOMIC TRENDS AND
UNEMPLOYMENT. AND THEN DRIVING
FORWARD TO THE NUMBER OF
FAMILIES WE EXPECT TO BE COMING
IN THE DOOR AND YOU NEED TO
SERVE. GOD IN APPRECIATE SO
SOLDIERS JUST TO REPEAT WHAT I
THOUGHT WHAT E JUST DID WAS.
ON THE ESTIMATE IS WE HAVE
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED FAMILIES
FORTY THOUSAND FAMILIES AROUND
NOW. POTENTIALLY SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND FAMILIES. ABOUT BIRTH
I GUESS I'M JUST OF TRYING TO
STAY ON THE BUDGET MATH BECAUSE
THAT'S NOT QUITE A DOUBLING BUT
THE BUDGETS A QUADRUPLING SO IS
IT BECAUSE YOU ANTICIPATE MORE.
FAMILIES WITH MOM MANY MORE
CHILDREN OR- I'M NOT SURE I
DIDN'T I HAVE NOT HAD THE ELLIE
OWES CHART PREVIOUSLY TO BE
ABLE TO TRY TO IDENTIFY THAT I
THINK PART OF WHAT COULD BE
COMPLICATING THE PICTURE HERE
AND WE CAN WORK WITH THEM MORE
TO TRY TO IDENTIFY IF THIS IS
THE CASE. IS THAT THE GENERAL
FUND AND HANNAH FUNDS ARE
FAIRLY FUNGIBLE AND SO HOW MUCH
WE- ADJUST THE BUDGET THAT
LOOKS LIKE GENERAL FUND VERSUS
THE WAY THAT WE ARE APPLYING
OUR TANNER FUNDS WHICH ARE. ARE
HISTORICALLY ALSO TRANSFERRED
TO OTHER PROGRAMS AND WE'LL BE
BACK TO SOME EXTENT IN THE
PUBLIC PROGRAMS COULD BE
COMPLICATING A LITTLE BIT THE
PICTURE. SO WE CAN WORK WITH
THEM TO TRY TO CROSS REFERENCE
ALL OF MINE ARE VARIOUS STARTS
AND FIGURE OUT WHAT IS. AN
ACTUAL INCREASE IN WHAT IS A
HOT SHOWING UP THAT WAY. GREAT
AND I THINK I THINK OUR OUR
OBJECT. WE WANNA TRY TO AS I
DEARLY ANTICIPATE CASELOAD AS
POSSIBLE BIRD GIVE GIVE BRING-
A TIME WE HAVE SO MANY FAMILIES
SUFFERING THE SOMEBODY
POPULATIONS ON THIS CHART
GETTING CAUGHT WOULD RATHER NOT
HAVE TO CUT THOSE SERVICES IF
WE DIDN'T HAVE TO SO I KNOW.
THAT NO PROJECTION IS PERFECT
WE ALL WE ALL KNOW THAT- BUT I
THINK WE ALSO WANT TO BE
CAREFUL NOT TO DO ANYTHING- ANY
ANY UNNECESSARY CUTS THAT WE
DON'T HAVE TO BECAUSE OF THAT.
WE UNDERSTAND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRAZIER YES THIS IS THE OHIO-
QUESTION TO THEM SO WE HAVE.
THE ANALYSIS BUT DID THE LA ILL
LOOK AT ANY KIND OF THE COOL
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT COST
SHIFTING. THE COST IS TO LOSE
IT IN. HOSPITALIZATION OR
PEOPLE BEING INSTITUTIONALIZED
BECAUSE OF THE REDUCTION IN
SERVICES WHAT THAT WOULD COST
HIM IN. AND IN RESPONSE TO THIS
AND THEN ALSO YOU KNOW- ONE ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE DIDN'T
RECOGNIZE WAS SEA BASS. ONE OF
THE PROVIDERS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA ALREADY- LEAVING THE
SYSTEM. AND THIS IS GOING TO
BE- TRAVEL AND I BELIEVE THAT
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO BE ABLE AS
ASSERTING IS TALKED ABOUT.
LOOKING AT. PROJECTIONS OF
BEING ABLE TO HAVE A PLAN B.
WHAT IS THE PLAN B. IF THE
PROJECTIONS ARE CORRECT OR OF
COST SHIFTING WASN'T
ACKNOWLEDGED SO. HAS THE LA YOU
LOOK AT THE- END RESULTS OF
COST SHIFTING IF IS SALUTE INST
TO INSTITUTIONALIZING OR
HOSPITALIZATION TECH HAS TO
TAKE PLACE BECAUSE OF
REDUCTIONS OF SERVICES BECAUSE
PEOPLE JUST CAN'T AFFORD TO
PROVIDE IT BASED ON WHAT IS IN
THIS BUDGET. THAT THAT IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE HAD A
CHANCE TO LOOK AT- FOR ALL OF
THESE PROPOSALS AT THIS POINT-
WE'RE STILL TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE UNDERSTAND THE MALL-
BUT I THINK THAT YOUR YOUR
POINT IS A GOOD ONE AND ONE
THAT COMES UP OFTEN IN AND
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
PROGRAMS IS KIND OF. NOT JUST
THINKING ABOUT AT THE SAVINGS
THE IMMEDIATE SAVINGS BUT MAYBE
WHAT WHAT THE POTENTIAL
DOWNSTREAM COSTS COULD BE THOSE
ARE VERY DIFFICULT ESTIMATES TO
MAKE- THEY REQUIRE A LOT OF
ASSUMPTIONS BUT THERE ARE
SOMETHING THAT. WE SHOULD BE
MINDFUL OF- AS AS WERE
EVALUATING THE BUDGET. THANK
YOU AND WITH THAT I SEE NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS I'M GOING TO
BRING IT BACK TO THE CHAIR TO
ASK THE FINAL FEW QUESTIONS.
BUT DO WANT TO THANK THE FELLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS FOR ASKING SUCH
DETAILED QUESTIONS. I JUST WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE MAIN
PURPOSE OF TODAY IS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO. ALLOW US TO HEAR
FROM THEM. BUT BEFORE WE GET TO
THAT I DID WANT TO ASK THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND YOU
MISTER DORSEY IF I COULD. WHICH
OF THE PROPOSED CUTS COULD
POTENTIALLY DEGRADE OUR ABILITY
TO SUCCESSFULLY RECOVER. FROM
THE ECONOMIC RECESSION THAT
WE'RE IN. SO YEAH I MEAN I
THINK THAT'S. I'VE BEEN
IMPORTANT PART OF KIND OF WHAT
WE TRIED TO ACCOMPLISH YOUR BY
MAINTAINING ELIGIBILITY TO
SERVICES SO- BUT THAT THERE IS
NO DOUBT ABOUT IT THAT I'M WE
REALLY NEED ASSISTANCE FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- THE STATE
IS NOT ABLE. TO WHETHER A
RECESSION OF THIS MAGNITUDE
WITHOUT THAT KIND OF
ASSISTANCE- AND CONTINUED OUR
PROGRAMS THE WAY THAT THEY'RE
CURRENTLY STRUCTURED- AND SO-
THAT IS WHY THAT THE STRUCTURE
WAS PUT IN PLACE TO SAY
REGARDLESS OF WHAT HAPPENS WE
WANT TO TRY TO MAINTAIN
ELIGIBILITY FOR SERVICES. AND
THAT IF WE CAN GET ASSISTANCE
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WE
CAN AVOID THAT THE MAJORITY OF
THESE REDUCTIONS AND OF RECOVER
MORE QUICKLY AND THAT'S THE
GOAL AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
ABOUT PLANNING FOR. IF I CAN
MISTER DORSEY AND I DO WANT TO
HEAR FROM MR ME H. REGARDING-
THIS NEXT RESPONSE. BUT HOW DID
THE ADMINISTRATION HELP TO
ASSESS WHICH OF THESE CUTS. MAY
FURTHER PUT PUBLIC HEALTH AT
RISK TO OUR MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS. WELL I THINK WHAT
YOU'LL SEE IS THAT. WE HAVE
TRIED TO CONTINUE INVESTMENTS-
IN IN CERTAIN KEY AREAS AND- SO
FOR EXAMPLE IN OUR- IN OUR USE
OF KERR CORONAVIRUS RELIEF
FUNDS AND SAY AND SAY I'M
SENDING COUNTIES- MONEY THROUGH
THAT PROCESS- BUT CERTAINLY
THERE WERE A NUMBER OF
DECISIONS YOU CAN MAKE WITH
THAT WITH A POT OF MONEY LIKE
THAT THAT GIVEN. THE PANDEMIC
THAT WERE INVOLVED IN A THAT
WAS A KEY TO THE BUDGET
STRUCTURE- AND AGAIN NOT
REDUCING ELIGIBILITY FOR
SERVICES I THINK THAT WAS THESE
ARE SOME KIND OF T. PLACES
WHERE WE TRIED TO MANAGE A VERY
VERY DIFFICULT BUDGET
ENVIRONMENT WITH- PANDEMIC
RESPONSE AND TRYING TO-
PRIORITIZE AS BEST WE COULD
GIVEN THE DIFFICULT
CIRCUMSTANCES AND I'M- HAPPY
THAT. ENDED OVER TO MY AGENCY
CALLED. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
DOCTOR ARAMBULA I MEAN I THINK
THAT YOU KNOW THESE ARE
UNBELIEVABLY DIFFICULT
DECISIONS AT A TIME WHEN WE ARE
ACTIVELY RESPONDING TO A-
WORLDWIDE PANDEMIC IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. OUR GOAL WAS
FIRST AND FOREMOST TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
HAVE- INCOME AND SO AS YOU WILL
SEE THAT IN THE CAL WORKS
PROGRAM IN PARTICULAR WE DID
NOT CUT GRANTS- WE WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE HAD
INCOME. IN ORDER FOR THEM
WHETHER THIS AND THEN THE
SECOND PIECE REALLY TO DOCTOR
MISTER DARCY'S COMMENT. IS THAT
WE DID NOT WANT TO CUT
ELIGIBILITY TO OUR PROGRAMS BUT
RATHER WHAT WE FOCUSED ON IS.
ELIMINATING THOSE PARTICULAR-
INITIATIVES OR EFFORTS THAT WE
HAD PROPOSED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET OR THOSE ITEMS THAT WE
ARE AT PASSED IN THE TWENTY
NINETEEN BUDGET ACT THAT WERE
EITHER NOT FULLY IMPLEMENTED OR
WORK TO BE BE IMPLEMENTED. WE
REDUCED OUR STUFF ALWAYS HERE
TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE WHO
NEED IT CASH ASSISTANCE WERE
ABLE TO GET CASH ASSISTANCE AND
THAT'S WHERE WE FOCUSED OUR
ENERGY IN TERMS OF THIS MAY
REVISION. IF I CAN MR ME
TONIGHT NOW WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
FROM THE PUBLIC REGARDING
PROPOSALS. BUT I DID WANNA WAY
AND MYSELF AS THE CHAIR TO SOME
OF THE PROPOSALS THAT WERE IN
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET THAT DID GET
TAKEN OUT. THAT I DO THINK
WE'LL HAVE DRAMATIC EFFECTS.
THE FAMILY URGENT RESPONSE
SYSTEM IS CRITICAL FOR MANY OF
OUR FAMILIES WHO. ARE SEEKING
SERVICES THAT TWENTY FOUR HOUR
HOTLINE WILL BE NECESSARY AND
WAS QUITE IMPORTANT FOR MANY OF
US TO BE ADVOCATING FOR LAST
YEAR. IN ADDITION THE CAL WORKS
HOME VISITING PROGRAM THAT- IS
SLATED TO BE CAUGHT IS.
CURRENTLY BEING RETROFITTED I
UNDERSTAND. TO ALLOW FOR
TELEVISION FOR THEM TO BE ABLE
TO ACCESS SERVICES. AND WHAT I
THINK THIS IS IMPORTANT IS THAT
OUR CAL WORKS OF FAMILIES
OFTENTIMES. OUR THE FAMILIES.
TO REALLY HELP US TO AVOID TWO
GENERATIONS OF POVERTY. AND
REALLY DO BELIEVE THOSE ARE THE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE CAPTURE
CYCLICAL. SO I STARTED MY
QUESTION IF I COULD REALLY
TAKING MISTER DORSEY WHICH- OF
THE- IN OUR ABILITY. DONALD
TRUMP JOB OF HELPING US TO KEEP
OUR RATES SENSE TO ALLOW OTHERS
TO PARTICIPATE. MY CONCERN. IS
JUST WITH OUR MOST VULNERABLE.
AND I'VE HEARD IT SAID CLEARLY
FROM THIS GOVERNOR AND THIS
ADMINISTRATION. THAT WE ARE A
GOLDEN STATE FOR YOUR GOLDEN
YEARS. AND HAVE CONCERNS THAT
THIS BUDGET AFFECTS OUR MOST
VULNERABLE. AND WHETHER OR NOT
IT'S THE SEA BASS OR MS S. P.
OR THE CUTS TO THE AGE TO
ELDERLY AND DISABLED I HAVE
CONCERNS. THAT OUR ELDERLY ARE
GOING TO BE EXPOSED TO GREATER
RISK DURING THIS PANDEMIC AT A
TIME WHEN THEY NEED US THE
MOST. AND SO JUST WANT TO LEAVE
WITH. YOU A QUESTION WHICH IS
HOW DO WE FEEL FILL. THE GAPS
WITHIN SERVICES IF WE ARE GOING
TO. LISTEN TO THE PROPOSED CUTS
THAT YOU HAVE HOW DO WE MEET
THE NEEDS OF. OUR ELDERS.
TUCKER ARAMBULA- YOU KNOW WE AS
AN ADMINISTRATION HAVE
OBVIOUSLY MADE SIGNIFICANT
STRIDES WITH REGARDS TO-
LOOKING AT THE MOST VULNERABLE
INCLUDING THOSE WHO OLDER
INDIVIDUALS WE HAD A CHOICE AND
NOT CHOICE WAS NOT TO KICK
OLDER PEOPLE OFF OF MEDICAID.
BUT RATHER KEEP PEOPLE ON
MEDICAID AND PERHAPS- LOOK AT
THE OPTIONAL SERVICES THAT ARE
PART OF MEDICAID IN ORDER FOR
US TO ENSURE THAT THEY HAD
HEALTH INSURANCE- SO OUR GOAL
HERE WAS DIFFICULT ARE ARE ARE
CHALLENGE HERE WAS UNBELIEVABLY
DIFFICULT AND NO ONE. IS
UNDERMINING THAT OR AYE
DEBATING THAT WE HAVE SIMILAR-CONCERNS AS YOU DO THE BUDGET
THAT WE HAVE PROPOSED IN
GENERAL WAS VERY DIFFERENT AT
THE SAME TIME. WE YEAH ANIME OF
HOW TO MAKE. OF THIS THIS A
PROPOSED THAT WE LOVE DOING
WITH WHEN THE REST OF THE SITE
YOUR AS WELL AS STAKEHOLDERS
ACROSS THE STATE ON AND THIS
GETTING A- BETTER HOPEFUL YOU
CAN FURTHERING. THE IN OF THESE
ARE PROPOSALS BUT WE TRY TO BE
FOR METHOD AROUND OUR THINKING
WITH SOME OF THESE AND WE HAD A
CHOICE WE COULD EITHER
COMPLETELY TELL SENIORS THAT
THEY ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
MEDICAID THE MOST VULNERABLE OF
MOTORABLE OR WE COULD SAY WE
WILL KEEP YOU ON MEDICAID BUT
CERTAIN SERVICES THAT WE MAY
NOT BE PROVIDED AND THAT'S- GEN.
I WILL HAVE ONE FINAL QUESTION
AND THEN I'M HAPPY FOR US TO
TURN IT INTO A PUBLIC COMMENT
AND I APOLOGIZE FOR. GETTING A
BIT WONKY AND ACTUALLY WANTING
TO ASK A REAL QUESTION THAT I
THINK WILL BENEFIT MY
COMMUNITY. BUT THERE WAS AN
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT WAS MADE BY
THE GOVERNOR REGARDING SENIOR
MEALS FOR. PEOPLE ELDERS. AND
SADLY. NONE OF THE COUNTIES IN
THE ENTIRE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
EIGHT COUNTIES WILL BE
IMPLEMENTING THIS PROGRAM DUE
TO THE WAY IN WHICH WE DESIGN
THE PROGRAM. IN AND SAYING THAT
WE HAD MATCHING FUNDS IN
ADVANCE. AND WHY THAT BECOMES
PROBLEMATIC IS POOR COUNTIES
LIKE MINE HAVE SENIORS WHO ARE
HUNGRY TO. AND WE NEED TO
FIGURE OUT WHEN WE'RE DESIGNING
THESE PROGRAMS HOW WAR HELPING
ALL REGIONS IN ALL PARTS OF OUR
STATE AND SO. JUST WANTED TO
ADD MY ADVOCACY TO THIS THAT I
THINK IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
FOR OUR MOST VULNERABLE. TO
HAVE A SEAT AT THIS TABLE AND
WANTED TO BE ABLE TO ADD MY
VOICE TO THAT DISCUSSION. WITH
THAT- HI WILL CONCLUDE OUR
QUESTIONS HERE ON THIS PANEL.
AND WOULD LIKE TO NOW OPEN IT
UP TO PUBLIC COMMENT. I WANT TO
FIRST START BY THANKING OUR
PANELISTS FOR PARTICIPATING. IN
TODAY'S HEARING. WE COVERED A
LOT IN A SHORT PERIOD TRYING TO
MAKE BEST USE OF OUR TIME. AS
WE DO NAVIGATE A REVISION. AND
AS I MENTIONED AT THE OUTSET OF
THIS HEARING WE WILL BE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE FOR
PUBLIC ON. OUR COLIN NUMBER
TODAY IS ONE EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
TWO EIGHT THREE FOUR THREE
EIGHT. AGAIN PLEASE ONLY TYPE
ONE ZERO ONCE. RE ENTERING
THOSE TWO DIGITS WILL TAKE YOU
OUT OF Q. SO PLEASE AVOID DOING
THAT. AT SOME POINT AN OPERATOR
WILL COME ON TO THE LINE AND
ASK YOU PRIVATELY FOR YOUR NAME
FIRST. SO PLEASE BE PREPARED
WHEN YOU SPEAK WITH THE
OPERATOR AS THIS WILL
FACILITATE WHEN YOU'RE TAPPED
TO SPEAK TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE. I
WOULD LIKE FOR YOU ALL TO
PLEASE KEEP YOUR COMMENTS BRIEF
IN ORDER TO HAVE US. TO OPEN UP
NINETY FROM EVERYONE WOULD.
SOMEONE WHO IS HERE- AT THE
STATE CAPITOL I WOULD LIKE TO
START BY HAVING THEM. HAVE
THEIR PUBLIC COMMENT FIRST.
CHAIRMAN ROBERT CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES SIR- FIRST- OFFER BELATED
HAPPY BIRTHDAY GREETINGS TO YOU
I WILL HAVE MINE IN AUGUST THE
SECOND THING I WILL SAY TO YOU
AND UNFORTUNATELY SINCE THE
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIRMAN TANG
HAS LEFT PLEASE CONVEY TO HIM.
FOR ALL OF THE CHAIR PEOPLE
PLEASE THINK RIGHT NOW I SAID
THIS IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT TO
THE- DONNA TOTALLY OF THE
SACRAMENTO BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
IS YOU GUYS NEED TO THINK THREE
YEARS IN THE FUTURE. AND THEN
TO TWENTY TWENTY HINDSIGHT IS
WHAT IS THE MOST CRITICAL AND
BEST DECISIONS YOU CAN MAKE NOW
TO DAY BECAUSE YOU ARE HAVING
TO MAKE DECISIONS I'M A LITTLE
PUZZLED PUBLICLY WEISS IS WHY
WE HAVE 7% IN PROGRAMS THAT ARE
SOLD VALUABLE BEING- BASICALLY
ELIMINATED OR DELETED. AND OUR
FRUIT EXAMPLE OF HIGHER
EDUCATION WHERE THEY'RE BEING
TOLD 10% CUTS SO MAYBE WE HAVE
A BETTER OF THE 7% CUTS THAT
ARE BEING USED NO I REPRESENT
HERE TODAY SHOWING YOU THE- SHE
WAS THE HUNGER COALITION THAT
YOU HEARD A LOBBYING EFFORT
MADE. THIS FRIDAY KERA
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE MORE THAN A
MILLION PEOPLE BEHIND ME MADE
EFFORTS TO SPEAK TO ALL OF YOU
ABOUT THE THREE MOST CRITICAL
IMPORTANT THINGS AIR ALSO STATE
HE TO YOU ALL OF YOU PLEASE GET
THESE COALITION. AND
COMMISSIONS BUT THE GOVERNOR
HAS RESTARTED BECAUSE THEY ARE
SO VALUABLE SO IMPORTANT. YOU
STILL KEEP TREATING THE MASTER
PLAN ON AGING AS IF IT'S A SUB
ALL COMPONENTS WHEN YOU KNOW
THAT THAT'S GOING TO INCREASE
THE MORE. THAN TEN MILLION
SENIORS. WHAT WITHIN THE DECADE
IF NOT SOONER THAN ACT SO HERE
MY FIRST. CALL TO ORDER IS
PLEASE AS YOU SAY NO THAT
HERE'S A FACE HERE IS PEOPLE I
TRIED THE LAST TIME IN BECAUSE
OF FEEDBACK I THINK ALL YOU
HEARD FOR ME WAS MY NAME. BUT
HERE I AM REPRESENTING
DISABILITY WHICH IS GOT
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE THAT YOU ARE
IMPACTING DIRECTLY. SENIORS
WHICH YOU ARE DIRECTOR OF MORE
THAN A MILLION OF US THAT WE'LL
BE OUT THERE PUSHING WHAT YOU
NEED TO HEAR SEE DO AND I WILL
REPORT BACK TO THEM THIS
THURSDAY AS FAR AS IS DEALING
WITH OUR LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS
AND WHAT WE NEED TO FOCUS ON WE
HIT YOU UP FRIDAY WOULD SAY.
YOU NEED TO GET HEALTH FOCUS
AND WORK ON YOU NEED TO GET
LONG TERM BECAUSE CURRENTLY
RIGHT NOW THOSE ARE COVINA
CENTERS RIGHT NOW HOT SPOTS.
AND LASTLY I THINK YOU'LL
HOPEFULLY ALL OF YOU
LEGISLATORS WILL SUPPORT ON THE
BALLOT IN ENDORSE IT INCREASE
THAT SCHOOLS NEED TO BE
ASSISTANT. THAT COMMUNITIES
NEED TO BE ASSISTANT AND THEY
NEED TO BE SPENT IT THERE IS A
REVENUE SOURCE THERE THAT YOU
SHOULD GENERAL. YOUR LOS
BETWEEN. SEVEN TO FOURTEEN. YOU
NEED TO IN PERSON AND SUB THAT
AGAIN THE CORPORATE. LANDLORDS
THERE HAVE BEEN AND FORTY YEARS
AGO LASTLY I WILL SAY TO YOU IS
ANYTHING I CAN DO PLEASE KNOW
AS I LISTEN TO THE- EMERGENCY
OFFICES EXPLAIN ABOUT THE
CURRENT PROBLEMS YOU NEED TO
ALSO PUSH TESTING. AND YOU NEED
TO ALSO PUSH HOW YOU GET
CALIFORNIA RESTARTED BECAUSE
THE SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS ARE
DYING OFF YOU ALSO HEARD ABOUT
THE RURAL HOSPITALS THEY ARE
ALSO IN SUCH BAD SHAPE. YOU
KNOW YOU ALL OF THESE THINGS
AND SO HERE I AM THE FACE RIGHT
NOW COMING TO YOU IN REMINDING
YOU THAT THIS ARE THE PEOPLE
THAT I TURN SIXTY FIVE. IN
AUGUST. THESE ARE THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE YOUR MOST VULNERABLE
AND BECOMING YOUR BIGGEST YOU
KNOW SINGLE COMPONENT OUT HERE
THAT YOU NEED TO FIGURE OUT THE
BEST WAY TO MAKE CALIFORNIA. I
WOULD LOVE IF WE COULD KILL
THIS PANDEMIC REALLY WOULD LIKE
TO SEE RATHER THAN ALL THE
MONEY THAT'S BEINGMADE OFF OF
IT I WAS GOING TO SHOW UP YOU
HEAR. ABOUT DEALING WITH. WHAT
CALIFORNIA ALSO NEEDS TO DO FOR
EACH AND EVERY OF THE FORTY
MILLION CALIFORNIANS. RIGHT NOW
IS HOW IN THE WORLD YOU GET THE
MASK. AND THE GLOVES. WE'RE IN
JANUARY I COULD CALM FOR A
DOLLAR AT THE DOLLAR STORE. AND
NOW WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
DOLLAR FOR A MASK TO JUST COVER
MARCHERS. YOU KNOW. THAT YOU
NEED TO FIGURE OUT WHETHER IT'S
USING THE PHARMACIES OR WHAT
OTHER HOSPITALS. I GUESS I'M
HAVING A PHONE CALL BUSINESS TO
BE DEBT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR- SYSTEM TO PUBLIC
COMMENT THANK YOU SIR. AND WE
HEARD YOU LOUD AND CLEAR THE
LAST TIME YOU CALLED BUT ARE
HAPPY TO SEE YOU HERE IN PERSON.
WITH THAT OPERATOR DO WE HAVE
OUR FIRST CALLER. WE WILL AND
YOU HAVE OUR FIRST CALL YOU
WILL BE INTRODUCED BY YOUR LINE
NUMBER PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
FOLLOWED BY YOUR COMMENT. BUT
FIRST WE WILL GO ON LINE EIGHTY
SIX. MY NAME IS ANNA JOHNSON
WITH JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES FOR
YOU I THANK YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
ALL THE WORK THAT YOU ARE DOING
DURING THIS VERY DIFFICULT
TIME- WE'RE CALLING IN TODAY
TO. AGAIN REQUEST SUPPORT TO
PREVENT FOSTER YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS- RIGHT NOW DURING
THE COPA NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
YOUNG PEOPLE AN EXTENDED FOSTER
CARE HAVE BEEN LOSING THEIR
JOBS HAVING INCREASED MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS. AND OTHER.
HARDSHIPS THAT WITH EDUCATION
AND THAT APPOINTMENT DURING
THIS TIME AND WE ARE ASKING FOR
SUPPORT FOR THE TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING PROGRAM HOUSING
SUPPLEMENT. I'VE YOU KNOW
HOUSING COSTS HAVE SKYROCKETED
WE ALSO THANK YOU FOR ANY
EFFORT THAT YOU CAN DO TO.
FURTHER PROTECTION FROM
EXECUTIVE ORDER FOR FOSTER
YOUTH PROTECTING THEM FROM
AGING OUT OF CARE DURING THE
PANDEMIC IN THE FOLLOWING
ECONOMIC RECESSION AND
PROTECTING THEM FROM
EXPERIENCING. HOMELESSNESS OR
OTHER NEGATIVE EFFECTS DURING
THE CRIME. REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR WORK TO PROTECT THE
POPULATION FROM FURTHER HARM-
AND FINALLY WE- WE DO
APPRECIATE ANY EFFORTS- DURING
THIS TIME TO. SATISFIED
HOMELESSNESS FUNDING FOR YOUTH
PROGRAMMING SPECIFICALLY MANY
OF THE PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN
FUNDED ARE NOT EVIDENCE FOR
YOUTH AND SUPPORTING THEM AND
THEY AGAIN THEY ARE. SOME OF
THE MOST LIKELY- YOUNG PEOPLE
TO EXPERIENCE. THE LOSS OF JOBS
AND RE ENTRY INTO THE MARKET
LOTS OF EDUCATION AND- BEING AT
RISK OF HOMELESSNESS- THANK YOU
FOR EVERYTHING YOU'RE DOING FOR
THEM DURING THIS TIME. THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT GO TO LINE
SEVENTY FOUR GO AHEAD PLEASE.
MY NAME IS DAN I LEFT IN MY
LOOKING AT DIRECTOR OF CHILD
WELFARE POLICY AND CHILDREN
NOW. EMERGING YOU TO REJECT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED ELIMINATION
OF THE FAMILY YOUR RESPONSE TO
THEM OUR FIRST. I DEFINITELY
NEEDED SERVICE IF THE COURT
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN AND YOUTH
IN FOSTER CARE AND THEIR
CAREGIVERS ALL THE CURRENT
PANDEMIC IS FORCING POLICY
MAKERS MAKE DIFFICULT CHOICES
THE BUDGET IS A STATEMENT OF
OUR VALUES. WE MUST PROTECT THE
CHILDREN AND YOUTH THAT THE
STATE'S RESPONSIBILITY.
CHILDREN AND YOUTH IN FOSTER
CARE ARE RESILIENT BUT THEY
NEED STABLE NURTURING
RELATIONSHIPS THE CARE IN ORDER
TO HEAL FROM THE TRAUMA OF
ABUSE NEGLECT. AND REMOVAL.
LEVINE FOR BY THE ISSUE SELECT
GIVERS THAT THE NEED CHAVEZ ON
FOR. TWENTY FOUR. THE WHITE
HOUSE LINE COUNTY MOBILE WITH.
AND THEY REVISED OF THE ONE BUT
BEFORE I DON'T OF THE BACK OF
ONE OF ONE FOUR THAN EVER. THE
MOVIE NEXT TO LINE NINETY SEVEN.
I'M GOOD AFTERNOON MY NUMBER
ARAMBULA AND MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE THAT THE CAMEL LATER
AT THE WITH ADVOCATE THE- I
WHEN I APPRECIATE THE COMMENT
BUT THE CHAIR- AROUND OUR
CALVET OPENING PROGRAM AND WE
HAVE CHILDREN NOW AND WHILE THE
WHEN I. URGE YOU TO REJECT THE
CUTS TO THEIR HOMEBUILDING
PROGRAM THEY ARE OPERATING AND
DOING VIRTUAL VISIT RIGHT NOW
AND FOR. AND THEN THAT
MEANWHILE KERR BUT KERR AND THE
COW WORK AS WELL AS THE PART OF
PUBLIC HEALTH BY AND HEALTH
PROGRAM WHAT MEETING THE NEED
OF THE ELIGIBLE POPULATION AND
NOW IT'S REALLY NOT THE TIME TO
BE REDUCING. THEIR REGION HI
I'M AND THEN COULD YOU. AND AT.
THEY'RE NOT ONE OF OTHER
CLIENTS. ONE OF THE LARGEST
FAMILY AGENCY. AND THE GET OUT
OF THE CARPET FROM IN A- AND
OUR- THAT ESPECIALLY RATING.
NOW TRIGGERED THAT MOVEMENT AND
RIGHT DIRECTION BUT- YOU KNOW
OUR FRONTLINE. ARE DO THEIR
HARD TO MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR
YOU AND DOCTOR CARE RIGHT NOW.
AND NOW NOT THE TIME TWELVE
THIRTY THE PROGRAM WHEN. EITHER
BANKING NEW TRAUMA AND BEING RE
TRAUMATIZED BY THE DESTRUCTION
FROM THEIR SCHEDULE THEN THE
CHANGE IS NOT BEING ABLE TO.
LEAVE THEIR HOMES THE TIME THAT
WE REALLY. NEEDED TO STOP THE
COURT I'M READY TO RICH. WELL
THANK YOU. I YOU MA'AM. FOR OUR
NEXT QUESTION WE WILL GO TO
LINE EIGHTY FIVE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. AND EIGHTY FIVE IF YOU
COULD PLEASE RE Q. WE OF SEEM
TO HAVE LOST TO THEIR PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. NINE EIGHTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS JULIE MCCORMICK FROM A
CHILDREN'S LAWCENTER WE
REPRESENT OVER THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND YEARS IN FOSTER CARE
IN LOS ANGELES SACRAMENTO AND
PLASTER COUNTY I WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR TAKING THE TIME TO
HEAR THE PUBLIC CONCERNS- IN
REGARDS TO THE MAY REVISION. IT
IS NOW MORE IMPORTANT THAN EVER
TO SUPPORT TO FAMILIES CARING
FOR DEPENDENT CHILDREN THEY ARE
FEELING THE IMPACT OF THIS
CURRENT SITUATION WITHOUT
SUPPORT THIS FUNDING AND
SERVICES WE WILL BEGIN TO SEE
AN UNPRECEDENTED LOTS OF
PLACEMENTS. ADDITIONALLY NON
MINOR DEPENDENTS ARE
EXPERIENCING LOTS OF LOSING
JOBS AND EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES WE NEED TO
SUPPORT THIS POPULATION TO
PREVENT THEM FROM BECOMING
HOMELESS AND HELP THEM SUCCEED.
I ECHO THE COMMENTS OF THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS ANNA JOHNSON
FROM J. MAY SOON JANICE AND-
FROM CHILDREN NOW- AND ASK THAT
THESE CUTS. REALLY LOOKED AT
OUR CHILDREN AND OUR VIEWS AND
FOSTER CARE- IN DESPERATE NEED
CONTINUED SUPPORT AND SERVICE.
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU
MA'AM. YOU WILL NEXT TO LINE
ONE THREE THREE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
JOHN WILL MOVE ON TO LINE ONE
FIVE EIGHT THE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. PLEASE MAKE SURE YOUR
PHONE IS ON MUTED AND A
QUESTION OR MAKE A COMMENT
ABOUT THE. NOTHING WE WILL MOVE
ON TO LINE ONE TWENTY ONE. GO
AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
KAREN MEMBER THE FACILITY
PHANTASM BEHALF OF AT THE IDEA
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR HAVING THE HEARING AND
GIVING THE PUBLIC THE
OPPORTUNITY TO. PARTICIPATE
UNLESS WE KNOW WHAT THAT THESE
DECISIONS ARE ENORMOUSLY
DIFFICULT- BUT WE URGE
COMMITTEE THANK. LATE LARA THE
MISTAKE THAT WE HAVE MADE.
PREVIOUSLY WHEN FACED WITH
SIMILAR ECONOMIC DOWNTURN AND
THAT SOCIAL SERVICES OP
PROGRAMMING STILL HAS NOT
RECOVERED FROM THE CUTS THAT
WERE IMPLEMENTED DURING THE
LAST RECESSION. AS OFTEN
HAPPENS WHEN WE GRAYSON
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN AND CUT THE
PROPOSED MULTIPLE CAUGHT ARE
BORNE BY THE SAME POPULATION-
POOR AND WORKING POOR
INDIVIDUAL ALL. MORE NORMAN AND
CLARENCE PARTICULARLY ABOUT
SOME OF THE PROGRAMMING HOT AND
WANT TO INCREASE THE- TILED
WALL COMES THAT- WE ARE
OBLIGATED TO CARE FOR THE MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATION. AND WHEN
YOU HAVE A GREAT CUTS THAT
AREN'T EVEN ASSOCIATED WITH
TREKKERS BUT ARE JUST STRAIGHT.
CUT SUCH AS THOSE TWO FOR FIRST
AND LA PUB HEALTH NURSE HI PRO.
THAT WOULD MAKE SURE THAT
THAT'S BY POP OF GETTING THE
SUPPORT OF THE NEW. HOW COLD
WET ALLOW FULL THROUGHOUT OUR-
FOR CPR RFA AND THAT FIRST
YOU'RE LOOKING AT CUT UPON CUT.
TO OUR MOST VULNERABLE CHILDREN
AND THIS IS A POPULATION OF
CHILDREN THAT IS IN DESPERATE
NEED OF ALL OF OUR CARE. AND
ATTENTION RIGHT NOW. WE ARE
REALLY BECAUSE OF THE COMMENTS
MADE BY THE LA OUT THAT ANY
CUT. SHOULD BE DONE THROUGH A
LAND- WILL THEY EXACT OF A
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS. CAN BE.
FADING WOULD BE REALIZED. AND
IS THERE A BETTER WAY TO DO IT
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT A PROPOSAL
SUCH AS THE ELIMINATION OF OURS
THE ELIMINATION TO THE LOS
ANGELES ON PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE
PILOT PROGRAM YOU'RE LOOKING AT
LEAVING FEDERAL DOLLARS ON THE
TABLE AND YOU'RE ALSO LOOKING
AT THE POTENTIAL OF NOT BEING
ABLE TO REALIZE. SAVINGS
BECAUSE FOR EXAMPLE WITH THE LA
P. A. TEN PILOTS YOU ARE
LOOKING AT A SITUATION WHERE IF
YOU PROVIDE THESE KIDS WENT UP.
TO PUBLIC HEALTH SERVICES. READ
THE TIMES KIDS NOT IN. THE AND
THE GOAL TO KEEP OUT OF THE IN
THE FIRST. FINALLY I WANTED TO
SPEAK TO A LACK OF FULL FUNDING
FOR THE ANTICIPATED DRAMATIC ON
GOING TO INCREASE THE- WE ARE
ALREADY SEEING. TO ELIGIBILITY
AND WILL CONTINUE TO BE
THROUGHOUT THE CRISIS- WE ARE.
YOU KNOW WORKING ROUND THE
CLOCK BUT WE- 1100% 2100% TRUST
INCREASES TWO APPLICATIONS AND
WE WILL CONTINUE TO BE INCREASE
WITH THE BE OBLIGATION. FELL IT
IS IMPERATIVE THAT WE SPEAK FOR
FUNDING ONGOING FUNDING FOR
THIS PROGRAM AND FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES THAT WE
ARE PROVIDING- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
MA'AM. WE WILL NOW TO LINE ONE
OH NINE GO AHEAD PLEASE. I
WOULD SUGGEST HERE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
COUNTY ASK THE FACT SHEET THAT
THE MERRY VISION PRIORITIZES
MAINTAINING INVESTMENTS FOR
CERTAIN SERVICES THAT ARE
CRITICAL FOR THOSE IN NEED
DURING THIS TIME SUCH AS COPS
RUSSIAN CAO WORKS AND- REALLY
APPRECIATE THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE FOCUSING IN ON SOME
OTHER KEY AREAS. THE SAFETY NET
PROGRAM THE COUNTY THE MINISTER
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE OR UNDER
IMMENSE STRAIN IS KIND OF
GRAPPLE WITH INCREASED SERVICE
DEMAND COUPLED WITH DECREASED
REVENUES EVERYONE PROJECTION BY
MAYOR VISION FOR STARK SHOWING
A ONE POINT SEVEN BILLION
DECLINE IN REVENUES IN THE
CURRENT YEAR. INCLUDING A
NEARLY SEVEN HUNDRED AND BASS
SHORTFALL FOR SOCIAL SERVICES
ACROSS A NINETY ONE IN TWENTY
ELEVEN REALIGNED THE FACT OF
REVENUE DECLINED OF
UNPRECEDENTED AND NEVER
ANTICIPATED TO OCCUR WHEN THE
REALIGNMENTS WERE CONSTRUCTED.
AND IT WILL DEFINITELY HAVE
DEVASTATING IMPACTS TO CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES EXTENDED
FOSTER CARE AND DAHLE
PROTECTIVE SERVICES. EFFECT HOT
BUDGET PARTY IS TO STABILIZE
REALIGNMENT FUNDING TO THE
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY BASE
AMOUNT THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICES. IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE STATE. AT
OUTSIDE THE- BURKE. TO REDUCE
BUT I THAT AND WHAT WE IN PLACE
FACTOR FOR FIRST. ZERO PRESS
FOR TWENTY TWENTY TWO ONE. THE
TWO PRIOR AND LOUISE LANGUAGE
THAT REDUCE INFLATION FACTOR IN
YEARS WERE. REVENUES THIS
CRITICAL RECEPTION PROTECTION
WILL HELP COUNTY BE ABLE TO
MEET. THE FAMILY OBLIGATION
HERE WHEN THE BAD NEWS.
AVAILABLE FOR THE EMILY HAVE
SHARPLY DECLINED. AFTER COUNTY
ADMINISTRATION FUNDING FEEDBACK
REQUESTED ABLUTION QUALITY
SIMPLIFICATION BUT ALIGNING
PERFORMANCE EXPECTATIONS I
MATCHING MINISTRY OF FUNDING
LEVELS. CONTINUOUS CARE TO
REQUEST FUNDING FOR INCREASE
WORKLOAD THE ARE PROCESS OF THE
BY LAW AND DETERMINE BY THE SEA
SURE. FINALLY EFFECTIVE OPPOSED
TO THEM VISION. TO ELIMINATE
FUNDING FOR CALYX. EMPLOYMENT
ELIMINATING THE FAMILY URGENT
RESPONSE SYSTEM AND REDUCE IN
BOTH CHILD OR AGENCY FUNDING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY RIGHT COME. THANK
YOU SIR. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE SIXTY NINE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER NUMBERS WHEN
ASKING ON BEHALF AND HER FAMILY
PARTNERSHIP WE UNDERSTAND THAT
WE ARE FACING UNPRECEDENTED
TIMES RIGHT NOW AND WE DO HAVE
APPRECIATION FOR HOW THE
ADMINISTRATION AND FINANCE HAVE
GONE ABOUT CREATING A BUDGET
THAT DOESN'T CUT DOWN ON
ELIGIBILITY ON PROGRAMS FOR
FAMILIES THAT SO VERY MUCH
NEEDED RIGHT NOW. OVER WITH
THAT WE ARE VERY CONCERNED AND
MUST OPPOSE BE CUT TO CAL WORKS
COME VISITING PROGRAM THAT'S
BEEN PROPOSED WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE CHAIR'S COMMENTS
WE HAVE MADE ALMOST ENTIRELY OF
FULL TO THAT TO TELL HELP
DELIVERY OF OUR SERVICES ON
HOME VISITING AND HAVE
MAINTAINED. AN EXCELLENT
RETENTION RATE WITH MOST OF THE
FAMILIES THAT WE WORK WITH
PUTTING REALLY DOUBT COMES ON
THAT SO KNOWING THAT BE HAVE
MAINTAINED CONTACT WITH FAMILY.
IN A LOT OF ANY IN A LOT OF IT
MAKING IT THROUGH THIS RIGHT
NOW HAS BEEN REALLY GOOD FOR US
pFOR AND IN THE SPIRIT OF
MORALITY AND HAVING LEARNED.
FROM WHAT WE- HAD TO DO NOT
THAT LONG AGO IN THE LAST
RECESSION. AND APPRECIATE ALL
THE WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING-RIGHT NOW THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM. WE'LL MOVE ON TO LINE
ONE LINE FIFTY FIVE. HI HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES MA'AM.
HELLO YES MA'AM HI HI- DOCTOR
ARAMBULA AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CHRISTINA
BONTA CHANNEL TEN I AM HERE-
COMMENTING ON BEHALF OF YOU W.
UNITED DOMESTIC WORKERS WE
REPRESENT. ALMOST A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THOUSAND AYE HFS
PROVIDERS IN TWENTY ONE
COUNTIES WE SUBMITTED OUR
COMMENTS TO THE COMMITTEE
YESTERDAY WE ADAMANTLY OPPOSED
ALL OF THE PROPOSAL RELATING TO
AYE AGE AT THAT. AND MOST OF
THE PROPOSAL THAT TARGET
FIFTEEN YEAR AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES POPULATION- VIS A
LOT OF THESE PROPOSALS ACTUALLY
CONTRADICT HE PUBLIC HEALTH
GOALS OF THE STATE- THERE IN
THE MAY REVISED IS TARGETING
PROGRAMS THAT ACTUALLY KEEP. IN
YEARS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND THEIR HOME
RATHER D. VAN BE PLACED AT THE
HOSPITAL THE NURSING HOMES
WHERE THE RATE OF DEATH AS YOU
WERE IN LITTLE FROM THE COLD IS
SO EXTRAORDINARILY HIGH. THAT.
ALL WHAT THINK WE MAKE IT
EASIER PEOPLE GO TO NURSING
HOME RATHER THAN THEM OUT OF
NURSING. WE ALSO ARE- OPPOSING
IN GENERAL THE CONCEPT AND THE
NAY REVISION WHICH IS THAT MOST
OF THESE. PROPOSALS FOR
REDUCTIONS ARE GOING TO BE
BORNE BY WORKING FAMILIES POOR
PEOPLE CHILDREN ARE MOST
VULNERABLE THERE IS NOT A FAIR
DISTRIBUTION OF PAIN IN THIS
MAY REVISION WITH YOUR NOT THE
PROPOSAL. BETTER ATTEMPTING TO
HAVE- REVENUE OBTAINED FROM THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE MAKING THE MOST
AMOUNT OF MONEY RIGHT NOW. WE
KNOW THAT BILLION IN WELL HAVE
BEEN ACQUIRED SINCE MARCH BY
CERTAIN COMPANIES AND PEOPLE
WHO ARE BENEFITING. THE BANKS
IS SPECIALLY IN TERMS OF BEING-
CHARGE FOR ALL THE MALL BANK OF
BUSINESS LOANS THAT WERE-
PROCURE TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THERE IS A LOT OF
WELL. BEING GENERATED FROM THIS
PANDEMIC AND NONE OF IT IS
BEING TAPPED. TO ACCOUNT FOR
THE LOSS OF REVENUE AND
THEREFORE WHAT IS HAPPENING IS
BEING NEGATIVE IMPACT IS BEING
BORN. ONLY BY MIDDLE AND
WORKING CLASS AND POOR PEOPLE
AND THAT IS COMPLETELY
UNACCEPTABLE WE ARE ASKING THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE LEGISLATURE
TO PLEASE PUSH BACK. AT THEIR
HAPPY PAIN FELT BY EVERYONE NOT
JUST THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE THE
LEAST AMOUNT OF BOYS AND
ABILITY TO PUSH BACK. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU MA'AM.
WILL OPEN LINE ONE SIXTY EIGHT
GO AHEAD PLEASE. HELLO I'M
WRITING CLEAR RAMSEY I AM AN
ATTORNEY WITH JUSTICE IN AGING
AND WE HAVE MADE A GREAT
COMMENT TO THE ASSEMBLY THIS
MORNING. BUT I JUST WANNA
HIGHLIGHT- AND SIMILAR TO WHAT
ARE CRISTINA COMMITTEE W. JUST
SPOKE ABOUT THE ABSOLUTE PAIN
THAT'S GOING TO BE BORNE BY
OLDER ADULTS WITHIN THIS
BUDGET. AND HOW STRONGLY WE
WANT TO. PUSH THIS COMMITTEE TO
REJECT THOSE- CUTS TO OLDER
ADULTS AND PEOPLE DISABILITIES-
WE HAVE REAL FEARS THAT AND I
THINK THIS IS ONLY GOING TO BE
TRUE IS THAT PEOPLE WHO LOSE
THEIR SEE DOCTOR WITH IS THERE
AN F. P. GET I JUST AFTERNOON.
AND HAVE LESS ACCESS TO
MEDICARE ALL OR GOING TO BE
MORE LIKELY TO BE HOSPITALIZED
TO GET SIX TO GET INJURED AND
TO GO INTO NURSING HOMES AND WE
KNOW THAT NURSING HOME DASH.
ARE COUNTING FOR AT LEAST 40%
OF THE DATA IN THE ENTIRE
STATE. AND I DON'T THINK THE
BUDGET SHOULD. BE BORN ON THE
BACK OF OUR OLDER ADULTS AND
PUTTING THEIR HEALTH AND WELL
BEING AT RISK AND SO WE ARE
URGING YOU TO REJECT CUTS WERE.
YOU TO IS IT'S REYES RENDON
REVENUE FIND THE CUT SOMEWHERE
ELSE BUT DO NOT MAKE THE MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATION TO KOBE
ALSO THE POPULATION THAT. IS
GOING TO SUFFER THE MOST. CUT
THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT LINE
THIRTY SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
SO CALLED LONDON ON BEHALF OF
THE ALLIANCE SUPPORTING PEOPLE
WITH INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENT
DISABILITIES DON'T START BY
THINKING MANY OF YOU WHO TOOK
THE TIME TO SIGN UP TO BE A
PART OF OUR WORK WITH ME FOR A
DATE THAT WAS PUT ASIDE BECAUSE
OF THE NINETEEN. CRISIS WILL
TRY TO THAT UP A WITH PEOPLE I
SEE WHAT. ACTUALLY HAPPENS IN
PEOPLE'S LIVES EVERY DAY. I
DON'T THINK MISTER FREEZE YOUR
MISTER MATHIS KICKER FOR. HIS
IT CONCERNS THAT HAVE ABOUT.
THIS ME REVISED PROPOSAL THESE
ARE PRETTY DEVASTATING CUTS AS
YOUR SAID MANY OF THE SYSTEM
THAT'S ALREADY FOUND TO BE ONE
POINT EIGHT BILLION BEHIND TO
COME IN WITH ANOTHER THREE
HUNDRED MILLION ON TOP OF THAT
IS PRETTY TRICKY. A COUPLE OF
THINGS I'D LIKE TO RAISE WILL
PUT OTHER THINGS IN OF IN
WRITTEN FORM BUT THANKS FOR YOU
TO CONSIDER- THE DIRECTOR
TALKED ABOUT HAVING JUST GO TO
THE TASK FORCE FOR DISCUSSION-
I WOULDN'T. TO WATER ACCESS TO
ALL VOICES IN THIS PROCESS SO
THAT- COULD NOT JUST LIMITED TO
THE SAME VOICE HEARD OVER AND
OVER AGAIN- SEKALI ONE ECHO THE
COMMENTS ABOUT RATIO
FLEXIBILITY WE REALIZE THAT
WE'RE PROBABLY GOING TO HAVE TO
TAKE ON CUTS THIS YEAR BUT
GIVING THE SYSTEM SOME
FLEXIBILITY ON A TEMPORARY
BASIS AND HOW IT MEET THE
DEMANDS MIGHT ACTUALLY DO
EXACTLY WHAT HE COULD COME. IN
THE- IN OFFICIAL WAY TO ALL OF
US WHERE WE SIT IN THE SYSTEM
TODAY WERE HAVING TROUBLE
FINDING PEOPLE ACTUALLY COME
WORK IN THE SYSTEM. TO BE ABLE
TO ALLOW PROGRAMS TO FLOAT
LIGHTLY ON A VERY TEMPORARY
BASIS. IN THE SIZE OF THE
NUMBERS OF PEOPE THEY CAN
HANDLE A ONE TIME MIGHT. BE A
VERY GOOD MOVE- ALSO I THINK- I
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO LOOK
VERY SERIOUSLY. AT THE PROSPECT
OF ASKING FOR SOME KIND OF
TEMPORARY AGAIN TEMPORARY WORK
FOR. SOMEBODY EACH CBS
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE BEING
ROLLED OUT BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. EVERY ONE OF THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE
CONVENIENT EACH CBS GUIDELINES
THAT ARE COMING DOWN. WHY MORE
COPLEY PROGRAMS IN THE SERVICE.
WHILE WE'RE IN THIS CRISIS IF
THE STATE COULD GET THE
TEMPORARY WAIVER FROM SOME OF
THOSE REQUIREMENTS WELL IT'S
NOT PREFERRED. IT WOULD ALLOW
US THE BETTER WAY TO HANDLE
SOME OF THE COST NEEDS. OF THE
POPULATION WERE SERVING AND
JUST COMPLETELY LOSE PROGRAMS.
LASTLY THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S SCHEME TO YOU A
COUPLE YEARS BACK. WITH A- BIRD
THAT DESCRIBE. SAVINGS THE BILL
WILL RESULT IN THE SYSTEM FROM
THE CLOSURE OF THE REMAINING
TWO DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS IN
THE SYSTEM. MY UNDERSTANDING
NOW IS THE POPULATIONS ARE IN
FACT OUT OF THOSE TWO.
FACILITIES FAIRVIEW IN COSTA
MESA AND THE CINNAMON
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER. AND WE
BELIEVE IT'S TIME TO LOOK AT
AND ACCOUNT FOR SOME OF THE
SAVINGS. THAT SHOULD BE
RESULTING ANNUALLY AD INFINITUM
FROM THAT IF THERE'S A WAY TO
SCORE SOME OF THOSE SAVINGS
THIS YEAR INTO THE SYSTEM. AS
PART OF THE MONEY THAT WE CAN
USE TO OFFSET OUR NEED TO COME
FORTH WITH CUTS WE WOULD REALLY
WELCOME THAT OPPORTUNITY I'LL
LEAVE IT AT THAT BUT WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
AND APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
COM AT. THANK YOU SIR. SIX WE
WILL OPEN UP LINE ONE SEVEN
ZERO GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN ARAMBULA AND
MEMBERS THIS IS JENNIFER
APPEARING ON BEHALF OF MEALS ON
WHEELS CALIFORNIA. WHICH
REPRESENTS MORE THAN FIFTY
LOCAL AGENCIES SERVING OVER
EIGHTEEN MILLION MEALS A YEAR
ACROSS CALIFORNIA PRE CODED. WE
URGENTLY EMPORIA TO REJECT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S MAY REVISED
PROPOSAL TO CUT SENIOR
NUTRITION PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA BY EIGHT POINTFIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. WHILE WE
CERTAINLY RECOGNIZE THE FISCAL
CHALLENGES FACING OUR STATE AS
A RESULT OF THE PANDEMIC WE
HOPE YOU'LL AGREE THAT THE
NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES OF
CUTTING SENIOR NUTRITION
SERVICES ESPECIALLY DURING THE
PANDEMIC BUT FAR OUTWEIGH ANY
SAVINGS TO THE STATE BUDGET.
AND PENETRATION PROVIDERS HAS
INCREASE TREMENDOUSLY AND IT'S
DEFINITELY OUTPACING OUR
CAPACITY. A REDUCTION IN OUR
RESOURCES WHAT CAUGHT THE
PROFOUND REDUCTION I ABILITY TO
INCREASE SERVICES THE
CALIFORNIA BORDER DOLE TO OUR
NEWLY HOME BOUNDED OR MEDICAL
CONDITIONS AND ON TEXT LIMITED
INCOMES. SENIOR POVERTY AND
HUNGER HAD BEEN DEEPLY
TROUBLING COMMITTEE ISSUED IN
CALIFORNIA BEFORE THE CRISIS
NOW THESE ISSUES ARE EMERGING
AS MAJOR CRISES. CUTTING KIND
ACTUAL TOOLS LIKE SENIOR
NUTRITION PROGRAM DURING THIS
TIME WOULD BE A TERRIBLE AND
TRAGIC MISTAKE. PLEASE REJECTED
PROPOSED CUTS TO BADLY NEEDED
RESOURCES TO FEED CALIFORNIA
SENIORS. YOU THANK YOU MA'AM.
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE THREE
SEVEN GO AHEAD PLEASE. KELLY
BROKE ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN
COUNTIES A CALIFORNIA AND THE
ROLE COUNTY- REPRESENTED OF THE
CALIFORNIA- I WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT FOR YOU SOMETHING
THAT'S NOT CLEARLY ARTICULATED
IN THE ME THAT MAY REVISED
DOCUMENT WHICH IS HOW THE
CLADDING REAL RELY NOT REVENUES
ARE GOING TO IMPACT- HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES PROGRAMS BUT-
THE LEGISLATURE CARES ABOUT-
REALIGNMENT WITH STRUCTURED. ON
MODELS FROM PREVIOUS RECESSIONS
BUT INCLUDED GRADUAL REDUCTIONS
AND REVENUES NOT A CLIFF LIKE
WE'RE EXPERIENCING WITH
REALIGNMENT REVENUES THIS YEAR-
I WOULD REMIND THE COMMITTEE
THAT SENSE TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
COUNTIES HAVE A 100% SURE OF
COSTS. FOR PROGRAMS LIKE CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INCLUDING ON
THE MEDI CAL PROGRAM. WE ARE
NOW EXPERIENCING OUR FIRST
RECESSIONS AND- TWENTY YEAR
ELEVEN REALIGNMENT WAS-
FRAMEWORK- AND WE DO ANTICIPATE
REDUCTION TO LOCAL PROGRAMS
BECAUSE OF THESE REVENUE TO.
THE CLIENT WHICH WILL IMPACT
THE PROGRAM'S ARE BANKS ARE
VOLATILE AND CHILDREN. AND
PARTNERSHIP THE LEGISLATURE IN
ADMINISTRATION I LEAVE TO SHORE
UP FUNDING- FOR REALIGNMENT
PROGRAM- SIMILAR TO WHAT-
DETECT TALKED ABOUT PREVIOUSLY.
AND SECOND I'D LIKE TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE TRIGGER
CUTS. I WOULD REMIND THE
COMMITTEE THAT IN TWO THOUSAND
AND NINE THE- STATE BUDGET-
WITH STRUCTURED ON RECEIVING.
TEN BILLION DOLLARS IN
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL REVENUE BY A
DATE CERTAIN- AND I THINK
QUESTIONS FOR YOU ALL TO
CONTEMPLATE IS THE REVENUE
TARGET REASONABLE. AND THE CUT.
ALL OR NOTHING SO IF THE STATE
GET. FORTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
REVENUE BUT IT DOESN'T GET IT
BY THE DATE CERTAIN. DOES NOT
MEAN ALL OF THE CUTS GO INTO A
FACT- WHICH IS PRESUMABLY HOW
THE PROPOSAL IS STRUCTURED- BUT
IF YOU GET THIRTEEN BILLION I'M
NOT FOURTEEN BILLION ARE YOU
STILL CUTTING FOURTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE PROGRAM- THE
PRESS REPORTS OVER THE WEEKEND
ROBERT IS PESSIMISTIC ABOUT
FEDERAL- FUNDS COMING. WITHIN
THE STATE'S TIMELINE AROUND A
TO LIFE- FIRST IMPLEMENTATION
DATE OF CUTS- ON A PARTICULAR
CONCERN TO COUNTIES I WOULD
MENTION THE CUP THE CHILD
SUPPORT. AND HOW THAT RELATES
TO CHILD POVERTY I WOULD ALSO
RIGHT REFERENCE THAT CAL WORK-
SUBSIDIZED EMPLOYMENT CUTS. AND
THE RELATIONSHIP TO
UNEMPLOYMENT RATES- WE'VE I
KNOW MR MIKE HAD TALKED TO THE
COMMITTEE ABOUT. THIS
PARTICULAR PROGRAMMING A LOW
RISK WAY FOR EMPLOYERS TO ADD
EMPLOYEES DURING ECONOMIC POUND
DOWNTURN I JUST WANT TO
EMPHASIZE BECOMING IT ARE DOING
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO FEDERAL
LEVEL. TO GET MUCH FUNDING OF
POSSIBLE WE REALIZE THAT AS A
LUNCH AND STATE BUDGET. AND FOR
ARE A EVENING. TO PROVIDE A-
KEY THING PROGRAM A THIRD OF
THE PARTY. AMONG. DURING WHAT
HE WHAT FILE. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK. THANK TAX
WILL GO TO IN THIRTY SEVEN. BUT.
WORKING WELL I CAN'T MY
DAUGHTER. BUT. THAT'S WHAT.
WHILE. NATURAL I. ALL AT RIGHT.
YEAH WHAT ABOUT WRITERS BUT- I
HAVE. NOT. RIGHT. OKAY YEAH
MISSION. MARK THANK AT WHAT
YOUR FAMILY MEMBER. BOX YOUR
LEVEL CARE. I CAN'T WAIT. WHAT
HAPPENED MANY. FOR EACH AND
EVERYONE. THANK THANK YOU YOUR
CAR. THANK YOU. MOVED OUT TO
LINE ONE BECAUSE PLEASE. HI MY
NAME KARIM JANET'S THE CARE
GIVER TO A ONE HUNDRED YEAR OLD
MOTHER PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE I AM
ALSO THE CURRENT CHAIR OF THE
NATIONAL ADULT DAY SERVICES
ASSOCIATION AND THE E. L. AN
ORGANIZATION THAT THERE'S FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY HE BACKED
FRAIL ELDERLY AND- ADULTS WITH
DISABILITIES. SO I AM HERE TO
IMPLORE YOU TO REJECT THE
ELIMINATION OF THE BATH AND
MATHIS P. I DEPEND ON YOU AFTER
TO ASK THESE QUESTIONS OF
YOURSELF AND ANSWER THEM FOR
ME. WHY AND IT'S CENTRO THIRD.
AND IDENTIFY SENIOR THAT THE
MOST PHONE POPULATIONS THAT
NEED TO BE FAIR. YET TURN
AROUND AND ELIMINATE THE
PROGRAM FOR THIRTY SEVEN
THOUSAND OF SUCH SENIORS AND
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES. TO
WHY WOULD YOU ATTEMPT TO SAVE
ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS BY
ELIMINATING THIS PROGRAM WHEN
IN FACT IT WILL COST TO STATE A
LOSS OF TWO HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
MATCH- IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
AND WHY WOULD YOU DO THIS
ELIMINATION CLASS COSTS THE
STATE EVEN MORE LAND WITHOUT AT
THE FOLKS WILL BE FLOODING TO
THE ER TO ACUTE CARE ADMISSIONS
AND TO SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES WHICH HAS. BECOME A
CENTRAL. I WOULD THE STATE
ATTEMPT TO ACT TAKE. THE IS
WITH. ILLEGAL BASED ON A
LAWSUIT THAT OVERTURNED THE
PREVIOUS ELIMINATION IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN PLEASE REFER TO
DARLING FIRST WITH DOUGLAS. WHY
OUR SEA BASS AND THAT'S THAT'S
P. THE ONLY PROGRAMS IN THE
BUDGET HE FIGHTS ONE PATH TO
PAROLE THE PROGRAM AND THE
PUBLIC HEALTH LA PILOT. PH AND
PROGRAM SLATED FOR TOTAL
ELIMINATION NOT CUT BUT TOTAL
ELIMINATION AND FINALLY IS THE
ONLY TRIGGER TO REMOVE THIS
PROPOSAL IS. BASED ON. FEDERAL
LEACH WHAT ABOUT THE MORAL
TRIGGER THE PRODUCT THAT THAT
PROTECT RATHER THAN DESTROY THE
LIFELINE FOR THIRTY SEVEN
THOUSAND FRAIL SENIORS AND
PERSONS WITH A DISABILITY. WE
DEPEND ON YOU TO ANSWER THESE
QUESTIONS AND NOT JUST THE
FISCAL MANNER BUT IN A MORAL
MANNER. PLEASE REJECT THE
ELIMINATION. THANK YOU MA'AM
AND JUST FOR THE PUBLIC THERE
ARE CURRENTLY SEVENTY SEVEN
MORE PEOPLE WHO ARE IN Q. WE
WILL CONTINUE TO TAKE CALLS
UNTIL ARE HARD TO STOP TIME-
THIS EVENING AND- OPERATOR IF
WE CAN HAVE OUR NEXT CALLER. I
WILL BE HOME LINE SEVENTY THREE
GO AHEAD PLEASE. HELLO MY NAME
IS WILLIAM MARIE I MEAN I NEED
TO TRACK HOME CARE PROVIDER
FROM PLASTER COUNTY. I CAN FROM
MY SON HIS FORTY FIVE YEARS OLD
AND THE ARTIST IN. I GET THAT
ALLOW MY SON TO SHARE. OUR BE
CARED FOR AT HOME MY WIFE BUT I
HAVE TO SPEND OUR LIVES
RECHARGE ONTO. AND RESEARCHING
WAYS THAT WE CAN GIVE OUR STAND
THE BEST THE MOST LOVING THE
MOST PERSONAL CARE POSSIBLE.
WITHOUT THE POOL I JUST GOT
HOURS EVERY DEBATE NEEDS TO
LIVE SAFELY AT HOME MANY
CALIFORNIANS LIKE MY SON WILL
BE FORCED INTO INSTITUTIONAL
CARE. THIS IS. BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC. IT HAD TO BE BUILT A
LONG TERM CARE FACILITIES HAS
BECOME THE MOST DANGEROUS PLACE
IN AMERICA. I JUST CLIENTS NEED
ALL THEIR HOURS TO LIVE AT HOME
EVERY AMERICAN DESERVES THE
RIGHT TO LIVE AT HOME. PLEASE
OPPOSE THE 7% CUT TO I GET
THAT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WE'LL MOVE NOW TO LINE NINETY
SIX GO AHEAD PLEASE YOU. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TODAY MY NAME IS
KRISTEN HIM IN NINETY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR ADULT BAKER
BERMAN SAID. I JUST WANTED TO
SAY THAT I KNOW YOU'RE
SUBCOMMITTEE AT ITS MEETING
TOMORROW ON FEET YES BUDGET.
AND THAT WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK YOU CAN ON
THE ISSUES RELATED TO THE
MEDICARE PROGRAM. BUT I ALSO
WANTED TO TAKE A MINUTE DURING
THE HUMAN SERVICES HEARING. TO
EXPRESS THAT WE DO NOT SUPPORT
GOVERNOR NEW SOME OLD BALK. AT
IN THE NAY REVISION TO
ELIMINATE THE ADULT DAY HEALTH
CARE ABOUT THE PROGRAM. BY THE
END OF THE YEAR. THE REASON I'M
MENTIONING AS THIS AT THE
HEARING TODAY IS BECAUSE AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE COLD BIT
NINETEEN. PANDEMIC GOVERNOR
ANYTHING DEEMED OUR PROGRAM AND
ESSENTIAL SERVICE BECAUSE IT
PROTECTS THE VERY PEOPLE WHO
ARE AT LOW RISK SOME COVERT
NINETEEN. TO THEIR. AGE AND
UNDERLYING HEALTH CONDITION. HE
ISSUED MARK NIGHT THE- OR- OUR
MEMBERS THAT OUR LEADERS. HAS
BEEN WORKING VERY COOL. BUT THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING IN AT A
RAPID DESIGN AND CONTINUED
SERVICE FIRST HE BASS
PARTICIPANT. DURING THE
TEMPORARY ALTERNATIVE SERVICES
MODEL WHICH WE REFER TO AS
PASSED. WITHOUT THIS CAST MODEL
THAT WE WERE ABLE TO DEVELOP IN
TANDEM WITH OUR PARTNERS. IN
RECORD TIME I MIGHT ADD. WE
WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO CARE. FOR I PROVIDE
THEM HELLO SURVEY. VIRTUAL
THROUGH DELIVERY FOR THE BACK
DISTRIBUTION AND CARE
COORDINATION. OUR SERVICES OF
NOT ONLY HELPS TO KEEP OUR
PARTICIPANTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
THEY FROM CO THAT NINETEEN. BUT
OUR SERVICES HAVE ALSO HELPED
MAINTAIN OUR PARTICIPANTS
HEALTH STATUS. AN ADDITIONAL
STRESS TO THE ISOLATION AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY REDUCE THE
POTENTIAL FOR PREMATURE
INSTITUTIONALIZATION. WE
WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
PIVOT SO QUICKLY AT THE BILL
FULLY WITHOUT OUR STATE AND
MANAGED CARE PARTNERS WHO HAVE
WORKED SIDE BY SIDE WITH US
OVER THE PAST TWO MONTHS. OR
PROTECT THE TENTH AND THEIR
FAMILIES DURING THIS
EXTRAORDINARY TIME. IF THE
ELIMINATION OF THIS PROGRAM IF
IT IS APPROVED WE KNOW THAT
IT'LL CREATE AN EVEN LARGER
BUDGET DEFICIT THAN THE
PROJECTED SAVINGS OF ONE POINT
SIX MILLION DOLLARS. IF THIS
PROPOSAL ISN'T REJECTED THIRTY
SIX THOUSAND FEET LAST
PARTICIPANTS COULD LOSE THEIR
SAFETY NET WHICH WOULD THEN
SHIFT HIGHER COST TO OTHER
PARTS OF OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM.
INCREASED HOSPITALIZATION
EMERGENCY ROOM VISITS AND A
FORESEEABLE THIRD AND ECONOMIC
MISSION. WITH REASONS WE URGE
THE SUBCOMMITTEE TO REJECT A
PROPOSAL TO ELIMINATE THE VERY
SPECIAL AND ONE OF A KIND
PROGRAM. WE ALSO URGE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE TO REJECT A
PROPOSAL TO ELIMINATE THE AND
THE TEST P. PROGRAM AND WE ALSO
OPPOSE THE DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES ROVIDER RATE
REDUCTION. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU FOR YOUR SPOT
ON COMMENTS AND IF I CAN ASK
YOU TO SAY HELLO TO YOUR
HUSBAND. MY FAVORITE. IN THIS.
THANK YOU. THE NEXT OPEN LINE
ONE THREE ONE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
LOU IF BURKE HERE FOR THE
JEWISH PUBLIC AFFAIRS COMMITTEE
TO URGE YOU TO REJECT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ON EMESIS
HE AND SEE BASS ELIMINATING
THESE PROGRAMS WILL NOT SAVE
THE STATE MONEY THEY WILL OST
THE STATE'S SUBSTANTIALLY MORE
BY THESE PEOPLE WINDING UP IN
LONG TERM CARE FACILITIES AND
PUT THEM AT RISK OF COVERT
NINETEEN IN A MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT AND DANGEROUS
ENVIRONMENT FOR THOSE REASONS
WE URGE YOU TO REJECT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. THANK YOU.
A LITTLE LINE EIGHTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AND YOUR GROUP
REPRESENTING THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION- WHILE WE
UNDERSTAND THE NEED TO BALANCE
THE GIGANTIC FIFTY FOUR BILLION
DOLLAR DEFICIT- THE CUTS BEING
PROPOSED THE I. H. AT THAT. THE
RESOURCE CENTERS DEPARTMENT
AGING I'M A S. P. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY THE ELIMINATION OF
THE BATH WILL HAVE LASTING HARM
WILL CREATE LASTING HARM ON
THOUSAND LIVING WITH DEMENTIA-
PUT NEW PRESSURE ON LOW INCOME
FAMILIES OVERWHELMED FIELD
NURSING FACILITIES INCREASE E.
R. USAGEAND THE MANY PEOPLE
LIVING WITH THE DISEASE.
ABSOLUTELY NO CARE OPTION. THE
FACT WILL REDUCE OF AND
ACCELERATE THE PROGRESSION OF
DEMENTIA FOR MANY PEOPLE WE
OFFER THE ASSEMBLY REJECTED
CUTS AND NOT SACRIFICE THE
LIVES OF OLDER CALIFORNIANS TO
BALANCE THE BUDGET. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WE WILL ALIGN ONE
THIRTY SIX. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARAMBULA AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I'M GREG WILSON
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE CHILD
FOR DIRECTIONS SO SHE SHOULDN'T
WE GREATLY APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN THIS CHALLENGING
TIME. WE ARE ALSO VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE PROPOSED
CUTS TO LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT
FUNDING THE ECONOMIC AND
ECONOMIC IMPACT OF THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC ARE
TRANSLATINGINTO HIGH
UNEMPLOYMENT AND EXPECTED
INCREASES TO SAFETY THAT
CASELOADS SOME OF WHICH ARE
REFERRED TO CHILD SUPPORT
PRIOR PRIOR YEAR LOCAL CHILD
FOR FUNDING WAS ALREADY
INADEQUATE FUNDING CUTS NOW
WILL TRANSLATE TO MANY ELVIA
THERE. NOT BEING ABLE TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF THE CURRENT CASE.
MUCH LESS ANY INFLICT OF
ADDITIONAL CASES. AS ONE
EXAMPLE THE CAPACITY OF LTO
SAVES TO ASSIST WITH REVIEWS AN
ADJUSTMENT FOR NEWLY UNEMPLOYED
PARENTS. WILL BE NEGATIVELY AND
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED. CHILD
SUPPORT PAYMENTS ARE A CRITICAL
PART OF EFFORTS TO FIGHT
POVERTY AND PROMOTE FAMILY SELF
SUFFICIENCY NOW MORE THAN EVER
THEY ARE CRUCIAL TO FAMILY
SURVIVING THIS ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN. WE WOULD URGE LOCAL
TIED FOR FUNDING THE RESTORED
TO THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
TWENTY LEVELS I THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
COMMENT. THANK YOU SIR. YEAH
LINE EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS DOCTOR BACK A
LITTLE AFTER TEN AM ON POVERTY
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES JESSICA.
GREAT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
I AM I WILL BE REFINED TO A
COUPLE OF THE ISSUES AND MY
COLLEAGUE MIKE CARROLL WILL BE
AT REPLYING TO SOME OF THE
OTHER ISSUES RAIN AND TODAY'S
HEARING. FIRST I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THE COLOR HOLDEN PROGRAM
AND YOU KNOW WE WORK CLOSELY
WITH YOU MISTER CHAIR- TO HELP
ESTABLISH IT'S REALLY ESSENTIAL
PROGRAMS. THAT HELP. CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES. ACHIEVE THE BEST
THEY CAN PREVENT THE HARM OF
TRAUMA INCLUDING. HOLOCAUST
BACK HUNGER AND- POVERTY AND AS
YOU MAY HAVE SEEN THE HUNGER
NUMBERS. ARE CURRENTLY FOR
SINGLE PARENTS IS UP TO FORTY
PERCENT. IN THE HOUSEHOLD FOR
THE ADULTS- SO WE KNOW THAT THE
FAMILIES ARE EXPERIENCING A
GREAT DEAL OF STRESS AND THAT
HOME VISITING. IT IS COME AT IT
IT'S BUILT TO HELP THEM THROUGH
THE EXTRA. AND AS YOU MENTIONED
IN THE HEARING PREVIOUSLY- AND
HAS BEEN DETAILED BY PRIOR
TESTIMONY. THESE PROGRAMS ARE
ADJUSTING TO THE STATE HOME
ORDERS AND PROVIDING ASSISTANCE
TO THE TELEPHONE AND INTERNET.
COMMUNICATION AND INCLUDING HOW
THE FAMILY TO GET CONNECTED TO
GO SERVICES- UNTIL WE JUST WANT
TO RECOGNIZE THAT THESE ARE
IMPORTANT PROGRAM WE'RE
GRATEFUL THE CURRENT PROGRAM
WASN'T THERE ARE NOW AND HELP
THAT. AND THEY CAN BE ADVOCATE
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE AS A TOOL
TO PREVENT HARM. TO CHILDREN
DURING THIS TIME. TO ADDRESS
THE CHILD SERVICES AND A PATH
THROUGH BEING REMOVE AS A
POTENTIAL SOLUTION TO POVERTY.
AGAIN WE WERE GRATEFUL TO FEED
THE PROPOSAL THAT CALIFORNIA
JOIN THE MULTIPLE OTHER STATES
THAT PASSED THROUGH THE MAXIMUM
ALLOWED AMOUNT ALLOWED. ONE
HUNDRED FOR OUR FIRST CHILD TWO
HUNDRED FOR THE SECOND OR MORE
CHILDREN IN THE CHILD SUPPORT
PASSED- TOOK OUR FAMILY- ARE
THE AMOUNT WE CURRENTLY. PASSED
THROUGH THE FAMILY THAT YOU
KNOW IT'S FIFTY DOLLARS THAT'S
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER OR NOT
THE NON CUSTODIAL. PARENT HAS
PAID FIFTY DOLLARS A HUNDRED
DOLLARS TWO HUNDRED THREE
HUNDRED- THE GOVERNMENT RETAINS
ALL BUT THE FIFTY DOLLARS. I AM
IN THE CURRENT CONTEXT THE
AMOUNT OF THE CALL THE DOLLAR
THAT. THAT ARE BEING GIVEN
THROUGH TAX IN US DOES CALL THE
AMBULANCE DOLLARS ARE BEING
RETAINED- IN WHEN A PARENT. IS
ON CAL WORK AND THOSE FAMILIES
ARE GETTING SIMPLY THE FIFTY
DOLLAR PASSED THROUGH SO- IN
THIS SITUATION ABOUT WITH
REGARD TO THE TALK. YOU AND THE
FUNDING FOR THE CAT THE POOR
AGENCIES ONE THING WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE AN IS THAT IN AN
ACCOUNTING OF HOW MUCH OF THE
TAX DOLLARS- THAT WERE
INTERCEPTED. AND GIVEN TO THE
STATE COUNTY AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AT WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE THOSE NUMBERS AS WELL AND
REQUEST THAT THAT BE PART OF
THIS LIKE A CONVERSATION LOOK
REGARD TO ELIMINATING. WE HAD
MADE A COMMENT WITH REGARD TO A
PANDEMIC RELATED PROGRAM
CHANGES. IN A LETTER THAT WE
SUBMITTED OER THE WEEKEND TO-
COMMITTEE STAFF AND TO THE
GOVERNOR AND IN THEIR WE
IDENTIFIED THAT THE ELIMINATION
OF THE WE'D LIKE TO SEE AN
ELIMINATION OF OVERPAYMENT AND
OVER INSURANCE. COLLECTION
DURING THE PANDEMIC- AND THERE
IS A GREAT A GREAT DEAL OF
PROGRAM MOVEMENT RIGHT NOW BOTH
PEOPLE APPLYING THE WAY THEY
APPLY THE WAY PUT CASES ARE
PROCESS. WHETHER OR NOT A
REPORT IS NEEDED OR DELAYED- AT
AT I CAN'T REMEMBER IN OVER
TWENTY YEARS FOR THE ANTI-
POVERTY ORGANIZING. SO MUCH
CHANGE AND HOW. ARE WORKING AND
RICK AND- WITH THE CASE WORKERS
AND THE CLIENT. ABOUT
APPLICANTS AND RECIPIENTS AND
WE KNOW THAT THIS IS IT ADULT
SO MANY OF THE CHANGES ARE VERY
GOOD THEY'RE ALSO- CHANGES
HAPPENING AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
AND WHAT COUNTS AS- INCOME AND
WHAT DOES IT- AND THIS
CONFUSION WE BELIEVE WILL LEAD
TO- A HIGH NUMBER OF
OVERPAYMENT AND OVER A SHE WENT
TO. IN THE COW OR CAN CALPERS
PROGRAM THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
HAS ASKED FOR SOME RELIEF FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WITH
REGARD OVER IF. THERE'S AN
ACCOUNT PRESS PROGRAM- SO WE
HAVE NOT RECEIVED- APPROVAL FOR
THAT RELEASE. WE WOULD LIKE
THERE TO BE A CONVERSATION AND
THE BUDGET CONTACT ABOUT HOW TO
MAKE SURE THAT. ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE TENDON IF WE DON'T
END UP WITH A WHOLE BUNCH OF
PEOPLE- GOING OVER INSURANCE
IS. NEVER PAYMENT I'M KIND.
SOMETIMES DUE TO A- THAT'S A
GOOD NATURE. ERROR ON THE
CLIENTS OR OUTLOOK. BEHALF OR
THE CASE. I AND SO LIKE TO
ENSURE THAT INTO THE
CONVERSATION. WITH REGARD TO
THE CALPERS PROGRAM. WE AND BY
THE WAY AS I MOVE AWAY FROM THE
CAO WORKS PROGRAM JUST TO KNOW
THAT MY COLLEAGUE IS GOING TO
HIGHLIGHT- OUR GRATITUDE TO-
YOU KNOW TO THE ADMINISTRATION
FOR REINFORCING THE IMPORTANCE
OF THAT THEY CAO WORKS GRANTS
AND THAT WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
STAY THE COURSE TO REDUCE AND
IN FACT AND THE CHILD COULD BE
POVERTY- BY NOT REDUCE IN A
GRAND INTO THEIR BUDGET. MOVING
ON TO NUTRITION- MY COLLEAGUE
MIKE IT'S GOING TO TALK ABOUT
THAT CAN BE AND THAT THE SSI-
HOUSEHOLDS AND THEIR NUTRITION
BENEFITS. WELL THERE WAS A
PROPOSAL- AS WE SAW INCOME
PROPOSED TRAILER BILL TWO
ACROSS. A REDUCTION IN THE
CALTRANS. OR PUSHING OUT THE
TIMELINE TO MAKE IMPROVEMENTS
TO CALPERS RESTAURANT NO
PROGRAM. THIS PROGRAM IS A
PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES- ACCESS
TO A PREPARED MEALS FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE ELDERLY DISABLED OR
HOMELAND. IT ONLY DOES SO
HOWEVER IN ABOUT ELEVEN COUNTY
ACROSS THE STATE AND RECENT
LEGISLATION HAS BEEN PASSED
AUTHORED BY DR- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DR SHIRLEY WEBER. AND SUPPORTED
BY PARTISAN LEE AND UNANIMOUSLY
IN THE SENATE ASSEMBLY- TO
EXPAND. THIS PROGRAM ACROSS THE
STATE. TO BETTER SERVE PEOPLE-
WITH SAFE FOOD AN ADEQUATE WAY
AND- THANKS SO SEAT WORK THINGS
HEALTH SAVINGS BANK PROPOSED BY
THE ADMINISTRATION. TO PUSH OUT
THAT TIME LINE AND THIS IS
REALLY TOO BAD IT'S AT A TIME
WHEN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
BOTH REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS
ARE MAKER. ARE LOOKING AT THE
REST PROGRAM AS A WAY TO
RESPOND EXCERPTED PREPARATION
NEEDS DURING THE PANDEMIC. AND
ALSO TO BONTA THINK. THE
INCREDIBLE LOSS. OF INCOME AND
JOBS AMONG RESTAURANT WORKERS-
ADD THAT BEING SAID HOWEVER.
DEAD COW FRESH TEAM AND THE EBT
UNIT OVER AT THE S. S. AND THE
OPPOSITE THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
GRAYSON HAVE BEEN HEROES.
THEY'VE GOTTEN MORE THAN. MORE
THAN A AND A HALF DOLLARS SO.
OF THE- NUTRITION OUT THE DOOR.
WHEN YOU TALK TO A POLICY MAY
CAN BE EIGHT REFER TO OUR
PROGRAM- AS AS A KIND OF
LEADERS IN THE FIELD- WE IT
THEY FIGURE IF WE CAN DO IT
ANYBODY ELSE CAN- ARE NOT
EVERYBODY ELSE CAN BUT IF WE
CAN'T DO IT AND NOBODY ELSE. SO
WE TRY INSIDE IF THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES IS SAYING
THAT THEY AT THIS POINT CAN'
SPLIT THE FLEX AND MAKE THAT
RESTAURANT NO PROGRAMS BE. A
STATEWIDE- PROGRAM. WE TRUST
THEIR INSTINCTS AND THE VERY
DISAPPOINTED- AND HOPEFUL THAT
IT'S NOT A FULL YEAR PUSH OUT-
WE OUT WE WILL FOLLOW THEIR
LEAD AND THEY ARE DOING THEY
ARE. THEY ARE MOVING NOW AND-
AND THEN FINALLY WITH REGARD TO
THE CHARACTER A MAN- WE PUT IN
OUR LETTER TO THE NOTE THAT
WE'D LIKE TO SEE. AND WE PUT. I
HOW. THE POOR CALIFORNIANS MANY
TIMES THOSE THAT DON'T HAVE A
BANK ACCOUNT THEY HAVEN'T FILED
TAXES THEY DON'T RECEIVE
BENEFITS THAT WOULD HAVE
ENTITLED IN PROGRESS PAYMENT.
IN THAT CARE TAX STIMULUS OR
FUTURE TAX CANNULA YOU MIGHT
WERE ALL IN SUPPORT OF THE
HEROES BACK NOT ONLY BECAUSE
THEY PROVIDE. ADDITIONAL FISCAL
RELIEF FOR LOCAL AND STATE
GOVERNMENT BUT ALSO BECAUSE IT
PROVIDES ADDITIONAL NUTRITION
FUNDING AND DIRECT CASH WITH
THE THINK THE PEOPLE. WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR YOU PUT SOME
EFFORT FORWARD TO MAKE SURE
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS ELIGIBLE
FOR THIS ENTITLED- STIMULUS
PAYMENT. RECEIVE IT AND- WITH
THAT WILL GO AHEAD AND CLOSE
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
HEARING AND- AND FOR ALL THAT
YOU HAVE BEEN AND WILL BE DOING
IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF WEEKS.
OUR BUDGET- PREPARED FOR
SIGNATURE. YEAH THANK YOU MISS
BIRTH OF. LINE TWENTY ONE YOU
ARE NOW ALL BUT. YES MY NAME IS
ADAM GREEN I AM NOT I AGES SO
CARE PROVIDER I WOULD ALWAYS
GET NAM BACKROOM ARM ALSO
UNITED DOMESTIC WORKER. OUR
HERO. YEAH ARE YOU AT RIGHT NOW
I AM VERY CONCERNED WHAT THE 7%
CUT. I WILL TELL YOU HOW HARSH
IT WOULD REALLY MAKE ISSUES I
WOULD ACTUALLY MY CELL BE
FORCED TO GO ON TO OUR HOME.
ALL BECAUSE I JUST DON'T MAKE
MUCH TAKE CARE OF MYSELF
WITHOUT MY RECIPIENT YEAH ALSO
IT WOULD PUT HER IN JEOPARDY-
WHAT HER. CARE IS WALL NO HOME
THAT WE KNOW RIGHT NOW IS NOT A
SAFE PLACE TO BE. WHY ARE YOU
DO THAT TO YOU FOLKS AND IT HAS
NOT BEEN TALKED ABOUT. ONCE
YOU'RE THERE WAS BROUGHT UP.
ABOUT THREE NUMBER EIGHT
RECEIVING A 25% TAX PAYMENTS.
RAMOS THROUGH THE USE OF THE
CURRENT ISSUE WE KNOW THAT'S A
BETTER ACT I AGAIN WAS THAT BMB
RECENTLY DO YOU MIND REVENUE
WISE SINCE THEY'RE STILL TAKEN
THAT TWENTY FIVE DOLLAR JACK
MUCH. WHY NOT LOOK INTO THE
BILLIONS IT'S PROBABLY ALREADY
MADE. AS A FORM OF OP SAID IN
THIS BUDGET AND HELPING YOU OUT
SO WHAT DOES NOT PUT US IN A
HARD FOUGHT YEAH I DON'T HAVE
TO WORRY EVERY SINGLE DAY FOR
MYSELF OR MY ROOMMATE. AS WELL
AS ALSO HAVING TO SAY I DO
OPPOSE THE 7% CUT. THANK YOU
MUCH GOD BLESS I DON'T HAVE
HARD DECISIONS. TO MAKE ON THIS
I WISH YOU ALL WELL. THANK YOU
SIR. NEXT WILL ALIGN NINETY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. LET ME
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M
GOING TO JUMP ON THE DIRECTOR
FOR THE MULTI PURPOSE CANISTER
WITH PROGRAM IF YOU RECORD YOUR
NASTY I SERVE THE LAKE AND THE
YOU KNOW COUNTIES WHICH IS ONE
OF. THIRTY EIGHT O'CLOCK THE
STATE. WE ARE WE ARE TOLD ME
ACTUALLY LIMITED. OKAY TO YOUR
SERVICES FOR HELP YOU MUCH
LOCAL HOME HERE LATE IF YOU
KNOW COUNTY WHAT ABOUT EIGHTY
THREE THOUSAND FIVE FIFTY
DOLLARS. PER YEAR. WE CALL.
FIVE THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY SIX DOLLARS- QUIET PER
YEAR. IT COST MORE
INSTITUTIONALIZED ONE THAT
WOULD COST TO TAKE CARE TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY WHY IN THEIR
OWN HOMES USING AND THE PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW I LIKE HOW HE ACTUALLY
ARE MOSTLY WHAT. WITH MEDICAL
CERTIFICATE AS THE CASE IN MANY
AREAS WHERE THERE IS AN AND
THAT HE THOUGHT. HOLD BY AND
YOU SHOOT POINTED OUT THE
DISPARITY IN HEALTH SERVICES
AVAILABILITY IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND STATE. ALL RIGHT SIR. HE.
YEAH THE AND THREE YEAH. I WILL.
OKAY IN YOUR HOME STATISTICS
ALL THEY. YOU MUST NOT
ELIMINATE AT THAT. WHAT A FOUR
YEAR OLD WHAT WHAT WHAT. NO
OTHER PROGRAMS THE STATE
PROVIDES SERVICE IN THE THAT HE
GOT TO LOW INCOME. OLDER ADULTS
WE EVEN BETTER CAL AND AT WE'RE
BUT HOME PLATE. IF THERE WERE
IN THAT THAT BE YOU MIGHT NOT
ELIMINATED THEM THE BEST. IT IS
YET BOB MORE. NOR ECONOMICALLY
SOUND. OVER THERE. ALLOW YOUR
COMPETE. I YOU SO MUCH WILL.
THANK YOU MA'AM. BY ONE FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NUMBER THREE
TAKING OUR CALL MY NAME IS
KIMBERLY I WORK AT THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF UNITED
LATIN AMERICAN CITIZENS AND
REPRESENT IMMIGRANT CONTENTION
I'M CALLING TO SUPPORT THE DUE
PROCESS IN DETENTION PROGRAM
BECAUSE NO FAMILY DESERVES TO
BE SEPARATED DURING A PANDEMIC
THE TENSION IS NOT A DEATH
SENTENCE FOR IMMIGRANTS. WE
NEED A STATEWIDE EFFORT TO
THREE PEOPLE FROM IMMIGRANT
DETENTION CALIFORNIA HAS MORE
THAN FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE IN
IMMIGRANT DETENTION WHO NEED
HELP WE NEED TO PROTECT DUE
PROCESS FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS IS
MORE IMPORTANT NOW THAN EVER
FOR OUR STATE TO KEEP FAMILIES
INTACT THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND FOR ACCEPTING OUR CALL.
THANK YOU MA'AM. WE WILL GO TO.
LINE ONE. ARE SKEWS ME LINE
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS MISS MATTHEWS COULD
HELP PROJECTS AND- BASIN
MODERATE YEAH BENITO COUNTY-
WITH SPECIAL THANKS TO CHAIRMAN
OF RAMBLE LOW'S SUCH A ORDINARY
TALK TO BE AT THE BEGINNING OF
THIS AND WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR SUPPORT WE ARE OPPOSING
THE ELIMINATION OF THE
MULTIPURPOSE SENIOR SERVICE
PROGRAM AND A REDUCTION IN
FUNDING FOR THE CARE GIVER
RESOURCE CENTER THE MULTI
PURPOSE SENIOR SERVICE THE
CENTER THE MSF PETER MILLION
TWELVE THOUSAND RAIL OLDER
SIXTY FIVE YEARS. OLDER AND
THEIR HOMES AND RATHER THAN
BEING AN INSTITUTION THEY CAN
HAVE THE HIGHEST QUALITY OF
LIFE BUT THEY'VE GROWN TO REAL
DOOR LIKE HE BEEN IN BEING ABLE
TO HAVE THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS
COME AND VISIT WITHOUT WORRYING
ABOUT CATCHING COULD HE JUST
NEEDS- AND BY DEFINITION THESE
FOLKS THESE FOLKS WERE POOR
ELDERLY COMPLEX MEDICAL AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL NEEDS AND REQUIRE
SPECIAL. SUPPORT SERVICE USE
OUR DATA REVEALED THAT EVER
INCREASING NEED INDICATE THEM
AWAY AS. SOON AS CONDITIONS.
EATING THE MEAT INCREASE WITH
THE ELDERLY. WE HAVE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH ISSUES MOBILE CALL MORE.
AND THE GREAT THINGS I AND
FEARS OF IN THE IN A HARSH
SITUATION WHERE THERE HEALTH IS
TO. NOT ONLY WILL THE ELIMINATE
OF THE INNOCENT PEOPLE PROGRAM-
INCREASED COST TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- BUT IT WILL ALSO
REDUCE THE QUALITY OF LIFE OF
THE FIVE HUNDRED PLUS EMPLOYEES
WORKING IN MISSISSIPPI AND ADD
TO THE UNEMPLOYMENT. WE
SINCERELY URGE YOU TWO THE
CHECK ELIMINATION OF HIM AS A
P. PROGRAM AND THE REDUCTION IN
TO THE CALGARY THANK YOU FOR
THE GREAT WORK ALL YOU'VE DONE.
THANK YOU SIR. PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE FIFTY SIX. HELLO MY NAME
IS AFTER BUILDING THERE I'M AN
AGENT THAT PROVIDER AND- I WANT
TO START BY SAYING THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN ARAMBULA. YOUR AND ALL
THE OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
YOUR COMMENTS I ECHO YOUR
CONCERNS AND WELL AS A MOTHER
OF A TWENTY ONE YEAR OLD ADULT
ARTISTIC WITH INTELLECTUAL.
DISABILITIES AND EPILEPSY HE
DEPEND UPON MANY OF THE
SERVICES THAT HAVE BEEN
PROPOSED GOV- THE CUTS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S NEWLY REVISED. AND
HAD BEEN IMPACTED SIGNIFICANTLY
ALREADY DURING THE TIMES OF THE
CALL THE PANDEMIC. I HAVE TO
SAY THOUGH I'M APPALLED THAT WE
CONTINUE TO BALANCE THE BUDGET
ON THE BACKS OF THOSE WHO ARE
AT THE BOTTOM. OUR COMMUNITY
BOTH VULNERABLE THE POOR AND
MIDDLE CLASS FAMILY AND THOSE
WHO SUPPORT THEM. I REALIZE AND
I UNDERSTAND IT- AND TURN TIME.
AND NO ONE SAW THIS COMING I
HAVE TOO MANY CONCERNED WITH
THE PROPOSED CUTS THAT I WOULD-GO WAY BEYOND THE TIME YOU ARE
USUALLY GIVE FOR ONE. PUBLIC
MOMENT SO WITH THAT I WILL KEEP
MY COMMENTS ON THE AYE AGES
THAT PROGRAM CURRENTLY. AND HOW
I CAN IMAGINE AGAIN HOW. THE
SERVICE OUR CUT THE 7% CUT TO
AN AGE OF THE CONSUMER IT'S
EVEN ON THE TABLE. ACTUALLY
DURING THE TIME WE HAVE TO
CONSIDER THE CONTINUITY OF CARE.
I HATE TO HAVE TO REPEAT MYSELF
BUT I SAID THIS YEARS AGO
DURING THE ADMITTED THAT
FORTUNATE OR MINISTRATION.
THANK YOU YOU WON'T REALIZE AND
UNDERSTAND THAT BY IMPLEMENTING
ANY KIND OF SERVICE. TO THE
COMMUNITY WHILE SMALLER BOTH
THE ELDERLY AND DISABLED YOU
ARE PUTTING THEM A GREAT REST.
RISK OF HAVING TO CHOOSE WHICH
VITAL FOR ITEMS THAT PURPOSES
THEY WILL GO WITHOUT. FROM DAY
TO DAY WHETHER IT WILL BE-
CHANGING OUR DRESSING- RISK OF
INJURY RISK OF INCREASED
MEDICAL COMPLICATIONS AND
EXPOSURE TO THE CALL THE
NINETEEN. RISK OF OUT OF HOME
PLACEMENT DISABILITIES WHERE WE
ALL AS YOU HAVE HEARD THE KOBE
NINETEEN IT'S PRETTY PREVALENT
EXPLODING- AND SOME OF THE
DANGERS. IT CUTS WILL HAVE AN
IMPACT HOW THEY WILL IMPACT OUR
CLIENTS. BUT WHAT ARE THE ONLY
ONES WE THINK ABOUT THE
PROVIDERS FAIR PROVIDING AN
ESSENTIAL SERVICE TO CARE FOR
THE CONSUMERS. WHICH I HAVEN'T
EVEN RECOGNIZING GIVEN ITS DUE
PROCESS AND NOT A WHOLE OTHERCONVERSATION- I THEM PUTTING
THEIR FAMILIES AT RISK BY GOING
IN PROVIDING THE KERR DAILY SO.
THESE IMPACT OUR PROVIDER
LIVELIHOOD- THEIR MEDICAL AND
DENTAL CARE THAT THEY MAY NEED
RECEIVE- BECAUSE BY THESE CUTS
THEY'RE LOSING THEIR HOURS ARE
LIVING HEY THEY'RE NO LONGER
ELIGIBLE FOR THE DENTAL AND
MEDICAL- INSURANCE THAT THEY
MIGHT BE GIVEN WITH THE COUNTY
THAT. IS THAT THEY NEED IT. L.
THEREFORE THE BE FORCED TO RELY
ON THE THING THAT ARE ON THE
CHOPPING BLOCK LIKE HOW THE COW
WORK IN CALPERS AND ALL THOSE
OTHER THINGS. YOU KNOW ON
AVERAGE OUR CLIENTS WOULD BE
LOSING UP ON AVERAGE A CLIENT
MAY BE LOSING ABOUT EIGHT HOURS
OF CARE FOR SOME OF YOU THINK
ABOUT IT FULL DAYS THAT COULD
MEAN A FULL DAY. WITHOUT MAG.
WITHOUT FOOD. I'M NEAL BEING
PREPARED FOR THEM I DAY OF
BEATING OR BALLOTS BLATTER
CARE. THEIR CLOTHES BEING
CHANGED HER MEDICAL PROTECT THE
PROVISION AND THE LIST GOES ON.
I JUST WANT YOU ALL TO THINK-AND I KNOW YOU GUYS HAVE A
REALLY TOUGH JOB. HOW
CALIFORNIA WANTS TO BE
REMEMBERED. IT'S HOW WE TREAT
OUR COMMUNITY LOOK VULNERABLE I
KNOW TO PROVIDE THE ESSENTIAL
SERVICES THAT ALLOWS THEM TO
LIVE SAFELY AT HOME WITH
DIGNITY AND RESPECT. I URGE YOU
ALL TO PLEASE HER. NOT APPROVED
AT THE PROGRAM. THANK YOU ALL
AND TAKE CARE A WELL. THANK YOU
MA'AM. JUST TO GIVE YOU AN
UPDATE WE NOW HAVE SIXTY EIGHT
PEOPLE IN THE QUEUE OPERATOR
CAN YOU HAVE THE NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THAT WOULD BE A LINE
ONE FORTY TWO GO AHEAD. HI
THERE MY NAME S JUSTIN MYERS I
AM A I H. SUCH PROVIDER- I CARE
FOR MY THIRTY TWO YEAR OLD
BROTHER KEEL- PRE COLD BED HE
WAS ALREADY LIVING ON A
VENTILATOR- HE SUFFERS FROM.
WATER PLEASE TRY HIS HAS US
REBEL QUALITY. AND I AM NOT
GONNA GET INTO. ALL THE OTHER
DETAILS AS I THINK A LOT OF THE
PREVIOUS CALLERS OF RISE SAT
BUT THE FACT THAT HE COULD BE.
LOOKING AT INSTITUTIONALIZED HM.
AT THIS TIME MEDICALLY. AS JUST
SOMETHING THAT MY FAMILY COULD
NOT LOCAL AT THE END OF TWENTY
THINGS THAT IT'S NOT FAIR FOR
SO MANY CALIFORNIANS. FAMILY
NUMBER LONGER THAT PUTTING THEM
IN INSTITUTION AND IN THIS. OF
AGE- AS WASTE THINGS THAT. I
HOPE YOU CAN DO WHAT YOU CAN
TO- ALLEVIATE AND HOPEFULLY OF
THE ELIMINATE THE POSSIBILITY
OF THESE CUTS COMING INTO PLACE
BECAUSE I HAD THERE'S ALREADY
AUTUMN FAMILIES OUT THERE
SUFFERING FROM. I HAD BE
ASHAMED TO SURELY. MORE
FAMILIES MATURATION SO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU.
WE WILL MOVE NEXT TO LINE THE
THIRTY FOUR. GO AHEAD AND ACT
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS KIND BURKE AND I WORK
AT HUNTINGTON HOSPITALAND
THAT'S THAT'S THE SITE AND I AM
A KITCHEN CONTINGENT OF
ASSEMBLED WOMAN. RUBIO THANK
YOU FOR MEETING TODAY I AM
CALLING TODAYTO PLEASE STOP
THE GOVERNMENT BUDGET PROPOSAL
TO ELIMINATE MSRP. AND THE HE
HAS FORTY YEAR THE TEST YEAR.
TECHNICALLY THEY'RE BEING.
INCOME VERIFIED SENIORS IN
THEIR HOME. THESE ARE THE
STATE'S OLDEST OR AND MOST RAIL
CALIFORNIANS LIVING OUTSIDE OF
THE NURSING HOME THEY OFTEN
DON'T HAVE THE CARE GIVER
SUPPORT OR NOT SUPPORT WITHOUT
AND WITH THE P. THE GOVERNMENT
PROPOSAL PUT OVER TEN THOUSAND
OLDER ADULTS AT EXTREME RISK
FOR NURSING HOME PLACEMENT AND
THAT. ANOTHER KEY CLIENTS AND
FAMILIES ARE COUNTING ON YOU TO
STOP THE GOVERNMENT BUDGET
PROPOSAL TO ELIMINATE THEM
SINCE HE- THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM. WE MOVED OUT TO LINE ONE
SIXTY ONE SIX ZERO GO AHEAD
PLEASE. HELLO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
JORDAN NINETY WITH THE
ARCHAEOLOGICAL PAUL THE
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION.
REPRESENT PEOPLE THEM SELECTION
AND ABOUT THE AILITIES AND
THEIR FAMILIES AND OUR CHAPTERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AT FIRST I
JUST WANT TO REALLY TAKE A
FAMILY MEMBER TEAMS FOR HIS
QUESTIONING ABOUT GIVEN THE
DEPTH OF THE CUT. AND IF THERE
ARE WAYS THE CALCULATIONS COULD
BE RE DONE SO WE DON'T EVEN
HAVE TO HAVE THE SEVERITY OF
THE CUT. ALSO THANK YOU OF
COURSE TO A SUPPLEMENT FRAZIER
IMPLEMENT MATHIS FOR YOUR
CONTINUED COMMITMENT AND YOUR
COMMENTS. ARGUMENT THE BOMB TO
DISABILITY COMMUNITY. AND THANK
YOU DOCTOR RAIN LOOKED LOOKED
UP IN THE IMPORTANCE OF OUR
PANDEMIC RESPONSE. AND
IMPORTANCE OF NOT LETTING
BUDGET CUTS IMPACT OUR PAN
DEMOCRATS RESPONSE. IT IS
EXACTLY THE PANDEMIC RESPONSE.
IN THE IN THE DEVELOPER
DISABILITY COMMUNITY BUT I WANT
QUICKLY DISCUSS. THE CDC HAS
RECOGNIZED OUR COMMUNITY AT THE
SPECIALLY BALL THE TO THIS
VIRUS. AND IN RESPONSE
FAMILIES. DIRECT SUPPORT STAFF
SERVICE PROVIDERS IN REGIONAL
CENTERS HAVE DONE HOLD WROTE
UNDERSCORE HOW WELL WHAT QUIRK.
TO PROTECT OUR COMMUNITY.
ADDITIONALLY AS RESULT OF
CLOSURES TO. EARLY INTERVENTION
SERVICES SPECIAL EDUCATION AND
DAY PROGRAMS FOR DOLE. WE'RE
EXPERIENCING OUR COMMUNITY A
SUBSEQUENT CRISIS. FOR BABIES
YOU WOULDN'T TO IN OUR FAMILY
IT WOULD WHICH IS  CRISIS. AT
IN A DETERIORATION OF MENTAL
HEALTH PHYSICAL. HEALTH AND
FAMILY HEALTH. RIGHT NOW IN
SIMILARLY IN RISK TO THAT
CRISIS. THE DIRECT REPORTS TO
THE STATE ARE THE FIRST LINE
PUBLIC HEALTH SERVICE PROVIDERS
AND AGAIN DOING HER ROLE QUIRK.
THIS BUDGET HOWEVER SAYS TO
THESE HELLO GAFFORD. THANK YOU.
AND NOW WE'RE GOING TO CUT TEN
PERCENT. WE'RE GOING TO FIRE
10% OF THE DIRECT SUPPORT STAFF
WE'RE GOING TO INCREASE WAITING
LISTS FOR SERVICES BY AT LEAST
10% THAT'S THE RESPONSE THIS
BUDGET FEZ. PLEASE THROW
CATHOLIC ON TOP OF THE 10% CUT
I REALLY WANT TO EMPHASIZE WE
TALK ABOUT THE UNIFORM HOLIDAY
SCHEDULE A. K. A. THAT'S FOR
LOW SCHEDULE. THIS TELLS
FAMILIES THAT WE KNOW YOU MAY
HAVE USED UP ALL YOUR PAID TIME
OFF OF WORK FOR THE LAST COUPLE
MONTHS YOU HAVE BEEN WITH YOUR
ADULT CHILDREN- CARING FOR
THEM. BUT NOW WE'RE GOING TO
ELIMINATE FOURTEEN DAYS IN YOUR
CHILD SUPPORT SO THAT NOW YOU
HAVE TO TAKE OFF WORK OFF AGAIN
FOURTEEN DAY OF THE YEAR THE
BUTTE YOUR ADULT CHILD THIS
MAKES NO SENSE IN RESPONSE TO
THIS PANDEMIC. ADDITIONAL
CONCERNS WHAT TO CUT TO AYE
CHIPSETS ANDWE ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH THOSE THAT YOU
PREVIOUSLY HEARD- AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE OF THE
NATION'S FEEDBACK ESPECIALLY
DURING PANDEMIC INDIVIDUALS
WITH DYLAN INTELLECTUAL AND
ABOUT TO DISABILITIES. WHO YOU
SEE BACK THIRTY DO SO FOR VERY
UNIQUE REASONS AND THOSE
INDIVIDUALS ARE ALMOST
ASSUREDLY GOING TO END UP IN
NURSING FACILITIES WHICH AS WE
KNOW WHAT WE REALLY WANT TO
KEEP PEOPLE OUT OF THOSE RIGHT
NOW.ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO ARE
SO VULNERABLE. WE KNOW THERE
ARE ANY YOU THE CUT. WE WANT BE
HELPFUL. BUT WE HAVE HOPE ANY
CUTS THAT INHIBIT OUR
COMMUNITIES RESPONSE TO THIS
CRISIS. THANK YOU FOR WHAT
HEARING YOU CALLED. THANK YOU
SIR. WE MOVE NEXT TO LINE ONE
SEVENTY FIVE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
THAT. HELLO LAIMBEER MORE
DISTANT. LOW A GREAT THANK YOU
SO MUCH MY NAME IS THE REIGNING
CHAMPION ON ON THE- COMMITTEE
BRIDGES AND ACTORS COUNTY
OPERATING ELDER DAY AT THE BEST
PROGRAM HELPING MEDICALLY
COMPLEX THE YEARS I JUST WANT
TO THANK THE CHAIR OF THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAKER FOR YOUR
WORD ABOUT THE CONCERN THAT THE
BEAR THESE CUTS WILL NEGATIVELY
IMPACT VULNERABLE SENIORS- WE
ASK THAT YOU RECONSIDER THE
ELIMINATION OF THE BATH PROGRAM
AT ALL SPEAKERS- AHEAD OF THE
CURVE BOOKING ABOUT. AND I
THINK HERE ARE FIVE MAJOR
REASONS WHY- THAT PEOPLE SHOULD
BE THINKING ABOUT THIS THAT
MOVING FORWARD YOU LOSE
MATCHING FEDERAL FUNDING
THROUGH FEDERAL WAIVERS- WE
WILL INCREASE THE BILL NURSING
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY
POPULATION WHICH IS NOW GOING
TO MAKE IT. MORE EXPENSIVE IN
ORDER PROP IMPLEMENT ALREADY
THAT PROGRAM COSTS BETWEEN THE
BATHROOM KILL NURSING
FACILITIES AS FOR ACTS IN OUR
CENTER ALONE 80% OF THE FOLKS
THAT COME TO OUR CENTER WOULD
QUALIFY FOR THE IF THERE WERE
THAT WE THE THING. IMPLEMENTED
THE ACCOUNT LEVEL THANK HAVE
THAT AVAILABLE THE MOST COUNTY
DO. NOT BE IN A REAL. QUICK ALL
HEALTHCARE ISSUE AND PUBLIC
HEALTH. WE HAVE A TO BE WITH
PROPER CARE BEING AT HOME OUR
AND WE WILL BE AND TAKING THAT
BACK FROM WHERE WE GOING TOWARD
WHICH IS MOVING TOWARD
INDEPENDENT AND LIVING AT HOME
AND MAKING THAT FACE
INSTITUTIONALIZATION WHICH IS
MORE COPLEY AND- WE'RE STEPPING
BACK IN THAT IN THAT BLOCK. I
THINK THAT WHAT WE CAN DO IS WE
KNOW THAT WE ALL NEED TO TAKE
SOME RESPONSIBILITY AND FROM
BURDEN UPON- THESE GREAT
CRISIS- ACROSS THE STATE AND
THE ONE THING THAT WE CAN DO IS
LOOK AT OUR RATIOS AND SOME OF
THESE PROGRAMS ACROSS ALL
PROGRAMS AND MAYBE INCREASE
THOSE RATIOS EVEN THOUGH THAT-
NEGATIVELY IMPACT OUR PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES WE KNOW THAT THAT
WILL REDUCE COSTS OVERALL AND
WE CAN SHARE THE LOAD ACROSS
MANY PROGRAMS. FURTHER WE ARE.
YOU KNOW I THINK IT DOES
BECAUSE- TO GOVERNOR THEM CLAIM
IN. ARE NOT ONLY GOOD PLAN ON
AGING- BUT THE VISION AND
UNDERSTANDING OF THE GROWING IN
YOUR POPULATION WHICH IS THE
FASTEST GROWING POPULATION
ACROSS OUR STATE. WE KNOW
PROGRAMS LIKE BE BATH AND OTHER
PROGRAMS LIKE I'M NOT THAT HE
ARE CRITICALLY IMPORTANT IN
ORDER TO MAINTAIN PEOPLE
HEALTHY. KEEPING PEOPLE OUT OF
INSTITUTIONS AND REDUCING OUR
COSTS OF FOR ALL. WE KNOW THAT
IF WE FAIL TO DO THAT NOW.
GOING TO BE ANY ANY PAYING FOR
THE ACT OR ACTS FOR MORE. ON
EVERY INDIVIDUAL AFTER THE
FACT. AND SO WE ARE WE REALLY
URGE THAT THIS SUBCOMMITTEE
REJECT THE PROPOSAL. AND THAT
WE NOT QUITE CHICKEN WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN
ANTICIPATION OF ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL DOLLARS. I'M BY PUTTING
THE PROPOSAL FOR. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND THE OTHER CAN YOU
SPEAK. THANKS SIR. WE WILL NOW
TO LINE ONE EIGHT FOUR GO AHEAD
PLACE TO. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN ARAMBULA MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I NEED AT LEAST
MAKE WATER I WORK AT HUNTINGTON
HOSPITAL. PEOPLE RIGHT AND I
ASKED YOU TO STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE ELIMINATION OF THE
MULTIPURPOSE SENIOR SERVICES
PROGRAM. AND THE THIRD NEARLY
TWELVE THOUSAND FRAIL OLDER
ADULTS AGE SIXTY FIVE AND OLDER
IN THEIR HOME AND THEY
CALIFORNIA MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ANNUALLY BY DOING SO. THAT ONLY
THE EIGHT THIRTY SHOW THAT AND
THAT'S THE LOWER HEALTHCARE
COSTS. LOCATION ACT THAT THE
RIGHT LEVEL OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND SUPPORT THE LOCAL
ECONOMY YOUR CONTRACT BUT
HUNDRED MALL. BUSINESSES
THROUGHOUT THE HE- THE SERVICE
DID OR MORE. THE EVER IN THE
NINE PANDEMIC SEVEN IN ON OLDER.
AS WE HAVE HEARD THIRD OF
COLLUDED NINETEEN THAT STATE
WIDE AND HALF OF THE DEATH AND
WALKED INTO WITH COUNTY ARE
NURSING HOME RESIDENTS KEEPING
CLEAN YOUR AT HOME IS THE
SAFEST PLACE FOR THEM TO LET.
AND HE IS THE CREATOR COST
EFFECTIVE MODEL CARE IT'S SAVE
MONEY FOR CALIFORNIA WELL
SAVING LIVES DURING THE CALL
THAT NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
ELIMINATION OF THE PROGRAM
WOULD BE A COSTLY MISTAKE.
PLEASE DO NOT ELIMINATE AND THE
THIRD P. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR CURRENT. THANK YOU FOR
COMMENTS NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE. A
LINE ONE TWENTY SIX GO AHEAD
PLEASE. HELLO HONORABLE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. I AM TRULY
WINE THEME AND I'M A SUPERVISOR
AT AMETHYST P. AT JEWISH FAMILY
SERVICE OF LOS ANGELES I URGE
YOU TO REJECT THE PROPOSED
ELIMINATION OF MS OF P.
ELIMINATING MSF PEOPLE FORCED
THE POOREST AND MEDICALLY
FRAILES SENIORS INTO NURSING
HOMES. COSTING THE STATE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND IT
GREATLY INCREASING THEIR RISK
OF EXPOSURE TO COVER NINETEEN.
DESIGNED TO PREVENT
INSTITUTIONALIZATION EMETH OF
P. SERVE NEARLY TWELVE THOUSAND
DRILL OLDER ADULTS ANNUALLY.
OUR CLIENTS ARE SIXTY FIVE
YEARS AND OLDER RELY ON MEDI
CAL AND ARE CERTIFIED ELIGIBLE
FOR NURSING HOME PLACEMENT
WHICH IS AN INDICATION OF THEIR
FRAIL HEALTH. IN THE MIDST OF
THIS TO COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. EMESIS P. HAS
LITERALLY SAVED LIVES. TO DATE
THERE HAVE BEEN JUST TAUGHT
FIFTEEN TOTAL COVE IN NINETEEN
POSITIVE CASES AND ONLY THREE
DEATHS. AMONG EMESIS P.
RECIPIENTS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT NOW AND IN THE PAST.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS SIX
BIGGER PLEASE. PINE SIXTEEN
CORE HAD PLACE. GOOD AFTERNOON
OUR ONE ARM CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY- MY
NAME IS EILEEN KUHN I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF ONE OF THE SITE AT
HUNTINGTON HOSPITAL IN PASADENA.
AND ART THANK YOU HIGHER TWENTY
YEARS AGO AND ONE OF OUR YOUTH
INCLUDING NUMBER ONE WILL BE ON
THE FOR AN- AGAINST. THE WAY.
BUT THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH ME
TODAY. I'M HERE THIRD FIFTY
OVER THE RAIL AND QUIRK MAYBE
TWELVE ELDERS. AND THE
POPULATION PROBABLY NOTICED AND
NOT A GOOD PHONE AGING OF THE
BABY BOOM GENERATION AND THAT
YOU'D BE THE CONVERSATION WE
HAD- WITH THAT MAYBE ABOUT THE
POPULATION- CALLED. HAS SORT OF
OVERTAKEN THE CONVERSATION AND-
AND BOUGHT A NEW URGENCY. THE
NEED FOR AN UP WITH HE HAS THE
KEY FOR THAT- ON. AND ALL.
BASED ON IN THE AVERAGE AGE
EIGHTY WITH MULTI DISABILITIES
REQUIRE MEDICAL CONDITION. PART
OF THE BOND YOUR CALL THAT
INSURANCE HOW ABOUT THE ONE AT
HOME SATURDAY THE HOME I'M SO
OF OUR IN A FIFTY COMMUNITY ON
LARGE GROUP. OF. DOES YOUR THE
FIRM IS A LIFELINE A CRITIC
REPORT WHAT THE OF THEM. LEVEL
ALL OF THE CALL THAN A HOW
ABOUT. A GROUP THAT OUR CLIENT
FIND RELATED TO THE SOUTH I
ONLY DONE ON. THAT IN INCLUDING
STOP SO WE SERVICE THE QUIET
QUIT MEANT THE LOCAL FARMERS
ONE NOW OTHER READ THERE. SO IT
REQUIRED BY YEAH AND IT THE
BEST FOR THE APPOINTMENT YOUR
TO THE FEDERAL. IRVINE GOT IT
OFF CALL BOB THE ANNUAL WITH
THE THIRD ONE OF. AFTER DINNER
FOR A HOME BEFORE YOU COULD
WIPE OUT THE- LOCAL CALL COSTS
OF A ONE ANOXIC. ONE OF THE
NOVEMBER FIFTH SOUTH TODAY ALL
HAVE A PUBLIC HEALTH. BONOBO
OLDER. OF THERE'S NO MAY IT A
SPECIAL BE. I AS OTHER HAVE OUT
O'DONNELL. WELL DON'T. ACOSTA
THAT NOT ACCOUNTED FOR IN THE
BY. THE PHONE CALL NINE ONE
ONE. URGENT REJECT THE PROPOSAL
IN THE NATION BENEFIT. ABOUT
PUBLIC HEALTH EVEN BEFORE THE
EVENT AND I THINK. THANK YOU
MA'AM. WILL MOVE DOWN THE LINE
FORTY EIGHT GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CHRIS THAT
STRONG AND I KEPT MY AUTISTIC
ADULTS ON ANTHONY YEAH I JUST
THIS PROGRAM AND THATYOUR
ACCOUNT. I JUST JUST ENABLES
TONY TO STAY HOME IN A SAFE AND
NURTURING ENVIRONMENT
SURROUNDED BY FAMILY WHO LOVED
HIM VERY VERY MUCH. ANY CUTS
THE HSS COACH TONY AND MANY
OTHERS LIKE HIM AND I'M MORE
PRECARIOUS ATTENTION UNSAFE
SITUATION. NOT ONLY SHOULD COST.
SB OPPOSED THE CURRENT PANDEMIC
HIGHLIGHTS THE NEED TO INCREASE
HOURS RESOURCES OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CITIZENS. I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU SIR.
WE MOVED NEXT TO LINE TWO ZERO
ONE GO AHEAD. HELLO AND WE'RE
BACK YOU CAN SALAS AND I AM-
BUT NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
POST WORK WITH CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER I AM HAPPY TO JOIN
ADVOCATES WHO HAVE BEEN CALLING
TO PROTECT PROGRAMS THAT WHOLE
BUNDLE OF ALL CALIFORNIANS FROM
WELLINGTON UNITY. AS WE KNOW
THOSE WERE MY WORDS HAVE BEEN
BASED ON BOTH IMPACTED BY FOR
THE NINETEEN WE WANT TO REMIND
OURSELVES BUT JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH ON COLLEGE
PROTECT FOUGHT FOR YOU FROM
HOMELESSNESS AND VEHICLE WITH
OUR COLLEAGUES FROM SOBRE NOW
OPPOSE THE BILL IN THE NATION
AT BURKE PROGRAM. WE BELIEVE
THAT THE CUTS HOW WORKS THERE
SORT BLIGHTED SINCE THE PROGRAM
FORGET IT HELP PEOPLE GET
EMPLOYED. AND THE PUMP UP THE
PENSION. ALSO AGAINST HAVE
BETWEEN. WITH IN FINAL PUBLIC
NOT. AT THE END OF HER NAME
FEEDBACK FROM. FUNDING FOR THE
LONG TERM BUT FOR WHAT MAY IN
OUR SENIORS MORE ON OUR BALL.
I'M LAUGHED THERE'S A HE WAS
USE I WANNA HIGH. FIRST IF YOU
ARE AWARE. OF THE FIGHT AT THE-
AT THAT HE PRO. THE YOUNG
PROGRAM THAT IS NOW BEEN WITH
STAR AND HELP FROM THE GREAT
AFFECTION. WE HAVE FIVE AFTER
TO RESTORE THE GRANT AND THE
ONLY BEEN PICKED UP ON FOR
HEARING ONE SMALL POSSIBLY.
INCREASE HAD WAITED FOR THE
PROGRAM WILL ONLY MAKE THE
POPULATION MORE VULNERABLE AND.
MORE LIKELY TO FALL INTO HOW
MUCH. SECONDLY ALLOW. BUT HAD
BONTA FAMILY. ALSO WERE WHAT
THE- OF. BUT YOU THINK THERE
ARE. ALL A 59% RATE WHAT THAT
THEY FOLKS WHO FOR BECAUSE NO
THE WAY. LOW EVEN BY WANT
SANDERS MANY OF THE PHONE ONE
COME FROM MANY THE OF POVERTY
THAN. AND SPREAD TO GET THEM
NOW JUST TO BRING A PHOTO. YES
THEY ARE STILL CHALLENGE TO
THEIR FAMILIES. STUDIES HAVE
PROVEN THAT IF YOU ONLY HAVE
ONE SOCIAL WORKER THERE AT THE
75% PERMANENT WEIGHT BUT THE
POSSIBILITY OF COMMON AND WE
DROPPED 18% ONE ARTS YOUR MORE.
SOCIAL WORKERS THAT INTERACT
WITH THE FACT THAT PROGRAM AND
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR-
THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT LINE
EIGHTY THREE GO AHEAD. A LINE
EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HEARING NOTHING WE WILL MOVE TO
LINE SIXTY FOUR GO AHEAD. YEAH
YOU HEAR ME YES MA'AM. FINALLY
GOT AND I HF IF PROVIDER IN EL
DORADO COUNTY FOR NINETEEN
YEARS. AND I STRONGLY AB ONE
WOULD LIKE YOU GUYS TO OPPOSED
27% BECAUSE I SEEN WHAT IT HAD
DONE TO MY FIRST WE SHOULD BE
AT. AND BE SENIORS AND DISABLED
SHOULD BE ABLE TO LIVE IN THEIR
OWN HOMES WITHOUT THE THREAT OF
BEING CUT HOURS. SO I STRONGLY
URGE YOU GUIDE TO OPPOSE THIS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
MA'AM. WE'LL GO NEXT TO LINE TO
SIXTEEN GO AHEAD PLEASE. MY
INCOME FROM THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
FULL INVESTMENT IN THE ONE
CALIFORNIA PROGRAM SO LEGAL
SERVICES PROVIDER CAN HELP
SERVE OUR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY
MEMBERS THEY ARE OFTEN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE DUE PROCESS AND-
PROPOSAL BECAUSE PEOPLE WHO ARE
DETAINED IN ITS ABILITY. NEED
ACT THAT THE COUNCIL MORE THAN
AT BURKE GIVEN THE DEADLY
OUTBREAK THE CO THE NINETEEN
THAT ARE CARRYING AND
INSTABILITY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ALL
HELLO. IT IS OPEN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. HELLO YES MADELINE IS
OPEN YOU MAY GO AHEAD. SORRY
ABOUT THAT- YES MY NAME IS
TEDDY WHAT CAN AND I AM AND I
HSS PROVIDER HERE AND PULL ME
COUNTY AS WELL AS THE U. D. W.
DISTRICT OR REPRESENTATIVE. AND
I HAVE BEEN A CARE PROVIDER FOR
MY DAUGHTER FOR EIGHT YEARS.
WHO IS DIAGNOSED WITH AUTISM
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY AND
ALSO HAS A HISTORY OF SEIZURES.
AND WE ON THE LIVING PROVIDER
AND- IDEAL- OPPOSED 27% CUT
THAT WOULD COME WITH THE AGENT
BUT BROKE GROUND SHE DOES NEED
EVERY HOUR OF CARE THAT SHE IS
THEN AT THAT FOR. AND I BELIEVE
THAT- CALIFORNIANS THAT
SPECIALLY CURABLE WE LIVE AND
OUR ROLE COUNTIES COULD BE
AFFECTED BY A 7% CUT SO I DEAL
OPPOSE THAT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MA'AM. NEXT TO ACCORDED
LINE ONE TWENTY NINE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS DANNY BIKER AND I
AM FROM INDEPENDENT THAT HALL
AND SCANNED COMMUNITY SERVICE
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY. WE ARE
AN MSF P. PROVIDER WITH OVER
SEVEN HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS ON
ENROLLED WITH US AT A GIVEN
TIME. I'M HERE TODAY TO ASK YOU
TO PLEASE OPPOSE THE
ELIMINATION OF THE AND THAT'S
THE KEY PROGRAM AS WELL WITH
THE SEA BASS PROGRAM. AND
THAT'S P. AS YOU HAVE HEARD
FROM MY COLLEAGUES SERVES THE
FINALISTS AND MOST VULNERABLE
IN OUR STATE. AND THE AND THAT
THAT THE MODEL SIMPLY WOULD NOT
BE REPLACED BY ANY OTHER
SERVICE IN THE COMMUNITY. OUR
CA ARE SOCIAL WORKERS AND
REGISTERED NURSES WRAPPED
AROUND THE NURSING HOME
ELIGIBLE INDIVIDUAL. HELP THEM
REMAIN IN THE HOME. THE TYPICAL
PROFILE IS A FEMALE WHO LIVES
ALONE IN THEIR IN HER EIGHTIES
SHE MAY VERY WELL AT THIS POINT
COULD BE MONOLINGUAL IN A
LANGUAGE OTHER THAN ENGLISH.
SHE IS UNABLE TO SAFELY LIVE AT
HOME BECAUSE HER NEED. A
MEDICAL NEED HER SOCIAL NEEDS
ARE GREAT SHE LIVING ON LESS
THAN ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
MONTH. AND SHE NEEDS HELP DAY
THERE. AND IT WOULD BE A REALLY
REAL SHAME FOR US GETTING TO
THE POINT THAT WE TELL SOMEONE%
LIKE THAT WHO IS. DONE
EVERYTHING RIGHT THEN LIVING
HERE IN THE COUNTRY BUT IN A
TIME OF A PANDEMIC THAT IT IS
TIME FOR THEM TO ONLY FACE ONE
OPTION THE POSSIBILITY OF A
NURSING HOME. BECAUSE OUR IN
PART THE PEOPLE WE SERVE ARE
ALREADY CERTIFIED NURSING HOME
ELIGIBLE IT'S A VERY REALISTIC
POSSIBILITY THAT WITHIN THE
FIRST THIRTY TO SIXTY DAYS OF
THE CLOSURE OF AND THAT'S THE
KEY. YOU WOULD IN MORE THAN 40%
OF OUR BUSINESS AND POSSIBLY
SHOWING UP LOOKING FOR THE
BECAUSE THEY NO LONGER CAN
PIECE IT TOGETHER IN THE
COMMUNITY. HE DOES EVERY RAP
AROUND THE END VIGIL. AT 45%
LOWER THAN A NURSING HOME. BUT
THERE IS REAL SAVINGS IN OUR
PROGRAM AND TRUE COST. MODEL ON
THE COST OF UNEMPLOYMENT FOR
OUR EMPLOYEES THAT WOULD UP
BEYOND THOSE ROLES. AND THE
IMPACT ON SMALL BUSINESSES IN
THE COMMUNITY THAT WE MOBILIZE
AND MARSHALL TO BE ABLE TO
SERVE THESE INDIVIDUALS AND
THEIR HOMES. I AM ASKING YOU
TODAY TO PLEASE REALLY THINK
ABOUT THIS CAREFULLY FOLD
LAMINATIONS OF A PROGRAM LIKE
AND THAT THE P. AND ALSO SEE
ABOUT. WHICH ARE SOMETIMES THE
LAST LINE OF DEFENSE. BEFORE
GOING TO A NURSING HOME WHERE
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH BEDS AND
THERE IS A PANDEMIC. IT OPPOSE
THESE CUTS THERE'S GOT TO BE
ANOTHER WAY I KNOW THAT THE
BUDGET DECISIONS THIS YEAR ARE
VERY TOUGH. BUT THERE'S GOT TO
BE ANOTHER WAY THAT THE TURN
OUR BACK ON OUR FAIL AT THE
MOST FRAGILE. THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING TO ME I KNOW YOU HAVE
A VERY TOUGH JOB. BUT PLEASE
SUPPORT THE SENIORS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT WILL
ALIGN TWO ONE NINE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. THAT LINE IS DRAWN TO
WILL NEXT TO LINE TWO TWO ZERO
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
UNDER ROBERT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER. DAY TO RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THE INCLUSION OF THE
DUE PROCESS IN DETENTION
PROGRAM AND THE BUDGET THE ONE
TIME THREE MILLION DOLLAR
PROGRAM WOULD HELP ESTABLISH
THE FIRST STATEWIDE
COLLABORATIVE. I WOULD HELP
PROVIDE ACCESS TO LEGAL COUNSEL
AND OTHER CRITICAL RESOURCES
SUCH AS SELF HELP LEGAL
SCREENING. ND REFERRAL TO PRO
BONO SERVICES FOR INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE BEING HELD IN
IMMIGRANT DETENTION. CALIFORNIA
HAS AN ESTIMATED FIVE THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS IN IMMIGRANT
DETENTION WHO NEED ASSISTANCE.
I NEEDS TO AND IN A STATEWIDE
EFFORT TO PROVIDE THESE
INDIVIDUALS WITH LEGAL
RESOURCES. ESPECIALLY AS
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT
OPERATIONS CONTINUE WITHOUT
OPERATE HERE IT TO THE CDC
GUIDELINES AND DETAINEES ARE
NOT BEING OFFERED. ACCESS TO
ADEQUATE MEDICAL CARE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM. WE'LL GO NEXT
TO LINE FIFTEEN GO AHEAD PLACE.
HELLO MY NAME IS FLORENCE CLOSE
THEN AND I'M I GET THAT
PROVIDER- FOR MOST THAT COUNTY.
I CARE FOR MY BROTHER ON WHO IS
HAS. GET THE CAN YET AND WITH
THAT CHRONIC EPISODES AND- HE
ALSO HAS A LITTLE OVER TWENTY
HALLUCINATION. AND HOME. TAKING
CARE OF THE HOME IT'S POSSIBLE.
I FOR ONE AND THAT. I'M NOT A
LONG TERM CARE FACILITY. WE
WOULD BE. AT HIGH RISK AS ON
HOLD AT NINETEEN OR AND YEAH.
SO IN EFFECT. FOUR OUR THAT YES
DEFINITELY ME AND STAY HEALTHY
AT HOME. READING THE HYPE OF
THAT OUR WILL PUT ME ON
CALIFORNIANS LIKE MY BROTHER.
IT. PROVIDES CRITICAL SERVICES
TO THE STATE AND HOME SUPPORT
SERVICES. ALLOW OVER A MILLION
CALIFORNIANS. IN YOUR PEOPLE
DISABILITY FOR MAIN IN THEIR
HOME WITH DIGNITY AND
INDEPENDENCE. RIGHT OPPOSED
FEDERAL AT A DEFENSE ON APRIL.
THANK YOU MA'AM. WE GO NEXT TO
LINE SEVENTY FIVE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
LUCAS FRANK MECCA WITH THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS AT THE
ASIAN. WE APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S ATTEMPTS TO PRESERVE
BASIC INCOME ASSISTANCE FOR THE
COURTS PEOPLE- FOR EXAMPLE
LEAVING CALYX GRANT. OR THEY
ARE- WE'RE SINCERELY
APPRECIATIVE ABOUT THAT PUT. WE
ARE ON THE OTHER HAND EXTREMELY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE FATE OF
ABUSED AND NEGLECTED CHILDREN
AND ADULTS BECAUSE OF THE
ALMOST SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR REDUCTION IN REALIGNMENT
REVENUES. FOR HUMAN SERVICES
PROGRAMS THAT WERE DISCUSSED BY
MY COLLEAGUE SHE- I JUST DIDN'T
HEAR IT FROM THE FACT IN THE
ABSENT- STATE SUPPORT TO
BUTTRESS THE SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTION IN REVENUES. WILL BE
STEEP REDUCTIONS IN SERVICES TO
PROTECT PEOPLE- CHILDREN AND
ADULTS ARE BEING AN ABUSED OR
NEGLECTED- EXACERBATING THAT
PROBLEM AT THE DECISION AND THE
NEIGHBOR ADDITION. TO NOT
REIMBURSED COUNTY FOR ABOUT
EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
COST. FOR THE NEW RESEARCH
FAMILY APPROVAL PROCESS. THOSE
ARE RESOURCES THAT WE NEED TO
GET CARE GIVERS TO ABUSE KIDS.
IT'S ALSO MONEY THAT WE ARE
CONSTITUTIONALLY ENTITLED TO
UNDER PROP THIRTY WE DON'T
AGREE WITH THE STATE'S
INTERPRETATION. THAT THE
RESEARCH FAMILY APPROVAL
ACTIVITIES WERE NOT THAT PRE
DATED TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
REALIGNED THEY CLEARLY DID NOT.
AND SO- WE BELIEVE THAT THOSE
FUNDS TO BE INCLUDED IN THE
CONSTITUTIONALLY MANDATED TRUE
UP BROUGHT THAT UNDER
PROPOSITION THIRTY. WITH
RESPECT TO ELIGIBILITY-
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES AND CAL
WORKS CAL FRESH. I JUST THAT.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT SOME
REDUCTIONS ARE INEVITABLE AND%
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTIONS ACROSS ALL OF THOSE
PROGRAMS AND WHAT WE'RE ASKING
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE. IS THIRD CALIBRATE
OUR EXPECTATION CALIBRATE
ACCOUNTABILITY IN CALIBRATE OUR
PERFORMANCE EXPECTATION BASED
ON THE AMOUNT OF MONEY WE HAVE.
I THINK THE BUDGET ESSENTIALLY
SAYS. DO YOUR BEST WE CAN'T.
BOND THOSE ACTIVITIES WHERE WE
OUGHT TO- WE AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL- MAKING WORK AND WE WILL
DO OUR BEST BUT WE HAVE TO
ALIGN. REASONABLE EXPECTATIONS
OF COUNTY PERFORMANCE WITH THE
RESOURCES THAT ARE AVAILABLE. I
SHOULD SAY THE SAME THING FOR
OUR CLIENTS WE HAVE TO LINE- UP
A LINE OR EXPECTATIONS OF WHAT
WE CAN EXPECT BY WAY OF
PARTICIPANTS- PARTICIPATING IN
WELFARE TO WORK ACTIVITIES IS
ABOUT A SIX HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR PLUS REDUCTION AND CAL
WORKS EMPLOYMENT SERVICE THAT.
WE DO NOT AGREE WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION BUT I'M SURE.
THAT THOSE FUNDS ARE NECESSARY
BECAUSE SOME SIGNIFICANT NUMBER
OF THE NEW COLD WAR COMING ON
TO POWER. OUR RECENTLY
CONNECTED TO THE LABOR FORCE
AND THEREFORE WON'T NEED
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES. WE THINK
LARGE NUMBERS OF PEOPLE COMING
ON TO CAO WORKS ARE GOING TO BE
COMING FROM A SERVICE SECTOR.
WHERE JOBS ARE GOING TO BE
PERMANENTLY LOST NECESSITATING-
CLUB RETRAINING FOR DIFFERENT
INDUSTRIES. AND SO WE'RE NOT
WE'RE NOT UP HOLDEN CAUGHT
WE'RE JUST SAYING WE KNOW
INEVITABLY PEOPLE WILL WILL NOT
GET SERVICE THAT THEN UNDER THE
LAW. WE PROVIDE PEOPLE GOOD
CAUSE FOR NOT PARTICIPATING BUT
WE HAVE TO TURN THEIR TIME
CAUGHT UP HERE SHOULD NOT BE
JEOPARDY TO THE CLIENT- TO HAVE
THEIR CAL WORKS. FINE ON AID
CHECK YEAH WE JUST BECAUSE OF
THIS TERRIBLE RECESSION AND
CAN'T AFFORD TO PAY FOR THEIR
SERVICES. NOW WE HAVE
SUBMITTED- A LETTER TO THE
COMMITTEE THAT GOES INTO MUCH
MORE DETAIL ABOUT THE TYPES OF-
PERFORMANCE EXPECTATIONS
CALIBRATION THAT WE WANT TO DO.
AND SIMPLIFICATION BUT WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE EXTENDED FROM THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER. FINALLY MISTER
CHAIR. WE THINK THERE ARE TWO
CUTS IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
DETERGENT. COUNTERPRODUCTIVE
GIVEN OUR DESIRE TO RESTART THE
ECONOMY AS QUICKLY AS WE CAN-
THE FIRST IS THE ELIMINATION OF
SUBSIDIZEDEMPLOYMENT ON THE
COUCH FOR CABINET THE VIRTUAL
ELIMINATION- WHAT WE LEARNED.
IN THE GREAT RECESSION WAS THAT
SUBJECT EMPLOYMENT WAS ONE OF
THE BEST WAYS THAT WE COULD
SUPPORT SMALL BUSINESS SAYS.
I'M AND SMALL EMPLOYERS TO HELP
SUBSIDIZE THE WAGE OF CLIENTS
FOR A TEMPORARY PERIOD OF TIME.
TO REDUCE THE COST OF THEM TO
ACTUALLY SORT OF RE OPEN THEIR
BUSINESS AS WELL AT THE SAME
TIME PROVIDING EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CLIENTS. DATA
FROM THE AT THAT INDICATE THAT
IT'S A VERY SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN THERE WERE SEVENTY TWO
HUNDRED PARTICIPANTS. THOSE
PARTICIPANTS DOUBLE THEIR
INCOME THE MEDIAN INCOME DURING
THEIR TIME ON HIM- BUT BUT
IMPLEMENT. THEM WHAT'S MORE
INTERESTING AND IMPORTANT IS
THAT AFTER THEY LEFT THE
PROGRAM- THE INCREASE IN MEDIAN
INCOME WAS MORE THAN TWO AND A
HALF TIMES- THEN. HAD THEY NOT
PARTICIPATE. WITH ABOUT FOUR
THOUSAND PEOPLE AT ANY GIVEN
MOMENT IN SUBSIDIZED
EMPLOYMENT. BUT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PASSES ON JULY FIRST WE
WILL ON EMPLOYEE FOUR THOUSAND
CHARACTERS THAT WE URGE YOU TO
REJECT THAT CUT. AND FINALLY
MISTER CHAIR WE ALIGN ORSELVES
WITH YOUR COMMENTS ABOUT HOW
IMPORTANT THE FAMILY URGENT
RESPONSIVE COMMITTED. THE TYPES
OF STRESSES THAT THAT SYSTEM IS
SO CRITICAL FOR HEALTH CARE
GIVERS AND YOU- REMAIN
CONNECTED INTO NOT A PLACEMENT
DISRUPTION SO THREATENS GO UP
AND HAVE GONE UP. AND ANYBODY
WITH CHILDREN NOTES ON IN THIS-
IN THE KOBE EMERGENCY AND SO WE
WOULD URGE THE ADMINISTRATION
IN THE LEGISLATURE BY TO KEEP
THAT THE MOMENTUM GOING INTO
EMPLOYMENT FIRST. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU MISTER AMERICA COM I DO ON
A- GIVE AN UPDATE FOR THOSE WHO
ARE LISTENING WE HAVE ROUGHLY
SIXTY CALLERS- THAT ARE ON HOLD
AT THE MOMENT WE DO HAVE A HARD
STOP AT SEVEN PM TODAY SO IN
THREE HOURS. AND WITH THAT
OPERATOR IF YOU CAN GET OUR
NEXT CALLER READY. THAT WILL BE
A LINE ONE FIVE NINE AND GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
NANCY VOTE FOR TRUMP JEWISH
FAMILY SERVICE FROM LOS
ANGELES. AND FIRST I WANT TO
THANK YOU ALL FOR TAKING ALL OF
OUR COMMENTS TODAY WE KNOW HOW
DIFFICULT THE DECISIONS ARE I
AM NOT GOING TO REPEAT THE
INFORMATION. THAT SEVERAL OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE MADE THAT I
WILL URGE YOU THAT YOU TO
REJECT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
TO AMONG LIMóN EIGHT THE MULTI
PURPOSE SENIOR SERVICES PROGRAM
JUST A YEAR AGO WE SAT IN THIS.
MANY AND YOU ALL STOOD UP AND
INVESTED IN AMETHYST HE AND
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
WORK. TO PROTECT OUR FRAIL
ELDERS THAT KEEPING THEM SAFE
AT HOME. A BETTER QUALITY OF
LIFE AND A LOWER COST TO THE
STATE IN KEEPING THEM OUT OF
HARM'S WAY WHICH IS OUR BOTH
OUR DUTY AND OUR
RESPONSIBILITY. TO THEM
ESPECIALLY IN A TIME OF COVERT
NINETEEN. THIS COMMITTEE HAS
STOOD UP FOR THE FRAIL ELDERLY
TIME AND TIME AGAIN. WE URGE
YOU TO DO SO AGAIN THIS YEAR
AND REJECT THE ELIMINATION OF
THE MSRP. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION. WE GO
NEXT TO LINE TO TEN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. LINE TO TURN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WILL MOVE ON TO LINE
ONE FOR ONE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS NATALIA I GOT IN I AM
AN EMPLOYEE WITH AND THE FIFTY.
WHAT'S YOUR AGING HERE IN SAN
FRANCISCO I'M CALLING TO
REQUEST THAT THE COMMITTEE
OPPOSED THE ELIMINATION OF AND
A FIFTY. THEN IMPORTANT PROGRAM
FOR THE MOST VULNERABLE I'M
HERE WE NEED TO PROTECT THEM AT
THE FIVE AND CONTINUE WITH THE
SERVICES WE PROVIDE TO THEM.
KEEP THEM SAFE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU MA'AM. WE
MOVED TO LINE ONE SEVEN ONE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THIS IS ON MY CAR WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEES- HEARING AND TAKING
ALL THE TESTIMONY GET YOU ARE
TODAY- I HAVE SEVERAL COMMENTS
YOU'RE MOSTLY RELATED TO CAL
WORKS IN A FEW RELATED TO OR-
AFTER FIVE- I THINK FIRST OF
ALL OVERALL. I MEAN WE REALLY
DO. OUR THE APPROACH TAKEN BY
THE ADMINISTRATION IN. DEALING
WITH THE CRISIS IN THE
SHORTFALL I MEAN WE ARE. WE
HAVE BEEN CONCERNED ABOUT THE
GRANT LEVELS THAT WILL OCCUR IN
THE TOWERS WILL GRAHAM GOING
FORWARD GIVEN DAHLE- HIGH
UNEMPLOYMENT NUMBERS AND WE ARE
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF- WHAT
MINISTRATION CHOSE TO. MAINTAIN
THOSE GROUND LEVEL AND TO TAKE
STEPS TO- MAKE SURE THERE WAS
GOING TO BE ADEQUATE FUNDING IN
THE BUDGET TO ABSORB THE
CASELOAD INCREASES THAT WERE
ALREADY SEEN THAT WE ANTICIPATE
GOING COURT- THE- WE ARE
CONCERNED THOUGH IT AND AS
MISTER MAC- JUST MENTION A FEW
MOMENTS AGO. ABOUT THE IMPACT
THE TIME LIMITS MAY HAVE ON
FAMILIES AS- MANY OF YOU KNOW-
WE HAVE. WE HAVE REDUCED OUR
TIME LIMITS AND IN TWO THOUSAND
AND TWELVE AND- MANY FAMILIES
ALREADY HAD SPENT TIME BACK IN
THE GREAT RECESSION ON TOP ON
EIGHT. MAY HAVE SPENT TIME IN
THE LAST TEN OR TWELVE YEARS ON
A BEGAN AND NOW. FOR A THIRD
TIME PERHAPS ARE FACING
ANOTHER- TIME ON CAL WORKS AND
THEY HAVE VERY SHORT TIME
CLOCK. AND FOR THOSE REASONS
WE'VE BEEN URGING THE COMMITTEE
TO LOOK THIS YEAR TO CONSIDER
SPENDING A TIME CLOCK TO THE
FOR MAC ON ONE. SIX MONTHS.
ADMIN THOUGH WE DO THINK THAT
ANY. FAMILY THAT. PARTICIPATE
IN WATFORD. GETTING SO CALLED
GOOD CAUSE FOR NON
PARTICIPATION SHOULD HAVE THEIR
TIME CLOCK STOP FOR ANY MONTH
TO. APART GET THERE ON A-
PROBLEM RIGHT NOW FAMILY CAN
ONLY HAVE THEM STOP IN THE
FIRST TWENTY FOUR MONTHS. AND
THERE ARE MANY FAMILIES NOW
THAT ARE GOING TO BE BEYOND THE
TWENTY FORMA CLEMENT. AND
CANNOT GO TO WORK AND YET WILL
NOT HAVE THE TIME CLOCK STOPPED
AND WE THINK. THAT THAT OUGHT
TO BE DEALT WITH IN TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE THIS YEAR- THE
ONLY MENTION MUCH. SEVERAL
HOURS AGO NOW THE LOOKING AT
THE FLEXIBILITY THAT HAVE BEEN
PROVIDED BY THE ADMINISTRATION.
IN THE CODE WORD CRISIS AND WE
ARE VERY CREATION OF A FAST
FOR. A BOOK THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE IN PDF THAT THAN THAT IN
THIS MATTER BUT WE DO AGREE
THAT THERE ARE THINGS THAT I
DIDN'T FEEL THAT. PERHAPS WE
DON'T NEED DOING ON ALL
BASICALLY COULD ACTUALLY BE
STRIP MINED. MADE FOR CHEN GET
PEOPLE THERE. THEIR BENEFITS
QUICKER AND REDUCING THE
BURDENS ON COUNTY WORKERS. I WE
TO ACTUALLY SUBMITTED A
PROPOSAL TO THE LEGISLATURE.
THAT WILL DO THAT IN PARTICULAR
ONE THING THAT WE WOULD KNOW IS
THAT. WE HEARD. TWO TO ADOPT
MANY OF THE STREAM WHAT
PROPOSAL SENATE BEEN- PROPOSED
BY THE ADMINISTRATION. THAT
HAPPENED- PART OF OUR ONGOING.
NUMBER EFFORT THAT IN THE
FUTURE. IF WE HAVEN'T QUITE
LIKE THIS WE WON'T TO. A NUMBER
OF EXECUTIVE ORDERS AND EIGHTY
ALL THIS. THOSE ISSUES CAN BE
DEALT WITH AUTOMATICALLY HAVING
HIM- IN MILWAUKEE IN ADVANCE-
WE ARE HAPPY TO ADMINISTRATION
DID NOT DO ANYTHING IN THE
BUDGET. RECUSE IN YOUR HOURS.
PROGRAMS HE ALSO. PROGRAM AND
OTHER ENDEAVORS WE THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE ABSOLUTELY CRUCIAL
THAT WE DO THAT BUT WE DO THINK
THAT THERE ARE SOME FLEXIBILITY
THANK BE. AND ALMOST SINCE
PROGRAM. EXAMPLE RID OF THE
RIVER. THAT WE WON'T PAY RENT
THAT HE- THAT IS INCREASE OF AN
ACCESS TO THE PERCENT OF
SOMONE INCOME. THAT IN BUT
BEING A BARRIER FOR MANY FAMILY.
WE THINK OF TâM TO GET MORE
THAN ONE BILLS SIX DAYS ATTEMPT
SISTER. ALLOWING THEM MORE THAN
ONE DURING THE CRISIS WOULD BE.
SOMETHING WITHOUT A CA. DOING
WE GOING TO HAVE A MAJOR NUMBER
OF A MASSIVE NUMBER OF
AFFECTION. BEING PROPOSED BY
LANDLORDS TH COMING MONTHS AND
WE NEED TO HAVE ALL THE
RESOURCES AND TOOLS ARE. WHAT
WE CAN. MANAGED FROM. AND THE
LASTLY ON AFTER OUR PARDON ME
MONEY SAY THAT WE ALSO- WANT
TO- JOIN YOU MISTER MAC OF
COMMENTS ABOUT THE SINGLE
ALLOCATION AND THE CONCERN THAT
WE HAVE ABOUT EMPLOYMENT
SERVICES BOB AND THE WIDELY ON
AT THE SITE- YOU KNOW WE'RE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
PROPOSED CUT AND WHILE I KNOW.
GIVEN SOME OF THE OTHER CUTS
THAT WE'VE HEARD DISCUSSED
TODAY THEY MAY NOT SEEN AT THE
MAGNITUDE OF THAT- I WOULD JUST
REMIND THAT WE ARE ON NOW IN
YOUR LAP AND OF OVERLY AROUND
TO CUT THEM DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION WHICH GRANTS WERE CUT
BY SEVENTY SEVEN DOLLARS A
MONTH FOR EVERY RECIPIENT HAVE
NEVERBEEN RESTORED AND IS SO
THIS CUT ON TOP OF THAT JUST
SEEMS. A LITTLE BIT GRATUITOUS
AND WE WOULD ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO REJECT
ADDITIONALLY- WE HAVE ASKED
FOR- PARITY FOR THE
TRANSITIONAL. KITCHEN HOW. AND
ONLY. RUSSIAN BENEFIT WHICH IS
TO AT THE FIVE RECIPIENT TO
HOUSEHOLDS WHERE THEY A WALK
INCOME DUE TO THE INDIAN OF
CASH OUT- MANY HOUSEHOLD GOT A
BUMP IN THEIR SNAP BENEFIT
NGUYEN FROM CONGRESS IN THE
CARES ACT- KIßM BE RECIPIENTS
DID NOT GET THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION ALREADY PROVIDED
A- ARE COMPLEMENTARY INCREASE
AND BENEFITS FOR A- CALIFORNIA
FOOD ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
RECIPIENTS- BUT WE HAVE NOT
PROVIDED ONE FOR THE TRANSITION
A CHRISTIAN BENEFIT PROGRAMS WE
WOULD ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO. TO BRING PARITY DID THAT
AND PROVIDE A STATE LEVEL
BENEFIT- FOR THOSE FAMILIES-
AND THEN THE FINAL THING IS WE
WOULD JUST CONCUR WITH MISS
BURKE EARLIER COMMENT ABOUT THE
BIGGER AND ABOUT TAKING POST
LOOK ABOUT BOTH THE TIME OF
WHEN THE TRIGGER WOULD GOING TO
AFFECT AND HOW ACT WE WILL
OPERATE ON WHETHER OR NOT ALL
THE CUTS WOULD GO INTO EFFECT
IF WE COME UP A LITTLE SHORT
SEVERAL MINE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WRITTEN. STRUCTURE THANK
YOU MISTER HERALD. WE MODOC
SEVENTY ONE GO AHEAD. AND IF
YOU CARED FISHERIES DRAWING
CALLING FROM THE COUNTY TO GIVE
HER A WHOLE CHARACTERS THOSE
THE XIN THANK YOU FOR HOLDING
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING
ADDRESSING THE HUMAN SERVICES
NEIGHBORHOODS A PROPOSAL AND
FROM THE BANK ALL THE PUBLIC
COMMENT TODAY ON X. FIFTEEN AT
THE TIME AS LOWER BY COUNTY
UNDER IMMENSE STRAIN. AND
COUPLED WITH THE GROWING
BEHAVIOR HEALTH AND PUBLIC
HEALTH CRACK. AND ECONOMIC
RECESSION WE GOING A COMMENT BY
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES AND OTHER COUNTY
PARTNERS AND NOTIFYING YOU THAT
SERVICES REALIGNED COUNTY ARE
AT EXTREME RISK AND IN DIRE
NEED OF DIRECT STREET THE
RECORD. WE REFER YOU TO OUR
JOINT RATE TESTIMONY AND A
STRONG URGE YOUR SUPPORT WE
ALSO ARE DUE TO RESTORE THE
FAMILY URGENT RESPONSE SYSTEM-
FOR NINE TO PROVIDE TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN COMMON FORM SUPPORT THE
CURRENT AND FORMER FOSTER YOU
AND K. THE HOT LINE AND COUNTY.
MOBILE RESPONSIVE. THE BILL DO
YOU MORE. THAN EVER THE AND- I
THINK AND A NEW HOME OR EVEN TO
READ. TREATMENT PROVIDERS COME
TO ADD THÅU TO ENSURE THAT
RISK OF EXPOSURE TO THE CROWN
OR MINIMIZE WE ESTIMATED
WRITTEN TEST ADDRESS THE- FOR
EXAMINATION OF THE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OUTLINED ONE SEVEN
FOUR GLAD PLACE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS HEALTHCARE AND I'M
CALLING THE SENATE CAFE MANY OF
AGENCY. I WOULD HAVE BEEN A
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY SERVING
YOUTH AND FAMILIES ACROSS THE
ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
GRAVERT THIRTY YEARS. I WANT TO
TELL YOU THAT NAY WHO HAS LIVED
IN CONGREGATE CARE FROM ATTACK
OF FLIGHT. NATE IS ACTIVE IN
HIS KARATE DOJO COMMUNITY AND
BECAUSE OF HIS MENTOR THEIR.
TYLER BECAUSE OF HIS MENTOR
THERE TYLER TYLER IS EXPRESSED
INTEREST IN WELCOMING MADE INTO
A FAMILY HELLO BUT WAS WORRIED
ABOUT THE FINANCIAL AND
PHYSICAL SPACE LIMITATIONS. A
COVERED BEGAN TO TEAR HER
COMMUNITIES SENICA WORKED WITH
TAX FAMILY TO SECURE THE
FINANCIAL AND SOCIAL SERVICES
NECESSARY TO BECOME A PERMANENT
HOME. LAST MONTH NEED LIVED IN
THE BUILDINGS LITERALLY JUMPED
FOR JOY COATED WILL CONTINUE TO
IMPACT THE MOST VULNERABLE
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES IN OUR
COMMUNITY. IN AN OUTSIDE WAY.
CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE NEED
EVERY AVAILABLE SUPPORT RIGHT
NOW. NEAT STORY ILLUSTRATES
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCIES LIKE
SENECA DOES. WE MAKE SURE THAT
ALL CHILDREN CAN GROW UP AND
LOVING FAMILY HOME. WE URGE YOU
TODAY TO PRESERVE THE CRITICAL
FUNDING FOR FOSTER FAMILY
AGENCY SERVICES. THERE BUT MORE
VALUABLE NOW THAN EVER THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT WE WILL
OPEN NINE ONE NINE NINE GO
AHEAD PLEASE. HELLO THIS IS
JACKIE RETIRED FROM THE
CALIFORNIA LINE THE CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES. WE REPRESENT A
HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE
ACCREDITED AGENCY EVEN
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
ACROSS THE STATE. PROVIDING
FOSTER CARE SERVICES FOR EVERY
CHILD IN FOSTER CARE. I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE TWO THINGS FOR TODAY
ONE. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
TIME THAT YOUR ALLOWING
EVERYBODY TO SPEAK AND TO SPEAK
FROM THE HEART WE KNOW HOW
DIFFICULT THIS IS TO IMPLEMENT
PLEASE CUT. I WANT TO FIRST
POINT OUT THAT A 100% OF THE
YOUTH. THAT ARE IN THE SHORT
TERM RESIDENTIAL. PROGRAMS
FORMALLY KNOWN AS FOSTER CARE.
ARE ONLY WITH A COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND THEY ARE THE
MOST. CHALLENGING YEAR AND THEY
ALL. IN THESE PROGRAMS ARE THAT
THEY ARE NOT IN JUVENILE
DETENTION CENTERS AND I'M NOT
ON THE STREET. AND THEN THE
SECOND TAKE THE HIGHEST LEVEL
OF CARE AND THE OFTEN THE LAST
PLACEMENT OPTION BEFORE THE IS
HOSPITALIZED. AND THEY ARE.
IT'S CRITICAL TO NOT UNDERSTAND
THEM RIGHT NOW. WHEN THE COST
OR EVEN HIGHER TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE TAKING CARE OF BUSINESS
CRITICAL YOU. I ALSO WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT THE 5% RATE CUT
FOR THIS PROGRAM WHICH IS
CALLED AFTER DEEPLY DOES
VIOLATE LAW AS DECIDED IN A
LAWSUIT ALLIANCE FORCES WAGNER
AND ROSE AND WE WILL BE
BRINGING THAT UP TO THE STATE.
BUT I DID WANT TO MENTION THAT
THAT WAS A LAWSUIT THAT WAS
EDUCATED IN A CALL THE COURT.
AND WE DO NOT THINK THAT THE
ACTION IS LEGAL. THEN I'D LIKE
TO TALK ABOUT THE FOX FAMILY
AGENCY SOCIAL WORKER. 90%
IDENTIFIES SEEN ON THE LOWEST
PAID OF MASTER LEVEL SOCIAL
WORKERS. A THIRD ONE THIRD F
ALL FOSTER KIDS IN HOMES. AND A
100% OF ALL FOSTER KIDS IN A
CAMPUS SERVICES FOSTER CARE
WHICH IS. THE LEVEL THAT WE TRY
TO KEEP THEM AND SO THEY CAN
RETURN HOME. TO THAT- NOT AT
RISK OF GOING INTO THE HIGHER
CONGREGATE CARE AND FORTY PIECE
OF EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. AND
IT'S A 100% GUARANTEES DOCTOR
FAMILY AGENCY YOU DO HAVE A 59%
TURNOVER. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. RUBIO FOR TRANSFORM.
LET'S GO TO WORK BECAUSE DID
GET A ONE KIND THE LIVING LACK
YEAR. I WOULD LIKE TO JUST
POINT OUT THAT ONE SOCIAL
WORKER AS WITH BACK UP FROM THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS THAT. WOULD ONE SOCIAL
WORKER YOU HAVE A 75% TO NOT
ACCEPT A COMMON FATE A TOP 18%
WHEN YOU HAVE TO REMARKS. I
THINK WHAT'S REALLY MOST
IMPORTANT AS WE RECOGNIZE THAT
THESE CUTS ARE DRACONIAN THAT A
FIFTY FOUR BILLION DOLLAR.
BUDGET DEFICIT MUST BE FELT AND
THE PAIN IS REAL. AND IF THE
BEARD. HOWEVER FOR THE
PROCESSING AGENCY SOCIAL
WORKERS WE HAVE PARTICIPATED IN
A STUDY THAT TOOK TEN YEARS TO
GET OFF THE GROUND. IT IS GOING
TO BRING IN FEDERAL FUNDING
IT'S BEING IMPLEMENTED.
POSSIBLY IN THE NEXT TWO WEEKS
JEFF TO PROVE FROM THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION OF CHILDREN AND
FAMILY. IT WILL PAY FOR THE
CUT. THAT'D BE PROPOSED THIS
ONE TIME CUT ONE TIME COLA.
THAT WAS JUST A NOT. BARELY
ENOUGH TO KEEP. THE FATHER CAME
AGENCY SOCIAL WORKERS. 90%
FEMALE 100% OF THE CONTENT OF
SOME OF THE TALK TO CARE. SO.
THE PROPOSAL IS REALLY. AND I'M
THE MEDIC BECAUSE IT A RED TO
STAFF AND WE- TO ALLOW THE COST
OF LIVING COULD NOT BE CUT IN
THE MIDDLE OF THIS CALENDAR
YEAR WHICH IS REALLY
DEVASTATING. TO LET IT GO TO
THE END OF THE YEAR AND WE ARE
GAMBLING AND BETTING. THAT THE
NEW FUND COMING UP IN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL BACK
SELECT AND THEN IF IT DOESN'T
COME IN YOU CAN ELIMINATE THAT
AND THAT I SHOULD POINT OUT WE
ARE UNDER THE TRIGGER SO
HOPEFULLY THAT WILL COVER IT
BUT IF IT DOESN'T COVER IT.
WE'LL FIND THE FUNDS FOR THAT.
SO JUST REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT. FOR THE FOSTER YEARS.
EITHER SOCIAL WORKER. AND FOR
THE KIDS AFTER KEEPING THAT
THERAPEUTIC PLACEMENT SO THAT
THEY ARE NOT. GIVEN A CHOICE
NOT GIVEN A CHANCE TO IMPROVE
AND GET BETTER AND FIND TO
NOTHING THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU MA'AM.
GOING OUT TO LINE ONE NINETY
THREE GO AHEAD PLEASE. HELLO MY
NAME IS TRICIA SO GLAD. I AM
CALLING TO EXPRESS MY CONCERN
FOR THE GOOD DISCOVERED NEW
BUDGET PLAN TO REMOVE THE MULTI
PURPOSE SENIOR SERVICES GRAHAM%
THE NSF FEE FROM THE BUDGET AND
REDUCE DEL MAR CARE GIVER
RESOURCE CENTER FUNDING. I'M A
NURSE AND SANTA CRUZ IN
MONTEREY COUNTY AND THAT HE-
AND I HAVE SEEN HOW THE PROGRAM
COURT OVERLOOKING YEARS. TO
CONTINUE TO LIVE IN THEIR OWN
HOME TO MONTHLY COORDINATED
CARE. EACH LOW INCOME SENIOR
HAS THEIR OWN SOCIAL WORK CARE
MANAGER. WHO HELPED THE CLIENT
EXCEPT ACCESS THE PROGRAM
RESOURCES. MEDICAL CARE FOOD
TRANSPORTATION AND CARE GIVERS
THANK YOU QUIT MEANT AND
SOCIALIZATION THAT VULNERABLE
IN YOUR NEEDS TO AVOID HAVING
TO MOVE OUT OF THEIR OWN HOME
AND INTO A NURSING HOME CARE
FACILITY. DURING THE COLD
MAKING PANDEMIC THE IMPORTANCE
OF AVOIDING A NURSING HOME
ENVIRONMENT BECOMES EVEN MORE
PRESSING. MANY OF THE MAJOR
COVERT NINETEEN OUTBREAKS HAVE
BEEN IN SKILLED NURSING HOME
AND LIVE A LOT. THAT PUTS THE
FRAIL ELDERLY AT INCREASED RISK.
OF ISOLATION ILLNESS AND DEATH
THIS YEAR HE PROGRAMS SUPPORT
AND PROVIDES EDUCATION AND
RESPITE CARE GIGER. OF THE
NORMAL POPULATION MANY OF WHOM
OUR FAMILY MEMBERS THE FAMILY
MEMBERS BENEFIT FROM THE
RESOURCES THAT BOTH THE MS FEE
AND HERE THE PROGRAM TO PROVIDE
HELP AND TAKE CARE OF THEIR
ELDERS AT HOME. IT'S SO
IMPORTANT TO OUR SENIORS TO BE
ABLE TO MAINTAIN A LIVING AS
INDEPENDENTLY AS POSSIBLE IN
THEIR OWN STATE. AND FOR THOSE
WITH DEMENTIA IT ALLOWS THE
MORE FAMILIAR ENVIRONMENT WE
CAME. AND CARE GIVERS THAT HELP
DECREASE EDUCATION THE
DISORIENTATION. THE PROGRAMS
THAT HELP THE HONOR AND CARE
FOR ELDERS I'M MORE MORE COST
EFFECTIVE THAN HAVING THE STATE
PAY FOR RESIDENTIAL KILLED
NURSING CARE IN A NURSING HOME.
THE MEASURE OF OUR SOCIETY IS
SHOWN IN THE COMPASSION AND
CARING OF ARE VULNERABLE
MEMBERS. I UNDERSTAND YOU FACE
MANY DIFFICULT BUDGET DECISION
AND I THANK YOU FOR YOUR CIVIL
SERVICE DURING THIS CHALLENGING
TIME. THANK YOU MA'AM- WE DO
HAVE FIFTY TWO PEOPLE IN QUEUE
AT THE MOMENT. NEXT CALLER
OPERATOR. NEXT IN LINE TWO ZERO
FIVE GLAD. CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT MY NAME
IS KATHY QUITE YET AND I WORK
AT HUNTINGTON HOSPITAL ONE OF
THE STATE AND THE COULD BE
PROVIDERS. THE PROPOSAL IN THE
NATION OF THE MST P. PROGRAM
PARTICULARLY DURING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS. WOULD HAVE A
DEVASTATING EFFECT ON THE
SAFETY. OF A VERY VULNERABLE
POPULATION BY INCREASING
INJURIES. HOSPITALIZATIONS
INSTITUTIONALIZATION AND THAT.
IN THE FIFTEEN YEARS THAT I'VE
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
INVOLVED WITH THEM AT THE P. I.
P. SO MANY EXAMPLES OF IMPROVE
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR PROGRAM
PARTICIPANTS. WHEN OUR TEAM
PROVIDE THE CRITICAL SUPPORT
THAT ALLOW THEM TO REMAIN SAFE
IN THE COMMUNITY. PLEASE HELP
ME THRILLED SENIOR BY REJECTING
THE PROPOSAL TO ELIMINATE AND
ASSIST CREATE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. NEXT COMES LINE ONE
ELEVEN GO AHEAD. LINE ONE
ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WE
WILL MOVE ON TO LINE ONE SEVEN
EIGHT GO AHEAD YES SIR HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES SIR. CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES SIR. CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES SIR I'M SORRY- OKAY
OKAY MY NAME IS RICK HAWKINS
I'M A FORMER MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES CONSUMER
ADVISORY COMMITTEE IS THAT'S
YOU PARK MONO WAS OUR SERVER
ALPINE COLUSA EL DORADO NEVADA
PLASTER SACRAMENTO SIERRA
SUTTER YOLO AND YUBA COUNTIES.
AND THE FIRST A LOT OF I DON'T
KNOW HOW MANY PEOPLE IN OUR-
IDT COMMUNITY SPOKE BEFORE ME
BUT I WANTED TO SAY FIRST OFF
MISTER FRAZIER MR FRAZIER THANK
YOU SO MUCH. FOR STANDING UP
FOR US AND ONE ENOUGH CUTS
ENOUGH CUTS. CERTAIN FOR THOSE
WHO SPOKE ABOUT THE UNIFORM
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE I WANTED TO
TALK ABOUT. EMPLOYMENT SERVICES
JUST AS WELL SO I'LL LET
SERVICES I GET FROM STRATEGIES
TO EMPOWER PEOPLE. PARTICULARLY
THAT WHEN IT COMES TO
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES YOU KNOW IF
I CAN AVOID WORKING ON A
HOLIDAY I WILL BUT THAT WHAT IF
I HAVE TO WORK ON A HOLIDAY-
AND I NEED AND I'M STILL.
GETTING ACQUAINTED TO MY JOB
AND STILL NEW TO MY JOB I MIGHT
NEED A JOB COACH AND IF I STILL
NEED A JOB COACH BECAUSE MY
EMPLOYER. INSISTS BUT I WORK ON
A HOLIDAY. I AM NOT GOOD YOU
KNOW I CAN'T AVOID WORKING ON
HOLD ENOUGH I STILL NEED A JOB
COACH. I AM NOT GOING TO. I'M
NOT GONNA TELL MY EMPLOYER WELL
LET LOW LOOK I CAN'T IF I DON'T
HAVE A JOB COACH I CAN'T WORK.
THE JOB COACH SAYS THE EMPLOYER
MIGHT SAY WELL EITHER YOU WORK
OR- YOU'RE FIRED AND IF I NEED
A JOB COACH BECAUSE I'M STILL
NEW TO THE JOB. THAT YOU KNOW I
NEED A JOB COACH SO THE UNIFORM
HOLIDAY SCHEDULES NOT GOING TO
WORK. AND I JUST CAN'T HELP BUT.
TALK ABOUT I HSS. IF YOU HAVE
DIABETES AND YOU NEED IN HOME
SUPPORT SERVICES TO HELP YOU
CHECK YOUR BLOOD SUGAR BECAUSE
YOU CAN'T SEE WELL ENOUGH TO
CHECK IT BY YOURSELF ANYMORE.
EVEN IF YOU HAVE CONTINUOUS
GLUCOSE MONITORING. BECAUSE THE
CONTINUOUS GLUCOSE MONITORING
SYSTEM THAT YOU HAVE BUT WHAT
YOU CAN CHECK WITH YOUR IPHONE
IS NOT ALWAYS ACCURATE. THEN
THAT'S ANOTHER ISSUE THERE. AND
SEVERAL PEOPLE MENTIONED THAT
SAYS SORRY. AND MAYBE SOMEONE
MENTIONED CALTRAIN SHUT DON'T
KNOW LUCKILY I DON'T I DON'T
GET US A SONG I GET A SIXTY ARE
YOU. AND I MISS YOU GUYS ON THE
COMMITTEE ON THIS COMING DOWN
BUT- UNABLE TO CALL IN AND
SPEAK ON THE PHONE. AND IF
THESE CUTS SHOULD GO THROUGH
BECAUSE WE DON'T GET THE
FEDERAL MONEY I'M NOT GOING TO
BLAME THE DEMOCRATS SOME OF THE
BLAME THE OTHER PARTY. AND IT I
KNOW MITCH MCCONNELL AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL SAID THAT HE
WANTS STATES TO GO BANKRUPT AND
I DON'T WANT TO SEE THAT HAPPEN.
SO AGAIN I'M NOT GOING TO WIN
THE DEMOCRATS A LITTLE BLAME
THE OPPOSITE PARTY SO BY. YEAH
THANK YOU SIR AND WE MISS
SEEING YOU IN PERSON TO. NEXT
TO LINE TO FORTY TWO GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS THIS
IS MICHELLE GO WITH CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER WE ARE
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF GOVERNMENT
BUDGET INVESTMENT AND THE MARY
FIVE FOUR ONE CALIFORNIA I WON
THE SHOWCASE OUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND HAVE A
WONDERFUL DAY. THANK YOU MA'AM.
AND WE GO TO LINE TWO FORTY
THREE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU CARE
AND COMMITTEE THIS IS LISA WITH
LARGE SITE DIRECTOR AT SOURCE
LIGHT THE ANTENNA CLARA COUNTY.
SINCE MID MARCH OUR SITE HAS
SOLD ITSELF A PARTNER IN THE
RESPONSE TO COPE WITH NINETEEN
WORKING HARD TO KEEP OUR
CLIENTS SAFE AT HOME AS THE MS
A T. HAS DONE FOR FORTY ONE
YEARS. WE SERVE ALMOST TWELVE
THOUSAND CLIENTS ACROSS THE
STATE SOME HAVE NO FAMILY. SOME
HAVE CAPACITY TO REJECT
INSTITUTIONAL HELP BUT NOT BUT
AND NOT TO MENTION TO MAKE THEM
UNSAFE ASK YOU TO REJECT THE
ELIMINATION OF THE MSRP
ESPECIALLY AT THIS TIME INSTEAD
ENGAGE A SIMILAR SPONSOR COCA
NINETEEN TO CONTINUE OUR WORK
OF KEEPING SENIORS SAFE AT
HOME. AVOID HOSPITALIZATION
NURSING HOME PLACEMENT AND
AVOID THE PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS
FROM TOO FEW BEDS. IN THE
FUTURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM. GO TO LAW TO SEVENTY TWO
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU JACKIE
GONZALEZ WITH AND GRINNED AND
ADVOCATE GOOD AFTERNOON I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE HOW
WE TO MEMBRANE- YOU KNOW OUR
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATION
COULD SPEAKING ABOUT TODAY AND
I WOULD HAVE THAT THERE THAT
WOULD BE HARD PRESSED TO FIND A
COMMUNITY MORE VULNERABLE
TODAY. THE GREAT DETECTION OUR
STATE AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
AFTER AND I'M GLAD PARTICULARLY
PREHISTORIC LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE ON BOARD WITH THE WORLD
TOUGHEST. AND ALSO- THEY
MIGRANT POPULATION IN GENERAL I
JOIN THE PREVIOUS CALLER I'M
NOT MAKING FOR THE DUE PROCESS
IN THE COUNTRY PROGRAMS IT'S A
PROGRAM THAT WOULD LAUNCH FOR A
WHITE SHIRT AT THE. IN THE-
BECAUSE- MICHAEL COULD NOT WE
NEED TO EIGHT AFTER I'D BE FOR
THE B. UMBILICAL MANY OF YOUR
MIND IF SEEN JUST WEEKS AGO THE
FIRST CALL THE DEATH IN PENSION
NEED HIGHER COULD PLACE RIGHT
HERE IN HELP AND LIKE ADVOCATES
HAVE BEEN MORE IT WITH FOURTEEN
ANOTHER WHITE REVENTABLE. THE
GENTLEMAN WHO HAPPENS TO BE
MAKING AT THE CURTAIN DIABETES
WHAT TO A WHEELCHAIR AND HAD
LIVED IN NINETY EIGHT FOR
NEARLY FOUR DECADES- THE
GENTLEMAN WHO LANGUISH IN
DETENTION INSTEAD OF RECEIVING
MEDICAL CARE BUT BECAUSE OF THE
STOCKS IN YOUR CARE OPPORTUNITY
FACILITIES HE WAS NOT TAKEN OFF
THAT CAN BE TREATED UNTIL IT
WAS TOO LATE- A RECENT STUDY
PREDICTS ANYWHERE BETWEEN 72%
21100% RATE OF INFECTION I.
THINK WE SHOULD WIDE WITHIN
NINETY DAYS FROM ACTUALLY
MAKING THE TECHNOLOGY AND I
WOULD SAY THAT THAT COULD GET
YOU CAN CONFIRM BUT NOTHING
GRADING ACTUALLY BUT I THINK
IT'S BEEN PREDICTING DUE TO THE
NEGLIGENCE OF OPERATING BUT
POLICE TO THIRTY THAN ALL OF
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S
FAILURE TO COME UP WITH A PLAN-
THAT STUDY PREDICT HOW HOSPITAL
THAN IT USED IN THESE REGIONS
AND- CITY FORTY FACILITIES ARE
LOCATED WILL ALSO BE
OVERWHELMING I IT BEARS
MENTIONING THAT I WOULD BE IN
THIS EIGHT- ARE PROTECTED
LOCATED IN THE REGION- THAT ARE
THE LEAST EQUIPPED TO DEAL.
WITH AN ADDITIONAL BURDEN
INCLUDING YOURS DOCTOR ADAM
BLACK AND. WITH ME AND THAT
GETS. IT FACT I SAY THAT THE
DATE THEY HAVE COME UP WITH NO
AND FOR. ALL EFFORT. IN
MINISTRY FONG FLAT. ON THE
ISSUE EVERYTHING UP FOR. I ANY
HAVE LED BY NOW. DOESN'T IN
FACT AND OF WHICH IT ON THE-
AND FOR THAT I'M THANK YOU. FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND WORKING OF
JOE OUTSIDE WITH THE- BEFORE IT
IS. AND WE FIRMLY BELIEVE OUR
STATE LEADER. AND MY BACK TO
PUT THAT. A THE IMAGE TWENTY.
RIGHT NOW. WE DO PROP
CONVENTION PROBE IS THAT. BE
CHECK IN THE MEMBER. AND IT
WOULD PROVIDE THE- ILLEGAL.
ADVOCATE MAKE SURE. THAT EVEN.
I THANK YOU. FROM THE GREAT
CONTENT. AND YOU REUNITE
FAMILIES. THE PROPOSAL ALSO
LIKE AT THE PORT IT DOESN'T. OR
ACROSS STATE THAT YOU OFFER.
COULD POTENTIALLY. PART WITH
THE STATE ON THIS INITIATIVE
INCREASING ACT WITH THE COUNCIL
FOR INDIVIDUAL. TO TAKE RIGHT
NOW COULDN'T BE MORE CRITICAL
ECONOMIC VIABLE WAYS. OF
REDUCING THE VISUAL SAVING
LIVES AND AT THE SAME TIME
PROTECT IT AROUND YOU
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA FROM
THE SPREAD OF THE VIRUS. I'LL
STATE YOU KNOW WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT ALL THE CUTS THAT ARE
BEING MADE. AND THIS ISN'T A
QUESTION OF BEING CUT THIS IS
ACTUALLY AN AREA WITH THE STATE
HAS FAILED TIME AND AGAIN TO
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
ACTING. ON A OF A CRISIS THAT
OTHERWISE BE AVOIDED. AND WILL
BE LEFT TO PAY THE PRICE SO I
URGE YOU- TO DO EVERYTHING IN
YOUR POWER. TO CURB THIS
PROJECT TO DO PROPER TESTING
PROGRAM OFFERS WILL LOOK VIABLE
PATHWAY TOWARD AT NINE. CORD
AND ON. THE YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM. THE MOVE DOWN TO LA. TWO
ZERO SIX GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
KAREN COMMITTING FOR THE PROPER
TO BRING BOY TO THE PA CARE
DURING THE BUDGET REVISION
DISCUSSION MY NAME IS WORKING
MATTHEWS I AM A PROGRAM
DIRECTOR WITH ALTERNATIVE
FAMILY SERVICE HE AND I'VE
WORKED WITH FOSTER YOUTH FOR
TWENTY FOUR YEARS. ALTERNATIVE
FAMILY SERVICES HAS SERVICE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA FOR OVER
FORTY YEARS. I'M DUE TO LOW
WAGES FOSTER FAMILY AGENCIES
HAVE GREAT DIFFICULTY
MAINTAINING STAFF MEMBERS THERE
BY COCKING FURTHER TRAUMA. TO
THE MOST VULNERABLE POPULATION.
STAFF TURNOVER CONTINUES TO BE
A DETRIMENT TO PERMANENCY FOR
OUR POSTURE YOU. AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE CUTS TO
FOSTER CARE IN THE FORM OF THE
ELIMINATION OF 4% COLA. I KNOW
THAT THE INDEED UNPRECEDENTED
TIMES CUT MIGHT BE MADE. BUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE FOSTER
CARE NOT CONTINUE TO BEAR THE
BRUNT OF EACH BUDGET FOR ALL.
ARE APPRECIATED COMMITTEE AND
ENJOYED LISTENING TO YOUR
THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS REGARDING THIS
BUDGET. I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING WATCHING YOU PROVIDE
PROTECTIONS FOR AND OVERSIGHT
TO THIS BUDGET CYCLE. AS GLIDER
LITERALLY AT STAKE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND
THIS OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU
MA'AM. YOU OPEN UP LINE TWO OH
SEVEN GO AHEAD PLEASE. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
MA'AM HELLO. YEAH THE GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I AM
AND YOU CAN ON A MONTENEGRO AYE
YEAH MONEY IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICE PROVIDER IN SAN DIEGO
AND I'D BEEN CARING FOR MY
COULD SURVIVE IN
DEVELOPMENTALLY TALENT. AND
BOBBING CARING FOR HER FOR
ALMOST SIXTEEN YEARS NOW. I AM
QUALITY BECAUSE BE IMMENSELY
ALL POLL. BUT HE THE ACTION OF
WEAPON FIRSTHAND IN THE NUMBER
OF OUR- CLIENTS ARE ALREADY
YES. AND YOU KNOW THE 7% CAUCUS
AFTER A DOUBLE EDGE OF NIGHT.
DOUBLE A DIFFICULT FIRST IT
WILL BE OF OR THEY WOULD
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY THE
MOST WILL NEVER FOR MEMBERS OF
OUR COMMUNITY. TO REDUCE. OUR
WHICH WILL PUT THEM UP WITH AND
LIGHT AND WE HAVE TO REMEMBER
ALSO THAT THE PROVIDERS ARE NOT
ONLY ESSENTIAL WORKERS WE ARE
ALSO ONE LINERS IN TAKING CARE
OF THE MOST VULNERABLE MEMBERS
NO THE OTHER END OF THE YEAR
THE REDUCTION OF THE SEVEN
HOURS WE ALSO WE DO. THE OF ALL
OF ALL ABOUT AND- WE'RE WE'RE
BY EVEN THERE IN. THE COST OF
THE OF OUR- ONLY BE DOING BUT
REDUCED THE EIGHT WE WOULD
CALIFORNIA YOUR- ARM AND
ECONOMIC BECAUSE OF THE BUT HOW
CAN HAVE ECONOMIC RECOVERY WHEN
THE VERY COOL REST OF THE POOR.
THANK YOU CAN GIVE BIRTH AND
PROVIDERS ARE UP PAID BACK UP.
OUR SO THAT GIVEN THE LAST HOUR
AND LEFT EIGHT UP FOR THE
PROVIDER BUT REMEMBER THE BILL
THE MONEY THAT YOU COULD BE UP
WOULD BE PUT BACK TO THE BY BY
YOU THEN SO AND. FOR THEIR
FAMILY. WITH THE YOU KNOW THE
PROVIDER ALL OF THE CALLS WE
LOOK OFF COULD NOT MAKE
DEVELOPING. BUT BUT LEAVING
THEM MORE FIVE IN ORDER TO. THE
REDUCTION THE SEVEN AFTER THE
REDUCING THAT OKAY I KNOW.
ALWAYS THE SEVEN FOR SCOTT. BOB
I EVEN ASK FOR MORE OUR OUR FOR
OUR CLIENTS AND YOU BETTER PAY
FOR THE PROVIDER ACROSS THE
MEMBER WE ARE NOT ONLY WORKERS
WE ARE ONE LINERS TO AND
THEREFORE YOU HAVE TO THEIR ARE.
NEXT WE GO TO LINE TWO NINETY
TWO GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS AMY WEST
PLAYING AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL
BETTER AGENCIES I WANT TO THANK
BANK BUT CHAIR AND MEMBERS- AND
YOUR STAFF FOR CONVENING THIS
IMPORTANT HEARING AND A FOR-
ALLOWING FOR SUCH WERE BY THE
PUBLIC COMMENT. FIRST AND
FOREMOST WE DO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE- THE INCLUSION OF
DOLLARS AND I APPRECIATE THOSE
FOR THE RESPONSE THAT RESULT
BETTER THAN THEIR COMMUNITIES
SERVICE PROVIDER PARTNERS. I
HAVE HAD IN THE RESPONDING TO
THE KOBE AND HEALTH CARE
CRISIS- YOU. OUR COMMUNITY HAS
HAD TO REACT VERY QUICKLY AND
HAS HAD TO- CHANGE SERVICES FOR
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE AND REACT WITH- VERY
NIMBLE AND CREATIVE SERVICE
DELIVERY AND APPRECIATE THE
FISCAL RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT. LOOKING AHEAD TO NEXT
YEAR I THINK EVERYONE. YOU
TROUBLED BY THE- THE PROSPECT
OF BE ECONOMIC SITUATION BUT
LIFE AND BROUGHT ABOUT AND I
WANT TO CALL OUT SPECIFICALLY
THE PROPOSED PROVIDER CUT. AND
SPECIFICALLY BE THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
WHICH TRANSLATES TO ALMOST HALF
A BILLION DOLLARS IN- RATE CUTS
AND OTHER EFFICIENCIES THE-
PURCHASE OF SERVICE. WE KNOW
THAT THIS FIFTEEN HAVE
STRUGGLED MIGHTILY WITH UNDER
FUNDING FOR A VERY LONG TIME
AND ARE CONCERNED THAT THESE
TYPES OF CUTS. WILL RESULT IN
LESS QUALITY OF LIFE- MORE
ABUSE AND NEGLECT THAT GOES
UNDETECTED BECAUSE OF MORE
PROFESSIONAL YOU HAVEN'T
SOMEONE LIKE THE GREATER THE
LIKELIHOOD. THAT THIS
VULNERABLE POPULATION HAS
ADDITIONAL EYES ON THEM- WE ARE
IN THE PROCESS OF TRANSITIONING
TO A NEW NORMAL YOU KNOW OUR
OLD NORMAL WAS THERE FOR A VERY
LONG TIME. AND THEN WE KIND OF
ONE INCH OF THIS PLACE WHERE OF
COURSE BECAUSE OF- CONCERNED
ABOUT CONGREGATE SETTING AND-
WE NEED TO SOCIALLY DISPENSED.
FOR VULNERABLE POPULATIONS WERE
IN THE MIDDLE OF TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT TOMORROW LOOKS
LIKE AND THE DAY AFTER AND THE
DAY AFTER THAT AND THEN FINALLY
WATER NEAR NORMAL BOOKS LIKE-
WE WOULD ENCOURAGE THAT AS WE-
MOVE INTO THAT PHRASE THAT
THERE BE- FUNDING MADE
AVAILABLE TO. ALLOW THE SYSTEM
TO BALANCE BUT HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF. PARTICIPANTS IN THE
PROGRAM BUT ALSO THE
PRESERVATION OF CRITICAL
RESOURCES AND THERE IS A
DOCUMENT THAT WAS SUBMITTED BY
A NUMBER OF SERVICE PROVIDERS.
THAT OUTLINED THE REALLY NICE
PLAN FOR HOW TO BALANCE THOSE
TWO INTEREST. AS WE MOVE
FORWARD AND WE MUST NOT FORGET
THAT IN THIS TIME ONE OF THE
REMARKABLE THINGS THAT WE'VE
SEEN IS THAT PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES HAVE
HAD MUCH MUCH LOWER RATE THAT
OKAY NINETEEN. EXPOSURE
DIAGNOSIS AND DEATH THEN WE
WOULD HAVE ANTICIPATED GIVEN
THE MEDICAL FERTILITY AND
VULNERABILITY OF THE POPULATION
AND WE OWE THAT TO THE DIRECT
SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS WHO HAVE.
REALLY DONE AMAZING WORK WITH
THEM. AND SO IT'S KIND OF
IRONIC THAT NOW WE'RE IN A
SPACE WHERE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HAVING TO MAKE CUTS TO THAT
VERY- GRADUAL WORKFORCE.
ADDITIONALLY WE ARE CONCERNED
AND OPPOSE THE- THE PROPOSED
CUTS CHIU RESULT IN OUR
OPERATIONS. THE HOW MANY A TIME
WHEN HE SAID MORE TO THE
PROVIDER NETWORK WE DON'T
CENTERS WERE ALREADY STRUGGLING
UNDER EXISTING MANDATES WE WERE
OVER EIGHT HUNDRED SERVICE
COORDINATOR SHORT STATEWIDE.
AND NOW WE CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND
THE NEED TO INCREASE ACCESS TO
GENERIC RESOURCES AGAIN TO
PROVIDE REALLY ROBUST SERVICES
TO PEOPLE AND DOING THAT WHILE
AT THE SAME TIME FINDING IF IT
SHOULD BE THE FUNDING IS JUST A
VERY SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES-
AND ONE THAT. MEANS THAT EACH
PERSON SERVED IN THE SYSTEM
POTENTIALLY COULD HAVE LAST
SERVICE COORDINATION EFFORTS AT
A TIME WHEN WE'RE EXPECTING-
GREATER NEED TO WALK PEOPLE
THROUGH GENERIC SERVICES
ADDING- ACCESSING THAT WAS AN
ESPECIALLY THE MEDI CAL PROGRAM.
AS AN ASSOCIATION WE ARE
COMMITTED TO MOBILIZING OUR
COMMUNITY TO DO YOUR PART CHIU-
SERVE AS- TO SECURE IT MUCH FF
HE IS POSSIBLE. AND FINALLY I
DO WANT TO NOTE GO SIGNIFICANT
CONCERN WE HAVE ABOUT PROPOSED
CUTS TO MEDICAL PROGRAM- ICF
GREAT BE BAD I INTEREST THAT
BECAUSE THESE ARE ALSO PROGRAMS
THAT PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES RELY UPON.AND
THAT HISTORICALLY WHEN THEY'RE
BEEN CUTS IN THOSE PROGRAMS.
REGIONAL BETTORS HAVE BEEN
THERE TO BACK FILL SOME OF THE-
UNMET NEEDS THAT RESULTS IN
THAT. THE GOVERNORS BUT NAY
REVISION BUCKING CLUED
ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR REACH
AUTHORS TO DO THAT. SO WE ARE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT A LOT OF
THOSE NEEDS BETTER CREATED BY
THE- PROPOSED CUTS IN THOSE
OTHER. WILL BUT NEGATIVE VOTE
IMPACT ON THE LIVES OF PEOPLE
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU MA'AM. WE'LL GO NEXT TO
LINE ONE EIGHTY GO AHEAD PLEASE.
OUR GOOD AFTERNOON- MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CHRISTOPHER SPONSORS
WITH CHIRLA THE COALITION
GROOMING AND THE LIKE
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS ORGANIZATION DIRECTLY
REPRESENTING IMMIGRANT FAMILIES
WORKERS AND STUDENTS ACROSS THE
STATE. ONE OF THE GOVERNMENT'S
FOOTBALL ME AND THE ONE.
FUNDING WE JOIN OUR COLLEAGUE
IN SUPPORTING THAT DO PROFIT
THE DETENTION PROPOSAL ABOUT
MANY OF THEM HAVE SPOKEN ON
ALREADY. IT WOULD ALSO REQUEST
THAT THE COMMITTEE CONSIDER
PROVIDING FUND HE TOOK SPENDING
IN THE CALIFORNIA. PROGRAM AND
I CAN ENTER GRANT SUCKING A
QUICKLY BEEN PACKED IT I CALLED
NINETEEN DURING THESE TIMES OF
AN EMERGENCY. WE APPRECIATE THE
EFFORTS BY THE GOVERNOR TO
PROVIDE SOME RELIEF CENTER AND
WHATEVER YOU KNOW THAT THE YOU
GET MUCH GREATER IN THESE
COMMUNITIES. OF THE CONTINUE TO
BE LAUGHED OUT OF COURT IN
NINETEEN REALLY. OUR COMMUNITY
THERE ARE CERTAINLY LIVING
PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK AND
POVERTY AND A SURVEY CONDUCTED
BY A MEMBER THAN OTHERS SO THAT
THEY HAVE LIMITED TRAINING. TO
SUPPORT THEM DURING THESE TIMES.
WE ARE JOINED BUYER. BY MEMBER
BUYER MEMBERS NEAR THE- TO.
FIVE HUNDRED. AND ORGANS. WAS A
CLOUD YOU WITH OUR CAMPAIGN
YOUR FOR CALIFORNIA. I AND
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU SIR. WE GO TO
LINE TWO SIXTY FOUR GO AHEAD
PLEASE. HELLO MY NAME IS PATTY
WATCHES FIND THE NURSING
SUPERVISOR AT HUNTINGTON
HOSPITAL SENIOR KERR NETWORK
ONE OF THE AND THE TESTING
SITE. THANK YOU DOCTOR ARUGULA
AND- COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR YOUR
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK. I'M HERE
COMMENT DOCTOR ARAMBULA. HOW DO
WE MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR
ELDERS. I ECHO THE COMMENTS
ABOUT ALL MY STATEWIDE IMAGES
COULD COLLEAGUES. PLEASE DO NOT
ELIMINATE EMMA SAYS P. FOR MORE
THAN FORTY YEARS AND A FIFTY
IT'S BEEN SERVING AND HONORING
OUR OLDEST POOREST AND MOST
FRAIL CALIFORNIANS AND THEIR
FAMILY CARE GIVERS. THIS IS A
PROVEN COST EFFECTIVE MODEL OF
CARE. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU MA'AM. WE
GO NEXT TO LINE TWENTY EIGHT GO
AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN ARAMBULA AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE BINDING
FINALLY FLORES I'M A CLINICAL
SOCIAL WORKER AT THE HOSPITAL
AND A FIFTY FIVE. I IMPLORE YOU
TO PLEASE STOP THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL TO ELIMINATE
THE FIFTY THE AND THE FIFTY
FIVE AFTER YOU TO STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE NOMINATION OF THE
MULTI PURPOSE YES OF THE
PROGRAM. FOR OVER FORTY YEARS
AND THAT THIS HE HAS A GOOD
THING THE THIRD THE OLDEST CORD
UPHOLDS FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
HAVE A FAMILY CARE GIVERS AS AN
ALTERNATIVE. TO NURSING HOME
PLACEMENT. THEY OFTEN DON'T
CARE GIVE SUPPORT OR HAVE INPUT
THIS BEFORE WITHOUT AND THE-
GOVERNOR'S CUP PUT OVER TO
DOLLARS ALTHOUGH. AT A- BEST
BUT I HOME. AND THAT. AND THE
PEOPLE EVERYTHING ARE MORE BY
THAN EVER. GIVEN THE CALL THE
NINETEENTH AND THAT MAKES THE
FITTED IMPECCABLE UP OLDER
ADULTS. AS PREVIOUSLY STATED
ONE PROTOCOL BUT NINETEENTH
THAT. WHY THE PUBLIC THAT LA
COUNTY ARE NURSING HOME
RESIDENTS. WITH THIS BEING SAID
HE WORKED AT HOME IT'S A
PERFECT FOR THEM FOR THAT. AND
BE FROM FAMILY ARE COUNTING ON
YOU THE TOPIC. BUDGET PROPOSAL
ELIMINATE THEM AT THE THREE
THANK YOU. FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU MA'AM I DO WANT TO SAY THAT
WE FOR A FULL FORTY CUED UP TO
BE TO ASK QUESTIONS AND WITHOUT
RISKING IT I DO I DO WANT TO
SAY FOR THOSE OF YOU SINCE
THERE ARE A HUNDRED AND-
SIXTEEN OF YOU WHO ARE ON. THE
CALL AT THE MOMENT TO REMIND
YOU TO PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU
HAVE NOT DONE SO THUS FAR. IS
THAT WE'LL QUEUE YOU UP FOR A
QUESTION- IF FOR WHATEVER
REASON YOU ALREADY HAVE DONE IT
HITTING ONE ZERO WILL TAKE YOU
OUT OF LINE FOR THE QUESTION.
SO JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU'VE ONLY DONE IT ONCE AND
ONLY ONCE. WITHOUT OPERATOR CAN
YOU GET OUR NEXT CALLER. OVER A
LINE THREE ZERO SIX WELL I HAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
SANDRA TONTINE AND I WORK AT
THE HELP PROJECT CENTER AND
MISSISSIPPI AND SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY. I JUST WANNA TAKE A
MINUTE AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY AND FOR
TAKING THE TIME TO LISTEN TO
THESE COMMENTS. I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE ELIMINATION OF AND
THAT THAT HE AND I THINK YOU
HAVE HEARD CLEARLY FROM MY
OTHER EMESIS EAT COLLEAGUES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WHY THE
CUT AND THIS IS HE AND OTHER
PROGRAMS WOULD BE DEVASTATING
FOR OUR FRAIL SENIORS. WITH
SUCH TINY I THEREFORE WANTED TO
SHARE WITH YOU A LETTER FROM
ONE OF THE SENIOR IS ONE OF MY
LONG TIME AND A FIFTY CLIENTS
WHO ASKED ME TO READ A LETTER
THAT SHE. WROTE TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HER BEHALF. THE
HER LETTER IS ALL. YOUR
HONORABLE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
ON HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES I
IMPLORE YOU TO PLEASE KEEP MS
THAT THE EMBASSY ARE THE OPEN
THESE PROGRAMS HAVE LITERALLY
SAVED MY LIFE. I AM A FRAIL
MEDICALLY ISOLATED ELDER WHO
HAS BENEFITED TREMENDOUSLY FROM
THE PROGRAM UP AND EAT WITHOUT
IT I WOULD BE IN A NURSING HOME
AND SUFFERING MORE OR EVEN DAD.
AND MISSISSIPPI HAVE BEEN A
MUCH NEEDED SAFETY NET IF THE
SYSTEMS HAS PROVIDED ME WITH
LIFESAVING SERVICES SOME OF
WHICH INCLUDE SENIOR
COMPANIONSHIP FOOD RESOURCES
TRANSPORTATION TO MY MANY MANY
MEDICAL APPOINTMENT MONEY
MANAGEMENT PSYCHOLOGICAL AND
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT AND EVEN
ADDITIONAL HELP FROM OTHER
RESOURCES. IF I HAVE A CONCERN
OR NEED A MESSAGE HE IS THERE
FOR ME THERE'S AN INVALUABLE
PROGRAM HAD SAID THERE FOR
EMERGENCY AID BECAUSE MY
MEDICAL EXPENSES ARE SO GREAT
AT TIMES I HAVE BEEN NOT ABLE
TO AFFORD VERY BASIC
NECESSITIES. I'M A FIFTY HAVE
SUPPLIED ME WITH FOOD RESOURCES
AND EMERGENCY CALL NECKLACED
USED OR IF I HAVE AN EMERGENCY
WHEN I'M OFTEN LEFT ALONE IN MY
HOME ASSISTED TECHNOLOGY
MICROPHONE MICROPHONE BECAUSE I
AM BLIND THEY FOUND ME OTHER
RESOURCES FOR SPECIAL
EYEGLASSES AND MEDICALLY
NECESSARY FLEET BATES DURABLE
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT AND THE LIST
GOES ON AND ON. MY NOT HAVING
FAMILY AND FRIENDS AROUND
ANYMORE MEAN MUCH IS MISSING
FROM MY LIFE EVEN THOUGH I
RECEIVE MAXIMUM HOURS OF AYE
YOU TO FAST I HAVE MANY UNMET
NEED ITEMS THAT WAS NOT ABLE TO
DEAL WITH THESE DEFICIENCIES
MSF. AT HE COMPLEMENT I IT THAT
BY FILLING IN SOME OF THESE
GAPS AND MORE IT HELPS. PROVIDE
A COMPLETE LIFE. AND NOT DO.
THAT BEFORE THE PROGRAM I
FOLLOW THROUGH THE- I ALONE I
WOULD ISOLATED OXYGEN DEPENDENT
LEGALLY BLIND AND UNABLE TO DO
MUCH FOR MYSELF. I WAS GIVING
UP ON LIFE. THE MSRP PROGRAM
HAS HELPED ME RESTORE MY
DIGNITY MY INDEPENDENT AND HAS
GIVEN ME A REASON TO LIVE. I
VALUE MY EXISTENCE AND HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO REDISCOVER MYSELF
FOR. EVEN THOUGH LIFE AS I KNEW
IT IS GONE I AM AGAIN. I CAN
SEE MY VALUE AND MY ABILITY TO
CONTRIBUTE TO SOCIETY. HAVING
THE SUPPORT MAINTENANCE FROM AT
MISSISSIPPI ALLOWED ME TO GIVE
BACK TO MY COMMUNITY. I AM ABLE
TO DO THE THINGS THAT I LOVE.
GOAL LIKE ME OUT OF NURSING
HOME AS LONG AS POSSIBLE SHOULD
SAVE MONEY. RIGHT NOW ONE THIRD
OF DEATH FROM CODE NINETEEN ARE
IN NURSING HOME. I WOULD BE AT
RISK OF DEATH. EMPOWERING LOCAL
SERVICES LIKE MS AS HE TO
SUPPORT SENIORS LIKE ME TO
CONTINUE LIVING INDEPENDENTLY
AS LONG AS POSSIBLE IT REDUCES
THE HEAVY FINANCIAL BURDEN. OF
NURSING HOME ON OUR STATE.
PLEASE CONTINUE SAVING LIVES BY
SUPPORTING THE M. F. F. P.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR POSITIVE
ACTION TOWARDS BEGINNING AT MSN
PETE YOURS TRULY NATASHA EAT
THEM. THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU MA'AM.
WE'LL GO NOW TO LINE TO TWENTY
TWO GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS
RETURN HEALTY WITH THE CHILD
CARE RESOURCE CENTER WE SERVICE
THE LA AND FOUND BERNARDINO
REGION- I WANT TO QUICKLY
HIGHLIGHT THE PROPOSED 10% RATE
INCREASE FOR A CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS AND THE NAY REVISION.
WE STRONGLY URGE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REJECT THE
REDUCTION OF TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THREE POINT EIGHT
MILLION GENERAL FUND 410%
DECREASE AND THE REGIONAL
MARKET RATE. AND SINGLE RATE
REIMBURSEMENT FOR CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS IT'S IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE CHILD CARE SERVICES
AT THE CRITICAL COMPONENT TO
COMBAT IT CRISIS AND OUR
ECONOMIC RECOVERY. WE NEED TO
SUPPORT CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
DURING THIS TIME SO THAT THEY
CAN REMAIN OPEN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU MA'AM. WE
GO NEXT TO LINE THREE THIRTY
FOUR GO AHEAD. HELLO. YES MA'AM
BLINDS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
JEREMY ARE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JEAN
SCHROEDER SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
FIRST PLACE FOR YOU. WE PROVIDE
EXPAND FOSTER CARE SERVICES CAN
USE AGING OUT OF FOSTER CARE
INDEX OF THE HIGHEST COST
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA.
CONDITION AGE FACTOR YOU ARE
ONE OF THE MOST UNIQUELY
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS IN THE
STATE. EXPERIENCE UNACCEPTABLY
HIGH RATES OF HOMELESSNESS AND
OFTEN FACE THE TRANSITION TO
ADULTHOOD WITHOUT THE SUPPORT
OF ANY FAMILY OF THE LIABILITY
DAHLE. PROGRAM THAT THE COURT
IS AN EXTENDED FOSTER CARE
PARTICULARLY BE TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING PLACEMENT PROGRAM FOR
NON MINOR DEPENDENT OR CAGE FAN
ANDY. HAVE BEEN REALLY POWERFUL
TOOLS IN PREVENTING FOSTER
YOUTH HOMELESSNESS BUT THEY'RE
ALREADY UNDER TREMENDOUS STRAIN
WITH HUNDREDS OF ELIGIBLE YOUTH
ON WAITING LISTS. DUE TO
INADEQUATE WAIT THAT DON'T
REFLECT THE RISING COST OF
HOUSING. WE RECOGNIZE THE
SEVERITY OF THE DEFICIT AND
RESPECT BUT DIFFICULT DECISION
BUT THIS COMMITTEE HAVE TO MAKE
BUT WE ALSO URGE YOU TO PLEASE
DO ANYTHING YOU CAN TO ENSURE
THAT YOU AGING OUT OF FOSTER
CARE RECEIVE THE SUPPORT THEY
NEED TO WHETHER THIS PANDEMIC.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY TO AVOID
HOMELESSNESS. OPEN NINETEEN AND
THE ECONOMIC CRISIS WHAT'S
COMING OUT HAS ALREADY HAD OUR
PROGRAMS AND ARE USED THE
TICKET I WOULD HARD. WE ALONE
HAVE ALREADY BEEN OVER 50% OF
THEM POINT YOU'VE PLAYED OFF
HAVING THEIR HOURS CUT. AND
DURING THAT TIME OUR DOCTOR
ACTING AS FIRST RESPONDERS
CONTINUING TO MUSIC NEWS AND
FROM HOMELESSNESS. ENSURING
THAT THEY HAVE FOOD AND SOME
SUPPLIES BUT THEY UNDERSTAND
LOCAL ORDERS AND SOCIAL THE
BEEPING PROTOCOLS AND HAVE
ACCESS TO MEDICAL CARE AND
ADVICE. AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
PROMOTING A MENTAL AND%
EMOTIONAL WELL BEING AS THEY
NAVIGATE THE SCARY TIME AND
DEAL WITH THE IMPLICATION OF
ISOLATE. THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF
YOU SITTING ON WAY. NEED HOW
AND SERVICES. NOW MORE THAN
EVER AND WE URGE YOU TO DO
ANYTHING YOU CAN TO ENSURE THAT
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
SUPPORTED IN THE BUDGET THAT
CAGE THE AND- PROGRAMS ARE ABLE
TO MEET THEIR NEEDS. AND
PARTICULAR BY SUPPORTING THE
FAMILY MEMBER TANK BUDGET
PROPOSAL TO INCLUDE A HOUSING
SUPPLEMENT. I THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION
TODAY. THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT TO
LINE THREE THREE SEVEN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. HI A I'M DEFERRED TAX
ERA I AM A SOCIAL WORKER AT THE
MULTI PURPOSE IN YOUR SERVICE
PROGRAM IN SANTA CRUZ COUNTY
FOR THE PAST ELEVEN YEARS. I AM
OPPOSED TO THE FUNDING OF THE
NSS P. OUR CLIENTS ARE AMONG
THE MOST IMPOVERISHED AND
DISABLED OLDER ADULTS IN THE
MOST AT RISK POPULATION DURING
TE KOPET NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
THE END OF THE STATE IS THIS
PRO. BUT WE THIS A LAW OF.
BECAUSE WE DEVELOP LONG TERM
PROFESSIONAL RELATIONSHIPS.
THAT STABILIZE THE OLDER ADULTS
IN THEIR HOMES LESSENING THEIR
NEED FOR EXPENSIVE THE
EMERGENCY ROOM VISITS. AND WE
HELP THEM WITH THEIR HOME FOR
AS LONG AS POSSIBLE AND AVOID
LIVING IS COSTLY SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES AT THE END
OF THEIR LIVES. I DO APPRECIATE
YOUR SINCERE CONSIDERATIONS
THESE MATTERS. TO KEEP THESE
THE COURT IS AND COST EFFECTIVE
SERVICES AS THE BABY BOOMER
GENERATION AGES. ESPECIALLY
DURING THIS TIME OF THE
PANDEMIC. THANK YOU MA'AM. BOOK
TO LINE THREE TEN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. HI CHAIR ARAMBULA
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR ARRANGING THIS
WAY FOR US TO PROVIDE COMMENT
THIS IS SHANTI PRASAD WITH
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION AT THE
BANK AND I'M A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIANS FOR SFI COALITION
IN THE CALIFORNIA HUNGER ACTION
COALITION. I RESPECTFULLY BUT
STRONGLY OPPOSED AND REJECT THE
IDEA OF CUTTING ANYTHING FROM
APPETITE GRANT FOR THE ONE
POINT TWO MILLION SENIORS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES. MOST
OF WHOM ARE WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR WHO HAVE BEEN
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST
THROUGHOUT THEIR LIVES IN THE
LABOR MARKET. THAT'S ONE THING
COULD MY MOM WHO'S DESPITE
GETTING A BACHELOR'S DEGREE
SUFFERED FROM POVERTY
THROUGHOUT HER LIFE SHE LIVED
ON AT THE BY IN THE LAST YEARS
OF HER LIFE AND RIGHT NOW UNTIL
TWENTY ELEVEN. SHE AND SO MANY
OTHERS. ARE NOT BUYING HAVE
ALREADY EXPERIENCED ANOTHER
COMMA AND THEY CANNOT WAIT TO
HEAR IF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WILL COME THROUGH THE PREVENT
PROPOSED CUTS TO THE GRANT. IN
THE GREAT RECESSION THE GRANT
WOULD CUT TO THE BARE MINIMUM
BUT THE STATE IS REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE. WHICH PLUNGED DOWN
BELOW THE POVERTY LINE. FOR THE
LAST DECADE CLASS. WE'VE BEEN
FIGHTING TO RESTORE THE LEGACY
CáC FROM THE RECESSION OF
OTHER PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN
RESTORED AND YOU PROGRAMS HAVE
BEEN CREATED AND FUNDED. HOW
MANY YEARS AFTER A CO THE
PANDEMIC AND- OVER ONE MILLION
AFTER FIRE AT THE END OF A-
SUCKER UNITS HEALTH PRACTICE
THAT AFFECTS THE MORE THAN
ANYONE. HOW MANY YEARS WILL
THEY HAVE TO ASK. AND FIGHT.
AND BAG TO RESTORE TRUST THE
FIVE DOLLAR PROPOSED CUTS WHAT
ALONE THE FULL AMOUNT BUT WAS
CUT IN THE LAST RECESSION.
LEADING UP TO FIVE RECIPIENTS
NOW IT LEFT THE 90% OF THE
POVERTY LEVEL. AT RISK OF
LOSING THEIR HOMES.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AROUND YOUR
AFTER FOR THE PUBLIC COMMENT.
WHICH WAS A WILL BE GREAT ARE
THE TO RESPOND TO THE CODE
CRISIS. THIS CAR I'M NOT
VULNERABLE AT RISK AND MOST
CERTAINLY DEGRADES OUR ABILITY
TO RESPOND EFFECTIVELY. TO THE
COVERAGE I THANK. AT RISK OF
ACTUALLY NOT EVEN THE ISSUE. WE
HAVE BEEN FAILING OUR SENIORS
AND PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
DURING. THE RECENT BOOMING
ECONOMY. MOST MANY OF THEM ARE
NO LONGER JUST AT RISK. THEY
ARE LIVING IN AND FROM THE FREE
WEIGHTS AND DYING FROM CO THAT
NOW. IF NOT MORE REASON DOESN'T
MEAN OF THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR. CONSIDER THE ETHNIC
BY GRANT ON ECONOMIC
MULTIPLIER. EVERY TEN MILLION
DOLLARS AND I FIFTEENTH THE
COURTS FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
IN ECONOMIC OUTPUT. IF PROVIDE
NINETY THREE JOBS AND NEARLY
ONE MILLION AND STATE AND LOCAL
TAX REVENUE. ADDITIONALLY WHILE
WE ARE FOUR EIGHT BOOK A
KEEPING THE WHOLE HOW MUCH YOUR
QUESTION PROGRAMS INTACT. FOR
THE FFI HOUSEHOLDS WHO ARE ON
OUR ALL ABOUT HOW BEST BENEFIT.
WE WANT TO BRING ATTENTION TO
THE CURRENT INEQUITY IN THE
COVERT RESPONSE WITH REGARD TO
THE TRANSITIONAL NUTRITION.
BENEFIT PROGRAM. ONE ECHO
MICHAEL HERALD COMMENT ABOUT
ABOUT THE PROGRAM AND- SAY THAT
PROGRESS HOUSEHOLDS ARE
RECEIVING THE MAXIMUM MONTHLY
ALLOTMENT FOR MARCH APRIL AND
MAY- AS OUR KEEP UP PROVIDERS
REBELS WHO ARE RECEIVING TOP. I
THANK THE RECIPIENT SHOULD ALSO
RECEIVE THE MAXIMUM BENEFIT AS
WELL. WE MUST FIND A WAY SO
THAT WE DO NOT CUT AT THE THIGH
PROGRAM OR THOSE ALRIGHT SO
LONG AFTER BY WHO ARE
RECEIVING. CERTAIN BENEFITS ANY
MORE THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM.
WE GO NOW TO LINE ONE HUNDRED
GO AHEAD PLEASE. HI MY NAME IS
PATRICK WILSHIRE WORKER CARE
MANAGER FOR CATHOLIC CHARITIES
AND STOCKTON. AND ELIMINATING
THE PROGRAMWOULD BE A MISTAKE
ESPECIALLY WITH THE CURRENT
PANDEMIC IT WOULD PART ARE
SENIORS MORE AT RISK IN IT
WOULD INCREASE THE NUMBERS IN
THE HOSPITALS AND NURSING
HOMES. AND THE POSSIBLE SPREAD
I ONLY ASK THAT YOU KEEP IT AS
IT WOULD HELP WITH THE PANDEMIC
IN KEEPING. NUMBERS DOWN IN IT
WOULD HELP THEM AS WELL TO STAY
HOME INDEPENDENTLY AS LONG AS
POSSIBLE. AND THAT IS THAT AS
WITH MOST OF MY COWORKERS- HAVE
SAID A LOT ABOUT THE PROGRAM
ALREADY. THANK YOU. WE MOVED TO
LINE THREE THIRTY TWO GO AHEAD
PLEASE. MY NAME'S KATIE WELCOME
REPRESENTING THE ASSOCIATION OF
COMMUNITY HUMAN SERVICE
AGENCIES AND LA COUNTY ECHOING
THE COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES
TODAY I'M CALLING TO EXPRESS
THEIR CONCERN REGARDING THE
PROPOSED ELIMINATION OF THE
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY SOCIAL
WORKER RATE INCREASES. I WANTED
TO SPEAK TO HOUSE SOCIAL
PARTICULARLY THE FAITH SO
WORKERS ARE SO URGENTLY NEEDED
FOR OUR FOSTER USE- TURKEY WITH
INSTEAD- FOSTER FAMILY AGENCIES
TAKE CARE OF THIRTEEN THOUSAND
FOSTER KIDS DAILY WHICH IS ONE
THIRD OF ALL FOSTER KIDS IN
HOME TODAY. AS WELL A FIFTH OF
SMOKERS CERTAIN SUPPORT A 100%
OF ALL FOSTER YOUTH IN
INTENSIVE SERVICES FOSTER CARE
IN SOME OF THE MOST CHALLENGING
SITUATION. UNFORTUNATELY A
FAITHFUL SO WORKERS ALREADY
HAVE 859% TURNOVER RATE DUE TO
LOW WAGES. AS PREVIOUSLY STATED
TODAY STUDIES HAVE PROVEN THAT
ONE OF FOSTER YOUTH DEVELOP THE
CONNECTION TO MAINTAIN A
RELATIONSHIP WITH ONE SOCIAL
WORKER THROUGHOUT THEIR STAY IN
FOSTER CARE THERE'S A 75%
PERMITTED. PERMANENTLY RATE FOR
THAT YOU. PERMANENTLY RATE
DROPPED EIGHTEEN. WHEN THEIR
CASE SHIP FROM WORK WITH TWO OR
MORE WORKER THEY'RE OUT THERE
TIME IN FOSTER CARE. REDUCING
FUNDING TO SOCIAL WORKERS WILL
SEVERELY UNDERCUT THE CHANT THE
PERMANENCY FOR OUR FOSTER YOU.
I STRONGLY URGE YOU TO OPPOSE
THE FROM THE NATION AND TO
INCLUDE THE FUNDING IN THE
BUDGET AT THE PRIORITY FOR
APPROVAL ON JUNE FIFTEENTH.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO CRIED COMMENT. REMOVED EXTRA
LINE THREE TO FOUR GO AHEAD
PLEASE. THANK YOU CAN MEMBERS
MY NAME IS THE ANTI SHORT WITH
THE ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S
RIGHT. CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE
WE DEPEND ON THE STATE OF HER
PARENTS MUST BE PRIORITIZED
WITHIN OUR BUDGET AND
PRIORITIZING AND SUPPORTING THE
CHILDREN. MEANS THE
PRIORITIZING AND SUPPORTING
THEIR CARE GIVER TO TAKE EARLY
THE RELATIVE CAREGIVERS TO CARE
FOR MORE THAN 40% OF OUR STATE
FOSTER CHILDREN. ARE RELATIVE
CARE GIVERS ARE MUCH MORE
LIKELY TO TAKE AN ENTIRE
SIBLING GROUPS BE CARING FOR
MULTIPLE CHILDREN. AND CHILDREN
PLAYED TO THE RELATIVE
TYPICALLY HAVE FEWER PLACEMENT
CHANGES AND EXPERIENCE PLUS
TRAUMA. EVERYTHING IS RELATIVE
CAREGIVERS DUE TO AGE AND OTHER
DISABLING CONDITIONS ARE
PARTICULARLY HIGH RISK FOR THE
IMPACTS OF CODED. IN ADDITION
OUR RELATIVES WERE ALREADY
LIKELY TO BE LIVING AT OR BELOW
THE POVERTY LINE BEFORE THE
ECONOMIC CRISIS THAT. WE KNOW
MANY OF THESE FAMILIES OF
EXPERIENCE LOST WAGES AND
EMPLOYMENT AS A RESULT OF THE
PANDEMIC. EVEN IF THEY'RE
TAKING ON INCREASED
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR THE
CHILDREN IN THEIR HOMES A
SERVICE OF THE SUPPORT HAVE
BEEN HALTED REMOVED ONLINE.
GIVE THE NEEDS OF THE FAMILY WE
WERE JUST TO SEE THAT WITHIN
THE CHILDREN'S PROGRAM AREA THE
NEIGHBOR VISION PROPOSES CUTS
LARGELY TARGETED AT THE SUPPORT
CONSERVATIVE CARE GIVER CAN
FAMILIES RELY ON TO BE
SUCCESSFUL. IN STABILIZING
SUPPORTING ABUSED AND NEGLECTED
CHILDREN. HEADING THE FAMILY
URGENT RESPONSE SYSTEM AND
ELIMINATING THE ABILITY OF CARE
GIVER TO GET ADDITIONAL
FINANCIAL SUPPORT TO CARE FOR
CHILDREN WITH THE MOST
SPECIALIZED NEEDS. IT SHORT
SIGHTED NO ONLY LEAD TO
INCREASED PLACEMENT INSTABILITY.
AND CHILDREN BEING SEPARATED
FROM THEIR RELATIVES AND
ASSEMBLING. BUT UP FAMILIES
RECEIVING THE SUPPORT THEY NEED
PARTICULARLY A FAMILY FACE ARE
YOU ON ECONOMIC HARDSHIP IN THE
FACE THE CURRENT UNEMPLOYMENT
AND FISCAL CRISIS. WILL BE LEFT
WITHOUT ENOUGH FAMILIES WITHIN
OUR FOSTER CARE SYSTEM. TO CARE
FOR THE CHILDREN THAT THE STATE
HAS SWORN TO PROTECT. IN
ADDITION IT'S CRITICAL THAT ANY
TIMELY THE TAKES ON A CHILD ON
A NUMBER TO SEE BASIS RECEIVED
FUNDING FOR THE ENTIRE TIME
THAT REPORT THE ONLY APPROVAL
ATTENDING. THANK YOU COMMITTEE
AND TERMINER AMBULACRAL COMING
TODAY CHANCE TO PROVIDE. THESE
COMMENTS. THANK YOU MA'AM. MOVE
NEXT TO LINE THREE FIFTY FOUR
GO AHEAD PLACE. HELLO THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
I'M JOHN BELIEVE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF HEALTH PROJECTS
MANNER AND DIRECTOR OF THE
STAND ACCUSED THE MONTEREY
MISSISSIPPI IN THE DEL MAR CARE
GIVER RESOURCE CENTER. I HAVE
SEVERAL. POINT I WANT TO MAKE.
FIRST PUTTING PEOPLE SKILLED
NURSING IS NOT A GOOD OPTION
NOW- I DON'T NEED TO BELABOR
THAT. BUT DETACHED YOURSELF THE
QUESTION WOULD YOU PUT SOMEONE
YOU LOVE IN A NURSING HOME IF
YOU COULD GET AROUND IT- WE
NEED TO BE THINKING ABOUT COLD
IT AT THE MAKE THE DECISION-
SECONDLY. CONNECTING DMS IT'S
P. TO FEDERAL RELIEF IT IS AN
ART THAT THERE'S NO REASON TO
DO THAT THIS IS THE MEDICAID
PROGRAM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. PUT IN A REQUEST TO
BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT OF THE
PART IS ALREADY HAVE FEDERAL
DOLLARS IN AT THE BY GIVING IT
AWAY. WE'RE CUTTING OUR NOSE
OFF TO SPITE OUR FACE. FINALLY
BOB THERE ARE FIVE HUNDRED JOBS
WILL BE LOST. THE CALIFORNIA
WHO FOR STATE AND PROVINCE
RECEIVING. AB TWENTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS WITH IF WE
DON'T WANT TO THINK ABOUT JEFF
THE- THE FOLKS WHO ARE GOING TO
BE POTENTIALLY LONG TERM CARE.
I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT IN STATE
PROGRAMS THAT KEEP THE MOST
VULNERABLE PEOPLE OUT OF LONG
TERM CARE AT HOME STATE FOR THE
NEED TO BE. ON THE TEAM WHO THE
CARE GIVER RESOURCE CENTERS.
THE SEA BASS PROGRAM ANOTHER
OLDER AMERICANS. ROGUE SO AGAIN
I HEARD YOU TO RECONSIDER THAT
I THINK IT'S A MISTAKE AND ON
REFLECTION. I HAVE CONFIDENCE
THAT- THAT THE PUBLIC CAN DO
THE RIGHT THING. THANK YOU.
WILL MOVE LINE- NEXT TO LINE
THREE FIFTY THREE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. NINE THREE FIFTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN NOW. YOU WILL
BE MOVING ON TO LINE TWO FIFTY
FOUR GO AHEAD PLEASE. HELLO MY
NAME IS CANNELLA BRADFORD I'M A
CARE PROVIDER FOR I. H. AT
THAT'S IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY I
PROVIDE CARE COMITE SIXTY ONE
YEAR OLD MENTALLY DISABLED. THE
BROWN THE BROTHER REGINALD I
DON'T CARE SERVICES MADE IT
POSSIBLE FOR MY BROTHER TO LIVE
AT HOME. AIRPORT IT AND WE ALL
KNOW HOW LONG TERM FACILITY
CALLED WITH OF DEATH. ERRORS
VIRUSES INCLUDING CALLED THE
NINETEEN IT IS BETTER TO KEEP
OUR CAR LOVE ONE THAT HOW. IT
IS IMPORTANT THAT MY BROTHER
CONTINUED RECEIVE EVERY. CARE
HE HAVE BEEN ASSESSED TO STAY
HOME THEY- IN. CUTTING I. OUR
WILL HAVE A- EFFECT ON THIS I.
AND LIKE MY BROTHER AND PLACE
IN HARM'S WAY. PLEASE HOLD 7%
CUT ARE YOU JUSTICE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM. WE MOVE NOT
ALIGNED THREE SIXTY TWO GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU CHAIR ARAMBULA
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR YOUR
TIME MY NAME IS LAURA RICHARD
PAN AND I WORK FOR QUEEN ANNE
OF FAMILY SERVICES. A FOSTER
FAMILY AGENCY AND SHORT TERM
RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC PROGRAM
PROVIDER. THAT SERVE TO
CALIFORNIANS CHILDREN IN FOR
NEAR FORTY YEARS. I URGE YOU TO
REJECT CUT TO ARE AT THAT THEY
CALL THAT AN EMPTY RTP RATE ARE
ALREADY UNDER FUNDED PROGRAMS
ARE ON THE FRONTLINE PROVIDING
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN ESSENTIAL
SERVICES AND SUPPORT.
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE
CHILDREN AND USE. AND THE
EIGHTEEN THAT WILL BE ESSENTIAL
TO THE COVERT RECOVERY
PROCESSES WE ANTICIPATE AN
INCREASE IN CHILD WELFARE
REFERRALS BUNCH CHILDREN RETURN
TO SCHOOL IN THE FALL AND NOW
IT'S NOT THE TIME FOR CUT. THAT
IMPACTED CALIFORNIA'S MOST
VULNERABLE CHILDREN IN YEARS I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO PRESERVE
OUR FUNDING FOR AFFECT DAYS AND
YOUR KEY PIECE THAT'S ONE OF
THE BUDGET PRIORITIES TO BE
INCLUDED FOR APPROVAL ON JUNE
FIFTEENTH THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU MA'AM. WE MOVED
NEXT TO LINE THREE SIXTY FIVE
GO AHEAD PLEASE. YEAH DOCTOR IN
YOUR MACHINE VERY JUDGING WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DISABILITY
SERVICES ASSOCIATION ON A THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT TODAY- AND FOR THE-
FOCUSED YOU AND THE OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE GIVEN TO-
THE LOCAL POPULATIONS OF
CALIFORNIA ME REPRESENT NINETY
SERVICE PROVIDERS OF SERVICES
TO INDIVIDUALS WHICH- UNLESS
ONE DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND OF
COURSE WE'RE VERY CONCERNED
WITH THE BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT
WOULD CUT PROVIDER RATE BY
THREE HUNDRED MILLION AS WELL
AS RE EMPLOYMENT OR HOLIDAY
SCHEDULE WHICH IS. IN EFFECT.
ADDITIONAL CREDITS FURLOUGH
DAYS- FOR PEOPLE WHO OTHERWISE
SERVICES. WE ARE COMING INTO
THIS CRISIS ALREADY HAVE A
SYSTEM THAT WAS GONE POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS IN THE FUNDED
THAT OTHER FOLKS HAVE TALKED TO
AND- WE ALREADY HAD SIGNIFICANT
ACCESS PROBLEMS. FOR THE PEOPLE
OF THE SERVICE INCLUDING WAIT
LISTS PROGRAM REDUCTIONS CLOSER
THE TRAILER- SO WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED THAT THESE CUTS WOULD
CANCEL TITLES PROBLEMS AND
REDUCE ACCESS TO THE- SERVICE
IS IMPORTANT WITH BILL CLINTON
WAS ONE ABOUT MENTAL
DISABILITIES MAYBE- IMAGES OF A
HUGE. CONCERN FOR OUR FLOWERS
POTS THE OTHER- IMPORTANT
POPULATION TO CONSIDER IS THE
DIRECT SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL TO
SERVE INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
THEY'VE ALREADY. STEPPED UP.
GET A WORKFORCE TO HIS BEEN
UNDER. ON ANOTHER PAGE. MANY
MANY YEARS AND THEY ARE THE
ONES WHO FACE VERY CUTS AND IN
A WAY THAT AND ATTENTION TO
LOSSES. IN THE EVENT THAT THIS
PROPOSAL GOES THROUGH WE KNOW
THAT CALIFORNIA SAY WITH BUT
IT'S- WE KNOW THAT WE WILL TO
WORK WITH THE- AND I. A BUDGET
ARE COMMENTS THINKING
CREATIVELY AN PROVIDE INFLUX
SO LAPIS THINKING WELL FOR YOUR
CAR ARE LEAST READY WORK WITH
YOUR PARTNER. TO COME UP WITH
ANY STRATEGIES AND CAN TO
MITIGATE THE IMPACT OF CUTS
SHOULD THEY SHOULD THE COMBO
INCLUDING HELP MAKE SURE
CHAMBER THAT FEDERAL SO THEY
NEEDED YEAH WE MITIGATED ONE
PACKED OF AN EXTENSION CUTS
FINAL PIECE OF THE LEGISLATURE
O. THE THIS LIMITED CAL CAP
SHE AGREED THE REQUESTED MARKET
SPOKE TO THIS I WAS VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE IDEA OF
CUTS IF YOU ONLY WITH REGARDS
TO THE- SIXTY. AT THE LEVEL
WHERE WE CAN YOUR FROM YOU. CAN
THINK OF RUSSIA CUTS AS WELL AS
HOW TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL. AS
FROM POLITICS WAS THE.
CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES MA'AM. GO AHEAD
MA'AM IN TWO THIRTY TO YOUR
LINE IS OF. CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
MA'AM. NINE TO THIRTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN YOU CAN BE HEARD
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MY NAME IS CYNTHIA STOLEN
THE FOSTER CARE AND ADOPTION
COORDINATOR CHILDREN'S BUREAU.
THE CHILDREN'S BUREAU HAS BEEN
PROVIDING SERVICES TO CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES IN THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN YEARS AND I HAVE BEEN
WITH CHILDREN TO GROW
PERSONALLY FOR OVER TWENTY
YEARS. AND I AM PASSIONATE
ABOUT THE FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY
SYSTEM AND HAVE PRIMARILY
WORKED IN IN FOSTER CARE FOR MY
ENTIRE PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCE
AND I'M I'M ENCOURAGING THE
COMMITTEE TO PLEASE SUPPORT
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY SOCIAL
WORKERS AND TO PLEASE RESTORE
THE FUNDING THAT GOVERNOR
NEWSOME JUST ELIMINATED IN THE
PROPOSED BUDGET. I CARE I
PERSONALLY CARE DEEPLY FOR
FOSTER CHILDREN AND THE
FAMILIES THAT WE SERVE SOCIAL
WORKERS ARE ESSENTIAL WORKERS
AT ALL TIMES COLD OR NO COLD IT
VULNERABLE CHILDREN WHO'VE BEEN
SEPARATED FROM THEIR BIRTH
FAMILIES DUE TO ABUSE NEGLECT
TRAUMA AND OTHER ADVERSE LIFE
EXPERIENCES. IN MY OPINION
THERE IS NO MORE IMPORTANT ROLE
THAN BEING A SOCIAL WORKER
PROTECTING FOSTER CHILDREN
PROVIDING THEM WITH SERVICES
AND SUPPORT. TO HEAL AND
OVERCOME THE TRAGEDY OF ABUSE
AND LOSS OF THEIR BIOLOGICAL
FAMILY WE ARE ALSO CHARGED WITH
SUPPORTING EFFORTS TO REUNIFY
CHILDREN WITH THEIR FAMILIES A
RESPONSIBILITY WE TAKE
SERIOUSLY. OUR GOAL IS THE
SAFETY PERMANENCY AND WELL
BEING OF FOSTER CHILDREN.
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT SOCIAL
WORKER STABILIY IS THE NUMBER
ONE INDICATOR OF FOSTER USED TO
ACHIEVE PERMANENCY WITH AS HAS
BEEN ALREADY SAID BY MY AMAZING
COLLEAGUES LAURA RICHARDSON
KATY WALTER AND SHE SWORE
SOMEBODY FROM SENECA FAMILY OF
AGENCIES AND JACQUI ROUGH HOUSE
ARE FROM THE ALLIANCE. OF CHILD
AND FAMILY SERVICES THAT WITH
ONE SOCIAL WORKER THERE'S A 75%
RATE OF PERMANENCY AND IT
DROPPED 18% WHEN THERE ARE TWO
MORE SOCIAL WORKERS SERVING
FAMILIES. WE ALL HAVE THE SAME
GOALS TO HELP OUR FOSTER
CHILDREN BUT REDUCING FUNDING
TO SOCIAL WORKERS WILL SEVERELY
UNDERCUT. THE CHANCE OF
PERMANENCY FOR OUR FOSTER YOU.
I STRONGLY URGE YOU TO KEEP THE
FUNDING IN THE BUDGET BECAUSE I
FOSTER CHILDREN DESERVE TO HAVE
A PERMANENT FAMILY. IT DOES NOT
MAKE SENSE TO TAKE AWAY THE
SOCIAL WORKER ONE TIME FUNDING.
THAT WE SO DESPERATELY NEEDED
LAST YEAR AND NEED TO CONTINUE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TAKING
THE TIME TO LISTEN TO OUR
COMMON. AND WE DO APPRECIATE
THE DIFFICULT DECISIONS THAT
THE COMMITTEE HAS TO MAKE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM. LINE
THREE SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YEAH YES HI THIS IS MERRY
FRAME AND I AM AT- QUALITY
ASSURANCE DIRECTOR AND SOCIAL
WORKER IN A FOSTER FAMILY
AGENCY AND I JUST WANTED TO
TAKE. THIS TIME TO THANK YOU
GUYS FOR ALL OF YOUR
CONSIDERATION I KNOW THESE ARE
DIFFICULT DECISION. BUT HE- FOR
THE REMOVAL OF THE COLA FOR THE
AFTER DAY WORKERS. I FEEL WILL
HAVE SUCH A DETRIMENTAL EFFECT
IN THE SHORT TERM. ON THE
FOSTER CHILDREN ALREADY DEALING
WITH SO MUCH. WHETHER IT BE
COVERED DIRECTLY OR INDIRECTLY
WITH FAMILY OR INDIRECTLY
THROUGH THE ARE PEOPLE OF THEIR
LIVES. THE SOCIAL WORKER IS
SUCH A KEY CONTACT IN SUCH A
KEY RELATIONSHIP FOR THEM
ANSWER REPORTER RESOURCE
PARENTS SUPPORT. THAT REMOVING
BAD AND JEOPARDIZING THAT IS
DAMAGING THAT FUNDING WILL HAVE
NOT ONLY LONG TERM PERMANENTLY
EFFECTIVE WE'VE ALREADY TALKED
ABOUT BUT ALSO SHORT TERM WELL
BEING A FAX ON THE- THE FONT
USED IN THE VULNERABLE
POPULATION WE. ARE THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
MA'AM. MOVING NOW TO LINE TO
TWENTY EIGHT GO AHEAD PLACE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AROUND
ALLOWING COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ABOUT THAT ASPECT AND I
AM THE SENIOR DIRECTOR OF
POLICY AND ADVOCACY AT PUBLIC
FAMILY SERVICES WHERE STATEWIDE
CHILDREN'S BEHAVIOR HELP THEN
BUT THE FAMILY AGENCY. I AM
HERE TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR FOSTER FAMILY
AGENCY SOCIAL WORKERS. AND TO
RESTORE THE FUNDING THAT THE
GOVERNOR ELIMINATED IN THE
PROPOSED BUDGET YOU'VE HEARD
FROM MANY FEATURES ABOUT THE
STATISTICS OF PERMANENCY FOR
FOSTER CHILDREN WITH THE KEY
RELATIONSHIP THEY DOUBLE UP
WITH ONE SOCIAL WORKER SO I
WON'T REPEAT THEM NOW- I WILL
SAY THAT WE ARE NORMALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE OUTCOME FOR
FOSTER CHILDREN. WITH THE
VARIOUS CUTS IN PROGRAMS THAT
IMPACTED VERY VULNERABLE
POPULATION I KNOW WE ALL HAVE
THE SAME GOAL TO HELP OUR
FOSTER CHILDREN BUT WE DO THINK
FUNDING TO SOCIAL WORKERS WILL
SEVERELY UNDERCUT THE CHANCES
OF PERMANENCY. FOR OUR FOSTER
YOU. SO WE URGE YOU TO RESTORE%
THE FUNDING FOR FOSTER FAMILY
AGENCY SOCIAL WORKERS AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND WE APPRECIATE
ALL YOUR DURING ALL YOU ARE
DOING DURING THIS UNPRECEDENTED
TIME. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM. WE GO NEXT DEADLINE
THREE NINETY THREE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. AND THREE NINETY THREE
OR LINE INSULT AND GO AHEAD
PLEASE. HI THIS IS TO EVANS
THAT WALDRON FAMILY SERVICES
I'M THE CEO- FOLD IN FROM THE
SEVEN SAY THE FOSTER CARE
AGENCY WE HAVE BEEN PROVIDING
FOSTER CARE SERVICES FOR MANY
IS. UP IN CALIFORNIA AND I GET
THE ECHO. OFF KIND OF THE FUNNY
AGENCIES I AM VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE IMPACT TO OUR
CHILDREN'S PERMANENCY BY
REMOVING THE HOLDER THAT WAS
GIVEN TO THE SSA SOCIAL WORKERS
LAST YEAR. WE WORKED WITH SOME
OF THE MOST VULNERABLE CHILDREN
I FOSTER CARE. IT WILL THEN WE
WHAT WE MANY CHILDREN WITH
SPECIAL HEALTHCARE NEEDS. VERY
VERY VALUABLE AND WE HAVE SEEN
GREAT RESULTS FROM BEING ABLE
TO OFFER THE STABILITY OF ONE
SOCIAL WORKER THROUGH THAT TIME
IN ALL FOSTER CARE AGENCY. I
KNOW THE DIFFICULT DECISION TO
MAKE BUT WE REALLY URGE YOU TO
RECONSIDER AND- AND WE CAN BE A
CODA TO THE FF FACE. WE
APPRECIATE THE TIME TO SPEAK.
WITH YOU THIS AFTERNOON AND
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE GO
NEXT TO LINE THREE NINETY SIX
GO AHEAD PLEASE. HI THERE YES
THANK YOU SO MUCH CHAIR
ARAMBULA AND MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK MY NAME IS
DEBBIE HEALTH AND I'M THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF CHOICE AN
AGING- WE ARE THE ONLY PROVIDER
OF AND I FIFTY SERVICES IN
CONTRA COSTA NAPA AND ONE OF
COUNTY. WE ALSO HAVE TWO ADULT
DAY HEALTH CENTERS THAT ARE ALL
THE FEEDBACK PROVIDERS IN
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY AND WE'RE
SERVING ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER
TH DISTRICT- IRONICALLY LAST
FRIDAY THE DAY AFTER THE MAY
REVISED CAME OUT ELIMINATING
THESE PROGRAMS WE CELEBRATED
OUR FORTIETH YEAR. OF BEING THE
SIXTEENTH LICENSE THE DEALT A
HEALTHCARE FACILITY IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. LAST JUNE
I WAS THRILLED WHEN THE
GOVERNOR RELEASED AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER CALLING FOR A MASTER PLAN
FOR AGING WELL WE'RE ALL OLDER
ADULTS AND THOSE WITH
DISABILITIES. AT AGE IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES IT SPECIFICALLY
CALLED OUT CALIFORNIA IS BEING
A LEADER OF HOME AND COMMUNITY
BASED SERVICES WITH IN HOME
SUPPORT SERVICES. COMMUNITY
BASED ADULT SERVICES AND THE
MULTI PURPOSE SENIOR SERVICES
PROGRAM I WAS FURTHER THRILLED
WHEN I WAS APPOINTED TO THE
STAKEHOLDER ADVISORY COMMITTEE
TO HELP CREATE THIS MASTER
PLAN. AND I'M NOW WONDERING HOW
WE CREATE A MASTER PLAN WHEN WE
READ MOVES THE BACKBONE OF THE
SERVICES THAT PROVIDE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE TO LIVE
IN THE COMMUNITY. THIS IS AKIN
TO ASKING TRANSIT PROVIDERS TO
DEVELOP A ROUTE WITH THEM BUT
REMOVING THE HIGHWAYS. YOU'VE
HEARD OF ALL RIGHTY OF.
SUPPORTERS OF BOTH MSF PM
FEEDBACK TODAY BUT WHAT I
HAVEN'T HEARD SOMEBODY ADDRESS
IS THE PEOPLE IF YOU ELIMINATE
COMMUNITY BASED ADULT SERVICE
CENTERS YOU DON'T JUST
ELIMINATE THE MEDICARE
POPULATION YOU ELIMINATE THE
REGIONAL CENTER CLAIMS WE THIRD
YOU ELIMINATE THE VETERANS THAT
WE SERVE YOU ELIMINATE THE
PRIVATE PAY PEOPLE BECAUSE AT
CHOICE AN AGING 80% OF THE
PEOPLE WE SERVE OUR MEDI CAL SO
IF 20% REMAINING WITH YOUR
VETERANS PRIVATE PAY IN
REGIONAL OPNER CLIENTS. I
CAN'T SUPPORT AN ENTIRE HEALTH
CARE STAFFING MODEL TO SERVE
ONLY 20% OF THE PEOPLE ARE
PROGRAMS WOULD PULL. SO THIS IS
A LARGER IMPACT IN YOUR EVEN
THINKING ABOUT TODAY IN A TIME
WHERE 40% OF CALIFORNIANS COLD
THE DEATH ARE HAPPENING IN
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES WE
ARE PROPOSING TO ELIMINATE THE
TO FORMALLY CLINICAL COMMUNITY
BASED CARE PROGRAM DESIGNED
SPECIFICALLY TO PREVENT SKILLED
NURSING PLACEMENT. DEPENDING
THE FED PACKAGE IN A HOSTILE
ENVIRONMENT WHERE MCCONNELL HAS
ALREADY SAID IT DEAD ON ARRIVAL
IF PLAYING RUSSIAN ROULETTE.
WITH FRAIL ELDERS LIVES. WHO
ARE WE AS A STATE. WHEN A
LIFELINE SERVICES PROVIDED TO
OUR ELDERS ARE THE ONLY STATE
PROGRAMS ELIMINATED THERE'S ONE
OTHER STATE WIDE PROGRAM BEING
ELIMINATED THE NEXT TO REMOVAL
FOR PAROLEES. BUT WE'RE GONNA
PULL AWAY THE SERVICES THAT
KEEP FRAIL ELDERS MOVING
INDEPENDENTLY IN THEIR
COMMUNITY I AM I AM SHOCKED AND
HORRIFIED AND SADDENED I HOPE
YOU FEEL THE SAME WAY AND I
CERTAINLY HOPE YOU WILL OPPOSE
THESE ELIMINATIONS AND NOT
INCLUDE BILLS IN YOUR BUDGET
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK. THANK YOU
MA'AM. RULED OUT A LINE FOUR
ZERO THREE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
ARAMBULA AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TAKING
THE TIME TO LISTEN TO ALL OF
THE COMMUNITY FEEDBACK- I WORK
MY NAME IS MONICA AND TO
COLLINS I WORK FOR CONSPECIFIC
OFFENDERS WITH CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES THE TERM A- SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY. WE SERVE OVER
FORTY FOUR HUNDRED YOU CAN
FAMILIES. THE COURTS HAVE LOW
WE OPERATE- AT THAT THEIR
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY AS WELL.
THERAPEUTIC RESIDENTIAL PROGRAM
AND VERY- LITTLE HELP SERVICES
AND REALLY WOULD LIKE TO ECHO A
LOT OF THE COMMENTS MADE BY
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS BUT ALSO-
JUST HIGHLIGHT A FEW POINTS
THAT I REALLY WOULD LIKE YOU
TO. TAKE HOME WITH YOU TODAY.
WITH REGARD TO THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH OF FUNDING WE REALLY
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT
THE LEGISLATURE CAREFULLY
CONSIDER THE EFFECTS OF THE
GROUP IN NINETEEN PANDEMIC. ON
THE DELIVERY OF MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE SERVICES.
WHEN WE TALK ND WE LISTEN TO
THE CDC. GIVE ALL THE VARIOUS
WARNINGS AND TALK ABOUT THE
ISOLATION- WE REALLY NEED TO
GIVE FURTHER THOUGHT TO THE
IMPACT OF. ISOLATION TO OUR
FOSTER YOUTH MANY OF WHOM
REALLY RELIED ON BEING ABLE TO
GO TO SCHOOL AND HAVE
pMANY OF THEM ARE AT HOME AND-
TRULY ISOLATED AND WE SEE THAT.
IN THE DRAMATIC DECREASE IN A
COLD- TO OUR- CHILD ABUSE
HOTLINE SO WE CAN ONLY IMAGINE
WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN AT
SCHOOL SLOWLY BEGAN TO AN OPEN-
WHAT. WELL I RUN A IS THAT THE
PUBLIC BE ABLE HELP DELIVERY
SYSTEM IS BEING. BUT IT'S MOST
NEEDED- AND WE CAN ONLY
ANTICIPATE MELODICALLY BUT THE
ON THE GOVERNOR. LOOKING TO
MAKE CUTS ON ON OUR ON OUR
SYSTEM SO I WOULD ASK THAT. SO
THE PROGRESS THAT WE'VE MADE
STEPS TO BE MAINTAINED AND- WE
REALLY LOOK OUT FOR THE MOST
VULNERABLE CHILDREN. DID YOU
FOR THEIR FAMILIES AND THAT
COULD BE INCLUDING- FOSTER
FAMILY AGENCY SOCIAL WORKER-
MAKING SURE THAT WE RESTORE
THAT 4% COLA THAT WE REALLY
SUPPORT TO THE FRONT LINES
THERE ARE FIRST RESPONDERS IN
MANY RESPECTS- AND I TRULY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE WELL BEING
OF THESE CHILDREN- THAT HAVE
ALREADY STOP APPROACH TRAUMATIC
YOU CAN THERE ARE IN OUR LIVES
AND- TO REALLY JUST TO KEEP
THEIR WELL BEING IN MIND THEY
ARE HURT FUTURE THERE ARE
COMMUNITIES FUTURE. AND AGAIN I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM. MON
NOT ALIGNED HREE FIFTY TWO GO
AHEAD PLEASE. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR THOUGHTFUL ATTENTION TO BE
UNIQUE BUDGET CHALLENGES MY
NAME IS KATE MAHONEY I'M THE
LITIGATION DIRECTOR OUTDOORS
STREET COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
CONFERENCE JUST GO I'M CALLING
TO VOICE MY SUPPORT FOR THE DUE
PROCESS AND ATTENTION PROGRAM-
FUNDING IF STATEWIDE LEGAL
COLLABORATIVE WOULD EXPAND. I
FIFTEEN IN FACT THAT LEGAL
RESOURCES COMPETENT LEGAL
ADVICE AND REPRESENTATION. THE
PROGRAM IS PARTICULARLY
CRITICAL NOW AS I CONTINUED TO
THE PAIN MORE IMMIGRANTS AND
FACILITIES IN CALIFORNIA
SECTION RIGHT NOT THE PHILLIES
CRIME AND THE AGENCY IS
ANYTHING NATIONAL CRITICISM FOR
ITS GROWTH FAILURE TO
ADEQUATELY ADDRESS THE
PANDEMIC. FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE STUCK IN AYE TENSION RIGHT
NOW ACCESS TO LEGAL COUNSEL AND
LEGAL INFORMATION IT'S
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY TO PROTECT
THEIR RIGHTS. AND HEALTH. IN
THE BAY AREA WE'VE SEEN THE
POSITIVE IMPACT AT LEGAL
REPRESENTATION COLLABORATIVE
HAVE. IN EXPANDING HIGH QUALITY
REPRESENTATION FOR. ICE
DETAINEES AND HOLDING ICE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR DON'T STANDARDS
AND BASIC PRINCIPLES OF DUE
PROCESS. AT FIRST GLANCE THIS
PROGRAM MAY NOT SEEM LIKE A
PUBLIC HEALTH CARE AND ECONOMIC
MEASURE BUT IT DEFINITELY IS-
IMMIGRANT DETAINEES ARE HIGHLY
VULNERABLE POPULATION I'M HIGH
RATES OF INFECTION. IF AMTRAK
TO ME PROBABILITY THEY'RE GOING
DURING CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES AND WORKERS. MANY OF
THESE- BALLPARK CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT FOR SEPARATED FROM THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY. AND THEY'RE
UNABLE TO SUPPORT THEIR
FAMILIES WHILE THERE TO CHANGE.
THE DUE PROCESS IN DETENTION
PROGRAM IS CRITICAL NOT ONLY TO
SUPPORT THE DETAINEES
THEMSELVES. BUT THEIR FAMILIES
AND THEIR COMMUNITIES. ALSO
SUFFER BECAUSE THEY CANNOT ACT
OF COMPETENT LEGAL COUNSEL. I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU MA'AM. WE'LL GO NEXT TO THE
LINE OF- NINETY THREE GO AHEAD.
YEAH HI THIS IS IT THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MANY MEMBERS WORKING
TIME HERE ARE COMMENTS MY NAME
IS ON ARTS WAIT ON THE VICE
PRESIDENT UP. LONG TERM
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS OUR
NURSING CARE FOUNDATION RENTAL
CANDIDATES. SEVERAL COUNTY WE
SERVE ABOUT. ONE THOUSAND IN
MISSISSIPPI LIVE WE- STRONGLY
OPPOSED THE ELIMINATION OF A
MESSAGE YEAH AND HE THAT. A LOS
ANGELES OVER FIFTY PERCENT. OF
KOBE- NINETEEN PONDERED HIS
PAIN FROM INSTITUTIONAL CARE
SETTING. ELIMINATING THESE
PROGRAMS WILL INCREASE THE RISK
OF CAUGHT TO OUR STATE. MORE TO
PORTABLE ADULT LIMóN EVERY
DATA SHOWS THAT LESS THAN 1% OF
EMPHASIS THE EMOJIS AT THAT THE
POSITIVE FOR KOBE NINETEEN THAT
IS EVIDENCE THAT IMAGE THE
STATE SIDE. WE NEED TO REDUCE
THE COST OF CARE NOT INCREASE
THE COST OF. YOUR STATE BUDGET.
THE AVERAGE COST OF NURSING
HOME CARE IS IN CALIFORNIA IS
THIRTY TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS PER
MONTH THE PROGRAMS ARE A
FRACTION OF THAT CAUGHT SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY INCOME WITH
FEDERAL MATCHING FUNDS. WE
SHOULD BE FOCUSING ON EXPANDING
PROGRAMS WILL BE CLIENTS FROM
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY TO
LOWER COST WORK RISK ON TEDDY.
AS WE ARE ALL FEE FOR AT HOME
SO OUR MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS. THANKS FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU SIR. WE'LL GO
NEXT TO LINE FOUR ZERO SIX GO
AHEAD PLEASE. BY A LOT IN ORDER
I'M NOT CALLING PLEASED TO ON A
CHAIR OF THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
COMMUNITY LIVING SERVICES I
HAVE A NUMBER OF YEARS AND BOTH
HOSPITAL AND COMMUNITY BASED
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM AND I AM
CALLING- AND IN SUPPORT OF
OPPOSING ELIMINATION OF THE
MESSAGE BE PROGRAM- ESPECIALLY
IN LIGHT OF THE CO THE
PANDEMIC. IT SEEMS SO SHORT
SHORT SIGHTED TO ELIMINATE
THESE PROGRAMS GIVEN THE
ABUNDANCE OF SAVINGS IN THE
ABUNDANCE OF FANTASTIC COME
THESE PROGRAMS GET SO PLEASE.
DON'T LET THIS PROGRAM THANK.
THANK YOU SIR. WILL MOVE ON TO
LINE FOUR ONE FIVE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
MA'AM. MY NAME IS MARLA DOES
NOT AND I AM I A CAT THAT
PROVIDER IN BUTTE COUNTY- I
DON'T TAKE CARE FAMILY MEMBERS
I HAVE THE ACTUAL CLIENT. AND I
HAVE ONE CLIENT IN PARTICULAR
THAT WE JUST BOUGHT TOGETHER-
MORE HOURS AND THEY GAVE HER
ONE MORE HOUR. I FIND MYSELF
DOING THAT ABOVE AND BEYOND. MY
ALLOTTED HOURS AND I ONLY CLAIM
THE HOURS I'M A WANTED TO BE
PAID- BUT HE IS COMPLETELY
DISABLED SHE CAN BARELY MOVE-
IT'S SAD BECAUSE HE'S YOUNGER
THAN I AM. BUT IF YOU. AT SEVEN
BIRTH THAT THEN I'M OKAY I'VE
BEEN TOLD I'M IN THE CENTRAL
WORKER. I CAN'T AB OR
TRANSPORTATION TO GO TAKE CARE
OF HER AND I JUST THINK THAT
THE SEVEN PERSON THAT CAT IS
COMPLETELY UNACCEPTABLE. A LOT
OF THESE PEOPLE ARE GETTING-
SERVICES PROVIDED FOR FREE
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
HOURS AND IF YOU HAVE A CARING
I A CAT THAT. PERSON AND I'M
I'M JUST DON'T HAVE THE HEART
TO SAY ALL I'M NOT GONNA DO
THAT BECAUSE I BONTA WORK
HOURS- EXCEL ESSENTIAL IF
YOU'RE JUST GONNA HAVE ME DOING
MORE FREE LABOR. WHAT WHILE I
RISK MY LIFE ON PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION GETTING THERE.
AND I THINK IT'S. COMPLETELY
UNACCEPTABLE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU MA'AM.
WHAT WELL NEXT TO LINE FOR
TWENTY FOUR GO AHEAD PLEASE.
LINE FOR TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I'M NOT BUT LATER ON
THE CALIFORNIA IF YOU GOT TO
HAVE GOT THEM UNHAPPY KIDS
HERE- THANK YOU DOCTOR ARAMBULA
YOUR AND MEMBERS I'LL BE I'LL
BE BRIEF I'M GONNA COMPLEMENT
THE COMMENTS MADE BY MY
COLLEAGUE- I WOULD SAY ON A
SOCIETAL HE GRANTS- THAT I
THANK YOU KEEP. CARE THREE YEAR
OLD. COMATOSE HERE CELLS OF THE
COMIC ALSO MADE BY MIKE HERALD-
THAT THAT CUT MAY NOT SEEM LIKE
MUCH BUT IT'S THE ONLY CUT
AVAILABLE AND IT'S REALLY
DISAPPOINTING. THAT IN THE
FIRST BUDGET HAD WIND. THAT THE
STATE WULD BE PROPOSING TO GO
BACK DOWN TO THE ABSOLUTE
FEDERAL FEDERAL MINIMUM AND I
APPRECIATE THE LA OWES LAND- TO
LOOK AT CUTS THAT ACTUALLY WILL
BE COUNTERPRODUCTIVE BY PUSHING
MORE OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE TO
ABILITY INTO POVERTY. HUNGER
AND EXPOSURE COCOA THAT. ON
CALPERS WE ARE SO GRATEFUL.
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PROPOSING TO CONTINUE THE AT
THE SITE EXPANSION DOCTOR ON
BELOW WE'RE SO GRATEFUL FOR THE
LEGISLATURE'S LEADERSHIP ON THE
INCLUDING OF COURSE HEALTH ALL
MEANT- AS WELL AT THE COURT FOR
THE AT BEEN BE ANTEON BE.
BENEFIT BUT AGAIN ALIGN
OURSELVES. ON TRYING TO PROVIDE.
WE CAN CAN BE DURING THIS
PERIOD OF THE- OF. ON CALPERS
WE ALSO WITH THE WESTERN CENTER
ON THE RESTAURANT MEALS PROGRAM
AGAIN IF THAT IS THE DECISION
BY THE DEPARTMENT- WE CUT THEIR
JUDGMENT AND THEIR PRUDENT- BUT
HELP TO MOVE FORWARD AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE AS IT'S OBVIOUSLY SO
IMPORTANT FOR A RESTAURANT AND
LOW INCOME PEOPLE- TO HAVE THAT
KIND OF COULD ACCESS DURING
THIS TIME ON CAL WORKS TO IT
ALONG WITH YOUR COMMENT- BY
WESTERN CENTER. ANTI TO BE GAY-
THINKING OF THE MINISTRATION OF
THE OURT THE GRANT LEVEL. AND
CONTINUE OUR MISSION TO FINALLY
STEP OUT YOU CAL PROPERTY IN
THE STATE- BUT THOSE OTHER
SERVICES INCLUDING HOME FROM
VISITING BEING SO CRITICAL-
FINALLY ON EMERGENCY FOOD- WERE
DEEPLY APPRECIATED THAT THE
MINISTRY CAN PROPOSES TO
CONTINUE TO COURT- WE KNOW
THAT. FROM THAT INTO CALIFORNIA
COULD BANK IN FRESNO TO THE
OTHER PARTY AROUND THE STATE.
THE LINES HAVE NEVER BEEN
LONGER THAT NEED. IS NOT GOING
TO GO AWAY IN THE SHORT TERM
AND WE'RE REALLY GRATEFUL AND
SUPPORT THE MINISTRATIONS
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR.
THANK YOU ANDREW- WANTED TO
GIVE EVERYONE AN UPDATE WE HAVE
THIRTY PEOPLE WHO ARE ON THE
CALL AND- WITH THAT OPERATOR
NEXT CALL. NINE FOUR TWO SIX GO
AHEAD PLEASE. HELLO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MY NAME IS TERRA DEALT
THE CZECHO AND THE STATE
DIRECTOR FOR THE AND THE AT THE
PROGRAM AT THE INSTITUTE ON
AGING AND CAMPUS THE PHOTO
SEVEN PART OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PHILIP TING DISTRICT AND FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY AFTER CLIENTS
AT A TIME AND EFFORT THAT'S
ALL. WE'VE BEEN THE AND THAT
THE PEOPLE BETTER THIRTY EIGHT
YEAR AND I JUST WANT TO GO OUT
MY COLLEAGUES I'M ALREADY AND
TO YOU TODAY ABOUT AND THAT HE-
AND THE COST A COST EFFECTIVE
ALTERNATIVE TO NURSING HOME
PLACEMENT. FOR TEN THOUSAND LOW
INCOME VULNERABLE TRAIL
CALIFORNIANS SENIOR PUTTING
THIS PROGRAM RIGHT NOW IS IN
DIRECT CONFLICT WITH OUR EFFORT
TO PROTECT OUR POPULATION
DURING THE. CALL THAT NINETEEN
CAN THAT NIGHT. I OUR CLIENTS
AND THEN IT WILL FOR A- WHEN
OUR HELP SYSTEM OVER. AND I OR
SIMPLY AREN'T NOT BAD INNER
CALLED. PLEASE DO NOT SUPPORT
THE PROPOSAL LIMIT AND THE THAT
KEEP. AND HELP US KEEP OUR IN
YOUR AT HOME. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM. WE GO NEXT TO LINE
FOR TWO NINE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
THANK YOU- MY NAME IS BRIANNA
CROWN I LOOK AT THE CENTER FOR
GENDER AND REFUGEES. GO AN
ADVOCATE FOR ASYLUM SEEKERS THE
DETENTION I'M CALLING TODAY TO
ECHO THE SUPPORT THAT HAVE BEEN
EXPECTED TO DUE PROCESS IN
DETENTION PROGRAM. RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE MORE THAN FIVE THOUSAND
IMMIGRANT FOUND LOCKED UP IN
IMMIGRATION DETENTION CENTER
THE CALIFORNIA THE MAJORITY ARE
NOW THE DEPORTATION PROCEEDINGS
ALONE. WITHOUT THE PRESENTATION.
AND FOR EVEN THOUGH. PROFOUND
BECAUSE THE OTHERS CONCLUSION
MEET A DEATH. WE NEED URGENTLY
TO A- STATEWIDE PROGRAM TO AND
BE YOU'VE GOT THAT'S RIGHT SOME
OF THE ARE ARE STACKED HEAVILY
THE- WE PROVIDE YOU CAN WITH
THE REALLY GO FOR. THEY TO THAT
THEIR TAKE AND TO GET THAT OUT
OF THE TENSION MOMENT TIME IN
BODIES BUT HISTORY PROVIDER AN
ADDICT MEDICAL. AND THE MANNER
DIRECTOR OUTBREAK ESPECIALLY
NOW. BECAUSE THE NINETEENTH AND
BUDGET AND THAT HE CAN HIGHER
RISK THAT AGREED THAN EVER
MAKING THE PROGRAM ALL THE MORE
CRITICAL. WE URGE YOU TO MAKE A
ONE TIME INVESTMENT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS TO ESTABLISH
THE DUE PROCESS. IN DETENTION
PROGRAM. THANK YOU. WE GO TO
LINE FOR THREE SEVEN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR TAKING MY COMMENT
MY NAME IS KATHLEEN CODA AND I
AM A SOCIAL WORKER AND
SUPERVISOR AT HUNTINGTON SENIOR
KERR NETWORK IN PASADENA I AM
COMMENTING TODAY URGE YOU TO
OPPOSE ELIMINATION OF THE MULTI
PURPOSE IN YOUR SERVICES
PROGRAM FOR ALL THE SAME
REASONS YOU'VE HEARD FROM OUR
COLLEAGUES ACROSS THE STATE. I
KNOW THE FUTURE PRESIDENT NINE
AND THERE ARE SEVERAL DIFFICULT
DECISIONS THAT ARE GOVERNOR AND
LEGISLATURE I'VE BEEN ASKED TO
MAKE RECENTLY I APPRECIATE THAT
YOUR ROLE IN CONSIDERING THESE
BUDGET CUTS IT'S CHALLENGING.
BUT I AM AFFECT CONCERNED.
ABOUT OUR MOST VULNERABLE
SENIORS HELPED BY AND AT THAT
HE- THE NEAREST THAT ARE AT THE
VERY MOMENT STAYING AT HOME.
WATCHING WAITING. HOPING THAT
THEY WILL NOT CONTRACT CODED
NINETEEN. JUNIOR IS THAT RELY
ON SUPPORT FROM THERE AND THE
FIFTY CARE COORDINATOR FOR
LIFESAVING SERVICES. IN YOUR TO
WANT TO AVOID
INSTITUTIONALIZATION WE KNOW
THE EIGHTEEN YEARS WELL AND
MANIAC NOW MORE THAN EVER THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM. WE'LL GO
NEXT TO LINE FOUR ZERO FOUR GO
AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
I'D LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
CHAIR STATED CONCERNED ABOUT
THE IMPACT OF THESE CUTS ON THE
MOST VULNERABLE SENIORS IN
CALIFORNIA- THOSE CONCERNS ARE
WELL FOUNDED AND I'M VERY
CONCERNED ALSO. MY NAME'S
RICHARD STRANGE AND- MS US P.
SITE DIRECTOR FOR NAPA SOLANO
COUNTY- WE SERVE A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY FRAIL SENIORS. I'M SURE I
SHARE THE FRUSTRATION OF MANY
PEOPLE HERE TODAY WHO- YEAR
AFTER YEAR IT SEEMS LIKE- THESE
OF THE PROGRAMS BUT THE FIRST
ONE CUT AND THE LAST ONES TO BE
RESTORED- BUT I THINK IT TO
PULL. OUT OF CONVERSATION- I
WOULD LIKE TO ASSOCIATE MY
COMMENTS- WITH OTHERS TO DAVE
SPOKE WITH THE FAMILY ABOUT THE
IMPACTS OF THE PROPOSED CUTS
THAN ELIMINATION OF SERVICES TO
OUR MOST VULNERABLE SENIORS.
IBM AT FIFTY PROVIDE SKILLED
NURSING ELIGIBLE- SENIORS WITH
CARE COORDINATION AND PURCHASE
OF SERVICE THE- TO LABEL THEM
TO MAXIMIZE THEIR INDEPENDENCE
AND QUALITY OF LIFE AT HOME.
YEAH IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
PROGRAM I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF AMETHYST AND
FEEDBACK. SAFETY NET PROGRAMS
FOR SENIORS ALIKE IN TALKING
PUZZLE PIECES WERE SENIOR MAY
BE RECEIVING SERVICES FROM MY
MATHIS P. FEEDBACK THE R. C.
FOOD PROGRAMS BY CHANCE THAT.
THE CATCHER AND DAMAGE TO ANY
OF THESE PIECES DISRUPT THE
ENTIRE NETWORK. AND ASSIST PNC
BASS RECEIVE REFERRALS FROM ALL
SECTORS OF. THE SENIOR SAFETY.
WITH AMETHYST P. BASCOMB WHERE
THOSE WERE. GO WELL WITH THAT
SHE NEEDED. WITHOUT THE HELP
THERE ARE NO. QUIBBLE SERVICE.
TO FILL THE HOLE. BUT WE MAKE
NO FISCAL TO AND P. THEN ASSIST
PIECES. OF MEDI CAL DOLLARS
DELAY OUR LINDA THE NEED FOR
NURSING HOME PLACEMENT ACOSTA
EFFECTIVE WAY. AND RECEIVES
FEDERAL MATCHING FUNDS THE
STATE'S COSTS WILL INCREASE THE
PHARMACIST HE IS ELIMINATED. IF
SOMEONE LATER MASSES OR BASS.
THANK SO MUCH FOR. THANK YOU
SIR. WE'LL GO NEXT TO LINE ONE
EIGHTY THREE GO AHEAD. FIFTY
WHITE LOOK AT THE CALIFORNIA
THAT THE VILLAIN OF THE FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIVE THOUSAND LONG
TERM CARE PROVIDERS- WE
DEFINITELY RECOGNIZE THE
DIFFICULT DECISIONS THAT HAVE
TO BE MADE DURING THE
UNPRECEDENTED HIGH OF THE CALL
THE PANDEMIC BUT UNFORTUNATELY
WE HAVE TO UPHOLD THE FOLLOWING
I EXPECT THE CALL BUTTON- DR
RANDALL WE DEFINITELY WILL.
CHECK WITH WITH- OF GET YOUR
STAFF ON COMMITTEE- WE OPPOSED
27% REDUCTION TOOK OVER THIS
I'VE JUST GOT TO COULD BE AND-
NOT ONLY DID VENTURE CONSUMERS
BUT ALSO PROVIDERS. NOT AGED
BECOME A MINISTRY TO FUND THE
CURRENT TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
TWENTY LEVEL VEHICLE COMPONENT
THE HST FEDERAL PROGRAM. AND WE
ARE CO CONTRACTING OUT- I AGES
THE TELEPHONES AND FOR STUDENTS
RELATED WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES WE OPPOSE THE
PROPOSED SUBJECT TO PROVIDER
RATE REDUCTION TO THE
OPERATIONS BUDGET THE REGIONAL
CENTERS AND THAT- DEFINITION OF
DATA- UNIFORM HOLIDAY SCHEDULE
OR AT MY COLLEAGUES. DALY NOTED
IT WAS. ALL THE CALL THAT HAS
PANDEMIC HAS SOME OF.
WEAKNESSES THAT DOES COURSE OF.
LOW INCOME AND OF. WE MY DEMAND
THE STATE ENACT A BUDGET ARE
SHOWS ABOUT OF OUR- ESPECIALLY
THOSE THAT IT COULD. MORE LAW
DATA AND DAY OUT ON BUT MINE.
ECONOMY WHERE THEY AND A COUPLE
BECAUSE- A THE STATE MORE
VULNERABLE. AMONG THE HOW WE
LIVE IN THE MARGIN. INDIVIDUAL
WE EMPLOY THE- TO STAND FOR
THOSE OUR STATE THAT ARE MY
BONTA. AGES FEDERAL AND POP.
YEAH THE STATE MOST. A BALANCED
BUDGET WE AGREE WITH THAT BUT
IT SHOULD NOT BE DONE ON THE
BACK OF WORKERS. AT THE EXPENSE
OF BOTH. MOST VULNERABLE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
MA'AM. WE'LL GO NEXT TO LINE
THIRTY THREE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
LINE THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN YOU MAY GO AHEAD YES I'M
SORRY YOU CAN HEAR ME NOW YES
MA'AM. OKAY YES. I'M MY NAME IS
MORE TO TOKYO AND I AM AND I
AGE HOME PROVIDER FROM KERN
COUNTY I'M HERE FOR MISTER
JAMES BROWN ON. HOME CARE MAKE
IT POSSIBLE FOR MY DRY YOU TO
LEAVE OUR HOME IN NOT IN NAM.
TERMS RELATED WHERE HE WILL BE
A ARE AN EXTREMELY HARD CARE RE.
DAD FROM PUBLIC NINETEEN HE HE
NEEDED EVERY OUR OKAY YEAR HE
HAVE BEEN THERE. TO A HOME. HEY
ANY HELP CUTTING AYE AYSHA
FOLLOWERS WILL ONCE S
LIFORNIANS LATE MISTER JAMES
BROWN AND ON YOUR PLEASE HOLD
ALL THE TEN WORST THE 7% HOW TO
HIDE YOUR SAYS HOURS DON'T PUT
THEIR LIVES AND- PLEASE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU. OUR NEXT QUESTION
OUR NEXT COMMENT WILL BE FROM
LINE THREE SIX FOUR GO AHEAD
PLEASE. DOCTOR ARAMBULA MEMBERS
WHICH IS PER CHILD DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR
HAVING THIS- HEARING WE'VE
GIVEN YOU ARE- WILL COME UP
COMMENTS THIS MORNING AND WE
ALL REFER THE COMMITTEE TO
THOSE I JUST HAVE A COUPLE OF
POINTS- THE WE'D LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT. IN THE AREA OF
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES PROPOSALS I JUST WANT
TO CALL OUT OF THE PROPOSAL AND
MAXIMIZE WITH FEDERAL FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES WHILE WE
CERTAINLY SUPPORT MAXIMIZING UP
FOR THE ELIGIBLE SERVICE
ASSEMBLY POLLS. I SERVICES
IMPORTANT WE BELIEVE THAT THE
PROPOSE TRAILER AND SUBSEQUENT.
OF SLIDE AND WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT
WE'LL BE ABLE TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE- AND- SOME OF THOSE
POSITIONS ARE MADE SPECIFICALLY
THAT THE MANY DON'T REALLY
PROVIDE ANY- UNICAL OBLIGATION
ON THE REGIONAL CENTER STILL
SAYS CONSUMERS AND MAKING FALE
APPLICATIONS IN. NEED OF THE
ASSISTANCE TO- LIKE THEM
THERE'S NO GOOD CAUSE
EXEMPTIONS INCLUDED IN THE- IN
THE PROCESS THAT THERE WOULD BE
CRITICAL IF INDIVIDUALS HAVE
PARTICULAR REASONS- WHY. THEY
COULDN'T MAKE THE APPLICATION
FOR MEDI CAL BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY- THE FLAW IS THAT
THERE IS A REQUIREMENT THAT
WOULD PLACE ON THE CONSUMER IF
THEY DON'T MAKE THE
APPLICATION- FOR MEDI CAL
BENEFITS WITH THEM- NINETY DAYS
THAT FROM THAT POINT FORWARD
PAGE THE RESPONSIBLE FOR- THE
FEDERAL COSTS- SO THAT'D BE
SHARED WITH THE CONSUMER IN THE
CONSUMERS- FAMILY SOMEWHERE.
ONE PARTICULARLY OPPOSED. TO
THAT THEN THE SPECIAL MORE NOW
TO PROCESS CONTRACTIONS
INCLUDED- INCLUDING THE NOTICE
OR HEARING RIGHTS THAT THAT
BILL CLINTON THAT STATUTE- THE
OTHER ISSUE WILL CHARGE YOU MAY
RECALL ON THE- MINISTRATION HAD
INCLUDED. IN ITS JANUARY BUDGET
A- A PROPOSED A TWENTY BETTER
EXPANSION OF THE INSTITUTIONAL
CARE AT PORTABLE ON
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER- IN AND
THAT- WE MAY BE ON THE- IN THE
MAY REVISED. AND DESTROY. THE
SERVICE AWAY SHE WILL A COME BY
ALL. INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE READY
TO BE DISCHARGED FROM
PORTABILITY AND RETURN TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES- WITHOUT THE LACKEY
AND CREATING SPACE FOR- ANY NEW
ADMISSIONS- RELATED TO THAT.
PROVIDED THE COMMITTEE STAFFS
IN WHICH- TO GIVE THE COURT
SOME ADDITIONAL DISCRETION TO
CONVERT INDIVIDUALS WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES FROM BEING IN A
PROPERLY FUNNELED. INTO THE-
JOBS IN THE FIRST PLACE THESE
DAYS CERTAINLY PROVISIONS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN EVER. IT'S ALSO
IN CHELSEA AND OTHER- THE
PENSION. THIS ORDER. IN CLOSING
WE JUST SHARE IN THE CAR. OF
ALL OF WE WARMLY IN A THE I. H.
SO IN PERSON. REDUCTION AND WE
ACCESS THE OPTION SLOUGH FOR
ALL OF THE REASONS SO
ARTICULATE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU KURT. WE GO TO LINE
FOR THREE FIVE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
BOB REPORTER DEFIED YOUR LINE
IS OPEN YES SIR HELLO MISTER
KAREN HELLO MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBER THIS IS DAVID
TATISHVILI IN A FIGHT AND OF A
LEVEL OF THE HOPPER BUILDING
CHOICE CARE FOR LIFE AND HOME
CARE AGENCY LEFT ON YOUR
ACCOUNT NOW THIS SERVICE THINK
IN EUROPE WE HAVE MULTIPLE
IMAGES SITES SUCH AS YOURS FROM
IT SERVICE OCT THANK YOU ARE
FOUNDATION AND CAN. INDEPENDENT
AT ALL BUT OVER KICKED IN YET.
WELL NEED IN CUTS AT THE
ADDRESS A AN IMPACT. HOWEVER
EVERITT HELP TO ARCHITECT MORAL
AND FINANCIAL. WHICH ONLY
UPLOADS ELIMINATION WITH THIS
BE PROGRAM FOR BOWLING GREEN.
MANY OF OUR COLLEAGUES MEASURE
THE MISSISSIPPI LITERALLY
SPACEFLIGHT BIGGER. NOT ON THE
LICENSING OF THEMSELVES BUT
ALSO LIVE LIKE WHAT. OPT OUT OF
OBAMACARE WORK UP THAT SERVICE
SO IF YOU NEED. OUR CARE GIVER
BEEN DRINKING THEIR ALL LIVE. A
LIFE OF THEIR FAMILY YOUR
RECORD NINETY CRISIS THEY'RE
ALL PURCHASE. I'M A FIFTY
PROGRAM IT MAKES TRYING TO
PREVENT BY FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
WHICH MEANT CUTTING GOVERNMENT
I'M OF THE P. FUNDING FROM
STATE BUDGET WILL AUTOMATICALLY
CUT CUT OFF ON THE GET WELL.
ATTENDED THE MAJESTY PROGRAM
WILL BE ELIMINATED. BUT INSTEAD
IT TO THINK IF THEY WALK APART
IF THE LOW END UP IN THE HYPE
OF NORFOLK BUT BUILT. IN
ADDITION TAPPED OUT OF THE HOME
CARE WORKABLE UP BY FOR STATE
FUNDED UNEMPLOYMENT. YOU KNOW
IT'LL BE A LOT FAILED SEVEN FOR
STATE AND ALSO PROGRAMMING AT
THE- CARE A LIKE THE- I'M AT
THE TABLE. WITH EVERYTHING YOU
FELL WILL UP FROM THE- WHICH
WILL BE A AMOUNT OF DOLLARS.
I'M A FIFTY OFF ON THE ONLY
BETWEEN SENIOR AND THAT AND
THAT IT STARTS DEVELOP TO THEM
IN A CALM. OUR CHARACTER ARE
HELP I'M BUT THE ALL THEIR
EIGHT YEAR AND SHOW THAT THERE
ARE IS I SAW AT ALL. AS A
RESULT ELIMINATION OF A OF
PIZZA NOW ONLY YOU MORE BUT
ALSO BY NAY NOT SUPPORT. BACK
AND THOUSAND MINUTES WHAT
pON A LOW FOR ELIMINATION OF THE
PEOPLE MOCKUP. WAS PRO ONE THAT
THE LIMóN OF A TO BE WILL NOT
SAVE MONEY TO THE STATE BUT
GOING STATE CALLED BY MANY UP
TO OUR HER BACK. NOTHING HAS
CHANGED AT THEM EXCEPT I'M
ADDICTED YOUR CALL NINETEEN THE
MARTHA SEVEN AM A GOOD FOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
PART TO WORK OUR CONCERN.
PLEASE TAKE A MINUTE BELLAMY OF
THE LATE FOR THAT LET ME
DEFAULT JUST YOUR WELCOME IS
NOW ANOTHER. I THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THAT. AND ONE OF THE
SAY THAT ALL OF OUR AFFAIR AND-
ALLOW AT LUNCH AND DOCTOR. AS I
WILL GOVERN OLDER SAYS ONE ONE.
LIKE THIS SO MY- AND- SENIOR
THEY DON'T NEED RESPECT AND A
VOICE AND COMMUNITY. AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR. YOUR KIND.
EMMA OF PEOPLE. AT THE DEFENSE.
QUALITY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
BOTH. WE'LL GO TO LINE THREE
THIRTY EIGHT GO AHEAD PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
ARAMBULA AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS LAUREN
HARRINGTON I AM A CLINICAL
SOCIAL WORKER AND HUNTINGTON
HOSPITAL AND THE P. SITE. WHICH
CIRCUMVENT GABRIEL VALLEY I
REQUEST THAT THE COMMITTEE
STRONGLY OPPOSED THE
ELIMINATION OF ABOUT FIFTY A
PROGRAM THAT IS NOW MORE VITAL
THAN EVER DURING THE
CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC. BUT
NEARLY TWELVE THOUSAND CRIED
AND IF P. HAVE HAD ONLY FIFTEEN
POSITIVE CO THAT NINETEEN KIDS.
I'M THREE DEATHS FROM VIRUS.
WHICH UNDERSCORED THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF KEEPING OUR
MOST VULNERABLE SENIORS FAITH
IN OUR HOMES. ELIMINATING THE
FINAL AND COST EFFECTIVE
PROGRAM WELL COMPROMISED BOTH
HEALTH AND SAFETY BY PUTTING A
CLIENT THAT DIRECT WAY OF
NURSING HOME PLACEMENT. AT A
TIME WHEN HAPPEN COOLEY
NINETEEN THAT. AND WHAT THE
ACTUAL COUNTY ARE TAKING PLACE
IN NURSING HOMES. THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THE TIME TO LISTEN TO MY
COMMENT. THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT
UP IS LINE FOR EIGHTY FIVE GO
AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD EVENING
TERMINATE AMBER LIGHT AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MANY
MATHEMATICAL AND THE TOTAL
REGRET WHO CAN HOSPITALS AND
THE FIGHT AS WELL AN ATHLETE IS
STRONGLY OPPOSED THE
ELIMINATION OF AND ASSIST
PEOPLE ALL THE RECENT STATED
BEFORE AND TO ALSO ADD WITH
OTHER SIGNIFICANT PIECE AND NOW
WITH THE COLD BUT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. AND HE HAS ACCEPTE
YOUR GO CLIENTS TO ADDRESS
ONGOING AND MEETS BUT ON BY THE
LEGISLATION AND DIFFICULT PIECE
EXACTLY SERVICES AND SUPPLIES
WHICH WITHOUT AND THE BILL
COULD BE DIFFICULT TO ATTAIN
PLEASE TELL AND ELIMINATE AND
HE COULD SPELL CALIFORNIANS AT
EVEN GREATER. THANK YOU FOR.
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU MA'AM.
WE'LL GO NEXT TO THE LINE JUST
ONE SECOND HERE HERE WE ARE.
HELLO NEXT TO LINE UP FOR
EIGHTY NINE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES MA'AM.
GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH
FISHERMEN AROUND YOU LEARN TO
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS TO CAMPAIGN ON THE CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA OUT REACH DIRECTOR
FOR THE COUNCIL ON AMERICAN
ISLAMIC RELATIONS IN SACRAMENTO
VALLEY AND CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
WE WORK WITH THE COALITION TO
HAD THE ADVOCATE FOR IMMIGRANTS
PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO ARE
FACING VERY VULNERABLE
CONDITIONS IN DETENTION. LIKE
MY COLLEAGUES I'M CALLING TO
SUPPORT THE DUE PROCESS IN
DETENTION PROGRAM BECAUSE THE
BUDGET ASK WITH ESTABLISH THE
FIRST STATEWIDE PENSION
COLLABORATIVE TO PROVIDE LEGAL
REPRESENTATION AND CULTURALLY
SERVICES FOR THESE INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE IN DETENTION WE KNOW
THAT THERE ARE FIVE IMMIGRATION
DETENTION FACILITIES ACROSS THE
STATE AND GET OUR STATE HAS
FAILED TO TAKE ANY ACTION. TO
STOP THE INFLUX OF INDIVIDUALS
INTO THE CIRCLE IS LEAD INTO
THE FACILITY OR TO HELP WITH
THEIR RELEASE WE REALLY
APPRECIATE FOLKS LIKE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RANDY Là WHO HAS
SUPPORTED IMMIGRANT INITIATIVES
IN THE PAST INCLUDING LEGAL
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA WHO IS CHAMPIONING
THIS REQUEST AND YOU HAVE HEARD
FROM MY COLLEAGUES BEFORE ME WE
REALLY WANT TO ADVOCATE THAT
FAMILIES AT THIS TIME WHEN THEY
ARE FEELING PAIN AND STRESS IN
THE POND THAT. SHOULD NOT
CANNOT BE SEPARATED YOU HEARD
OTHER PARTS BEING AND OR IN
CLOSE QUARTERS IS NOW BECOMING
A DEATH SENTENCE FOR IMMIGRANTS
WHO HEARD STORIES ABOUT THOSE
WHO HAVE ALREADY HAD LOTS OF
LIFE DUE TO THE PANDEMIC
SPREADING IN THE FACILITY WE
REALLY WANT TO CONTINUE TO
ADVOCATE FOR STATEWIDE EFFORT
TO FREE PEOPLE FROM IMMIGRATION
DETENTION AND YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA HAS MORE THAN FIVE
THOUSAND PEOPLE WHO ARE
IMPACTED IN THIS WAY. WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THE DUE PROCESS IS
APPLIED FOR QUALITY
CALIFORNIANS SO I THINK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND REALLY
JUST WANT TO KEEP STRESSING
THAT IT'S MORE IMPORTANT NOW
THAN EVER FOR OUR- STATE AND
OUR LEGISLATOR TO MAKE SURE WE
KEEP FAMILIES. INTACT THANK YOU.
HELLO TO LINE THREE FORTY THREE
GO AHEAD PLEASE. HELLO. MY NAME
IS JUST SHUFFLING AND I'M A
SOCIAL WORKER MANAGER FOR AN
EFFECT PETERING YUBA COUNTY I
AM REQUESTING THAT HIS
COMMITTEE OPPOSES THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL TO
ELIMINATE THE MULTI PURPOSE
SENIOR SERVICES PROGRAM I HAVE
HAD THE PLEASURE OF
COLLABORATING WITH THE LOW
INCOME FRAIL ELDERLY
PARTICIPANTS TO KEEP THEIR
LIVING. SAFELY IN THEIR OWN
HOMES AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN
DURING THAT TIME I HAVE
PERSONALLY WITNESSED THE
POSITIVE IMPACT THE PROGRAM HAS
HAD ON OUR SENIORS AND THEIR
SUPPORT SYSTEMS MAJORITY OF MS
FIFTY CLIENTSLET ALONE THEY
ARE LIVING ON IT ABOUT A
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER MONTH. AND
THEY HAVE COMPLEX NEEDS THAT
REQUIRE SPECIALIZED MEDICAL AND
SOCIAL SERVICES THAT AND THAT'S
IT HE IS ABLE COULD PROVIDE.
AND I SAID HE IS A THAT- VERY
VALUABLE PROGRAM AND I JUST
WANT TO REITERATE THAT FOR THE
CAUGHT THE FIVE THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX DOLLARS
HER CLIENT PER YEAR MSF HE IS
ABLE TO KEEP THE THROW IN YOUR
LIVING IN THEIR OWN HOME. BASED
BUSINESS THAT STANGEL COST
SAVINGS WHEN COMPARED TO THE
AVERAGE COST IN CALIFORNIA FOR
A SKILLED NURSING FACILITY
WHICH IS EIGHTY SIX THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
DOLLARS PER YEAR OUR ELDERLY
PARTICIPANTS THEIR FAMILY AND
OR CARE PROVIDERS OFTEN EXPRESS
THEIR GRATITUDE FOR EMMA FIFTY
SUPPORT SERVICES. AND WE ALL
WOULD GREATLY. APPRECIATE YOUR
ASSISTANCE. IN KEEPING THEIR A
THE FACT AND PROVEN PRO UP AND-
THE A LIMóN. OF A- HE COULD
AND WOULD HAVE DEVASTATING
CONSEQUENCES TO OUR SENIORS. I
RECOGNIZE THAT CUTS MAY BE
NECESSARY BUT THE OLDER ADULTS
OF THIS STATE PARTICULARLY THE
MOST FRAIL AND NEEDY. HAVE
OVERWHELMINGLY BEEN IMPACTED
HISTORICALLY PLEASE DO NOT
LEAVE THE SENIORS UNDERSERVED
DURING A TIME IN WHICH THEY
NEED THESE PROGRAMS THE MOST.
WE THINK THAT VALUABLE PROGRAM
AND OPPOSED THE ELIMINATION OF
MSF HE AND FEEDBACK THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU MA'AM.
THANK YOU AND NOW TO LINE UP
FOR NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING CHAIRMAN ARAMBULA
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS LAURA SO FAR THEY WORK
AT THE HOSPITAL AND I SAID THE
FIGHT OF HE BILL CHAU WORK
CASE MANAGER. AND I AM URGING
YOU TO REJECT THE PROPOSAL TO
ELIMINATE AND THAT THIS YEAR
FALL I THINK OTHERS THE FORMING
A POINTED OUT VERY WELL OF THE
MANY REASONS WHY AND HE SHOULD
REMAIN INTACT. SO. I WILL MAKE
MY COMMENTS BRIEF. I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO. THAT AND IT'S A HE IS
A VITAL PROGRAM ACTORS TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF LOW INCOME RAIL
ALTER EGO. ACTUALLY AT LAST
DURING THE CALL THE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC AND MEET OUR SERVICE
IS NOW MORE THAN EVER. IT'S
VULNERABLE POPULATION NEED
ELECTED NEED CONTINUED SUPPORT
AND SERVICES TO CONTINUE LIVING
SAFELY AT HOME. SO I AGAIN URGE
YOU TO OPPOSE THE ELIMINATION
OF BENEFITS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU MA'AM. THANK
YOU AN OUTLINE OF. FOUR THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
SIR HI THERE GOOD AFTERNOON-
THIS IS TRUTH MEDICARE YOU DOOR.
AND A SINGLE MOM AND THEN IN
HOME SUPPORT SERVICE PROVIDER
IN SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY. WE ARE
ASKING YOU TO PLEASE SUPPORT
THE CARD ONLY MOVE ALL OF IT
AND THE S. S. B. AND ALL. I AM
TAKING CARE OF MY DAD
UNDERGOING DAILY SHE PAYMENT
THAT WEEK. I'VE BEEN TAKING
CARE OF THEM IN A FIVE YEAR. I
HAD TO GIVE UP MY JOB BECAUSE
CARE HOME CAN YOU. CAN THEM
THERE BECAUSE OF THE INSURANCE
ISSUE. WE CAN'T AFFORD TO PAY
OUT OF POCKET. THIRTEEN YOU
WAITED THE- SURE NEED CUTTING
OUR EXPOSURE IN THE END BUT- IT
WILL BE MUCH HARDER FOR ON IT.
WE ARE ASKING FOR YOUR HELP.
BUT THE MORE PERSONAL NOTE
IMMENSELY AND HE HELPED ME A
LOT IN TAKING CARE OF BOTH MY
EXPERIENCE. IN WHICH MY MOM HAD
ACTUALLY LEFT YET NO WORRIES.
AGAIN WE ARE ASKING FOR YOUR
HELP WE PRAY THAT GOD WILL BE
WITH YOU ACTUALLY ARE. CHILD HI.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR LETTING
US COMMENT FOR LISTED SO I.
THOUGHT I'D LET. THANK YOU
MA'AM. THANK. THANK YOU AND NOW
TO THE LINE FOR EIGHTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS- THIS IS
JANET HEATH EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE IN OF THIS PIECE ALSO
CHANGED. I SUPPORT THE PREVIOUS
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO THE
ELIMINATION OF THEM EXISTING.
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT
THAT WHILE COPING NINETEEN HAS
IDENTIFIED SYSTEM WEAKNESSES.
IT ALSO SAYING AREAS OF
STRENGTH THANK YOU THE END OF
THIS PM FEEDBACK. TIMELY
RESPONSE TO ME IN THEIR QUIET
THE- I'VE BEEN ASKED TODAY THE
SPEAKER ONE OF OUR NORTHERN
MOST LIKE SINCE THEY'RE HAVING
A- POWER OUTAGE UP IN THE
SHASTA AREA RIGHT NOW. SO ON
BEHALF OF JENNIFER POWELL WHO'S
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
DIGNITY DIGNITY HEALTH
CONNECTED LIVING. AND SERVING
SHASTA AND SISKIYOU COUNTY. SHE
HAS BOTH OF THEM A FIFTY AN
ADULT DAY HEALTH CARE PROGRAM.
SO CALLED HER. I CAN APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT BUDGET CUTS ARE
REAL AND AFFORDABLE. HOWEVER WE
ARE FACING A LIFE AND DEATH
SITUATION BY ELIMINATING AND
THIS IS KEY AND THROUGH THE-
INCLUDED IN THE POPULAR. OUR
OUR LOCAL SENIORS THAT SUFFERS
FROM THE CAR IN DELTA FIRES.
AND OTHERS THAT NEED LOCATED TO
OUR SERVICE AREA FROM THE
DEVASTATING CAMP FIRE. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT I THINK THAT
THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE THE MOST
AT RISK TO COPE WITH NINETEEN
INFECTION. PROGRAMS ENSURE THAT
THEY DECIDED TO TAKE ME HOME.
WHAT IS THE PLAN FOR THE
SPOKESMAN AND ASSISTING THE
DOCTOR INUNDATED. WE DO NOT
HAVE SUFFICIENT BEDS IN MY
REGION TWO WEEKS BEFORE
COOPERATIVE LET ALONE AFTER.
ADDITIONALLY SMITH HAVE PROVEN
TO BE A DEADLY PLACE DURING THE
COLD WITH NINETEEN PANDEMIC. I
WAS TOLD THIS AFTERNOON BY
EIGHTY EIGHT THE STAFF AT THE
SHELTER IN PLACE ORDER. WE HAVE
HAD TWO OF OUR EIGHTY EIGHT
PARTICIPANTS PLACED IN SKILLED
NURSING. INSTEAD OF A HUNDRED
DOLLARS A DAY FOR THREE DAY
FIVE DAYS A WEEK. OF EIGHTY
SERVICES. TWO FORMER FOR
INDIVIDUALS ARE NOW OCCUPYING
THEIR TO THE COST OF EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER MONTH EACH.
LASTLY ELIMINATING OF INNOCENCE
P. AND FINANCE PROGRAMS WILL
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
UNEMPLOYED SKILLED WORKERS. AM
I ORGANIZATION LOAN THIS
TRANSLATES TO NEARLY 25% OF MY
TOTAL WORKFORCE. THESE ARE THE
VERY WORKERS THAT CONSIDER
THEMSELVES THE SENSUAL AND
SHOWED UP TO THE OFFICE
IMMEDIATELY AFTER THE GOVERNOR
SHELTER IN PLACE ORDER TO CALL
THE CLIENT. SHOWED UP THROUGH
DELIVERY ORDER CLEAN SUPPLIES
AND TALK WITH DESPERATE CARE
GIVERS OVERWHELMED AT THE
PROSPECT OF CARING FOR THEIR
LOVED ONES WITHOUT RESPITE OR
SYSTEM. I FEAR FOR THE HEALTH
OF OUR CLIENTS IN THE PHYSICAL
AND MENTAL HEALTH OF THE
FAMILIES WHO CARE AND LOVE THEM
SHOULD AND WITH PNC BANK. HERE
ELIMINATION OF END OF THE
STREET AND SEE ABOUT PROGRAMS
IS VERY MUCH A LIFE AND DEATH
CHOI. YOU ARE FACED WITH.
REJECT THE PROPOSED CUTS TO
VULNERABLE OLDER ADULTS. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK AND ADVOCATE FOR HUNDRED
FIFTEEN YEARS IN THE NORTH
STATE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE ON
THIS CALL. THANK YOU MA'AM.
THANK YOU AND DOWN THE LINE ONE
NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES MA'AM. THANK YOU I'M
CHECKING AROUND BILL AN ARTICLE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR OPENING
UP THIS TIME FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
MY NAME IS OUT TODAY AND I'M A
LICENSED CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER
AND HUMBOLDT COUNTY. AGAIN
HUMBOLDT SENIOR RESEARCH CENTER
WHERE I SUPERVISED A MULTI
PURPOSE IN YOUR SERVICES
PROGRAM. AND PROVIDE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES BUT FEEDBACK
ADULT DAY HEALTH PROGRAM. WE
FIRMLY OPPOSE THE ELIMINATION
OF AND THAT THAT P. AND
FEEDBACK. AND I'M GOING TO ECHO
SOME OF THE THINGS MY
COLLEAGUES ABOUT HE SAID
BECAUSE IT'S POWERFUL NECESSARY
AND WE NEED TO EMPHASIZE HOW
PARAMOUNT THE SERVICE THE FIRE
TO GO TO A MOST VULNERABLE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES. GLOBAL FORTY
YEARS MSRP HAS HAD A PROVEN
TRACK RECORD OF KEEPING THE
OLDEST POOREST. AND MOST FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS. IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES OUT OF SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY. SEVEN ABOUT.
ALMOST TWELVE THOUSAND OLDER
ADULTS KEEPING THEM IN OUR
HOME. PROVIDING A SIGNIFICANT
ANNUAL SAVINGS TO CALIFORNIA
AND REDUCING THE BURDEN ON THE
ALREADY OVERTAXED HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM. AND THE P. AS COST
EFFECTIVE AND IT'S ELIMINATION
BOTH THOUGHT INCREASE FONG TERM
CARE PLACEMENT AT A GREATER
COST TO THE STATE AND A GREATER
PERSONAL COST. WE LIVE ALSO
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT
SENIORS AND RURAL COUNTY SUCH
AS HUMBOLDT IN WHICH GEOGRAPHIC
AND SOCIAL ISOLATION ARE HIGH.
AND SERVICES AND SUPPORT ARE
SEVERELY LIMITED. ADDITIONALLY
PUBLIC HERE RESOURCE CENTER
STEADFASTLY OPPOSED TO THE
ELIMINATION OF FEEDBACK FROM
THE STATE BUDGET. AT THE OKAY
SO YOU CAN TALK FOR ADULT DAY
HEALTH I'VE SEEN FIRST HAND THE
INCREASING SOCIAL ISOLATION
DEPRESSION. EIGHTY DESPAIR AND
SUICIDALITY IN THE LIVES OF OUR
MOST AT RISK INDIVIDUALS AND
THEIR CAREGIVERS. FEEDBACK
WITHOUT WALLS CONTINUING TO
PROVIDE ESSENTIAL SOCIAL AND
HEALTH SERVICES PEOPLE HAVE A
LITTLE. THE MAN'S FACE OUT OF
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY. THE
BACK END. AND IT PROTECTS THE
VERY PEOPLE WHO ARE MOST AT
RISK FROM COVER NINETEEN
BECAUSE OF THEIR AGE OR
UNDERLYING HEALTH CONDITION
INNOVATING FEEDBACK NOT ONLY
AFFECTS SENIORS BUT ALL
GENERATION. WITHOUT THE
INTERVENTION FROM BOTH MSF PNC
BATH IS VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS
ARE LEFT TO NAVIGATE AN
INCREASINGLY COMPLICATED SYSTEM
OF MEDICAL AND SOCIAL SERVICES
ALONE AND MAYBE TAKE A
PLACEMENT AND LONG TERM CARE
FACILITIES. OUT OF ALL
CHAIRPERSON COMMITTEE MEMBERS I
AM FOR YOU. PLEASE REJECT THE
ELIMINATION OF AND ACCESS PNC
BACK ON THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET. THIS PUTS THE MOST
PRESSING YOUR THAN ADULTS WITH
DISABILITIES EVEN HIGHER RISK
AND WITHOUT THEIR SAFETY NET.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
AND YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU MA'AM. THANK YOU IT NOW TO
THE LINE ONE ELEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I AM ONE ELEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD WILL MOVE ALONG THE
LINE. FOR SIX SIX FOUR SIXTY
FIFTH. AT HI. KILL TOOL FROM
THE CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON
AGING- THE COMMISSION ON AGING
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS GREAT
CONCERN OVER ALL OF THE
PROPOSAL IN THE NAY REVISED
AFFECTING THE HOME AND
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES FOR
OLDER AND DISABLED ADULTS. WE
ARE FIRMLY- OF THE BELIEF THAT
PROTECTING PROGRAMS THAT KEEP
PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY. IT'S
COST EFFECTIVE THESE PROGRAMS
HELP PEOPLE LIVE THE FOUR
FLIGHTS POSSIBLE ARE IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THE OLD THE
DECISION. AND THAT WE ARE
KEEPING PEOPLE SAFE AND
PROTECTED FROM THE RISK OF
CODED NINETEEN BY ALLOWING THEM
TO STAY IN THEIR HOMES WHEN THE
PANDEMIC FIRST OF. BECAME
APPARENT IN THE STATE GOVERNOR
NEWS URGE TO OLDER ADULTS AND
PERSONAL LIVES. CHRONIC
UNDERLYING. TO REMAIN IN THEIR
HOMES HE HAS MADE CLEAR
STATEMENT THAT THESE PROGRAMS-
PARTICULARLY SEA BASS IS AN
ESSENTIAL PART OF THE SYSTEM TO
HELP KEEP PEOPLE SAFE. GIVEN
THE RATE THAT WE'RE STAYING ON
OF THE DEATH IN NURSING HOME
RIGHT RIGHT NOW IT JUST MAKES
NO SENSE AT ALL TO. LEARN
CONSIDER ELIMINATING THESE
PROGRAMS HERE OPPOSE ONCE AGAIN
WOULD YOU THINK THE MOST VITAL
PROGRAMS FOR OLDER ADULTS. ON
THAT WE HAVE BARELY BEEN ABLE
TO RESTORE FROM THE LAST
RECESSION- WE HAVE SOME BETTER
COMMENTS AND WE APPRECIATE ALL
THE OTHER COMMENTERS THAT WE'VE
HEARD- SO WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND WE URGE YOUR REJECTION
OF. CUT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND NOW TO LINE. FIVE FIFTEEN
FIVE FIFTEEN. GOOD AFTERNOON M
NAME IS KAREN I'VE GOT EMAIL
I'M A SOCIAL WORKER FOR AND
THAT'S P. FROM HUNTINGTON
HOSPITAL IN PASADENA I AM
REACHING OUT TODAY TO VOICE MY
CONCERN WITH THE ELIMINATION OF
THE MULTIPURPOSE SENIOR
SERVICES PROGRAM THE OLDER
ADULT POPULATION THAT WE SERVE
ARE THE MOST FRAIL AND
VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS THE
SERVICES THAT AND THAT'S THAT'S
THE PROVIDE A VITAL TO ENSURE
THEIR SAFETY AND WELL BEING IN
THE HOME. AND TO PREVENT
PLACEMENT IN NURSING HOME I
DEEPLY CARE FOR THE CLIENTS AND
FAMILIES THAT WE SERVE BUT YOU
THROUGH THE AND ALL THE OTHER
REASONS THAT PEOPLE GIVE
SPEAKERS HAVE MENTIONED I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO PLEASE
STAND TOGETHER AND OPPOSED THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
ELIMINATE THE NSF. FEE PROGRAM.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU AND OUTLINED FIVE OLD FIVE.
HELLO MY NAME IS NANCY GO WITH
HUMAN SERVICES ASSOCIATION WE
OPPOSE THE TOTAL ELIMINATION OF
MSN P. BALANCING THE BUDGET ON
THE MOST VULNERABLE MEMBERS OF
OUR POPULATION OUR SENIOR IS
SHAMEFUL AND I'M MORE ALL
PLEASE SAVE OUR TEEN YEARS
PLEASE STATE EVER SINCE HE-
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND NOW TO
THE LINE FIVE THIRTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS VALERIE
AND I'M CALLING I WORK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CLAPPER FOR
IMMIGRANTS NOTHING AND I'VE
BEEN WORKING AT THE THING I'M
REPRESENTED IMMIGRANT IN
IMMIGRATION DETENTION. IN KERN
COUNTY AND IN YUBA COUNTY FOR
THE PAST THREE AND A HALF
YEARS. AND I'M CALLING THE
SUPPORT THAT YOU PROCESS AND
ENGINE PROGRAM. I WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT THE COMMITTEE
UNDERSTAND HOW MUCH THIS
IMPACT. FAMILY UNITY AND PUBLIC
HEALTH AND NO FAMILY DESERVES
TO BE SEPARATED ESPECIALLY
DURING A PANDEMIC AND
IMMIGRATION THE PENCIL IS A-
FORM OF FAMILY SEPARATION. MOST
PEOPLE IN IMMIGRATION DETENTION
CENTERS ARE MOTHERS AND FATHERS
HARDER THOUSAND. SO MANY OF
THEM ARE BREADWINNER AND CARE
GIVERS FOR FAMILY. MEMBERS JUST
PARENTS WHO THEY ARE SEPARATED
FROM ALL IN DETENTION.
CALIFORNIA HAS OVER FIVE
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN. IMMIGRATION
DETENTION WE NEED HELP. IT IS
NOW DOESN'T FOR EVER. AS YOU
COME ALREADY KNOW THE FIRST
THAT AND EIGHT TO TENSIONS WILL
CALL THE NINETEEN HAPPENED HERE
IN OUR STATE. THE ONLY ANSWER
IS A COMPREHENSIVE STATEWIDE
PROGRAM TO PROTECT YOU PROCESS.
WHICH CAN THREE PEOPLE FOR
IMMIGRATION DETENTION. ACCESS
TO LEGAL REPRESENTATION IS THE
SINGLE MOST IMPORTANT FACTOR IN
DETERMINING WHETHER A THINKING
PERSON WIN THEIR CASE AND THEIR
BIKING FREEDOM. AT A MINIMUM WE
WANT CALIFORNIAN INDEPENDENT TO
BE ABLE TO MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS BEFORE DECIDING TO
ACCEPT OUR MOBILE DEPORTATION
ORDER. WHICH WOULD RESULT IN
HAMMOND AND FAMILY FEDERATION.
MORE IMPORTANT THAN EVER FOR
OUR STATE TO KEEP FAMILIES
TOGETHER THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CALL. THANK YOU MA'AM. AND OUT
OF THE LINE OF FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS JUANITA CRAFT COLOR
FROM. FORTY FIVE IN A SENSE P.
AND SANTA CLARA COUNTY. I'M
GOING TO ADD MY VOICE TO THOSE
WHO HAVE TALKED ABOUT SERVING
THE MOST TRAIL AND FINANCIALLY
AT RISK SENIORS. MSF P. HELP
THESE INDIVIDUALS THEIR
FAMILY'S MEDICAL TEAM AND OTHER
SUPPORT SERVICES TO KEEP THESE
INDIVIDUALS LIVING IN SAFE
CLEAN LIVING SAFELY IN THE
COMMUNITY OR THE BETTER FOR
THEM AND THEIR FAMILIES. LESS
EXPENSIVE THAN HOSPITAL FINANCE
AND PLACE. IN ORDER OUR
POPULATION IS GROWING IN MANY
SENIORS DON'T HAVE INFORMAL
SUPPORT AND HAVE DIFFICULTY TO
ASK ACCESS FORMAL SERVICES. AND
THE FIFTY IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTING IS GETTING MORE OF
THESE TYPES OF REFERRAL THEY
MUST SENSE P. CASE MANAGER
NURSE CASE MANAGER ARE AN
ESSENTIAL PIECE TO HELP
COORDINATE. CARE IMPROVE THE
CLEARANCE HOLE SITUATION.
PLEASE DON'T BOB UP IN A FIFTY.
THANK YOU MA'AM. THANK YOU AND
NOW TO LINE UP. FIVE FOUR FIVE
FIVE FORTY FIVE. HELLO GOOD
EVENING THANK YOU FOR TAKING
THE TIME TO LISTEN TO MY
COMMENTS MY NAME IS DOCTOR
MICHELLE RODGERS I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE EARLY
LEARNING INSTITUTE OF ENTERED
PROGRAM OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. SERVING
NEARLY FIVE HUNDRED SPECIAL
NEEDS INFANTS AND TODDLERS IN
CINEMA COUNTY. EVEN WITH CODE
NINETEEN CHANGES WE HAVE
CONTINUED TO PROVIDE SERVICES
TO THESE CHILDREN AND FAMILIES.
USING REMOTE AND TELL HEALTH
SERVICES NOT ONLY ARE WE
PROVIDING DEVELOPMENTAL
EDUCATION AND TEACHING WE ARE
NOW PROVIDING SUPPORT FOR BASIC
NEEDS. THINGS LIKE FOOD AND
SHELTER MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORTS.
AND DOING A GREAT DEAL OF CHILD
ABUSE PREVENTION. WELL I
APPRECIATE THE DIFFICULT
DECISIONS BEFORE YOU I AM
REQUESTING THAT YOU RECONSIDER
MAKING ANY CUTS TO THE RATE OF
EARLY INTERVENTION SERVICES
PROVIDED UNDER THE DEPARTMENT
OF DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. AS
YOU MAY RECALL EARLY
INTERVENTION WAS LEFT OUT OF
THE VENDOR RATE INCREASES
INSTITUTED IN THE NINETEEN
TWENTY BUDGET. THIS WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE FIX THIS YEAR
BUT THAT INCREASES BEEN
WITHDRAWN AND NOW A CUTS BEEN
PUT IN ITS PLACE. TO IMPOSE
ADDTIONAL 10% RATE REDUCTION
ON US WILL CAUSE MANY PROVIDERS
WHO BEEN LITERALLY HANGING ON
BY THEIR FINGERNAILS. TO CLOSE.
ADDITIONALLY OUR GOVERNOR SPOKE
OF SPECIAL EDUCATION AS A CORE
VALUE IN CALIFORNIA AND IN FACT
GAVE THE CATER TWELVE SPECIAL
EDUCATION SERVICES EACH 15%
INCREASE. SOMEHOW THE SPECIAL
NEEDS INFANTS AND TODDLERS HAVE
BEEN OVERLOOKED IT SEEMS
FUNDAMENTALLY WRONG TO BALANCE
ITS BUDGET BY CUTTING SERVICES
TO THESE VULNERABLE BABIES AND
THOSE WHO SERVE THEM ESPECIALLY
CENTS FOR EVERY DOLLAR WE SPEND
ON IT EARLY INTERVENTION. WE
ULTIMATELY SAVE SEVEN DOLLARS
IN KATY TWELVE SERVICES. PLEASE
RECONSIDER THE CUTS TO EARLY
INTERVENTION THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK.
THANK YOU MA'AM. WE'LL GO NEXT
TO LINE FIVE FIVE EIGHT GO
AHEAD PLACE. GOOD EVENING THIS
CARE. KAREN KIESLER WITH.
LEVINE I REQUEST. I CAN HEAR
MYSELF. IN THE PHONE AND IT
RIGHT GREAT CARING HE FIRED
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF ABOUT
THIRTY. AND WE'RE ON THE FORTY
TO FIFTY FACT OPPOSED BALL-
WAVE. THAT MAY BE FOR YOU WE
OFFER SUPPORT BEAR PROPOSAL. TO
INCREASE THAT- BACK FROM
REALIGNMENT. WELL 7% FROM THE
BOARD AT I BAD I WANTED THE-
THAT BOTH FOR THE MAY REVISED
DEAL WITH WITH THAT THANK
FEDERAL RESPONSIBILITIES TO THE
STATE THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT
WASN'T WITHOUT BUT THE COUNTY
FOR THE PUBLIC AUTHORITIES WE
DON'T THINK THAT THAT BILLION
FULLY. AND WORK CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU MA'AM. EXTRA LINE
FIVE FIVE NINE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
HI HI MY NAME IS CAROLINE
SHOALS AND- I'VE BEEN MEDINA
MRS P. FOR ALMOST TWENTY YEARS
WORKING AS AN ARE IN CARE
MANAGER AND NOW CLINICAL
SUPERVISOR. I BELIEVE THAT
ELIMINATION OF MS WITH KEEP TO
DEGRADE THE STABILITY AND
SECURITY THAT SO MANY OF OUR
CLIENTS FEEL KEEP IN ALL THE
WAYS THEY'RE SUPPORTED BY
IMAGES KEY KOHLER'S HEARD IS TO
HELP CLIENTS AVOID UNNECESSARY
EMERGENCY ROOM VISITS LESSEN
HOSPITALIZATIONS. AND JUST TO
AVOID BEING INSTITUTIONALIZED.
I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT ON
PAPER THIS MAY SEEM LIKE A
SIMPLE LINEAR PROCESS BUT IT IS
SO MUCH MORE COMPLICATED THAN
THAT. WE WORK WITH PEOPLE WHO
WERE LIVING ON THE EDGE OF
FOLKS WHO ARE PHYSICALLY FRAIL.
MEDICALLY COMPLICATED SUFFERING
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES SUBSTANCE
ABUSE CHALLENGES. SOMETIMES
ABUSIVE AND NEGLECTFUL HOME
SITUATION REALLY FEARFUL IN
HIGH RISK FOR ALSO TO CALAMITY
HOUSING SITUATION CAN BE LIVING
IN AN SRO. WORKING IN
CLUTTERING SITUATIONS LIVING IN
A MAKESHIFT APARTMENT IN THE
BACK OF THE GARAGE THAT'S
TOTALLY ONLY GO ON AND ON OUR
MOST IMPORTANT TOOL IN WORKING
WITH THIS VULERABLE POPULATION
IS RELATIONSHIP BUILDING. NOT
ONLY DO WE NEED TO CONNECT WITH
THEIR CLIENTS GEN THEIR TRUST
AND DEVELOPED A PARTNERSHIP
WITH THEM. BUT WE MUST BE
EXCEEDINGLY RESOURCEFUL AND
CREATIVE IN MOVING THEM TOWARD.
A SIMPLE GOLD KEEPING MEDICAL
APPOINTMENTS TAKING MEDICATIONS
ENGAGING WITH PROVIDERS WHO CAN
HELP WITH ANY NUMBER OF
CHALLENGES AND OBSTACLES.
SENATE THESPIAN TEMPERATURE
CLOSER TO THE VERY DIVERSE
POPULATION WITH LANGUAGES
INCLUDING SPANISH CHINESE
RUSSIAN FORESEE AND OTHERS. AND
OUR TEAM IS A DIVERSE TO THE
POPULATION WE SERVE SO IT IS
WELL SUITED TO UNDERSTAND AND
MEET THE CULTURAL AND LANGUAGE
MAINTENANCE OF THOSE RESEARCH.
WE URGE YOU TO OPPOSE CUTS
GENESIS. WITHOUT AN EXISTING
MANY WILL NO LONGER BE ABLE TO
REMAIN IN THEIR HOMES WILL NEED
TO BE MOVED FROM HOME
CONSISTENT WITH THESE PUTTING
SOMEBODY MORE AT RISK FOR
COVERT NINETEEN OTHER
INFECTIONS AND DEATHS. SO I
THANK YOU DOCTOR ARAMBULA AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE WITH
YOU. ONE TWO NINE FOUR NINETY
NINE GO AHEAD PLEASE STE. OKAY.
NINE FOUR NINETY NINE YOU'RE
OPEN GO AHEAD. THIS IS JEFF IS
THAT BORING OR SOMEBODY ELSE.
IN YOUR LOCAL. WE CAN HEAR YOU.
HELLO THIS IS A JEFF HARDY HERE
I WAS THE FIRST PERSON ON I
DON'T KNOW WHETHER I STATED WHO
I WAS AND WHAT ORGANIZATIONS
BUT I'VE HEARD MANY OF MY
COALITION TALK ABOUT THESE
THINGS FORTY YEARS AGO
CALIFORNIA WAS VERY GOOD TO ME.
I TRIED TO KEEP GIVING BACK
THEN I'M A SINGLE SURVIVOR SO I
WAS THE FOSTER CARL TRIALED FOR
MY TEENAGE YEARS FORTUNATELY
RICHARD STEPPED UP. BUT FOR THE
OTHER ASPECTS OF PARTS YOU
THERE WILL SAY TO YOU IS THIS.
PLEASE AFTER THIS BEING THE
SECOND TIME THAT THE SAFETY NET
HAS BEEN REDUCED. X. ASSEMBLY
PEOPLE ONLY USE WHAT THE SENATE
HAS DONE WE'LL LOOK AT COMING
UP WITH AN ALTERNATIVE PLAN FOR
THE FUTURE EMPLOYEES GET THE
REST OF THE GOVERNOR'S
COMMISSION TO ENCOURAGE THEM TO
START SO THAT THEY CAN GET
FINISH THE WORK THAT IS SO
CRITICAL TO BE DONE FOR OUR
MOST SENIOR AT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE. SHOULD WE SAY.
INDIVIDUALS IN CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYEES ALSO CONSIDER HOW IN
THE WORLD THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN GET OUR FORTY
MILLION RESIDENTS MASKS. AND
THE- A SUPER SAKE PROTECTIVE
GEAR THAT IS NEEDED. THERE ARE
DEAD IN OUR OTHER SERVICES SO
THEY CAN PROVIDE THE SERVICE
VERY NEAT- AS WELL AS OUR RURAL
COMMUNITY YOU NEED TO LOOK AT
OUR WHOLE SYSTEM AND REDEFINE
IT. YOU NEED TO LOOK AT WHAT
HO WE. DO BETTER OF ASSISTING.
OUR OTHER CENTERS SO CENTERS
AND GET THE BACKBONE OF
INTERNET IN CALIFORNIA SO THAT
CAN PROVIDE THE NEEDS FOR OUR
TELECOMMUNICATION TO EXPAND
THESE ARE ALL BASIC. BACKBONE
SERVICES THAT YOU IS PART OF
THE HELP IN PART OF THE MOST
SENIOR COMMUNITY NEEDS TO BE
EFFECTIVELY TREATED AT
ADDRESSING ALL OF THESE NEEDS
AND THEY'RE ONLY GOING TO GET
BIGGER. THANK YOU. AFTER A
REGULAR AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS-
PLEASE CONSIDER WHAT HOW YOUBEST COME UP WITH THE DECISIONS
IN THE WORK. THANK YOU SIR.
WILL MOVE TO LINE FIVE SIXTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
EVENING. YOU KNOW WHAT THE HELL
ARE YOU. WELL YOU'RE DOING
GREAT MA'AM YOUR LINE IS OPEN
GO AHEAD. HI ALL. THANK YOU TO
HIM FOR AWHILE AND SO MANY
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY TO
SHOW THEIR COMPOUND BOW WITH
YOU ALL COULD YOU OFFER YOUR
ABILITY TO OPEN COMPASSIONATELY.
SO IT NOT A MORE LEVEL OKAY
OKAY HELLO. HE IS A NATIONAL
MEMBERSHIP ORGANIZATION THAT
THE HOUSEHOLD HELP IN ALL. AT A
LOCAL ARE WILL WITH YOU
TOMORROW ON WILL BE WITH THE
MORE MORNING CAN YOU EXPECTING
ON THE SON ABOUT THE- CUT IN
THE PLEDGE. NOTABLE. I DO WANT
TO KNOW THAT WHILE WE'RE VERY
THAT THE MAYOR PLAN BUT IF YOU
GOT GOING TO GIVE. BUT WILL
ALSO GRATEFUL THAT. CALPERS
WOULD NOT REDUCE. WE ALL VERY
PEOPLE TROUBLED ABOUT THE BUT
OVER CUTS TO A HE APPROACH TO
KEEP HOLD HELLO. PERSON WITH
DISABILITIES NEVER HOME THANK
YOU WELL FOR THE BE NOTABLY
FROM COMBO SAID WE THEY ARE
DOES PROPOSED ELIMINATION OF
CAN THEY DON'T SERVICES.
WELCOME PURPOSE SENIOR SERVICES
PROGRAM ALONG WITH THE AWFUL
CONCERN ABOUT THE 7% REDUCTION
IN I HOURS. SO ARE YOU ONLY
LOOKING TO TALK TO YOU ARE OF
ME BUT. LOOK FOR TO WHILE
YOU'RE NOT FIVE. CONVERSATION
MOVED ON THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM. WELL GO NEXT LINE FOR
SIXTY TWO GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CAN MEET A MEMBER MY NAME IS
DAVE I'M WHEN I AM THE DIRECTOR
FOR LIKE YOU KNOW MANY TO TODAY
FOUGHT FAMILY BOB. AGENCY I AM
ASKING YOU TO PLEASE HELP HOLD
THE ELIMINATION OF THE FAA
SOCIAL WORKER RATE- INCREASE.
OUR AND NOW THAT MY COLLEAGUES
ALREADY SAID- A LOT OF A GOOD
THINK ABOUT IT BUT- BOTTOM LINE
NEEDS. AT LEAST OUR CHILDREN
RECEIVE THE MEDICAL MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS- OF THE NEED FOR
MORE SOCIAL WORKER. OUR SOCIAL
WORKERS- REFUSE SAFETY THE WELL
BEING OF OUR KIDS. AND TEY
HELP ON THE NO COURTNEY THE
VISIT BASED ON EVEN THOUGH WITH
ALL THE VARIOUS REGARDING CALL
THE NINETEEN. THEY ARE HELPING
THEM EVERY DAY TO COMPLETE
THEIR SCHOOL ASSIGNMENTS
SPECIALLY FOR THOSE THAT ARE
GRADUATING OUR OUR GRADUATE
SENIOR THAT ARE YOU SEE SOME-
THAT THEY NEED THE ASSISTANCE
FROM OUR SOCIAL WORKER. WE
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE SERVICES TO
NON MINORITY AND THEN IN ORDER
FOR THEM TO REMAIN SERVICES
AFTER THE AGE OF TWENTY ONE AND
FLAT OUT YOU KNOW OUR SOCIAL
WORKERS ARE JUST. THERE YOU
KNOW FOR IN SUPPORT OF THE
CHILDREN SO PLEASE PLEASE I
ASK. THAT YOU PLEASE CONSIDER A
POLICY IN THE ELIMINATION OF
THE S. AT A RATE INCREASE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR. WILL MOVE
NEXT TO LINE FIVE SIXTY FOUR GO
AHEAD. LOW LOW. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GO AHEAD. YEAH HI MY NAME
IS GEORGE SOME OF YOUR- SAN
FRANCISCO WOMEN FIFTY. AND I'M
CALLING TO DEFINITELY OPPOSE
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL OF
ELIMINATING THE AMETHYST PETE.
M. P. HAS THREE YEARS SERVE THE
NEEDY ELDERLY POPULATION THAT
WE NEED SO MUCH ASSISTANCE
WITH- MYSELF APPROXIMATELY FOR
FOURTEEN YEARS TOTAL WORKING
WITH THEM FIFTY- HAVE CLIENTS
THAT NEED ALL KINDS OF ONGOING
SOCIAL SERVICES AND WE CONNECT
PEOPLE WITH MEDICAL NEEDS WITH-
TRANSPORTATION TRANSLATION ALL
KINDS OF. REGULAR THINGS THAT
PEOPLE NEED ON A REGULAR BASIS
AND NOT EASILY ACCESSIBLE OR
KNOW HOW TO GET AND SO WE DO IT
AND MARK TIED LANGUAGES AND WE
DO IT CONSISTENTLY DAY AFTER
DAY- BY THE UNIQUE. SYSTEM OF
GOING TO PEOPLE'S HOMES-
QUARTERLY AND ALSO- CALLING
THEM ON A MONTHLY BASIS ABLE TO
GET MORE INTO THE ESSENTIAL
NEEDS OF EACH INDIVIDUAL SO I
URGE. GOVERNOR PLEASE. HOLD
THIS AND OF THE DECISION
MAKING- THOSE INVOLVED OPPOSE
WHAT'S BEING SUGGESTED THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU SIR.
WELL MOVING NOW TO LINE FIVE
SEVENTY GO AHEAD. I EIGHT THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MY NAME IS SLOWLY AMEND
THIS AND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE MONTEREY COUNTY AND THE
FIFTY HOW IS IT THAT A MISTER
YES UP FOR ELIMINATION WE HELP
US THIS KEEP OUR POOREST FRAIL
HIGH RISK ELDERLY PEOPLE IN THE
HOME. THEREBY PREVENTING PEOPLE
FROM BEING ADMITTED INTO
NURSING HOMES WE HELP BY
GETTING MEDICAL SAFETY
EQUIPMENT FOR THE HOME AMONG
OTHER NEEDED SAFETY DEVICES FOR
THEM TO BE ABLE TO REMAIN SAFE
AT HOME THEREFORE AGAIN. WE PRE
VENT OUR POPULATION FROM GOING
INTO A NURSING HOME IF OUR
PROGRAM IS ELIMINATED IS A PLAN
TO HAVE OUR CLIENT POPULATION
GO INTO A NURSING HOME OR WHAT
IS THE PLAN I THANK GOD FOR MY
COLLEAGUES WE SERVE ABOUT
TWELVE THOUSAND PEOPLE ANNUALLY
AND IN THIS PROGRAM IS PROVEN
TO BE COST EFFECTIVE AND ASSIST
HE IS A VERY VALUABLE PROGRAM.
A TESTIMONY FROM ONE OF MY
CLIENTS DAUGHTER MY MOM HAS
DEMENTIA AND SHE GETS TO STAY
IN THE COMFORT OF FROM HOME THE
PLACE SHE RECOGNIZES I DO NOT
NEED TO PLACE HER IN A NURSING
HOME BECAUSE I GET EDUCATION
COMMUNITY SERVICES AND MEDICAL
THINK THE EQUIPMENT FOR HER THE
BEST PART IS. MY MOM GUESTS TO
LAST HER REMAINING YEARS IN HER
HOME AT THE NEW YORK BY HER
FAMILY LET'S HELP OUR FAMILIES
KEEP THEIR LOVED ONES AT HOME
FOR THEIR REMAINING YEARS
PLEASE OPPOSE THE IN
ELIMINATION. OF THIS PROGRAM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM.
WE'LL GO NEXT TO LINE FIVE
SEVENTY ONE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES MA'AM.
OKAY THANK YOU I'M THANK YOU
TERRY AND- MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CANDACE
RIGHT WITH BRIGHT FUTURES
RESIDENTIAL AND THE I. P. CARE
FACILITIES I AM A DIRECT
SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL WE HAVE
FOUR HOME SERVING TWENTY ONE
CONSUMERS AN EMPLOYEE FORTY TWO
D. S. P. WE PROVIDE RESIDENTIAL
SERVICES TO CHILDREN AND ADULTS
WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES. WE
SERVE INDIVIDUALS ARE
CONSIDERED HARD TO SERVE IN THE
COMMUNITY. THE MAY REVISE
IDENTIFIES. BUT THREE HUNDRED
MILLION CUT TO PROVIDERS AS A
FAMILY MEMBER FRAZIER BOUGHT
AT. OUR SERVICE SYSTEM WAS
DETERMINED TO BE UNDER FUNDED
BY OVER TWO BILLION DOLLARS AN
RDSP WORKFORCE CONTINUES TO
DWINDLE. WE ARE ALSO STILL
RECOVERING FROM OUR FOUR POINT
25% CUT THAT WAS. GIVEN TO
PROVIDERS ARE TAKEN FROM
PROVIDERS IN TWO THOUSAND NINE
EXCEPT AT THAT TIME MINIMUM
WAGE WAS EIGHT DOLLARS AN HOUR
AND A COST OF LIVING WITH MUCH
LOWER. UNIVERSAL THE UNIFORM
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE IS ALSO
ANOTHER CUTS RESIDENTIAL
PROVIDERS AND IT IS NOT A PART
OF THAT IS NOT A PERSON CENTER
APPROACH. AND OUR CONSUMERS
WANT TO GO TODAY SERVICE SAYS.
PLEASE REJECTED THREE MILLION
DOLLAR CUT PROVIDER RATE
EXPENDITURE AND UTILIZATION AND
REJECT THE ENFORCEMENT OF THE
UNIFORM HOLIDAY SCHEDULE. IT
DEEP CUTS GO THROUGH. WE WILL
HAVE TO CLOSE MATH AND WE WILL
HAVE TO CLOSE AND MOST HOMES
ARE ALREADY STRUGGLING TO
OPERATE. ANY CUTS WILL BE
DEVASTATING TO OUR CONSUMERS
AND OUR RESIDENTIAL PROVIDERS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM.
WE'LL GO NEXT TO LINE FIVE
SEVENTY SIX GO AHEAD PLEASE.
THANK YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS SO
MY NAME IS BOBBY SUITOR I AM A
SOCIAL WORK CARE MANAGER FOR
THE MS JUST KEY IN SANTA CRUZ.
AND I'D LIKE TO ECHO WHAT MY
COLLEAGUES ALL OVER THE STATE
HAVE ALREADY SHARED AND I'D
LIKE TO EMPHASIZE THAT
ELIMINATING AND A FIFTY WILL
INCREASE MUCH SUFFERING THAT
COULD OTHERWISE BE AVOIDED. I
AM FROM THE GOAL OF THESE
PROPOSED BUDGET REVISIONS IS TO
SAVE MONEY. ELIMINATING EMETH
OF P. WOULD BE AT ODDS WITH
THAT PRIMARY GOAL. IN
MISSISSIPPI HAS A LONG HISTORY
OF SAVING THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
BY KEEPING PEOPLE SAFE AT HOME
AND OUT OF SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES- URGE YOU TO NOT
ELIMINATE MSF P. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM. WILL MOVE NEXT
TO THE LINE FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN
GO AHEAD PLEASE. HELLO THERE.
HELLO HELLO SIR. YEAH HELLO. I
UNDERSTAND THAT MY FRIEND TO
GET TARGET WITH THEIR LIVES AND
THEN ALL AND SO I THOUGHT I
WOULD DO THE SAME AGAIN THIS IS
RICK HAWKINS OF I WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT ONE THING I'VE BUT THE
ONE THING I FORGOT TO SAY
EARLIER. IS IF THESE CUTS GO
THROUGH TO THE REGIONAL CENTER
SERVICES. I COULD SEE MYSELF.
FOR THE MOST PART BEING
OSTRACIZED- HAVING. HAVING A
BUNCH OF CONFLICTS THAT ARTICLE
ONE DON'T DEAL WITH ON WHICH
VERY WELL- I NEVER HAVE. MOST
OF YOU KNOW WHAT THAT TWO DAYS
AGO WHAT THE THIRTY IT BENT
OVER. ARE YEAH AND JUST LIKE
JIM HENSON. I FOR ONE DON'T
DEAL WITH CONFLICTS VERY WELL
AND DON'T WANT TO KNOW WHAT
CONFLICTS AT ALL AND- MAKE SURE.
REFUSE TO DEAL WITH CONFLICTS
VERY WELL KNOWN. ARE YOU KNOW
NOT WANTING TO GO INTO A GREAT
PROGRAM. ALL RIGHT YOU KNOW I
DON'T ARTS COOPER I MEAN THAT'S
JUST ME I DON'T LIKE A
PROGRAMS- WHEN I RAN GOING INTO
WORK I MEAN I DON'T IF I WAS TO
GET AN INDIVIDUAL JOB WORKING
IN A RESTAURANT OR WHATNOT A
BAKERY. IF MARKETS ARE AGAIN I
PERSONALLY DON'T WISH TO WORK
HOLIDAYS MYSELF ONE OF MY
EMPLOYER. TELLS ME THAT I NEED
TO WORK ALL DAY. AND MARI. AND
I THEIR JOB COACH BECAUSE I
NEED TO GET MORE COMFORTABLE
WITH THE JOB BUT I'M NEW TO THE
JOB IF I CAN'T GET MY JOB COACH.
HEY ONE OF MY TO DO. HOPEFULLY
THAT THE EMPLOYER PROVIDES.
PEOPLE TO TRAIN THE TWENTY NEW
EMPLOYEES- SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RICH MODE EXTENT LINE ONE
FIFTY FIVE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
HELLO THE FIVE YEAR OPEN EVEN
GO AHEAD. HELLO MANY MCCARTY
MAC MARINE AND I WORK WITH HIM
AT THAT HE PROGRAM IN SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY- I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE ELIMINATION OF THE AMETHYST
HE PROGRAM AND EFFECT HE IS A
PROVEN COST EFFECTIVE PROGRAM
THAT IS ALWAYS THE CENTRAL NOW
AND HISTORICALLY. WE PROVIDE
CASE MANAGEMENT ADVOCACY AND
COORDINATION OF SO MANY
SERVICES THAT HELP OUR MOST
VULNERABLE SENIORS GET THEIR
VERY BASIC NEEDS MET. AND I'D
LIKE TO DEAL ELIMINATED WE
WOULD UNDOUBTEDLY BE MANY OF
OUR CLIENTS IN HOSPITALS
NURSING HOMES IN FOR THOUGHT
THEY WOULD BE NOTHING SHORT OF
A DEATH SENTENCE. EMMA BUT HE
IS AN ESSENTIAL PROGRAM AND WE
URGE YOU WE IF NOT ELIMINATE IT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM.
WE'LL GO NEXT TO LINE THIRTY
THREE YOU GO AHEAD PLEASE. I AM
THIRTY THREE OR OPEN. YEAH.
GLORIA I HAVE A NUMBER IN
NUMBER I HAVE A SECOND KOREAN
AND I WOULD LIKE TO TALK TO A
BAR HEARD AS WELL- MY NAME IS
MARTHA TO HEAR YOUR IN HER NAME
IS. AN ANGIE SAID SHE IS DEAF
AND DUMB SO IF YOU IF YOU. THEY
DECIDE TO GO OUT HOURS BECAUSE
I AM A- IN HOME SUPPORT
SERVICES- EARLY AND MARK.
WRITER THAT IT'S GONNA BE A BIG
IMPACT BECAUSE- HE LEADS HER
HER LIFE HE'S ALREADY MISERABLE
IN ALL KEY THING OUT FOR ROLES
WITH HARD THREE CATS AND A FEW
THEY DECIDED TO CUT HOURS AND
THEY PUT A NOT. A NOT. LONG
TERM TODAY'S HOW TO CONNECT
RURAL KEEP UP IN HERE TO
PREVENT TALK. THAT'S
HIGHLIGHTED GONNA BE IN POWER.
READ BACK TO GOING TO BE
DEPRESSED. SO YES IN A LITTLE
AND PROSPER SENT TO TAKE ON A
HOT. REALLY HARD LIFE. ALREADY
HOW THAT REALLY HARD LIGHTS. SO
IF YOU THEY DO THEY CALL THIS
7% I HOPE THEY'RE COMING TALK.%
IT'S GONNA BE A BIG CHANGE THEY
MIGHT LEAN ON- IF YOU FOR A
LITTLE BIT BUT NOT ALL IT'S
GONNA BE A LOT OF THEM THEY
FEEL LIKE TARA. WHEN THE BOXER.
I'M INTO ARE RINGING RATING
YOU'RE NOT CAUGHT UP BY BECAUSE
I. AUTOMATICALLY THEY PUT THEM
RIGHT ON THE CORNER THEY DON'T
KNOW WHAT TO DO WITH STATE
THREE OH PARDON STERN. MY PUNCH
BY PUNCH WE DON'T KNOW WHAT TO
DO THANK YOU OPERATE. WE ARE
READY FOR SUPPER. THE CARE
GIVER. I IN THEY DON'T HAVE TOO
MUCH HELP MA'AM. NOT EVEN IN
THE GAME NINETY BEING ABOUT DMV
OFFICE NOT EVEN AT THE DOCTOR'S
OFFICE BECAUSE THEY DON'T KNOW
FIRST SIGN LANGUAGE. FOR ME. A
CHALLENGE I HAVE TO LEARN WITH
HER I CRIED WITH HER A LOT I
LOST WITH HER.BECAUSE I DON'T
I DON'T DO SIGN LANGUAGE MY
PROCLAIM WHICH IS A SPANISH AND
I HAVE TO LEARN HOW TO
COMMUNICATE WITH HER. SO SHE
ONLY HALF ME. IN MY NAME IF YOU
TAKE ME AWAY FROM HER HOW ARE
LIKE IT'S GOING TO IMPACT.
PLEASE PLEASE TOUCH TO HARD
ANYTHING A MEDIUM. OKAY FIRST I
NEED TO THANK YOU SIR GOD BLESS
YOU. HOW A GOOD REST OF DO THEY
EAT GRASSES THANK YOU. WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN Q. AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU OPERATOR. AT THIS
TIME I WANT TO THANK ALL OF THE
PUBLIC WHO HAS HELPED TO GIVE
US THE TESTIMONY WE HAVE HEARD
FROM MANY OF YOU THAT THE NEEDS
ARE GROWING AND INTENSIFYING
DURING THIS CRISIS AS WE
DISCUSSED IN OUR MAY FOURTH
HEARING THE CHALLENGE OF OUR
BUDGET IS THAT WE HAVE TO STEP
UP AND PROTECT THE PROGRAMS
THAT SERVE OUR MOST VULNERABLE.
AT EXACTLY THE TIME THAT WE
FACE DRAMATICALLY LESS
RESOURCES. THAT FORCES US TO BE
TOGETHER. CREATIVE AND BRAVE AS
WE MOVE TOWARDS A BUDGET
AGREEMENT I REMAIN HOPEFUL THAT
WE WILL FIND OUR WAY THROUGH
THIS SO THAT WE CAN AVOID HARMS
TO OUR MOST VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS AND CONTINUE TO
ADVANCE THE CALIFORNIA DREAM
FOR ALL COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU
EVERYONE WHO HAS PARTICIPATED
TODAY AND I HOPE THAT EVERYONE
HAS A GOOD NIGHT BE SAFE AND
WELL THE SOMEONE IS ADJOURNED
UNTIL TOMORROW AT NINE AM.